FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON ARCHIE
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN- MERCHANT C.
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING HAS MADE AND
HAS MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
TO NORMAL PRACTICE TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WHILE CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. AS WE
COMPLY WITH THESE ORDERS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH
TESTIMONY BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE BEING PROVIDED REMOTELY
THROUGH USER VIDEO CONFERENCE
SYSTEM. FOR THOSE. WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS. PARTICIPANTS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MUTING AND
MUTING THEMSELVES WHEN THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THIS WILL GREATLY
AID AND ELIMINATION OF ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASKED EVERY
TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR
QUESTION YOU USED THE RAZOR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM
WHICH I'LL BE MONITORING HERE.
WHAT'S RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND THE
GENDER ISSUE TO WHAT YOU ARE
REFERRING. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT TO A MODERATOR WILL
INDEMNIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
UP YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY TRUST THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING ON THE HEARING. PRIOR
TO GIVING ANY TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. AS CHAIR
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUALS OR DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES TO SUSPENSE FOR JUSTIN TO
USING. OR TO USE OUR NEW ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL. AND PATIENT SO
ALL PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. THIS
HEARING WILL BE HELD IN TWO
PARTS. PART A IS BEING HEARD
THIS MORNING COVERING
DEPARTMENTS RELATED TO HEALTH
IS LISTED IN THE AGENDA AND
PART B. WILL BE HELD THIS
AFTERNOON BEGINNING AT TWO PM
COVERING DEPARTMENTS RELATED
HUMAN SERVICES AS LISTED IN THE
AGENDA FOR PARTY. BECAUSE OF
THE VEIL ABILITY OF THE HEARING
ROOM IN TECHNOLOGY THE TOTAL
TIME FOR THE HEARING INCLUDING
PUBLIC COMMENT. WILL NEED TO BE
CAPPED. PART EIGHT WILL
CONCLUDE AT ONE PM AND PART B.
WILL CONVENE AT TWO PM AND
CONCLUDES AT SIX PM. PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE STRICTLY
LIMITED. TO ONE MINUTE MAXIMUM
PER SPEAKER TO PERMIT AS MANY
WITNESSES TO SPEAK AS POSSIBLE
BEFORE. ANY TIME WHEN IT.
RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE
NUMEROUS ITEMS BEING HEARD I
ASK THAT PUBLIC COMEDY FOCUSED
ON IDENTIFYING THE ITEMS THAT
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. MORE
DETAIL PUT TESTIMONY CAN BE
SUBMITTED IN WRITING TO THE
SECOND BY EMAIL THROUGH THE
LINK ON OUR WEB PAGE. TO ALLOW
AS MANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO EXPRESS THEIR VIEWS IF YOUR
TESTIMONY IS SIMILAR TO
TESTIMONY ALREADY PROVIDED BY
PREVIOUS SPEAKER. PLEASE
BRIEFLY INDICATE YOUR AGREEMENT
WITH THAT PREVIOUS SPEAKER. IF
WE ARE UNABLE TO HEAR TESTIMONY
YOUR VERBAL TESTIMONY BECAUSE
WE HAVE REACHED A TIME CAP
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR TESTIMONY IN
WRITING FOR THE RECORD. I WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE THAT FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WILL BE HEARING ALL OF
THE ITEMS I'M PART OF THE
GENDER PRIOR TO TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT AND VOTING. ONCE WE
HAVE HEARD ALL OF THE ITEMS AND
PART EIGHT WE WILL HAVE A
SINGLE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO VERBALLY
COMMENT ON ANY ITEM ON THE
AGENDA. INCLUDING ANYTHING ON
THE VOTE I'D ONLY I'D AGENDA.
SUBSEQUENT TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD WE WILL THEN
VOTE ON THE AGENDA ITEMS. YOU
EITHER TAKE ONE VOTE TO ADOPT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS LIST
ON THE GENDER OR TAKE SEPARATE
VOTES IF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WHICH TO. PULL ITEMS
EXTRACT ITEMS FOR SEPARATE VOTE.
PART B. THIS AFTERNOON WILL BE
SIMILARLY ORGANIZED. SO TODAY
FOR PART A WE HAVE NINE ISSUES
PROTECTION NINE APARTMENTS FOR
DISCUSSION THE GENDER IN
ADDITION TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR. SO BEFORE WE BEGIN
THE GEN ITEMS WE WILL ESTABLISH
A QUORUM FOR THE SUB COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND M. CAN PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE FOR THE RECORDS WE
CAN HEAR THAT YOUR RESPONSE.
HERE ARE TOP. HERE FIND US HERE.
EVERCORE THANK YOU TO SEPARATE
NOTES A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. FOR FIRST ITEM. IS
WE WILL BE HEARING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO WELCOME TO THE PART OF
FINANCE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND REPRESENTS OF THE
DEPARTMENT WHO ARE PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ALL PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
AGENCY PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. AND BY NAME IN YOUR
TITLE BEFORE YOU BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION PLEASE FOCUS
REMARKS ON THE QUESTIONS ON THE
AGENDA AFTER WE HEAR FROM THE
AGENCY WILL ASK. COMMENT FROM
FINANCE AND FROM THE LA- AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE TO MEMBER
QUESTIONS REGARDING ITEMS ON
THIS- DEPARTMENT SO LET'S BEGIN
LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN. WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. OKAY EVERY
MONTH OUR. OKAY. CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK. OKAY YES. GOOD MORNING-
MY NAME'S ELAINE SCORE DOCKETS
AND I'M THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
HEALTH INFORMATION INTEGRITY AT
ALL WITH ME THIS MORNING IS
JENNIFER SCHWARTZ WHO IS OUR
CHIEF COUNSEL. SO THIS MORNING
I'M JUST GOING TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTION IN THE AGENDA WHERE IT
WAS ASKED- HOW THE CENTER FOR
DATA INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION
PLANS TO MAINTAIN ACTIVITIES OF
THE OFFICES IT WELL AND THE
OTHER ENTITIES THAT WILL
ABSORB. ARTICULAR LEE THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH INFORMATION
INTEGRITY PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
AND THEN FINALLY- ON THE
COMPLAINT DATA RECORDING. ALL
BE BRIEF I JUST WANT TO SHARE A
COUPLE THINGS AS YOU KNOW THE
CENTER IS GOING TO ABSORB IN.
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
INFORMATION INTEGRITY OR WHAT
WE CALLHELLO HI SH AND ONE OF
THE PILLARS OF CALLOW HIGHS
WORK HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE
PRIVACY AND PROTECTION OF THE
USE AND DISCLOSURE OF PATIENT
HEALTH INFORMATION. AND THIS
WILL CONTINUE UNDER THE NEW
CENTER. OUR GOAL HERE IS TO
ENABLE THE USE OF DATA TO
IMPROVE HOW WE DELIVER HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS.
AND THIS INCLUDES MAKING SURE
WE'RE USING THE HELLO I
EXPERTISE. TO BREAK DOWN THE
BARRIERS TO THE CHANGING OF DAY
THAT WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
ENSURING THE PROTECTION OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION. THE
CENTER WILL CONTINUE TO PERFORM
OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES OF STATE
DEPARTMENTS ON THEIR COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL AND STATE. HEALTH
PRIVACY LAWS AND STANDARDS
INCLUDING HIPAA. AS THE STATE'S
LEVEL THEN AS THE STATE'S LOW
COMPLIANCE CHANGES THE CENTER
WILL- CHANGES COMPLIANCE
PROGRAM IN RESPONSE AND ALSO
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE TOOLS
AND EDUCATION FOR STATE
DEPARTMENTS TO USE FOR THEIR
OWN COMBINE. NEXT WE'LL
CONTINUE TO PUBLISH THE
MANDATORY STATEWIDE HEALTH
INFORMATION POLICY MANUAL WHICH
IS FOR STATE DEPARTMENTS WHICH
ALSO INCORPORATES THESE FEDERAL
AND STATE HEALTH PRIVACY LAWS
AND REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING HAVE
FUN. AND JUST AS INFORMATION
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
STATEWIDE HEALTH INFORMATION
POLICY MANUAL HAS. THIRTY TWO
PRIVACY POLICIES POLICIES IN
ADDITION TO OTHER TYPES OF
POLICIES. SO IT'S QUITE FAST.
THE CENTER WILL CONTINUE
TARGETED COMPLIANCE REVIEWS TO
ENSURE DEPARTMENTS ARE
FOLLOWING THE FEDERAL AND STATE
HEALTH PRIVACY LAWS
INCORPORATED IN THIS MANUAL.
FINALLY WE WILL CONTINUE OUR
INVOLVEMENT IN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
INFORMATION ADVISOR INFORMATION
GOVERNANCE ADVISORY COUNCIL
PARTICULARLY RELATED TO RISK
MANAGEMENT AND DATA GOVERNANCE.
AND SOME OF THE PRODUCTS WE'VE
DONE WILL CONTINUE WORK ON IS
THINGS SUCH AS THE INSTRUCTOR
ARE METAL EXCHANGE AGREEMENTS.
ARE WE DONE A MODEL
STANDARDIZED PRIVACY AND
SECURITY TRAINING AND MODEL
CONTRACT LANGUAGE. THESE
SAFEGUARDS NOW REGARDING THE
COMPLAINT DATA REPORT THERE
HAVE BEEN LAST MINUTE EDITS TO
THE TRAILER THE LANGUAGE AND I
APOLOGIZE IF THIS IS NOT YT
REACHED YOUR DESK- BUT THE
CENTER WILL CONTINUE TO
LEVERAGE THE EXPERTISE OF THE
OPIATE OF THE OFFICE THE
PATIENT ADVOCATE RELATED TO
DATA ANALYTICS AND RESEARCH AND
WILL CONTINUE TO COLLECT THE
COMPLAINT DATA AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE GOAL OF THE
COMPLAINT THAT A REPORT AND
THAT IS TO COLLECT AND ANALYZE
MULTI DEPARTMENTAL COMPLAINT
DATA AND RELATED SO WE'RE
ASSISTANCE INFORMATION TO HELP
IDENTIFY TRENDS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO APPROVE TO
IMPROVE THE CUSTOMER ASSISTANCE.
PROTOCOLS FOR THE FORWARD
DEPARTMENTS- FINALLY RECOGNIZE
THE VALUE OF THIS COMPLAINT
DATA REPORT AND PLAN TO
CONTINUE TO PRODUCE IT. AND
ALSO SEE THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT IT-
AND PERHAPS FIND OTHER WAYS TO
USE THIS DATA TO HELP TO HELP
THE FORTY APARTMENTS ADDRESS
THE COMMON TRENDS FOUND IN THE
DATA. AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER-
JENNIFER AND I ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR
ME NOW. THANK YOU ACTUALLY
QUICK QUESTION FIRST STAFF-
BECAUSE WE HAVE. SO THIS THIS
IS JUST QUESTION NUMBER TWO ON
THE AGENDA WE ALSO HAVE AN
MAYBE IT'S DIFFERENT STAFF
PEOPLE IN THE DEPARTMENT FOR
QUESTION ONE WAS AROUND ETV.
PHASE TWO AND QUESTION NUMBER
THREE. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL
MAYBE WELL DO IS SINCE THEY ARE
SORT OF DISPARATE. THEM DOING
THE SAME DEPARTMENT TO
DISPARATE ISSUES I JUST. MAYBE
HALF BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENT
PEOPLE TESTIFYING ON THOSE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO- SO JUST I
GUESS REGARD TO THIS QUESTION
AND PREVIEW THE PRESENTATION ON
THAT. ON QUESTION TOO IN
RELATION TO ISSUE ONE. TO THE
CALIFORNIA TEAM SERVICES AGENCY
IT IS OUR COMMENTS FROM- FROM
LA ON THIS RESPONSE. HI WE'RE
TRYING TO AND MEET YOU I THINK
AT THE MOMENT. IN CENTER. CITY
YES OKAY HI I'M SONYA PATRICK
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND- THE ONLY THING WE
TALK ABOUT THIS A PARTICULAR
PROPOSALS THAT SO LONG AS THE
CORE FUNCTIONS OF THE VARIOUS.
OFFICES ARE MAINTAINED AND
CONSUMER PRIVACY IS PROTECTED
WE DO THINK THAT THIS PROPOSAL
COULD HAVE SOME BENEFITS TO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS IN THE SENSE THAT THE
COORDINATION OF DATA COLLECTION
AND DATA ANALYSIS- MIGHT BE
MORE STRATEGIC AND COULD LEAD
TO BETTER DECISION MAKING. OKAY
THANK YOU. COMMENTS FROM
FINANCE. WE HAVE NOTHING TO ADD
BEYOND WHAT WAS ALREADY- WERE
MARKED BY THE AGENCY THANKS
OKAY THANK YOU- QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ABOUT THIS
FIGURE. ALL RIGHT- SO I THINK
THAT THAT WE DID HAVE A BRIEF
WE DID HEAR ABOUT THIS- PRIOR
TO OUR GERMAN FROM CRYING OF
OURS SAID THAT PRECEDED
MINISTRATION RECOGNIZING THE
FACT THAT THIS YOU TALK ABOUT
BRINGING THESE DEPARTMENTS
TOGETHER MANY OF THE FUNCTIONS.
WE NEED TO BE CONTINUED AND
PARTICULARLY- THAT COMPLAINT
DATA ANALYSIS SO APPRECIATE
THAT. LET'S MOVE ON TO I'M NOT
SURE WHO'S GOING TO BE
PRESENTING ON DESCRIBING THE
CHANGES IN THE LACONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION PHASE TWO PLANNING
REQUEST. GOOD MORNING SENATOR
PAM THIS IS BRIAN WONG I'M THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
OFFICE OF SYSTEMS INTEGRATION.
AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
CYNTHIA TUCKER WHO IS OUR-
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR PROJECT
MANAGEMENT DIVISION SHE'S GOING
TO SPEAK TODAY ON THE CHANGES
FOR EBV. THANK YOU. YES GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME SENATOR
PAM YES. OKAY GOOD MORNING SO
EBV ELEKTRONIK VISIT
VERIFICATION PHASE TWO IS TO
IMPLEMENT.A PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES IN HOME HEALTHCARE
SERVICES FOR FIRE DEPARTMENTS
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
DEPARTMENT OF AGING PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THE MAIN CHANGES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REQUEST WAS FOR PLANNING
RESOURCES. AND PRIMARILY TO
CONTINUE THE EXISTING STAFF
ALREADY WORKING ON THIS AFTER.
WHEN HE WILL BE COMPLETE AND
THE COMING MONTHS THAT MAY-REVISION REQUEST ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR THE DESIGN
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION.
IT'S A USUAL PRACTICE IN IT
PROJECTS TO BRING ON ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT ONCE PLANNING IS
WEAK. IS A NATIONAL RESOURCES
ARE SPECIALLY NEEDED DUE TO THE
NUMBER OF SYSTEMS AND PROGRAMS
THAT WILL BE IMPACTED BY THIS
IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL AS THE
AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULE OF THE
PROJECT TO AVOID FURTHER
FEDERAL PENALTIES. FURTHER
STATE HOUSE START DATE AFTER
THE RESOURCES REQUESTED IN
INTIMATE REVISION ARE SCATTERED
ACROSS THE YEARS THEY WILL BE
HIRED OR- COME ONLINE AS THEY
ARE NEEDED BY THE PROJECT. THE
PHASE TWO SOLUTION WILL NEED TO
INTERFACE WITH MULTIPLE OTHER
SYSTEMS AS WELL INCLUDING DH CS
SYSTEMS FOR FEVER SERVICE
MEDICARE HOW MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE THE MEDICAL DATA WAREHOUSE.
AS WELL AS THE GDS SYSTEMS FOR
THEIR THEIR REGIONAL CENTERS.
IN OUR PLANNING PROCESS WE HAVE
DETERMINED THAT THE STATE WILL
USE AN OPEN TENDER MODEL FOR
EBV SIMILAR TO THE APPROACH
BEING TAKEN IN OTHER STATES.
THIS WILL PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
TO PROVIDERS AND WILL
ACCOMMODATE BOTH THE AGGRESSIVE
SCHEDULE AND MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
AND DEPARTMENTS IT WILL BE
SERVED BY THE SOLUTION. THE
PROJECT HAS COMPLETED THE CTA'S
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
STAGE ONE BUSINESS ANALYSIS AND
STAGE TWO ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS
RECEIVING APPROVAL ON BOTH.
ROGER JUST CURRENTLY DEVELOPING
THE SOLICITATION DOCUMENTS
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE THIS STAGE
THREE SOLUTION DEVELOPMENT.
THESE EXISTING RESOURCES HAVE
BEEN FOCUSED ON PLANNING TASKS
AND WILL CONTINUE INTO THE
DESIGN DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION PHASE. EXCUSE ME
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
FOR THE SUCCESS OF THE DESIGN
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
PHASE THE ACTIVITIES OF THIS
PHASE INCLUDES SOLUTION
DEVELOPMENT CHANGES TO EXISTING
SYSTEMS GENERAC NEAT SOLUTION
INTERFACES WITH NONSTATE
ENTITIES AND CHANGES TO SYSTEMS
TO SUBMIT NEW DATA TO OUR
FEDERAL PARTNER. ALL OF THESE
ACTIVITIES ARE GOING TO REQUIRE
THE STATE CONTRACTOR RESOURCES
REQUESTED TO ENSURE SOUND
DEVELOPMENT TESTING TRAINING
AND OUTREACH AND TO MINIMIZE
THE IMPACT OF FIRE PROGRAM
DEPARTMENTS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
WITH REGARDS TO THE SPECIFIC
CHANGES I'M ACTUALLY SORRY TO
INTERRUPT I CAN I JUST ASK-
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE THIS IN
FRONT OF ME- SO YOU TALKED
ABOUT MORE RESOURCES SO WHAT'S
THE ACTUAL DOLLAR CHANGE- FROM-
IN THE MAY REVISE COMPARED TO
THE PREVIOUS REQUESTS I KNOW WE
DID HEAR. SOME OF THIS EARLIER
THIS YEAR. SO IT'S AT THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION AND THAT IS
RIGHT- WITH A 90% FEDERAL
FUNDING MATCH. OKAY SO IT'S SO
IT WAS A 90% MATCH SO DOES THAT
OUT TO THREE POINT IS A TOTAL
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION OR
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION THE
STATE PORTION. THE STATE
PORTION IS SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIVE THOUSAND. DOLLARS OKAY ALL
RIGHT AND THEN JUST IN TERMS OF
THE- I KNOW THERE'S A SERVICE.
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
THIS PHASE TWO. THAT YOU'RE IN
THIS PROCESS BY TERMS OF WHAT
WHAT WHAT SORT OF THE FEDERAL
EXPECTATION FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT THAT FACE TO TERMS
OF DEADLINES. THE ORIGINAL
DEADLINE WAS. FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OKAY AND SO WE HAVE TIME
IN. WE ALREADY HAVE L. TEAS OR
SENT IN TO THE DHS AND DDS
BUDGET OUR GOAL. IS TO GET THIS
IMPLEMENTED BY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OKAY OR TO
MINIMIZE. ANY FURTHER IMPACT
OKAY SO YEP WE ARE CURRENTLY
BEING PENALIZED FOR NOT HAVING
IT AVAILABLE CREDIT YET CORRECT
NOT CURRENTLY NOT CURRENTLY
OKAY WE BEGIN IN JANUARY OKAY
SELL. SIDE NOT NEAR UP BUT- IT
DID ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANT TO
SAY ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL. NO SIR
A NO THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
JUST WANT TO BE SURE WE PUT IN
THE CONTEXT- COMMENTS FROM ELIO.
OKAY AT THE END MEET YOURSELF
LMAO I CAN'T HEAR YOU. OKAY HI
OKAY I'M SORRY I'LL I'LL GET
THIS TECHNOLOGY DOWN BECAUSE
AFTER A FEW ISSUES- WE JUST
WANTED TO SAY WITH. ANY ANY
CONCERNS WITH THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL AND WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT IT'S AN EFFORT TO REALLY
AVOID LOSING FEDERAL DOLLARS
OKAY THANK YOU FINANCE. GLORIA
LET DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST
TO PUT A LITTLE BIT INTO
PERSPECTIVE ON THE STATE THAT
AND THE GENERAL FUND REQUEST IS
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN CASH THE
PENALTY IN THE FIRST YEAR WOULD
BE APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS. THE GENERAL FUND OKAY
THANK YOU THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
CONTEXT OKAY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MMHM OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL CERTAINLY- THAT
WE WANT TO AVOID- LOSING MORE
MONEY I THINK- YOU KNOW AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS DEFICIT
BUDGET- WE DO WANT TO. THINK
VERY CAREFULLY ABOUT THEIR
SIZE- HOW TO BALANCE OUR
EXPENSES AND- APPRECIATE THAT
EVEN THOUGH THERE'S AN INCREASE
REQUEST FOR MONEY FOR WHAT THEY
SEEM TO BE AN IT SYSTEM IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE- ARE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT IN THE TIME THAT
PREVENTS US FROM HAVING A
PENALTY. SO APPRECIATE THAT.
OKAY LET'S. MOVE ON TO THE
MINISTRY OF RESOURCES FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ARE
PROPOSALS- SO THAT'S THE-
NUMBER THREE. JUST SAID
DESCRIBE THE CURRENT STATUS OF
THE MYSTERIES OF PLANT CREATES
THE GENERIC DRUG LABEL. HE'S
PRESENTING ON THAT. I BELIEVE
WE HAVE ALICE CHAN FROM THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY ON THE PHONE OKAY.
ACTUALLY MODERATOR ON THE PHONE
THERE IS HIS. ALLOCATION OF A
LEVEL. GOOD MORNING CAN YOU
HEAR ME WELL YES THANK YOU.
HELLO AND EXCELLENT GOOD
MORNING SENATOR PAM THIS IS
DOCTOR ALICE CHAN AND THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR POLICY AND
PLANNING AND DIRECTOR OF
CLINICAL AFFAIRS AT THE AGENCY
AND I'LL BE SPEAKING AND CAN
THE MINISTRATION OUR PLAN TO
CREATE A GENERIC DRUG LABEL-
I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF AS YOU
KNOW- ONE OF THE MINISTRATION
KEY PRIORITY SHOULD SPEND TEN
CREW THE HOARDING BILITY OF
HEALTHCARE INCLUDING A FOCUS ON
DRUG PRICES- AND WHILE AND THE
PANDEMIC HAS PUT SOME OF THIS
WORK. FLOATED DOWN IT CERTAINLY
HASN'T STOPPED IT AND IN MANY
WAYS THE URGENCY HAS ONLY
INCREASED- IN TERMS OF THE
STATUS WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGED
WITH THE. DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES INCLUDING. TGS TGS CAR
CALIFORNIA AND- AS WELL AS KEY
ACADEMIC PARTNERS- INCLUDING AT
YOUR ALMA MATER AS SENATOR
PANJANG TALKING- AND PRIVATE
SECTOR PARTNERS- WE- WHAT ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN- EXPLORING
DIFFERENT PARTNERSHIPS. IN
ORDER TO- IDENTIFYING KEY AND
MEDICATIONS THAT WOULD BE
SUITABLE FOR THIS INITIATIVE-
IN TERMS OF THAT REQUESTED
RESOURCES AND WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO BALANCE- I NEED TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD QUICKLY. WITH
AN UNDERSTANDING OF THE FISCAL-
REALITIES OF THE STATE INCOME
OR ASKING FOR ONE S. T. SERVICE
THE PROJECT MANAGER AND SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERT. TO GO TO THE
POLICY ANALYSIS- AND HELP SET
UP THE EVALUATION FRAMEWORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR ACADEMIC
PARTNERS- WITH CONSIDERATION TO
THAT POLICY LEGAL AND
REGULATORY CONSIDERATION SO
IT'S A FAIRLY INVOLVED PROCESS.
THAT L. WILL REQUIRE SOME TIME
IN TERMS OF YOUR QUESTION I'M
EXPECTED TIME LINE WE DON'T
HAVE A CLEAR TIMELINE RIGHT NOW
PART OF IT DEPENDS ON EACH
RESOURCE. AND HOW. MUCH BAND
WITH OUR PARTNER AGENCIES HAVE.
TO FOCUS ON THIS EFFORT AND
WE'LL HAVE A CLEARER IDEA BY
THE END OF THE SUMMER. OKAY
THANK YOU COMMENTS BY ELLIS
FROM LA. HELLO YOU NEED DONE TO
YOURSELF. WE JUST HOPE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF SIGNIFICANT
UNCERTAINTY- IN TERMS OF THE
OUTCOMES OF PLANNING EFFORTS.
OKAY THANK YOU FINANCE COMMENTS.
THEY COME FROM FINANCE. HI
NOTHING OKAY THANK YOU A
QUESTION HOW MANY MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT. APPRECIATE THE
EXPLANATION- I HOPE THAT-
MINISTRATION WILL PARTNER WITH-
THE LEGISLATURE- THERE IS A
BILL AT THAT I. R. AND
MONITORING SO EVEN THOUGH IT'S
NARROWED MY BILL PACKAGE DOWN
TO ONLY A VERY SMALL NUMBER OF
BILLS I THINK THREE THE SENATE
AT THE MOMENT- THIS IS ONE OF
THEM AND SO I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
PARTNERING ON AND- SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
WITH ADMINISTRATION. ON THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT THIS
POLICY BUT ALSO ASK THE
DEMONSTRATION ACTIVELY ENGAGE
THE LEGISLATURE AND DEVELOPMENT
OF THAT POLICY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE THIS ITEM
AGENCY OKAY SEEING NONE FROM
MEMBERS HERE- WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY AND THERE
ARE TWO QUESTIONS THAT WE
REQUESTED- ANSWERS FROM THEM
SIR ASOS OR SOMEONE PRESENTING
FOR EMSA
MORNING SENATOR CANISTERS DR
DAVE DUNCAN I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE AMBASSADOR TORY. AND WITH
ME TODAY IS CROSS ALL OUR ADMIN
CHIEF WHO'S GOING TO ADDRESS
THAT FIRST QUESTION. THANK YOU.
YES JUST TO PLEASE DSCRIBE THE
RATIONALE AND DISTRIBUTION. OF
THE- PARTY MADE STAFF WITHIN
THE MODIFIED LOCAL ASSISTANCE
REQUEST WERE REQUESTING THREE
POSITIONS AND WE'RE REQUESTING
THAT THEY THE THREE POSITIONS
BE DISTRIBUTED TO THE JURY- YES
THAT MINISTRY IN REGIONS- IN
THE COASTAL INLAND AND SOUTHERN
REGIONS. COASTAL IS REGION TO
INLAND AS REGION THREE FOUR AND
FIVE. AND SOUTHERNERS REGION
ONE SIX IT MEANT THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE REGIONS HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY CARRY OUT THE
COORDINATION OF INFORMATION AND
RESOURCES WITHIN THE REGION.
AND BETWEEN THE STANDARDIZED
EMERGENCY STATE AND REGIONAL
LEVELS. EACH ADMINISTRATIVE
REGION SERVES AS THE REGIONAL
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER AND
PROVIDES LOCAL EAT ONLY US
REPRESENTATIVES TO SUPPORT THE
COUNTIES. IN EACH
ADMINISTRATIVE REGION CALORGAS
ACCORDING TO REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATOR DEPUTY REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATOR BETWEEN FIVE TO
TEN REGIONAL EMERGENCY SERVICE
COORDINATORS. AND THEY'RE THERE
BECAUSE- THE RATIONALE BEHIND
IT IS TO. GET THE- GET EXTRA
RESOURCES INTO EACH OF THESE
REGIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IMPACTED BY NOT ONLY- EMERGENCY
PLANNING BUT ALSO CODED
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES. THAT'S THE
RATIONALE BEHIND THAT. OKAY
THANK YOU AND THEN WHAT ABOUT-
AND OF YOUR ANSWER QUESTION THE
SECOD QUESTION OR SOMEONE ELSE
AND- ALL RIGHT I CAN ALSO TAKE
A SECOND QUESTION OKAY. ALL
WHAT ACTIVITIES AND UNDERTAKEN
THAT IN RESPONSE THAT THE
PANDEMIC WOULD BE REIMBURSED.
I'M CURRENTLY WE ARE IN THE
MIDST OF PURCHASING BOTH
MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND EQUIPMENT.
AND THEN WE ARE STAFFING THE
FIELD VARIANTS ARE ALTERNATE
CARE SITES SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND- KILLED MEDICAL
SITES. CURRENTLY WE HAVE ABOUT.
EIGHTY FOUR HELP FOR MEMBERS
DEPLOYED SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES WE ALSO HAVE.
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY CAL MAG MEMBERS OUT IN
VARIOUS MEDICAL SITES AND
NINETEEN M. DISPATCH. WE AFTER
REVIEWING IT STEAM-
REIMBURSEMENT GUIDELINES WE
BELIEVE THAT ALL OF OUR
ACTIVITIES ARE COVERED. HI
TRICIA. OKAY AND YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT TOTAL AMOUNT IS SO YOU
SAID 75% OF THIS WOULD BE
REIMBURSED BUT WHAT WOULD BE
THE TOTAL AMOUNT THAT- OR WHAT
HOW MUCH IS THE STATE AND PAIN
FOR. I GUESS WE CAN AT THE
BEATLES TOTAL WE ANTICIPATE
YOUR JUNE THIRTIETH BASED ON
OUR CURRENT OUR CURRENT
RESPONSE LEVEL THEN WE WILL.
ENCOURAGE SIX MILLION WHICH
PUTS THE 35% ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION TO BE REIMBURSED WITH
THE STATE PICKING UP THE
ADDITIONAL NINE MILLION. HEY DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER FURTHER.
THINGS SAY. OKAY THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT THOSE ANSWERS
COMMENTS FROM LA. HI WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THESE
CALLS THANK YOU I THANK YOU FOR
CONTRAVENING ANTS. I THINK I'M
A FINANCE MANAGER INSTALLED-
DIFFERENT FINANCE I JUST
COMMENTING THAT AN ADDITION TO
OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR THE YEAR REGIONAL
MANAGEMENT DECISIONS. WE HAD A
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE STATES TAKE AN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL MONEY IF IT
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE- THAT'S
REDUCING THE POTENTIAL COST THE
GENERAL FUND. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. YES SENATOR MELINDA'S
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
JUST WOULD LIKE- SOMEONE TO
ADDRESS WHETHER OR NOT GIVEN
THE NUMBER OF RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE SPENT ON THIS PANDEMIC ARE
WE READY- FOR FIRE SEASON. HI
DOCTOR DUNCAN HERE I CAN
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION. WE HAVE
FOUR GROUPS WITHIN HELLO YES
CURRENTLY THAT HAS SPECIFICALLY
TAKEN ON THE CONCERN OF
DISASTER WITHIN A DISASTER. WE
HAVE REALIGNED OUR SHELTER
PLANNING IN PREPARATION FOR
THIS FIRE SEASON SUCH THAT.
OKAY BIDS. HEY SUEDE SHELTER
ENVIRONMENT OCCURS SO WE HAVE
AN ALTERNATE SHELTER PLAN IN
PLACE WE HAVE- BOLSTERED OUR
RESPONSE EFFORTS WITH RESPECT
WITH RESPECT TO THE NUMBER OF
SHELTER ENVIRNMENTS MEANT WE
MAY REQUIRE GIVEN THIS FIRE
SEASON WE'VE ALIGNED THE-
ONGOING SHELTER CAPABILITIES
FOR COPD PATIENTS. THAT MAY BE
MOVED FROM ONE SHELTER TO
ANOTHER SO YES WE'RE WELL
PREPARED FOR THIS FIRE SEASON
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION I'M THINKING IF I
COULD JUST FOLLOW UP SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND
THAT FINANCIALLY SPEAKING ALL
THE THINGS THAT YOU JUST LAID
OUT BORDERS- ARE COVERED OR YOU
EXPECT TO BE COVERED. I MAY ASK
FOR ASSISTANCE FROM RECTAL SO
BUT YES WE EXPECT ALL THOSE
ITEMS TO BE COVERED WITHIN OUR
NORMAL. APPROACH TO FIRE SEASON
OF THE MSA. MAINTAINS THE
MEDICAL RESPONSE TO THE FIRE
SEASON WITH RESPECT TO
SHELTERING. BUT THAT DSS TAKES
ON THE SPECIFIC SHELTERING
REQUIREMENTS THOUGH. I DON'T
WANT TO DABBLE IN THEIR SPACE
BUT LET ME LET ME HAVE A RACK
THAT. OFFER ADDITIONAL.
RESOURCE COMMENTS. WELL AS
YOU'RE AWARE WE'RE NOT WE'RE
NOT WE'RE FUNDED THE
DEPARTMENT'S WANTED TO PREPARE
NOT TO RESPOND SO ANY RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES IN CONNECTION WITH A
WILDFIRE- WOULD WE WOULD EXPECT
TO BE REIMBURSED ALONG WITH IT
IF THEY STRUGGLE DECLARATION
WAS DECLARED UP AGAIN UP TO THE
FULL 75% FREE BURST RATE. OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH SIR CAN I HAVE A SURF
QUESTIONS WELL SO I APPRECIATE
TERM LENDERS BRING UP THE WILD
FIRES BUT ALSO JUST- FOR IN
TERMS OF COVERAGE YEAH WE GET A
75% REIMBURSEMENT BUT AS YOU
INDICATED THAT MEANS THAT AS A
STATE WE'VE- HAD SPENT NINE
MILLION FOR THIS OBVIOUSLY VERY
NECESSARY AND FACT OUT THAT OUR
TOP PRIORITY SHOULD BE TO.
CONTAIN THE CORONA VIRUS SO WE
CAN RESTORE OUR ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY AS WELL AS- OTHER
PARTS OF OUR LIFE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING GIVEN
WHAT WE KNOW OF OUR CURRENT
SITUATION- FUND A STATE FUNDS
GOING TO THE FUTURE- FOR SOME
OF THESE ACTIVITIES KNOWING
THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO STOP ON
JULY FIRST AND- WELL WE MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO SPEAK THE EXACT
AMOUNT WE MAY NEED TO. THINK
ABOUT WELL WE SHOULD BE
ALLOCATING AT LEAST SOME STATE
FUNDS- AND- SINCE WE LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE STILL PAYING A QUARTER OF
THE EXPENSES SO IS THAT IN THE-
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED AND THAT MAY REVISE
OUR AS AN INSPIRATION TO
SUPPORTING COMING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THAT- FOR
FUNDING REQUESTS FOR MS
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO
PREPARATION. FOR A COVETED. BUT
WHAT WE HAVE DONE THIS WORK
TRUST WITH THEM SO WE HAVE NO
MAJOR REVISION PROPOSALS THAT.
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY SO I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT- I THINK THE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THERE'S A
PROPOSAL FOR A GENERAL POOL OF
MONEY IN RESPONSE TO COVET BUT
ME FRANKLY SOME OF THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WE CAN ANTICIPATE-
AND THEY SAID YES WE'LL HAVE TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS BASED ON WHAT
HAPPENS AND DALE CASELOAD AND
WE HAVE A SECOND SERVES AND SO
FORTH. BUT FOR IT YOU KNOW WE
KNOW THAT- AS WE'RE GETTING
FUNDS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- IF THEY'RE COVERING
THE MAXIMUM 75% WE STILL HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO FUND THE
REMAINING. 25% AND CERTAINLY- I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
BE ENGAGED IN THAT DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW WE CAN APPROPRIATELY
ALLOCATE OUR STATE FUNDS IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWS US TO ADDRESS
THECODE- PANDEMIC BUT ALSO OF
COURSE- PRIORITIZE THAT VARIOUS
OTHER. EXPENDITURES THAT WERE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
AS WELL SO- YEAH I THINK HAVING
THAT KIND OF DISCUSSION AND-
GAUGE MEN CERTAINLY NOT ONLY ON
HIMSELF ON A VARIETY OF OTHER
THINGS AS WELL. I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT SO
THAT- OUR LEGISLATURE IS HERE
YEAH IT IS INVOLVED AND NOW
INVOLVED YOU KNOW IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS. TO LEGAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT. TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS. ACTUALLY MAYBE
MY QUESTION FOLLOW QUESTION AND
THE COURT TO FINANCE IS THAT.
TO ANTICIPATE- FURTHER- THE
PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OF.
COVERT PREPARATION- ON ON GOING
BASIS PROTECT YOU KNOW FIGURING
OUT WE HAVE A BUDGET THAT
STARTS JULY FIRST. CERVANTES
STRESSFUL FROM FINANCE MMHM YOU
KNOW WHAT I THINK WE'VE GOT A
NUMBER OF AVENUES TO DO THAT IN
THE REVISION PROPOSAL NUMBER OF
CONTROL SECTIONS THAT WILL
ALLOW THE ADMINISTRATION SAID
MOST BEST UTILIZE FEDERAL
FUNDING- AND MAXIMIZE THE
BACKUP L. DOT REVENUES THAT WE-
HAVE A LIMITED IMPACT ON THE
GENERAL FUND. AND OF COURSE ANY
ANY SORT OF- GERMAN MATCH WITH
THE SOURCES FOR. THAT'S SORT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING NOW OF COURSE
WE WOULD HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH SUCH BOUT THAT. OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT. CERTAINLY THE
ALLEGED LATER EVEN ON THE
FEDERAL IN TERMS OF FEDERAL
FUNDS AND- SORRY WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER TO MAXIMIZE OUR
FEDERAL FUNDING. MATCHES
DELICIOUS ALSO HAS IT THROUGH
ITS APPROPRIATIONS AND- FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITIES- DOES HAVE
EVEN FOR FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
COME TO THE STATE. HAS A SAY IN
HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE ACTUALLY-
MANAGED WITHIN THE STATE AS
WELL SO IN TERMS OF POSITIONS
AND OTHER TYPES OF DECISIONS.
ALL RIGHT WELL BUT THAT THERE'S
NO OTHER QUESTIONS REGARDING-
AND SO- LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT. SO WE
HAVE THREE QUESTIONS RELATED
TO- RESPOND AND- SO I CAN HAVE
SOMEONE FROM OUR SPOT IS
PRESENT. AND BY THE WAY JUST
FOR MEMBERS- WE WE'VE CAME UP
WITH THESE QUESTIONS BUT IF YOU
HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT FEEL FREE TO ASK
AS WELL WE- NOW. YES GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHURNING. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS RICHER A GOOD
MORNING. AS LONG AS I AM THE
ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT
THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
DELIGHTED TO BE HERE. WITH ME
ARE MICHAEL TALLEY ACTING
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR OUR
INFORMATION SERVICES DIVISION.
AND KAREN RICE CELL WHO IS
SERVING AS ACTING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS EDUCATION. I WILL
BE THE MAIN PRESENTER OF OUR
ITEMS. SO PRIME NUMBER ONE IN
THE CATEGORY OF NEW REQUESTS.
LET ME REVISE INCLUDES A THIRTY
THREE MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND REDUCTION FOR THE SONG
BROWN HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS. SOME
BACKGROUND- THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN INCLUDED
ONE HUNDRED MILLION OVER THREE
YEARS. IN THE JANUARY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED THE
SONG BROWN GENERAL FUND. THIRTY
THREE MILLION TO CONTINUE. IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THIS
MAY REVISE PROPOSES TO
DISCONTINUE THIS EXPANSION OF
THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM. AS A
RESULT THE SONG BROWN'S LANDING
WILL CONTINUE WITH ITS HISTORIC
BASELINE BUDGET. I JUST NOTE IF
FEDERAL FUNDING INTEREST IS
RECEIVED THIS PROGRAM IS TO BE
RECONSIDERED FOR GENERAL FUNDS
OR- FISCAL NINETEEN TWENTY
AWARDS HAVE BEEN MADE AND THESE
CONTRACTS ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING EXECUTED OR HAPPEN IT'S
CUTE. WELL FOR ITS BASE
APPROPRIATION SONG BROWN
ANNUALLY RECEIVES APPROXIMATELY
SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION FROM
WASHINGTON'S HEALTH DATA AND
PLANNING ON. THE ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS. OKAY WELL WELL WELL
WOULD YOU GO JUST CONTINUE AND
ANSWER ALL OF THE QUESTIONS
UNLESS THERE IS OTHER PEOPLE
AND- SPOTS THAT ARE GONNA BE
ANSWERING THOSE. YES WE PUT
THAT'S THE BACKGROUND- MISTER
CHAIR- POPPING DOWN TO ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS. OKAY YEAH
OKAY WELL THERE'S OTHER. OKAY
WELL IF YOU CAN PLEASE CONTINUE
ANSWERING THE OTHER QUESTIONS
ON THE AGENDA AND THEN WE'LL
TAKE WHAT STAND- WILL WILL WILL
TAKE COMMENT FROM LA IN FINANCE
AFTER THAT. SURE THANK YOU
MOVING ON AUSTIN HAS PROPOSED
VERSIONS IN THECATEGORY OF
WHAT. WE REQUEST A REVISION FOR
THE WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAM. OF THE
200-019-2060 MILLION DOLLAR WET
MONEY APPROPRIATED. THIRTY FIVE
MILLION OF THAT WAS GENERAL
FUND. TWENTY MILLION IS
PROPOSED TO BE REVERTED. THIS
WILL NOT HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT DUE TO TIMING. FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE SCHOOL
YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY WAS A
PLANNING YOUR FOR AUSTRIA. THE
MAIN REASON PROPOSES TO
APPROPRIATE THE SAME ABOUT
TWENTY MILLION. IT'S JUST COOL
YOU'RE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
M. HSA FUND HE CONTINUED TO
WORK FOR WHAT. SO THIS SHIFT IN
FUNDING SUPPORTS THE WET TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE PLAN AT THE
ORIGINALLY APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF SIXTY MILLION. AND I'M HAPPY
TO CONTINUE LESTER IS THAT IT'S
A DISTANCE PLEASE CONTINUE.
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION AND I
DIDN'T WANT TO COMMENT AFTER
THE CONCLUSION OF ALL THE ITEMS
ALL THE PORTIONS ON. THE STAGE
AND SEE THANK YOU. A THE
RESEARCHER AUSTIN IS ALSO
REQUESTING A RE APPROPRIATION
FOR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHERE
APPROPRIATED FUNDS. PREVIOUS
WHAT APPROPRIATIONS HAPPENED
LANGUAGE FOR MULTI YEAR BILL
ABILITY. OF THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WOULD APPROPRIATION
DID NOT HAVE A MULTI YEAR BILL
BUILDING THAT I WAS AN
OVERSIGHT. ON NEXT. THERE IS
ONE MODIFICATION TO THE
GOVERNORS- JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL PROPOSAL AND THAT IS
THE ADMINISTRATION IS MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE HEALTH CARE
PAYMENTS DATABASE TRAILER BILL.
WITH THE MAY REVISE
MODIFICATION OF ADDING AN
EXPLICIT PROHIBITION AND NO
GENERAL FUND WILL BE USED TO
FUND THE DATABASE. OPERATOR
YOUR REGIONAL STATUTE AB
EIGHTEEN TEN. OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ARE SPEAKING BEING A
REVIEW COMMITTEE OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND EXPERTS. THAT
WRAPPED UP ITS WORK IN FEBRUARY
OF THIS YEAR. THAT REVIEW
COMMITTEE WAS COMPOSED OF A
VERY BROAD GROUP OF HEALTH CARE
EXPERTS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
REPRESENTING OUR DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES OF PAYERS
PROVIDERS CONSUMERS RESEARCHERS
AND OTHERS. AND THE BODY
PROVIDED THIRTY TWO UNANIMOUS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO DEVELOP AND
GOVERN THE DATABASE. IN AUSTIN
SUBMITTED A SUMMARY OF THIS IN
A REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
MARCH. WAS REQUIRED TO BE
SUBMITTED IN JULY THAT WE
RECORD OUT THERE EARLY FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. SO THIS TRAILER
BILL WOULD PUT IN STATUTE DOES
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND ALLOW OUR
STATISTICS STANCE WE COMPLETE
THE DATABASE AND BEGIN
OPERATIONS OF IT BY JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. FINALLY
LAST ITEM STILL BUILDING FUND
LOAN. FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IS
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISE AS A
LOAN FROM THE HOSPITAL BUILDING
FUND TO THE GENERAL FUND. THE
PROJECTED FUND BALANCE FOR THE
FUND WOULD BE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION AFTER THE LONG.
THIS WILL BE ONLY FIND IT'S
FUNDED BY FEES PAID BY HEALTH
FACILITIES UPON APPLICATION FOR
CONSTRUCTION PLAN REVIEW. THE
HOSPITAL BUILDING FUND HAS BEEN
UTILIZED IN THE PAST. TO LOAN
TO THE GF IN IN PREVIOUS YEARS
AND HAS ALWAYS BEEN PAID BACK
IN FULL FROM THOSE ACTIONS.
THAT CONCLUDES MY ITEMS- WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE SOME QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU- BEFORE- YEP LA-
IN FINANCE COMMENT ON THE
HOSPITAL BUILDING FINE YOU SAID
THAT YOU KNOW VOICE DATA BACKED
DOWN UNDER WHAT TERMS SO FOR
EXAMPLE ARE WE PAYING INTEREST
BACK- WIN LOSE WHEN WE- PRAY
BACKS ARE. IS INTEREST INVOLVED.
SO BARRING FORTY MILLION ONLY
PAY BACK. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I'M SORT OF FINANCE
OKAY WELL THAT FINANCE COMMENT
ONE FINDS COMMENTS OKAY L. AS
COMMENTS ON THE PRESENTATION
FROM OCCUPIED. BY BEN JOHNSON
FROM THE LA OKAY NEIL NO
CONCERNS- WITH THE REQUESTS OF
THE BUDGET IN THE REVISED. OKAY
THANK YOU FINANCE. HI WE ARE
ALMOST A PART OF FINANCE SO
QUESTION NUMBER ONE WE'VE BEEN
ASKED TO DESCRIBE WHAT CRITERIA
THE ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERED
IN THE DECISION TO PULL BACK
THE PROPOSED EXPANSION OF SONG
BROWN AND HOW IT COMPARES TO
RECENT INVESTMENTS IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS. THOUGH IN RECENT
YEARS OSCAR WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
UP AND PRIMARILY FUNDED THROUGH
SPECIAL SIGNS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF A TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
ADMINISTRATION. BUT THE
EXISTING SONG RUN PROGRAM AND
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN- ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT TO
SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS WE KNOW THAT BOTH
PRIMARY CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH
WORKERS PROGRAMS ARE. EXTREMELY
HELPFUL TO ASSIST IN ADDRESSING
THE IMPACT OF COMMON NINETEEN-
YOU'RE NOT THE ONE TIME GENERAL
PLAN FUNDING FOR SONG BROWN IS
SET TO EXPIRE IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAD
PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED TO MAKE THE
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT ON GOING
THERE BY EXPANDING THE PROGRAM.
HOWEVER IN LIGHT OF THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDER OUR
BROAD POLICY TO PULL BACK
PROPOSED EXPANSIONS WHILE
MAINTAINING WHERE POSSIBLE THE
EXISTING COMMITMENTS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE WE PROPOSE TO HOLD BACK
THE EXPANSION FROM THE SONG
BROWN PROGRAM WHILE MAINTAINING
THE EXISTING FUNDING FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS. WE ALSO CONSIDER THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. ABOUT
CULMINATES IN A SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT AT THE END OF
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
UNLIKE THE MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE PROGRAM ONE TIME
INVESTMENT. FULLY BACKED
EXPANSION OF SONG BROWN WOULD
HELP ADDRESS THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT. AND WE ALSO CONSIDER
THAT THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM HAS
EXISTING BASE FUNDING. FROM THE
ENACTED- TRUMP IS AN ACT ON
HEALTH FACILITIES AS OSCAR. HAS
PREVIOUSLY NOTED YOU. THERE IS
ANOTHER. SPECIFIC TO WHAT TERMS
ARE THE INDUSTRY TENTS REPAIR
LOAN THE HOSPITAL. FOR AND WILL
THE INDUSTRY RESPONSE. IF THE
PROGRAM MEETS FIND LET ME
REVISE PROPOSES A ONE TIME
TRANSFER OF FORTY MILLION. FROM
THE HOSPITAL BUILDING FUND TO
THE GENERAL FUND. WE UNDERSTAND
THE SPECIALFUNDS ARE INTENDED
TO SUPPORT SCIENCE PROGRAMS AND
AS SUCH THERE'S PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PAY BACK THE
LOAN. PLUS INTEREST. TO EITHER
THE PROGRAMMING SO MANY BACK OR
THE GENERAL FUND DOES NOT NEED
ALONE ANYMORE. OKAY IN CHESTER
THE TERMS OF THE INTERESTS ARE.
THERE REGARDING THE- SMITH
FINDING I DON'T HAVE THE
SPECIFICS WITH ME BY WE CAN GET
BACK TO YOUR STAFF. OKAY THAT
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL I AND I
AM A CHRISTIAN MAKE THIS
ASSUMPTION. WE ARE COMPRISED
BORROW SO MANY SPECIAL SIGNS IN
ORDER TO HELP SELL THE CASH
FLOW AND SO I DON'T KNOW STAY
ALL. THE SAME TERMS APPLY TO
ALL OF THEM TERMS OF THE
BORROWING TERMS OR DATE.
SOMEONEDIFFERENT FOR DIFFERENT
SPECIAL SIGNS BUT PERHAPS WE
CAN GET BACK ON THAT. OKAY ALL
RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. YES TADA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST HAVE A
QUICK COMMENT JUST WANTED TO
REALLY EXPRESS MY- YOU KNOW
CONCERN FOR THE ELIMINATION OF
THE SALT BROWN PROGRAM AND I
THINK NOW IS THE TIME WHERE WE
REALLY NEED TO FOCUS AND INVEST
MORE ON OUR PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE
WE HAVE IT IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO GROW- WHAT.
HOPEFULLY THIS NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN AND FACING ANOTHER
PANDEMIC BUT- WE REALLY DON'T
WANT TO PUT OURSELVES IN A
FURTHER DISADVANTAGE OF NOT
HAVING. YOU HAVE POSITIONS
AVAILABLE AND SO I JUST REALLY
WANT TO. EXPRESS MY CONCERN FOR
THE CUTS- THE ELIMINATION. OF
THE EXPANSION AND SO I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN REALLY LOOK AT
INVESTING EVEN MORE. SIR
MELINDA'S THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
JUST A DOVE TAIL ON SENATOR HER
TODDLER'S COMMENTS- CAN I ASK
WHAT THE- ESTIMATE IS OF HOW
MANY HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
WE WILL LOSE IN THE NEXT FIVE
TO TEN YEARS BECAUSE OF THE
SONG BROWN CUTS. BUT. SURE.
WELL IN TERMS OF RESIDENCIES
THAT ARE PARTIALLY FUNDED BY
THE SONG GROUND PROGRAM THIS
WOULD REPRESENT A REDUCTION-
YOU KNOW FROM THE THIRTY THREE
MILLION. SETTING IS DOWN TO
ABOUT SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION
IN BASE FUNDING SUPPORT IT'S A
DIFFICULT QUESTION TO ASK
BECAUSE THE SONG BROWN
COMMISSION. HAS THE ABILITY TO
DELINEATE OR ARE SEPARATE THOSE
FUNDS INTO DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
BUT WITH THE- THIRTY THREE
MILLION. LAST YEAR ARE SPENT
PROVIDED YOU KNOW NINETY SEVEN
OUR PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY
AWARDS. TWENTY NURSE
PRACTITIONER. FORTY FIVE.
REGISTERED NURSE PROGRAM AWARDS
SHOW US FROM YOU KNOW WITH THE
TOTAL FUNDING OF APPROXIMATELY
YOU KNOW GIVE OR TAKE FORTY
FOUR MILLION I'LL WITHOUT-
BEING REDUCED TO THIS HISTORIC
BASELINE FUNDING THE PRODUCTION
WOULD BE A ROUGHLY PROPORTIONAL.
BUT THE COMMISSION ULTIMATELY
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO AWARD
THESE DOLLARS TO SEPARATE THEM
INTO CATEGORIES. BETWEEN
EXISTING SLOTS EXPANSION SLOTS
NEW PROGRAM- SLIDES AND
TEACHING HEALTH CENTER SLOTS SO.
IT'S INDETERMINABLE AT THIS
TIME EXACTLY THE EXACT NUMBER
OF THE REDUCTION OF SLOTS- BUT-
YOU GET A SENSE FROM THE
PROPORTIONAL REDUCTION. OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THAT IS
CONCERNING TO SAY THE LEAST-
BUT HI I'M WE'RE GONNA WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
WITH ONE ANOTHER I'M SURE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IT'S
THE LAST THING WE NEED IS FEWER
MEDICAL PROVIDERS NOT LAST SO
BUT THANK YOU FOR THE- FOR THE
ANSWER. THANK YOU I HAVE A
QUESTION REGARDING SONG BROWN-
SO I USED TO BE RESIDENCY
DIRECTOR. AND SO I KNOW THAT-
WITH MATCH DAYS ALREADY PASSED-
SO THE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS ARE
ACCEPTED. THE RESIDENTS FOR THE
COMING YEAR- ALSO. RESIDENCIES
ARE THREE YEARS LONG SO WHEN TO
ADMIT SOMEONE THAT'S A THREE
YEAR COMMITMENT. THE CUTS ARE
BEING PROPOSED ARE THEY GOING
TO AFFECT RESIDENT THAT
PHYSICIANS AND THEN OF COURSE
WE ALSO FIND AND HE'S I'M SURE
THERE'S AN PEACE WHO'VE BEEN
ACCEPTED AS WELL MAY HAVE BEEN
EXCEPT AS WELL NOT SURE WHEN
THEY MAKE THOSE DECISIONS. ARE
GONNA FACTS. RESIDENTS WHO'VE
ALREADY ESSENTIALLY MATCHED
INTO THEIR TRAINING PROGRAMS
AND NOW THESE PROGRAMS ARE NOT
GOING TO GET THE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE RESIDENCY TRAINING.
AND EDUCATION AS RESIDENTS THE
OTHER THING JUST AS A COMMENT
BEFORE YOU ANSWER THAT-QUESTION. IS THAT. IN ADDITION
TO THE FUNDING THAT SONG BROWN
MAY PROVIDE FOR THOSE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
TEACHING HOSPITALS OR THE
TEACHING. HEALTH CENTERS AS
WELL- OFTEN DO FIND PORTIONS OF
THAT TRAINING AS WELL AS A
CLINICAL REVENUES BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT. HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS HAVE. INDEED OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS HAS
ACTUALLY LOST A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF CLINICAL REVENUE
BECAUSE OF PREPARATION FOR
COVERT AS WELL SO THEREFORE NOT
IN. A GOOD FINANCIAL POSITION
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE UP
DIFFERENCES. THAT HAVE OCCURRED
AS WELL SO I JUST WANNA PUT
ALSO PUT THAT OUT THERE TO MAKE
UP FOR. THE GAP THAT SOME
GRAMMYS CREATES OKAY AND I CAN
APPRECIATE OF US WHAT COMMENT
ON THIS CUTS IN FUNDING. AND
SONG BROWN IS IT GOING TO HAVE
AN IMPACT ON RESIDENTS WHO'VE
RAISED IN ADMITTED TO THEIR
PROGRAMS WILL BE STARTING THEIR
TRAINING. AND JULY FIRST- ORDER
MAY BEEN STARTING EVEN EARLIER
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN MOVING
PEOPLE EARLIER BUT BASICALLY
PEOPLE EXPECTED STARTER
TRAINING JULY FIRST. OF. TWENTY
TWENTY. BECAUSE SOLAREDGE
MONTHS NOW. THANK YOU SIR AND
IF WE COULD WE WOULD HAVE TO
TERREL BRAZIL FROM MARCH BID
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION THANK YOU.
I YES GOOD MORNING. SO I HAD
THEM AWARDS THAT WE MAKE WITH
THE SONG ROUND FINDS FIND THE
UPCOMING CLASS SO WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT THE AWARDS THAT
WE MADE WITH THE FINES FROM
NINETEEN TWENTY YEARS ARE
STARTING TO FIND THE UPCOMING
CLASS SO WE ALWAYS MAKE THEM
UNIQUE VANCE SO THOSE THOSE
AWARDS HAVE BEEN MADE AND
THEY'RE IN PLACE FOR THAT
CLASSES THAT ARE STARTING THIS
YEAR. OKAY AND MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS ARE PRETTY FUN FOR A
MULTI YEAR AWARD SO THAT THEY
RECEIVED A FUNDING OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD FOR SOME OF THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS OKAY SO JUST
TO BE CLEAR YOU'RE SAYING THE
FUNDING CUTS THAT WERE BEING
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISE
WOULD ACTUALLY IMPACT THE CLASS
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE BECAUSE
YOU ALLOCATE THE MONEY HERE TO
DANCE. CORRECT OR NOT AFFECTING.
THE ENTERING CLASS OF TWENTY
TWENTY. REACHED NO FOR THOSE
THAT WE HAVE FUN THOSE WIND
PROGRAM ALWAYS A WARD. AND FOR
THEIR FOR THE UPCOMING. AT THE
NEXT COHORT OKAY ALL RIGHT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE DON'T UNDER KIND- THE
RESIDENTS WHO VERY MADE A
COMMITMENT TO GO TO THEIR
PROGRAMS- LITERALLY HIT HIM
MONTH AND A HALF. AND SO I'M
GLAD TO HEAR THAT- IDEA SURE TO
CONCERNS OF MY COLLEAGUES ABOUT
THE IMPACT THIS HAS ON OUR WORK
FORCE YOU KNOW WERE LATER GONNA
BE TALKING TO DEPART CARE
SERVICES. AND THE CASELOAD
INCREASE IF I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATE TWO
MILLION MORE PEOPLE MEDI CAL-
THE SHORTAGES IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES WILL CONTINUE TO
EXIST AND- CERTAINLY SONG
BROWN'S GOING TO BE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT. AND SO-
SO I THINK. YOU KNOW WE SHOULD
CAREFULLY LOOK I'VE CERTAINLY-
UNDERSTAND THE SOMEONE WHO CAME
INTO THE LEGISLATURE AND A
TWENTY TEN WIN WITH A TWENTY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT-
THE NEED TO. BE ABLE TO BALANCE
OUR BUDGET AND HAVE. TO MAKE
CUTS THAT WE MAY NOT NORMALLY
LIKE TO. DO TO HAVE TO DO BUT
AGAIN I HOPE THAT WE CAN BE
SURE WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS VERY
CAREFULLY- IN TERMS OF BEING
SURE WE MAINTAIN OUR WORK
FORCE- BOSA AND PRIMARY CARE
AND CERTAINLY- I'D- APPRECIATE
THAT WHAT THEY TALK ABOUT WITH
MENTAL HEALTH. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY I THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION FROM OSHKOSH.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT
MANAGED HEALTHCARE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES I CAN GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU HI- SO I'M
SHELLEY RELIED ON THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AND I'M I'M HAPPY TO
BE HERE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
OUR- ON THE REVISED PROPOSALS-
I THOUGHT I DO A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
FOCUSED INVESTIGATION AND THEN
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THE LAUNDRY.
ALONE FIND. SO THE DEPARTMENT'S
TOTAL PROPOSED FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET IS
NINETY SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIVE AUTHORIZED PHYSICIANS. AND
THAT INCLUDES THE POSITIONS
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED IN THE-
THE BUDGET. AS WELL AS THE
REVISED. SO STARTING WITH THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOCUSED
INVESTIGATION SO THE DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY UTILIZES A VARIETY OF
REGULATORY TOOLS TO ASSESS
WHETHER ENROLLEES. ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS TIMELY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. THESE TOOLS INCLUDE
ROUTINE MEDICAL SURVEYS WE DID
FOCUS SURVEYS OF THEIR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH. PARITY AND ADDICTION
EQUITY ACT ON THE KIA- ANNUAL
REVIEW OF HEALTH PLAN PROVIDER
NETWORKS ARE REVIEWING HEALTH
PLAN TIMELY ACCESS ANNUAL
COMPLIANCE REPORTS AND TRACKING
AND TRENDING IN RALEIGH
COMPLAINTS AN INDEPENDENT.
MEDICAL REVIEW APPLICATION. BUT
DESPITE THIS RIGOROUS OVERSIGHT
OF ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND MENTAL MENTAL HEALTH PARITY
COMPLIANCE MANY UNRELEASED
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE
DIFFICULTY ACCESSING TIMELY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. AND
RELEASE OFTEN EXPERIENCE
CHALLENGES FINDING IN NETWORK
PROVIDERS THAT ARE ACCEPTING
NEW PATIENTS AND SCHEDULING
TIMELY INITIAL AND FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS. EVEN WHEN IN A
REALLY SUCCESSFULLY CONNECTS
WITH THE PROVIDER HERE SHE MAY
FACE ADDITIONAL OBSTACLES IN
OBTAINING CARE. HEALTH PLAN OR
HEALTH PLAN DELEGATE CLINICAL
GUIDELINES IF THEY LIMIT OR
DELAY INITIAL AUTHORIZATIONS
TREATMENT DURATIONS ARE COVERED
SERVICES. AS A RESULT MANY
ENROLLEES ABANDONED THEIR
EFFORTS TO SEEK IN NETWORK CARE
AND THEY SUBSEQUENTLY PAY OUT
OF POCKET FO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES BUT AN OUT OF NETWORK
PROVIDER. OR THEY MAY SEEK CARE
AT A HOSPITAL EMERGENCY ROOM OR
AT WORST NOT GET HERE AT ALL. I
AM REQUIRED TO FACILITATE
ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND ITS SISTER ALWAYS
NAVIGATING THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. AND REMOVING THE
UNNECESSARY RESTRICTIONS SUCH
AS THOSE THAT I DESCRIBED. TO
FURTHER UNDERSTAND THE ENROLLEE
EXPERIENCE AND THE BARRIERS
THAT THEY FACE THE DEPARTMENT
PROPOSES TO CONDUCT FOCUSED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
INVESTIGATIONS TWENTY FIVE FULL
SERVICE COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLANS
ACROSS THE LARGE GROUP SMALL
GROUP AND INDIVIDUAL MARKETS.
SO THIS WOULD AVERAGE FIVE
INVESTIGATIONS A YEAR OVER FIVE
YEARS. CONDUCTING A FOCUSED
SURVEYS ARE THE BUT
INVESTIGATIONS AS NECESSARY TO
DETERMINE WHY ENROLLEES AND
PROVIDERS CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE DELAYS IN OBTAINING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. AND
IDENTIFY ANY NON COMPLIANT
PRACTICES OR BARRIERS IN THE
HEALTH PLANS DELIVERY SYSTEMS
THAT MAY LEAD TO IN RALEIGH ARE.
ANY NON COMPLIANT PLANTS WILL
NEED TO PROVIDE A CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN AND OR MAYBE
REFERRED TO OUR OFFICE OF
ENFORCEMENT FOR FURTHER
INVESTIGATION AND POTENTIAL
PENALTIES OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
ACTION. WITH THE GOAL OF
BRINGING ANY PLANTS THAT ARE
DEFICIENT IN COMPLIANCE. THESE
INVESTIGATIONS WILL BE SHARED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TASK FORCE. AND WILL
LEAD TO RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE HEALTH PLAN PRACTICES
AND ELIMINATE BARRIERS ARE. THE
RESULTS OF THESE INVESTIGATIONS
MAY ALSO IDENTIFY WHETHER
ADDITIONAL REGULATORY OR
LEGISLATIVE ACTION. IS
NECESSARY TO REDUCE THE
BARRIERS THAT ARE ALWAYS FACED
WHEN ATTEMPTING TO ACCESS
SPEAKING FROM HEALTH SERVICES
AND TO MITIGATE. YOUR DELIVERY
SYSTEM VIOLATIONS. THE
DEPARTMENT REQUEST FOURTEEN
POINT FIVE POSITIONS AND TWO
MILLION SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
FOR ADDITIONAL POSITIONS- IN
AND FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND APPROXIMATELY
FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION. IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FROM THE
MANAGED CARE FUND TO ADDRESS
THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
CONDUCTING THE TWENTY FIVE
LOCUST SURVEYS. WITH RESPECT TO
THE LOAN FROM THE MANAGED CARE
FUN- INCLUDING THE MAY REVISE
IS A ONE TIME TRANSFER TO
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
MANAGED CARE FUND TO THE
GENERAL FUND TO ASSIST WITH THE
CASH SHORTAGE RESULTING FROM
THE NINETEEN. THERE IS
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT THE
LOAN WILL BE REPAID WITH
INTEREST IF THE DEPARTMENT
NEEDS THE SITES. SO I WILL GO.
TO THE QUESTIONS THAT I. HAD
ASKED- THE FIRST ONE WAS AROUND
JUST ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON THE
METHODOLOGY IS REGARDING THE-
H. SO THESE INVESTIGATIONS WILL
INCLUDE A REVIEW OF EACH OF THE
HEALTH PLANS PROCEDURES FOR
OBTAINING HEALTH. COVERAGE IN
HER HEALTH SERVICES THE
PROCEDURES FOR REGULATING
UTILIZATION. REVIEW MECHANISMS
INTERNAL PROCEDURES FOR
ASSURING QUALITY HERE AND THE
OVERALL PERFORMANCE OF THE PLAN
AND PROVIDING HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS AND MEETING THE HEALTH
NEEDS OF SUBSCRIBERS INTERNALLY.
THE AREAS OF THE FOCUSED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INVESTIGATIONS WILL INCLUDE A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF
ENROLLEES SPECIFIC EXPERIENCES.
REVIEW OF MEDICAL RECORDS FROM
THE DATE AND TIME AND IT REALLY
WAS DIAGNOSED THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONDITION OR NEEDED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THROUGH THE TIME THE ENROLLEE
RECEIVED THE TREATMENT. WILL
CONDUCT IN ROWLEY AND PROVIDER
INTERVIEWS TO DETERMINE THE
SPECIFIC BARRIERS THAT ARE
ROWLEY'S EXPERIENCED IN
OBTAINING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. FOR EXAMPLE HOW MANY
CALLS DID YOU ONLY HAVE TO MAKE
TO FIND A PROVIDER THE
FREQUENCY OF IT REALLY CONTACTS
WITH THEIR HEALTH PLAN TO TRY
TO FIND A PROVIDER OR GET
AUTHORIZATION FOR SERVICES. AND
THE FREQUENCY OF PROVIDER
CONTACTS TO THE HEALTH PLAN
PRIOR TO WHEN THE INITIATION OF
TREATMENT. OTHER AREAS OF FOCUS
INCLUDE THE TIMELINESS AND
AMOUNTS OF PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENTS. REVIEW OF
ENROLLEES SPECIFIC UTILIZATION.
DATA AND IN DEPTH ASSESSMENT OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CLINICAL
GUIDELINES AND HOW THEY WERE
APPLIED IN SPECIFIC AND REALLY
CASES. AND REVIEW OF OTHER
RELEVANT UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
PROCESSES SPECIFIC TO HUMAN
HEALTH SERVICES THE SECOND
QUESTION WAS ABOUT THE TERMS
FOR REPAYMENT OF THE MANAGED
CARE FUND I DID MENTION THAT
THERE IS PROFESSIONAL- THE
PAYMENT- PROVISIONS IN THE IN
THE MAY REVISE. THAT WOULD
INCLUDE- INTEREST BUT THAT IF
THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS MONEY BUT
FINANCE MAY BE ABLE TO SHARE
SOME MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THAT. YOUR THIRD QUESTION
RELATES TO HOW WE'RE THE
DEPARTMENT IS MONITORING THE
ADEQUACY OF HEALTH PLAN
PROVIDER NETWORKS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT- THE PROVIDER NETWORKS ARE
ADEQUATE AND THAT PLANS FULFIL
THEIR RESPONSE. SO OF COURSE
ENSURING ACCESS TO MEDICALLY
NECESSARY SERVICES IS A HIGH
PRIORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT THE
DEPARTMENT CONDUCTS ITS NETWORK
ASSESSMENTS BY CLAN AND BY
NETWORK. THE KNOX KEEN ACT
REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS REPORT
WHEN A NETWORK EXPERIENCES A
CHANGE IN 10% OF ITS PROVIDERS
SO FOR EXAMPLE WHEN KAISER
CLOSE SOME OF ITS MEDICAL
CENTERS. AND RE DIRECTED STAFF
TO OTHER HIGH IMPACT AREAS DUE
TO THE COLD IN NINETEEN
OUTBREAK. KAISER FILED THAT
INFORMATION WITH US.
ADDITIONALLY HEALTH PLANS MUST
ANNUALLY SUBMIT THE NETWORK OF
CONTRACTED PROVIDERS FOR THEIR
INDIVIDUAL COMMERCIAL AND
MEDICARE LINES OF BUSINESS.
THAT INCLUDES ALL PROVIDE-
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
SPECIALIST PHYSICIANS AND NON
PHYSICIAN MENTAL HEALTH.
PROFESSIONALS THAT'LL HELP
FACILITIES HOSPITALS CLINICS
ETCETERA. DEPARTMENT ALL
NETWORKS FOR COMPLIANCE WITH
THE NETWORK ADEQUACY
REQUIREMENTS. THEY ALMOST PLANS
MUST ALSO SUBMIT WHAT WE CALL A
BLOCK TRANSFER FILING PRIOR TO
A CONTRACT TERMINATION BETWEEN
A HEALTH PLAN AND PROVIDER
GROUP OR A HOSPITAL THAT
IMPACTS- TWO THOUSAND OR MORE
ENROLLEES. WE REVIEW THE PLANS%
PROPOSED ALTERNATE PROVIDER
GROUPS AND HOSPITALS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE NETWORK
CAN PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
GEOGRAPHIC ACCESS AND THE
CAPACITY TO SERVE THE ENROLLEES
WHO WERE AFFECTED BY THE
CONTRACT TERMINATIONS. AFTER
THE DEPARTMENT APPROVES THE
NETWORK FOR A PARTICULAR-
PRODUCT TO THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES TO MONITOR THE
ADEQUACY OF THE NETWORK. IF IT
FAILS TO MEET THE ADEQUACY
STANDARDS THE DEPARTMENT HAS A
NUMBER OF TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
HELP HELP. HELP HELP PLAN
COMPLIANCE INCLUDING. LAKES
LEVYING ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES REQUIRING THE PLAN TO
SEND AND RELEASED OUT OF
NETWORK PROVIDERS TO ACCESS
MEDICALLY NECESSARY CARE. OR
ORDERING THE PLAN TO CEASE
OFFERING HEALTH PLAN PRODUCTS
IN. YEAH HEALTH PLANS HAVE AN
ONGOING DUTY TO ENSURE THEY
HAVE ADEQUATE NETWORKS TO
PROVIDE ENROLLEES WITH ALL
MEDICALLY NECESSARY SERVICE
SERVICES IN A TIMELY AND
GEOGRAPHICALLY APPROPRIATE
MANNER PROVIDERS INCLUDING
MEDICAL AND DENTAL CLINICS AND
HOSPITALS HAVE REPORTED
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES DUE TO HER THAT
NINETEEN AS PATIENTS HAVE
DELAYED RECEIVING ALL BUT
EMERGENCY AND URGENT MEDICAL.
SO LAST WEEK ON MAY TWENTIETH
THE DEPARTMENT ISSUED AN ALL
PLAN LETTER DIRECTING HEALTH
PLANS FOR COMMERCIAL LINES OF
BUSINESS JUST A MINUTE
INFORMATIONAL FILING EXPLAINING
THE STEPS THE PLAN HAS TAKEN.
OR WILL TAKE TO ENSURE
CONTINUED NETWORK ADEQUACY. WE
WILL RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION
ON JUNE FIFTH AND WE'LL HAVE A
BETTER IDEA WHAT STEPS THE
PLANS ARE TAKING TO ENSURE THEY
MAINTAIN ADEQUATE NETWORKS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THIS ALL
PLANNED LETTER ALSO ENCOURAGE
PLANTS TO TAKE STEPS TO REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS AND
EXPEDITE PAYMENTS TO PROVIDERS
EXPERIENCING FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES. THIS INCLUDES
EXPEDITING CLAIMS REVIEW AND
PAYMENT OF ACCOUNTS RECEIVABLE
FINANCING PAYMENTS WHEN
FEASIBLE AND REDUCING THE TIME
PROVIDERS HAVE TO WAIT ON
PHONE. ON THE PHONE FOR
AUTHORIZATIONS AND AMENDING
COORDINATION OF CARE PROCEDURES.
THE KNOX KEEN ACT REQUIRES UP
PLANS TO REIMBURSE PROVIDERS
WITHIN FORTY FIVE WORKING DAYS
OF THE PLANT'S RECEIPT OF A
COMPLETE CLEAN CLAIM. IF THE
CLAIM IS CLEAN IS IT IT
PROVIDES ENOUGH INFORMATION. TO
DETERMINE ITS LIABILITY FOR THE-
IF THE CLAIM IS INCOMPLETE THE
PLAN WORKS WITH THE PROVIDER TO
GET MORE INFORMATION BEFORE AND
THE CLAIM. GIVEN THE STATUTORY
FRAMEWORK THE DEPARTMENT DOES
NOT HAVE THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO
DIRECT PLANS TO PAY CLAIMS MORE
QUICKLY OR TO PAY CLAIMS THAT
ARE. SO WITH THAT I WILL PAUSE
AND SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH- COMMENTS FROM LA. A GOOD
MORNING SENATOR PAD I'M COREY
HAS SHE DID WITH THE L. A. L. I
JUST HAVE A FEW COMMENTS ON THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INVESTIGATIONS.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL- REQUEST ONGOING
RESOURCES FOR THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH TWENTY FIVE
INVESTIGATIONS- IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS PLANNING TO.
INCORPORATE SOME OF THE NEW
PROPOSED METHODOLOGIES INTO ITS
EXISTING SURVEY REVIEW
WORKLOAD- AND- WE WERE JUST NOT
THAT YOU KNOW THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MAY WANT TO. LEARN MORE ABOUT
HOW THE DEPARTMENT PLANS TO DO
SO GIVEN THAT- THE REQUEST IS
FOR ONGOING RESOURCES. OKAY
THANK YOU. FRENCH FINANCE. WHAT
WE ARE ALMOST DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON
THE CONVERSATION ON THE LOANS
SO GENERALLY ALL THE LOANS HAVE
SIMILAR LANGUAGE WITH SOME
LANGUAGE SPECIFYING A REPAYMENT
SCHEDULE THE LOANS MUST BE
REPAID WITH INTEREST ON IT
BALANCE CALCULATED AT THE RATE
ARE NOT THE POOL MONEY
INVESTMENT ACCOUNT AT THE TIME
OF THE TRANSFER AND THE RATE IS
CURRENTLY ONE POINT SIX
PERCENT. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR GETTING INFORMATION
QUICKLY SO QUICKLY. ALL RIGHT
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT I HAVE
SEVERAL QUESTIONS AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION I
APPRECIATE THAT DO YOU NEED C.
IS ASKING THE PLANS- TO AT
LEAST PROVIDE INFORMATIONAL
FILINGS- REGARDS TO THEIR-
INTERNS THERE SPOTS A CODED AND
THE NETWORKS- BUT I'M ALSO VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT. THE FUTURE OF
OUR PROVIDER NETWORKS. THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATION DID A SURVEY OF
PHYSICIANS AND FOUND THAT 30%
ARE WORRIED THAT THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO CLOSE. 30% HEARING FROM
HOSPITALS- THE DATA THEY ARE
HAVING. THE RECORD TREMENDOUS
LOSSES IN THIS PERIOD-
IRONICALLY BECAUSE THEY HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO PREPARE FOR
TOTAL BID AND- SO IT'S ACTUALLY
BEEN SEEING FEWER PATIENTS.
IT'S IN MANY WAYS IT'S A-
UNDERSCORES THE SUCCESS OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH EFFORTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE DID NOT
EXPERIENCE WHAT HAPPENED IN NEW
YORK CITY OR OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY- SAME TIME- YEAH IN
ORDER TO GET THERE WE BOTH HAD
TO SPEND MORE MONEY- TERMS OF
SAAS YOU KNOW HOW. PRACTICES IN
HOSPITALS HAVING TO GET MORE P.
P. E. CHANGING THE PROCEDURES-
ACTUALLY REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
VISITS THAT THEY'RE SAYING
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
PROCEDURES ARE BEING DONE IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN A CAPACITY
FOR BECAUSE OF IT. SO I THINK
THAT CERTAINLY THE DEPARTMENT'S
HEALTH CARE AS A PLAIN
REGULATOR- HAS A ROLE IN
HELPING IT AND CERTAINLY ONE OF
THE GOALS IS TO BE SURE WE HAVE
ADEQUATE PROVIDER NETWORKS- YOU
KNOW THE PLANS THEMSELVES HAVE
CONTINUED CONTRACT FREEMAN'S-
AND PEOPLE WELL DAVE THERE MAY
BE SOME LOSSES BECAUSE- PEOPLE
LOST THEIR JOBS AND FOR LOST
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE- THERE I
THINK WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT- THE PLANS- DO YOU HAVE AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN HELPING
MAINTAIN NETWORKS ON A MORE
PROSPECTIVE BASIS SO REALIZE IT
AND THE RECKLESS BUT FRAMEWORK
ACTUALLY OFTEN WHAT WE DO IS WE
IDENTIFY WHEN THERE'S A PROBLEM
AND THEN. ACT FOR A CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN OR SOME CONSEQUENCE
TO THAT BUT WE NEED TO BE MORE
PROACTIVE WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON RIGHT NOW SO. TO APPRECIATE
THEIR YOU GOT THESE
INFORMATIONAL FILINGS I
APPRECIATE THAT MEANS THAT
PLANTS HAVE TRIED TO COME UP
WITH- THAT FIRSTS- LIKE LOANS
TO PRACTICES AND SO FORTH BUT I
PERSONALLY THINK THAT'S FINE
NOT ENOUGH. SO I GUESS THE
FIRST QUESTION I HAVE AN EIGHT
UNDERSTAND THAT U. UNDERSCORE
THAT THE CURRENT LAW DOESN'T
ALLOW YOU TO ENFORCE BEYOND-
EARLIER IN FORTY FIVE DAYS- I
THINK FIRST OF ALL WE NEED TO
TRY TO SPEED PAYMENTS TO
PROVIDERS- MORE QUICKLY- AND- I
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE CAN YOU
KNOW WE CAN CERTAINLY RECONCILE
THINGS ON THE BACK AND DO IT WE
CAN CERTAINLY INDICATE THAT
IT'S A YOU KNOW THE THERE'S A
PROVIDER DOESN'T HAVE MUCH OF A
RECORD OR HAS A RECORD OF A-
FRAUD OR OTHER BEHAVIOR THAT I
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT MAYBE FOR
THOSE PARTICULAR. ENTITIES
THERE MIGHT BE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT RAPID PAYMENT BUT- MOST
PROVIDERS DON'T FALL IN THAT
CATEGORY AND- THEY'RE SUFFERING-CASH FLOW ISSUES OF THAT A
SIGNIFICANT MAGNITUDE IF LAID
OFF STAFF- THIS DOESN'T HELP A
BIT UNDER YOU KNOW THAT THIS
UNDERMINES OUR EFFORTS TO TRY
TO KEEP THE ECONOMY GOING SO-
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT THE FARM IS HEALTH CARE
ARE DOING BEYOND WHAT YOU
DESCRIBED IN TERMS OF. FOR
EXAMPLE TRYING TO SPEAK TO HIM
AND SO OF COURSE WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE SAYING THAT YOU'RE
LEGALLY YOU CAN'T DO MORE SO
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE THINGS YOU
WOULD SUGGEST TO US AS THE
LEGISLATURE WE CAN CERTAINLY
GIVE YOU MORE LEGAL POWERS TO
BE ABLE TO SPEED UP PAYMENTS
MORE RAPIDLY TO PHYSICIANS
PERHAPS AND HOSPITAL SO AND
OTHER HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS SO
FOR EXAMPLE IS THERE A WAY WE
CAN MOVE IT UP TO THIRTY DAYS
INSTEAD OF FORTY FIVE DAYS.
SECONDED. DEPARTMENT PLEASE
COMMENT ON THAT. THANK YOU DOC
PAN WELL SIR. I SHARE YOUR
CONCERN ABOUT THE- THE
CHALLENGES THAT OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IS FACING IT'S-
DEFINITELY SERIOUS AND
WIDESPREAD AND WE RECOGNIZE
THAT. WE ARE LIMITED BY WHAT
THE LAW ALLOWS US TO DO- AND
THAT'S WHY IN THE- A PLAN
LETTER THAT WE JUST RELEASED WE
ARE. ENCOURAGING PLANTS TO DO
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING- TERMS OF PAYING.
CLAIMS MORE QUICKLY AND- YOU
KNOW TAKING CARE OF THE BACKLOG
OF ACCOUNTS RECEIVABLE OR
ACCOUNTS RECEIVABLE- ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT WE DID WAS
TO- DIRECT THE PLANS TO. BE
SURE TO PAY TELEHEALTH VISITS
AT THE SAME RATE AS AN IN
PERSON VISIT. BECAUSE A LOT OF
THE FEE FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS
IN THE CLINICS IN PARTICULAR
WERE WERE REALLY HURTING AT THE
BEGINNING WHEN THERE IS- THERE-
PATIENT. VISITS DROP
SIGNIFICANTLY AND THEY DIDN'T
HAVE YOU KNOW THE BENEFIT OF A
CAPITATED PAYMENT ARRANGEMENT
WHICH IS BEEN CONTINUED TO BE
PAID. TO THOSE PROVIDERS WHO
ARE- UNDER CAPITATION- WITH
RESPECT TO WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN DO I'M I'M REALLY NOT IN A
POSITION TO SUGGEST THAT- YOU
HAVE YOUR OWN IDEAS ABOUT THAT
BUT- AS I SAID WE ARE. LIMITED
BY WHAT THE LAW ALLOWS US TO DO
AND WITHIN THAT WE DO TRY TO.
ENCOURAGE AND PUSH AND
SUGGESTED THE PLANS THAT THEY
NEED TO DO SOME OF THESE THINGS
AND MANY OF THEM ARE STEPPING
UP AND WE'LL FIND OUT THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THEY ARE DOING
THAT. ONCE WE RECEIVE THESE
FILINGS- IN EARLY JUNE. OKAY
SO- I KNOW YOU MENTIONED
TELEHEALTH AND APPRECIATE THE
ACTIONS TAKEN AROUND
TELEHEALTH- WHAT ABOUT
TELEPHONIC CARE WHICH SOME
PEOPLE WOULD INCLUDE WITHIN
TELEHEALTH BUT SOMETIMES. IT'S
NOT- SO CARE PROVIDED. BY OVER
THE TELEPHONE MANY. PATIENTS
DON'T MEAN TELL HOW IS GREAT
SPEAK SUPPORT TELEHEALTH BUT
YOU NEED SOMETHING A BOTH AND
SOMETIMES THE ONLY THING AT THE
OTHER END OF PATIENTS A
TELEPHONE- I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT MY A LAWYER AND ACCOUNTANT
CERTAINLY. IS WILL THAT BILLS
ME FOR ANY TIME I TALK TO THEM
ON THE PHONE SO WHY SHOULDN'T-
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS BE
PAID. WHEN THEY PROVIDE.
TELEPHONIC ADVICE. TO RESPOND
TO THAT. HELLO MHC STILL ON THE
LINE. SEE YOU'RE STILL ON MY
SWEETER HI CAN YOU HEAR ME I
CAN HEAR YOU YES OKAY I'M
SORRY- I DID I DID RESPOND TO
THAT ALL RIGHT YOU CAN HEAR YOU
AT THE TIME OKAY THAT'S OKAY-
SO TELEPHONIC VISITS- WERE
INCLUDED IN OUR DIRECTION TO
THE PLANTS TO PAY THOSE AT THE
SAME RATE AS AN IN PERSON VISIT
TO BECAUSE AS AS YOU SAY YOU
KNOW SOME PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO DO A VIDEO VISIT
SO TELEPHONIC VISITS ARE ARE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS FOR PAYMENT. OKAY
PROJECT THAT- I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER YOU'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE- PACIFIC
BUSINESS GROUP ON HEALTH
RELEASED A PROPOSAL- I THINK ON
WEDNESDAY- TWO. I THINK-
SUGGESTS THAT PLANS COULD
ESSENTIALLY DO ACER PROTESTS
THE PROSPECTIVE PAYMENT SYSTEM
DOT HELP AGAIN STABILIZE THE
FINANCES IMPROVED CASH FLOW FOR
A PRIMARY CARE PRACTICES- IS
THAT. RIGHT SO. I WOULD LIKE TO
GET YOUR OPINIONS ABOUT WHAT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
PROPOSAL AND- IT FLEW PAST WE
USE THE LEGISLATURE WANT TO
IMPLEMENT THAT BUT SORTIES
WOULD YOU NEED. THOSE
DEPARTMENTS IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT SUCH A PROPOSAL THANK
YOU- I HAVE SEEN THE PROPOSAL
AND- IT'S VERY INTERESTING I.
WOULD BE HAPPY TO- WE WILL BE
REVEALING IT AS IF IT IF IT
MOVES FORWARD- AND BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE- TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS
NEEDED. OKAY WELL PRECIADO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE I THINK WE
SHOULD PROBABLY CONSIDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ADDRESS THAT AND WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR ASSISTANCE IN
THAT REGARD. OKAY OKAY. AND
THEN- I KNOW THAT THE HOSPITALS
HAVE ALSO EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS AS WELL. AND I DON'T
WANNA FORGET OUR SUBSPECIALTY
COLLEAGUES BUT IN TERMS OF- YOU
KNOW THEY'VE THEY'VE RAISED
SOME CONCERNS IN TERMS OF-
AGAIN TO THAT. POST THAT
PAYMENT TIMING WHICH I KNOW WE
TOUCHED ON AS WELL AS- ALSO-
TRYING TO. NOW THERE'S A TRYING
TRYING TO STABILIZE OUR
FINANCES WELL SO THIS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THESE- INFORMATIONAL
FILINGS YOU SAID THEY'RE GOING
TO BE BACK ON. JUNE FIFTH I
REALIZE WE HAVE A BUDGET TO
PASS BY JUNE FIFTEENTH. WHAT
KIND OF INFORMATION WILL YOU BE
REPORTING BACK TO LEGISLATURE.
AND I'VE BEEN A WHAT TIME LINE
IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU'RE FINDING
FROM THESE INFORMATIONAL
FILINGS. I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY
ON THE TIME FRAME TIME FRAME WE
OBVIOUSLY WILL IT DO THE
ANALYSIS AND PUT TOGETHER SOME
INFORMATION AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE ONCE YOU RECEIVE THE
FILINGS- SO THAT WILL BE.
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE WE'VE MADE
IT CLEAR TO THE PLANS THAT THIS
IS NOT A CONFIDENTIAL FILING
THAT THEY'RE SUBMITTING TO US
SO. WE WILL GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. OKAY I APPRECIATE
THAT- SO REALLY WANTED DO YOU
WANT TO HEAR FROM THE PLANS
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND
APPRECIATE THEM- SHARING THIS
INFORMATION ONLY WITH YOU BUT-
WITH- THE PUBLIC. AND AGAIN YOU
KNOW WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO
IS FIND ON THE BACK AND WE
DON'T HAVE AN ADEQUATE PROVIDER
NETWORKS- BECAUSE THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH PROVIDERS ANYMORE. I
MEAN WE DO HAVE RADIO AREAS OF
SHORTAGES IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND SO FORTH BUT- MORE BROADLY-
WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT WE'RE
ACTING PRO ACTIVELY- NOT TRYING
TO ACT RETROACTIVELY. IN TERMS
OF ADDRESSING AN ISSUE THAT WE
ALREADY KNOW IT'S COMING DOWN
THE LINE. AND SO THAT'S WHY I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE-
TAKE ACTION NOW. AND YEAH. BE
SURE THAT- OUR PRESS THESE ARE
PRACTICES ARE AVAILABLE TO TAKE
YOUR PATIENCE- WHEN PATIENTS
NEED THEM. UNDERSTOOD OKAY
THANK YOU SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. IN TERMS OF- HERE
SO I ACTUALLY TOOK MORE LONG
TERM- YEAH WE'VE TALKED WE
SPENT SOME TIME IN OUR HEARINGS
TALKING ABOUT- SOME THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS HAD WITH- YOU KNOW DOING
YOUR SURVEYS AND SO FORTH
REGARDING AN AT WORK ADEQUACY
L. YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH FOCUSED
INVESTIGATIONS- AND DOING
INTERVIEWS AND SO FORTH HOW DO
YOU SEE COVE IT IMPACTING
THOSE. THOSE EFFORTS- YEAH
WE'VE HAD CHALLENGES GETTING
ACCURATE DATA REGARDS TO-
NETWORK ADEQUACY SURVEYS BEFORE
I REALIZED THAT IN OUR MORE
RECENT PRESENTATIONS MANY OF
THOSE ISSUES WERE BEING
ADDRESSED OVER TIME- BUT ALSO
IN ORDER FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
BE ABLE TO ENFORCE THE LAWS
THAT THE LEGISLATURES PASSED.
THOUGH THAT DATA WAS CRITICAL
TO THAT SO DO YOU SEE. WHAT'S
HAPPENING WHAT'S COVERED- AND
IMPINGING ON OUR- THE ABILITY
OF THE PART AND TO BASICALLY
ENFORCE THE LAWS THAT- WE'RE
ASKING DEPARTMENT TO FORCE. AND
GETTING THE DATA TO DO THAT.
WELL CERTAINLY IT PRESENTS A
CHALLENGE AND THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE DOING- ON SITE
VISITS AT THE PLANTS IN EITHER
OUR SURVEYS OR OUR FINANCIAL
EXAMS AT LEAST AND IN THE SHORT
TERM. SO THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
ALL BEING DONE- FOR CALLING
DESKSIDE IT'S BASICALLY IN THE
PLANTS ARE SUBMITTING THE
INFORMATION TO US
ELECTRONICALLY. WE ARE WE
EXPECT THAT WE'LL STILL BE ABLE
TO- CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK
THAT WE'VE ALWAYS DONE IN THAT
REGARD- BUT IT CERTAINLY IS A
CHALLENGE WITH RESPECT TO THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INVESTIGATIONS- THE- THE BUDGET
ASSUMES THAT DATE THIS WILL BE
FUNDED ARE STARTING TO IN
JANUARY- SO WE HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME TO SEE HOW. THINGS
GO- AND IF WE HAVE TO DO THESE
INVESTIGATIONS REMOTELY WE
WILL- AND WE'LL JUST. HAVE TO
TAKE THE NECESSARY PRECAUTIONS
TO KEEP. THE STAFF AND
EVERYBODY IS SAFE OKAY. WELL I
THINK I KNOW THAT YOU MENTIONED
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT NOT ONLY
TO TALK TO AND REVIEW WHAT THE
PLANS ARE DOING IN THEIR
PROCESSES BUT ALSO TO TALK
DIRECTLY TO THE- ENROLLEES AND
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS WHICH I
KNOW YOU MENTIONED SO I THINK
THAT'S GONNA BE PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT- IT'S YOU WANT TO
LOOK AT PROCEDURES BUT- YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL
IMPACT OF PROCEDURES UNTIL YOU
TALK TO THE PEOPLE ARE
SUBJECTED TO THOSE PROCEDURES.
SO ALL RIGHT ARE THERE OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SPEAKING OKAY ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DIRECTOR RELIED FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU- I'M TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT WE- KEEP OUR
PROVIDER NETWORKS GOING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. AND WE
HAVE FOR. FOURTEEN QUESTIONS AS
WELL AS- MANY ITEMS TO DISCUSS-
SO- WE JUST GO AHEAD AND GO
THROUGH ALL THE ALL THE-
HIGHLIGHTS IN THE QUESTIONS AND
THEN WE'LL TAKE COMMENT FROM
LA- AND FINANCED AND WILL TAKE
MEMBER QUESTIONS SO. PART OF
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JC COOPER CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
MEDICAID DIRECTOR I THANK YOU
FOR HELPING ME THIS THIS
MORNING SENATOR PAN. I'M SO WE
HAVE QUITE A FEW ITEMS I WILL
TRY TO GET THROUGH THEM AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE BUT TRYING
TO MAKE SURE I HIT ALL OF THE-
ITEMS AND THEN WE'LL GO FORWARD
WITH QUESTIONS. ON THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN POINT SEVEN BILLION%
DOLLAR TOTAL FUN FOR THE
SUPPORT OF DH YES PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES IN THE BUDGET YEAR
THIS IS AN INCREASE OF EIGHT
POINT 5% OVER THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT NEARLY DOWN
TWO POINT NINE BILLION. DOLLARS
OR TWO POINT EIGHT PERCENT. A
RELATIVE TO THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT THIS CHANGE
IS THE RESULT OF A NUMBER OF
FACTORS INCLUDING. UPDATED
ESTIMATED CASELOAD UTILIZATION
TIMING OF PAYMENTS. AND THE
IMPACT OF KOBE IN NINETEEN.
THESE REDUCTIONS RELATIVE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTS
THE NET IMPACT OF SEVERAL KEY
FACTORS OF WHICH ALL WALK
THROUGH. I'M THE FIRST ONE
BEING ABOUT A ONE POINT- SORRY
THREE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN GENERAL FUND COSTS
DUE TO PROJECTED INCREASE IN
THE MEDIC HOW CASELOAD. TO KOBE
NINETEEN ABOUT CURRENT YEAR END
BUDGET YEAR. I'M NOT DCS
PROJECTS AN AVERAGE MONTHLY
MEDICAL ENROLLMENT TO BE
THIRTEEN MILLION INDIVIDUALS IN
CURRENT YEAR VIRTUALLY FLAT
COMPARED TO WHAT IT IS IN JUNE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT. HOWEVER DO YOU SEE AS
PROJECTS AN AVERAGE MONTHLY
MEDIC HOW CASELOAD FOR BUDGET
YEAR TO BE APPROXIMATELY
FOURTEEN POINT TWO MILLION OR
NINE POINT 2% INCREASE OVER THE
RISE CURRENT YOUR FORECAST.
EACH CASELOAD REFLECT THE
NUMBER OF THINGS- IT REFLECTS A
HISTORICAL CORRELATION BETWEEN
THE MEDIC HELP SHE SLOWED IN
THE CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES. IT IS SEEMS A ONE MONTH
LAG BETWEEN UNEMPLOYMENT AND
SHE SLOWED AND PACKED. IT ALSO
USES- I KIESLER DISTRIBUTION
ACROSS OUR VARIOUS- PROGRAM
SERVICES. ARE BASED ON WHAT WE
SAW FROM THE RECOVERY IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN. AND WOULD
JUST POINT THAT PIECE OUT IS IT
WILL BE A BIG- DISCUSSION
ORDERS THE ELLY ELLS. REVIEW OF
OUR CASELOAD AS WELL. YEAH
THING THAT YOU'LL SEE WITHIN
OUR CHANCELLOR PROJECTIONS AS
IN ORDER TO COMPLY WITH H. R.
SIX TWO OH ONE AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT ALLOWED TO
SUSPEND. OR I JUST ENROLL ANY
MEMBERS FROM THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM THIS IS JIM'S
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FOUR THOUSAND MEDI CAL ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
HAVE LOST THEIR ELIGIBILITY
DURING A GIVEN MONTH THAT WILL
CONTINUE ON DUE TO THE
SUSPENSION OF RENEWALS. THANK
YOU BRIAN WITH H. R. SIX TO R.
ONE. LEO HAS A PROJECTED IRAQIS
ARE PROJECTIONS AS OF YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON NEELY- HAS
RECOMMENDED REDUCING THE
GENERAL FUND. AND BY ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- FOR BOTH CURRENT YEAR
END BUDGET. THAT BASED ON OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HAS REDUCED THEIR
ESTIMATE- DELEO IN DH CS IS
OVERALL CASELOAD PROJECTIONS
ARE SIMILAR. THE DEPARTMENT OF
KOBE NINETEEN CASELOADS
INCREASE INCLUDED A GREATER
NUMBER OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND SENIORS
POPULATION. RESULTING IN A
HIGHER GENERAL FUND COSTS. ARE
THE L. E. O. N. DH CS I'VE HAD
MANY DISCUSSIONS REGARDING THE
ASSUMPTIONS. OF CASELOAD. AND
DCS HAS PROVIDED SOME
ADDITIONAL CLARITY I REGARDING
THOSE PROJECTIONS AS RECENTLY
AS IN THE LAST TWENTY FOUR
HOURS JUST TO BE CLEAR- AND
THOSE INCLUDE- REVISIONS IN
REGARDS TO IN THE DH CS
ESTIMATE BE ATTRIBUTED PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES KOBE NINETEEN
IMPACT. SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CATEGORIZED AS PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND SENIORS. AS
WELL AS NOTATING THAT THE
CASELOAD INCREASE FOR THIS
CATEGORY CATEGORY IS MAINLY
ATTRIBUTED TO THE SUSPENSION OF
RENEWALS. THERE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT USES DRIVING
CASELOAD- WITHIN OUR
PROJECTIONS- SO WELL THE ACS IS
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES AND
SENIORS CASELOAD- IT MAY BE ON
THE FISCALLY CONSERVATIVE SIDE.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE L. A. AS
ESTIMATE LIKELY UNDERESTIMATES
THIS POPULATION- HOWEVER THE
DEPARTMENT- IS REVIEWING THE
CURRENT CHANGES IN NEARLY AS
RECOMMENDATION. AND THE
DEPARTMENT. AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE'LL CONTINUE TO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS ELLIE
REGARDING. IT BUT PERFECT. I'LL
THERE ARE IN ORDER TO
ATTRIBUTES THIS IN CASE AND
COST ON THERE ARE NUMBER OF
SAVINGS PROPOSALS WITHIN THE
MEDICARE BUDGET- INCLUDING A
THREE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND SAVINGS
RESULTING FROM AN INCREASE OF.
FEDERAL FUNDING TO THE ENHANCED
EMERGENCY F. MAP- I MADE
AVAILABLE THROUGH H. R. SIX TO
R. ONE. I THINK YOU KNOW I WILL
NOW KIND OF WALK THROUGH SOME
OF THE ADDITIONAL SAVING
PROPOSALS- I WOULD JUST NOTE
GIVEN THE SIZE AND SCOPE OF THE
DEFICIT- THE INCREASE CASELOAD
WITH THEN. ON THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM THE NEED TO PUT FORWARD
A BALANCED BUDGET YOU JUST HAVE
TO MAKE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
BUDGET RECOMMENDATIONS. WE WERE
CONSTRAINED BY NUMBER OF BOTH
FEDERAL AND STATE REQUIREMENTS-
WHILE ALSO TRYING TO MAXIMIZE
WHERE POSSIBLE FEDERAL FUNDS
I'M SO VERY CHALLENGING-
RECOMMENDATIONS WE HAD PUT
FORWARD. ON THEY INCLUDE
RECOMMENDATIONS- FOR
ELIMINATING ITEMS WITHIN BOTH
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT AND JANUARY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. OPTIONAL
BENEFITS OF RE PURPOSING PROP.
FIFTY SIX IN A VARIETY OF OTHER
REDUCTION I WALK. THE
DEPARTMENT DOES PUT FORWARD A
DECREASE OF TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS A GENERAL FUND
FOR THE FOLLOWING BUDGET
SOLUTION. A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND FROM
REVERTING FUNDS FROM PREVIOUS
AUGMENTATIONS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT. ON THESE
INCLUDE THE REVERSION OF THE
ENROLLMENT NAVIGATORS AND MEDIC
COW INTERPRETERS PILOT PROJECT.
ELIMINATION OF THE REMAINING
FUNDS FOR THE CAREGIVER
RESOURCES CENTER AUGMENTATION.
ELIMINATION OF FUNDING FOR THE
CAL HOP PROGRAM. AS WELL AS THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COUNSELORS
FOR THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
THERE IS ALSO A SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS RELATED TO PROPOSALS IN
THE JANUARY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
WHICH INCLUDES NOTABLY THE- CAL
AIM OR THE CALIFORNIA DANCING
IN INVADING MEDIC HELP FOR A
PROPOSAL. HERE I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN ENGAGING A WITH CMS
EXTENSIVELY IN REGARDS TO A ONE
YEAR EXTENSION OF OUR CURRENT
ELEVEN FIFTEEN WAIVER. THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING VERY
WELL- OUR PROPOSAL AND CMS DISK
HAVE BEEN AN AS IS EXTENSION
FOR ONE YEAR ARE PROPOSING WITH
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THAT
CORRESPONDING YEAR THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS TO
BE HAD WITH CMS AND DETAILS TO
BE DONE AND DISCUSSED. BUT DID
WANT TO GIVE YOU AN UPDATE
REGARDING OUR EXTENSION WE DO
SEE THE CONVERSATIONS VERY
PROMISING AS THEY HAD
RECOMMENDED WITH THE NINETEEN
FIFTEEN B. SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH LABOR THAT IS CURRENTLY
UP. FOR RENEWAL- THAT THEY
RECOMMENDED WE EXTEND THAT
THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO ALIGNED
WITH OUR PROPOSED ELEVEN
FIFTEEN ONE YEAR EXTENSION.
WELL THIS WILL BE CRITICAL IN
ORDER TO YOU GIVE PROVIDERS I'M
IN MANAGED CARE PLANS TIME- I
HAD TO GET THROUGH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND TO BE
PREPARED FOR THE- THE CALLIN
PROPOSAL ON DOWN THE LINE AS
WELL AS- THE EXTENSION OF
ELEVEN FIFTEEN. IT ITEM AND
DEAL. OF THE BASIC HEALTH
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM- ON
THE POSTPARTUM MENTAL HEALTH
EXPANSION. AGE BLIND AND
DISABLED FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
INCREASED AS WELL AS THE
MEDICARE PART D. DISREGARD. THE
UNDOCUMENTED OLDER ADULTS
ELIGIBILITY EXPANSION THE THREE
FORTY B. SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT
TOOL. AND THEN THE WITHDRAWING
OF THE- HEARING AID GRANT
PROGRAM FOR NON MEDICAL
CHILDREN UP TO 6100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO PUT FORWARD A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND- RELATED TO
ELIMINATING VARIOUS ADULT
OPTIONAL MEDICARE BENEFITS. I'M
I WON'T READ THEM THEY ARE
AVAILABLE WITHIN OUR- SUMMARY
ON ONE NOTABLE ITEM WOULD BE ON
THE REVERSION OF ADULT DENTAL
SERVICES FROM CURRENT FULL
RESTORATION. A REVERTING TO THE
TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN
RESTORATION LEVELS- WE WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THE ELIMINATION
OF THE MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ADULT SERVICES PROGRAM
BOTH OF WHICH ARE CONSIDERED
OPTIONAL BENEFITS. I WOULD NOTE
THAT ANY OPTIONAL BENEFITS
REDUCTIONS DO NOT APPLY TO
CHILDREN OR EPS U. G. BENEFITS
BENEFICIARIES IN LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES. SEE RELATED
SERVICES EMERGENCY AND HOSPITAL
BASED SERVICES AS WELL AS THEY
WILL MAINTAIN. TO BE AVAILABLE
WITHIN FQHCS. THE NEXT PORTION
OF PROPOSED SAVINGS IS I'M A
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND TO REDIRECT-
PROPERTY SIX REVENUES TO OFFSET
GENERAL FUND COSTS WITH THE
MEDICAL CASE WOULD GROW. I'LL
BE THE LIMITATIONS INCLUDE
ELIMINATING SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS FOR PHYSICIANS- DENTAL
OFFICES A DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS AND NON EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION. YES
FAMILY PLANNING AND WOMEN'S
HEALTH AS WELL AS THE BASS AND
I. C. F. T. D. IMMENSE. IT ALSO
PROPOSES TO ELIMINATE THE VALUE
BASED PAYMENT PROGRAM. AND THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INTEGRATION
PROGRAM. IT ALSO PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE THE PHYSICIAN AND
DENIS LOAN REPAYMENTS FOR
COHORT TWO THROUGH FIVE I WOULD
NOTE. THAT WE ARE STILL
COMMITTED TO THE- APPROPRIATION
THAT HAS BEEN GIVEN TO COHORT
ONE AND CONTINUE THOSE PAYMENTS
OR CO HOST ONE THROUGH THE FIVE
YEAR PERIOD AS COMMITTED TO.
THERE IS A REDUCTION FOR TRAUMA
SCREENING AND TRAUMA PROVIDER
TRAINING AND THERE IS NO CHANGE
IN PROPERTIES SIX RELATED TO
HOME HEALTH. PEDIATRIC DAY
HEALTH CARE CENTERS
FREESTANDING PEDIATRIC SUB
ACUTE AND THE HIV AND AIDS
WAIVER ADJUSTMENTS. THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO PUT FORWARD
RATE REDUCTIONS IN PROGRAM
EFFICIENCIES EQUAL TO THREE
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION GENERAL
FUND- FOR A VARIETY OF.
PROGRAMS I WON'T MENTION ALL OF
THEM BUT WILL NOTABLY MANSION
INCLUDES A REDUCED- MANAGED
CARE CAPITATION RATE OF ONE
POINT 5% FOR THE BRIDGE PERIOD-
WHICH INCLUDES JULY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. YOUR
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY IT
ALSO INCLUDES IMPLEMENTING A
RISK CORRIDOR- BUT FOR THE SAME
TIME PERIOD- WITHIN THE MANAGED
CARE PLAN I WOULD NOTICE THE
RISK CORRIDOR IS NOT SCORED
WITHIN THE BUDGET- AS IT WOULD
I'M NOT WE WOULD NOT RECEIVE
THE CASH OR CASH BUDGET INTEL
BUDGETYOUR PLUS YOU. IT ALSO
PROPOSES THE ELIMINATION OF PPS
CARVED OUT FOR ACCURACY'S I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF OTHER FAN OF FUND
TRANSFERS AND RECOVERIES. I'M
NOT EQUAL TO THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION GENERAL FUND
WITHIN THE BUDGET MOST NOTABLY
THE REAR- IMPOSING THE MEDI CAL
ESTATE RECOVERY PROGRAM. OTHER
BUDGET ITEMS ON THEIR OTHER
CANDIDATES YOU OTHER KEY
FACTORS WITHIN THE MEDIC HOW
BUDGETS- TO MAKE NOTE OF A
DECREASE OF ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION GENERAL FUNDS FROM THE
RECENTLY APPROVED MCO TAX. ON
THAT OFFSETS THE GENERAL FUND
WITHIN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TIME PERIOD AS WELL AS AN
INCREASE OF ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION GENERAL FUND SHORT TERM
FEDERAL FUNDS AND THAT IS
ESTIMATED. FOR INAPPROPRIATELY
CLAIMING VARIOUS FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR STATE ON THE PROGRAM. I GO
INTO DETAIL ON THAT IN A LITTLE
BIT ON THE QUESTION. THE FAMILY
HEALTH ESTIMATE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT FAMILY HEALTH ESTIMATED
PROGRAM EXPENDITURES ARE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IN CURRENT YEAR
AND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR. I'M
OVERALL FAMILY HEALTH- ESTIMATE
SHE'S LOADS ARE PROJECTED TO
REMAIN RELATIVELY STABLE OR
EXPERIENCED MINOR GROWTH-
NOTABLE ITEMS WITHIN-
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES WITHIN THE
FAMILY HEALTH OR OUR QUEUE
ITEMS ONLY TO NOTE. ON CURRENT
YEAR INCLUDE SAVINGS BASED ON
ACTUAL RETROACTIVE COLLECTIONS
OF NON BLOOD- NONE OF BLOOD
DOCTOR REBATE READ- BUT DOCTOR
DRUG REBATES SORRY ABOUT THAT-
DOES YOUR SCORED THROUGH APRIL
OF TWENTY TWENTY AND INCLUDED
IN CURRENT YEAR HOWEVER WOULD
NOTE THAT THERE ARE NO WE BIG
COLLECTIONS CURRENTLY INCLUDED
IN BUDGET. HERE FOR EVERY WOMAN
COUNTS- CURRENT YOUR ALTHOUGH
DOWN FROM THE NOVEMBER
ESTIMATE. ON IS UP SLIGHTLY
HIGHER ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
I'M IN THIS DISTRIBUTED TO
INCLUDING AN MRI IS AN MRI
GUIDED BIOPSIES WITHIN EVERY
WOMAN COUNTS PROGRAM. WHICH IS
A FEDERAL REQUIREMENT. NEXT I
WILL GO OVER VERY KOBE EXPENSE
EXPENSES THAT WERE PUT IN THE
BUDGET IN REGARDS TO OUR
RESPONSE TO COPE WITH HERE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. I'M QUOTED AND-
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE FEDERAL
AND STATE DECLARATIONS OF
EMERGENCY DID TRIGGER A LARGE
NUMBER OF AVAILABLE MEDICAID
FLEXIBILITY IS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT SPEAKS FOR.
ADDITIONALLY THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED A MAJOR FEDERAL
LEGISLATION THAT PROVIDES
INCREASED FEDERAL FUNDING TO
THE MEDICAID PROGRAM. AND
CREATES NEW OPTIONS FOR US TO
ADDRESS THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WITHIN OUR PROGRAM.
THE FIRST NOTABLE ONE AS
MENTIONED BEFORE WAS THE
EMERGENCY F. MAP IMPACT I'M I
WOULD JUST MAKE SURE IT'S
NOTATED THAT H. R. SIXTY ONE
DOES INCREASE THE AFTERMATH ON
A REGULAR MEDICAID 50% AND
EXPENDITURES BY SIX. PERCENT
BUT THEN SHIPPED BY FOUR POINT
34% ON THIS BEGINS IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY- IT WILL LAST
IN THE LAST DAY OF THE CALENDAR
QUARTER IN WHICH THE NATIONAL
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND-
EMERGENCY F. MAP IS ASSUMED IN
THE BUDGET TO. REMOVE JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FOR DH CS DH YES OTHER ADMIN
AND FOR OTHER SISTER
DEPARTMENTS AS APPROPRIATE AND
IN ALIGNMENT WITH CMS'S
GUIDANCE IN REGARDS TO WHAT
THAT F. NOT APPLIED YOUR- THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO DID. RESULT ASK
FOR A REDUCTION OF THE
UTILIZATION WITHIN THE MEDICARE
FEE FOR SERVICE PROGRAM BOTH ON
THE MEDICAL AND DENTAL SIDE. IN
RESPONSE YOU COULD BE NINETEEN
THE DEPARTMENT HELP. I NEEDED
THREE ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE WAIVER
REQUEST YOU C. M. S. ONE
EMERGENCY ELEVEN FIFTEEN WAIVER
REQUEST AND ONE DISASTER STATE
PLAN AMENDMENT RULING OVER FIVE
DOZEN FLEXIBILITIES ARE FOR THE
STATE DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ARE THESE
FLEXIBILITIES SPANNED OVER A
NUMBER OF AREAS. INCLUDING
PROVIDER PARTICIPATION BUILDING
IN CONDITION FOR PAYMENT-
INCLUDE FLEXIBILITIES FOR
AUTHORIZATION AND UTILIZATION
CONTROLS STATE FAIR HEARINGS
BENEFIT FLEXIBILITIES
TELEHEALTH AND TELEPHONIC
EXPANSION CAME IT RAINS AND
VARIOUS ADMINISTRATIVE
FLEXIBILITY- SOME OF THE WAIVER
FLEXIBILITIES ADOPTED ROLE WILL
ROLL BACK IMMEDIATELY UPON THE
CLOSURE OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
PERIOD HOWEVER SOME MOST
NOTABLE ARE THE TELEHEALTH THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE LOOKING AT
HOW WE SHOULD ADJUST ITS POLICY
ON TELEHEALTH IS SHOWN TO BE-
TO HAVE A LOT OF POTENTIAL AND
INCREASING ACCESS TO CARE FOR
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS OF THE STATE IN EXPANDING
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR
PRIMARY AND SPECIALTY CARE.
WITH SUCH A RAPID ADOPTION OF
TELEHEALTH SERVICES WE WANT TO
LEARN FROM IT YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHEN IT WORKS WE WANT TO KNOW
WHEN IT DOESN'T WORK- AND WHEN
IT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE WHILE
MAINTAINING QUALITY OF CARE IN
INCREASING ACCESS- SO WE WILL
BE SPENDING TIME TO ANALYZE
THIS NEW DOCTOR EVEN HAD
CONVERSATIONS RECENTLY WITH
BOTH COVERED CALIFORNIA AND
CALPERS. BUT WE CAN ALL LEARN
TOGETHER IN REGARDS TO THE
EXPANSION OF TELEHEALTH.
SERVICES FOR THE FUTURE. IT IS
A BIT ESPECIALLY IN EVENINGS IN
AND WE CAN. I'M AS WELL AS THE
WEEK DAY IT COULD BE REDUCED
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS AND
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR US TO EXPLORE THIS. I WOULD
NOTE THAT MEDICARE HOW TELL
HELP PAYMENT PARITY FOR THE
TELE HEALTH PORTION- PRIOR TO
KOBE WOULD KOBE DID IS BRING
THE PARITY FOR THE TELEPHONIC
HE'S A BIT. AND THEN WE WOULD
NEED TO EXPLORE THAT POLICY
AFTER THE EMERGENCY THE BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW WOULD INCREASE
ACCESS TO CARE AND SERVICES. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WHILE WE
HAD PARITY WITHIN P. FOR
SERVICE WE NEED TO EXPLORE WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE IN MANAGED
CARE. AS WELL AS WITH R. S.
WHICH THE PARTNERS IN ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SIDE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE- AN ETIQUETTE
ADEQUATE NETWORK ADEQUACY AFTER
THIS SURE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
SERVICES. THE PANDEMIC AND
AFTER I WOULD THERE ARE NUMBER.
KOBE RELATED EXPENSES SCORED IN
THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET- I WILL
JUST QUICKLY LIST THEM SO ODD
PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF THOSE. AND
THEN I WILL GO INTO RESPONDING
TO CERTAIN QUESTIONS THAT I
HAVE NOT GOTTEN THROUGH THROUGH
THIS OVER TO YOU. I'M SO I
DON'T SCORED IN THE BUDGET
INCLUDED ON A NEW ELIGIBILITY
GROUP FOR UNINSURED INDIVIDUALS
THIS COVERS TESTING TESTING
RELATED SERVICES AND CODE
NINETEEN TREATMENT. I WOULD
NOTICE THE KOBE NINETEEN
TREATMENT PORTION IS WITHIN THE
ELEVEN FIFTEEN WAIVER WHICH WE
ARE STILL WAITING FOR APPROVAL
FROM THE- FROM CMS. WE HAVE
RECEIVED APPROVAL FOR A
DISASTER SPOTS AND A LARGE
NUMBER OF THE ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE WAIVER REQUEST ALL OF
WHICH ARE POSTED ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S WEBSITE. WE SHARE
BROADLY THROUGH A WEEKLY
STAKEHOLDER UPDATE AT THE
DEPARTMENT SENT OUT WITH BOTH
GUIDANCE AND CMS APPROVAL TO
MAKE SURE STAKEHOLDERS
PROVIDERS. AND OTHERS ARE AWARE.
OF WHAT HAS AND HAS NOT BEEN
APPROVED. OTHER ITEMS AND THE
X. OF HOSPITAL PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY FOR SIXTY FIVE- AND
OVER. IT INCLUDES ALLOWING FOR
Q. HOSPITAL PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY PERIOD WITHIN A
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD. AND IT
COVERS ADULT OVER THE COUNTER
COUGH AND COLD MEDICINE. ALLOWS
FOR AN INCREASE FOR BOTH I HSS
AND WAIVER PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES FOR SICK LEAVE
BENEFITS ALLOWED. ON THROUGH
VARIOUS. FEDERAL BILLS. AS WELL
AS THE CLINICAL LAB
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AT MEDICARE
RATES I JUST. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PAYMENTS TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
INCREASING CASH FLOW TO OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS. UPPER BEHAVIOR
HELP HIM IS BOTH ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SIDE. A 10% RATE
INCREASE FOR LONG TERM CARE-
INCLUDING VARIOUS OTHER ITEMS
WITHIN THE ELEVEN FIFTEEN I'M
CURRENTLY HAVE BEEN APPROVED.
OUR SUPPORT WITHIN THE BUDGET
AS WELL. THERE IS OUR HIGHLAND
WALKS OF BOTH- MEDIC HOW LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND FAMILY HELPED US
CEMENT- AS WELL AS KOBE
NINETEEN ESTIMATED IMPACTS- I
ANSWERED A HANDFUL OF THE
QUESTIONS THROUGH THAT ABUSE
BUT THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAD
ON. THAT YOU PROPOSED TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO WALK THROUGH. BUT
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS WHICH I
HAVEN'T ADDRESSED YET IS HOW
THE DEPARTMENT- PLANS TO FOCUS
ON THE MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS- AND WHAT THEY WILL
UNDERTAKE TO PRESERVE NETWORKS
AN ADEQUATE ACCESS TO PROVIDERS
DURING THIS TIME. ONE THING I
WOULD JUST NOTE IS THAT YOURS
DOES HAS BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
TO MONITOR OUR MANAGED CARE
PLANS NETWORKS. DAILY REPORTING
BY THE PLANS PLANS ALREADY WERE
REQUIRED TO REPORT TO US EVERY
DAY. ON ANY PHYSICIAN OFFICES
OR FACILITY CLOSURES EVEN IF
THEY ARE TEMPORARY CLOSURES OR
CONSOLIDATION CLOSERS.
SIMILARLY TO WHAT YOU HEARD.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. IN A MARCH
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS REPORTED THE
TEMPORARY CLOSURES AND-
CONSOLIDATION OF SOME CLINICS
IN PROVIDER OFFICES. WHICH
RESULTED IN DECREASED
UTILIZATION OF SERVICES DUE TO
THE POSTPONEMENT ELECTIVE
PROCEDURES EMERGING SERVICES.
DEPARTMENT DIRECTLY WORK WITH
THOSE MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
ENSURE THOSE INDIVIDUALS WOULD
HAVE ACCESS. TO ALTERNATIVE
CARE WHETHER THAT IS TELEHEALTH
SERVICES. WERE REDIRECTED TO
OTHER PRIMARY CARE LOCATIONS-
DURING THIS TIME PERIOD ALL
MANAGED CARE PLANS HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY RESPONSIVE. TO
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
ADDRESS ADEQUATE ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND TO ENSURE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
LANCER COURTS- MEMBERS IMPACTS-
BY THESE CLOSURES- ON ON A
DAILY BASIS TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
ALREADY MENTIONED THAT
PARTICULAR PIECE. ONE THIRTY
YEARS YES WILL CONTINUE TO
REQUIRE PLANS TO REPORT ON
NETWORK AVAILABILITY BEYOND
ABOVE THEIR CURRENT CONTRACTUAL
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
PLANS ARE MEETING. PERFORMANCE
LEVELS THIS WILL GO ON I'M
INCLUDING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE TRACKING NOT JUST THE-
DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE- PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY BUT ALSO ANY
OF THE BUDGET- IMPACTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PUT FORWARD.
THEY WILL HAVE AN INCREASED
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR BOTH
NETWORK ADEQUACY MEMBER
GRIEVANCES I'M AS WELL AS
OUTRAGED MEMBERS TO PROVIDE
FOCUS ON ACCESS TO CARE. I
WOULD NOTATE THAT- A LARGE
NUMBER OF MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS HAVE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
SUPPORT FOR PROVIDERS. DURING
THE PANDEMIC INCLUDING.
PROVIDING ADVANCED EVENTS FOR
PROVIDERS ACCELERATING PAY FOR
PERFORMANCE IN INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS. TO PROVIDERS
ADVANCING CAPITATION OR CLAIMS
PAYMENT. ON IS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE WAVING PUBLIC HOSPITAL
RATE RANGE FEES AND EXPEDITING
INTERGOVERNMENTAL TRANSFER
PAYMENTS. ON ENHANCING RATES OR
EXPANDING INCENTIVES FOR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
PROVIDING VARIOUS GRANTS
PROVIDERS. AS WELL AS FUNDING
PROVIDERS FOR THE PURCHASE OF
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
ON DCS IS ALSO WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH C. A MASTER
REQUEST AND- PROVIDE
INFORMATION FOR THE
DISTRIBUTION OF KERR'S ACT
FUNDING TO MEDICARE PROVIDERS.
WHICH HAS NOT BEEN DISTRIBUTED
YEAH. ONE OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ASKED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DISCUSS- IS
B. ELIMINATION OF BERRIES HOLLY
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS MOST
NOTABLY- M. S. S. P. AND C.
BASS I'M GIVEN THE CHALLENGING
TIMES WITH THE COLD OUTBREAKS
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMPLETELY
UNDERSTANDS THAT THESE
PROPOSALS WERE VERY DIFFICULT
TO PUT FORWARD. WITH THE
ELIMINATION OF BOTH SEA BASS
AND M. S. S. P. A G. H. C. S.
WOULD COMPLETE A FULL
TRANSITION PLAN FOR BOTH OF
THESE PROGRAMS WHICH WOULD
ALLOW FOR TRANSITION OF THOSE
BENEFICIARIES TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE GETTING THE SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED- THIS WOULD
INCLUDE. EXISTING MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS AS WELL AS
OTHER ACA H. CBS PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE AVAILABLE WITHIN OUR
PROGRAM. I'M MOST NOTABLY I
WOULD MENTION THAT INDIVIDUALS
WHICH THE MAJORITY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS AND BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ENROLLED IN
MEDICAID MANAGED CARE. YOU HAVE
ACCESS YOU- ENHANCED CASE
MANAGEMENT AND CARE
COORDINATION- AS WELL AS
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
ASSESSMENTS TO ENSURE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ASSESSED AND
NEEDS. ARE BEING MET. THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
NURSE ADVICE LINES AS WELL AS
FULL SERVICES INCLUDING
DIETITIAN PHYSICIAN SOCIAL
WORKER NURSING PHARMACY
ETCETERA WITHIN THE MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLAN BENEFITS.
THEY WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
COORDINATING THOSE SERVICES FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL THE HELP. ALLOW
THEM TO SAFELY RESIDE IN THE
COMMUNITY- WE ALSO THEY WOULD
ALSO HAVE AVAILABLE TO THEM- IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ARE I.
JUST A SERVICE THEN. AND WE
WOULD MAKE AVAILABLE AS
NECESSARY OTHER HOME AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE WAIVER
PROGRAMS INCLUDING. BUT NOT
LIMITED TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONS PROGRAM.
ON V. H. C. B. A. OR THE HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ALTERNATIVES WAIVER ASSISTED
LIVING WAIVER THE PEACE
PROGRAMS- AND IN CERTAIN AREAS
THE MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS
PILOT PROGRAM THAT DOES EXIST.
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT AND-
HOWEVER I WANTED A LONG TO KIND
OF WALK THROUGH ANOTHER
PROPOSAL THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN WORKING ON- IT WAS
JUST ANNOUNCED YESTERDAY- SORRY
FRIDAY. THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES THE DEPARTMENT
OF. AGING AS WELL AS AGENCY I'M
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON SURGE CAPACITY WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON. I'M
DECOMPRESSING BOTH HOSPITALS
AND SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
DURING THE PANDEMIC. INTRUDERS
CONVERSATIONS FOR THE LAST
MONTH AND A HALF OR SO WE'VE
REALLY BEEN BRAINSTORMING ON
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THIS THIS
CURRENT ISSUE. IN SO- THAT WE
HAVE PUT FORWARD ON IT WILL BE
EXPLORING A NEW BENEFIT WITHIN
MEDICARE OUT- IT IS SOMETHING
WE ARE CALLING TO LONG TERM
CARE AT HOME BENEFITS. ON AND
IT WOULD BE. ABLE TO PROVIDE
I'M ELIGIBLE CONSUMERS WITH A
COORDINATED AND BUNDLED SET OF
SERVICES TO HELP- OLDER ADULT
INDIVIDUAL STAY HOME AND BE
HEALTHY. IT WOULD BE AVAILABLE
IN BOTH THE FIRST SERVICE AND
IN MANAGED CARE- THERE ARE A
LOT OF DETAILS TO BE FIGURED
OUT WITH THIS PROPOSAL- AND WE
JUST KNOW THAT WE PLAN ON
ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH THIS
PROCESS- BUT WHEN I WALK
THROUGH JUST. A FEW OF THE
DETAILS TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE AWARE OF THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL AS WE ARE. AND
DISSECTING IT AT THIS TIME. THE
TARGET PARKING. WERE INCLUDE
SHORT SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
STAYS SO SOMEONE TRANSITIONING
FROM HOSPITAL TO HOME. AND IN
THOSE PARTICULAR AREAS WOULD
INVOLVE ADDITIONAL THERAPY IN
CLINICAL SERVICES. AND ALSO
WOULD INCLUDE LOW ACUITY
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY STAYS
LONG TERM. STAYS ON AS WELL AS
PREVENTING SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY STAYS. ON I WOULD NOTE
THIS MODEL IS DESIGNED FOR HOME
CARE WITH RAP SERVICES BOTH
MEDICAL AND COMMUNITY BASED BUT
IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
TRANSITIONS. BUT THAT THAT
LIVING FACILITIES SUCH AS
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES.
FOR THE ELDERLY ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES OR
BOARDING CHAIR IT IS A SPECIFIC
BENEFIT FOR HOME BASED MAKES
SENSE. HELLO TERM CARE HOME
BENEFIT WOULD INCLUDE-
INDIVIDUAL PERSON CENTRED
ASSESSMENTS TRANSITION CARE
MANAGEMENT AND OF COURSE THE
BUNDLED MEDICAL AND HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. AND
TO HELP THEM RESIDE SAFELY
WITHIN THEIR HOME. AS SO MANY
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE HARD DECISIONS I'M HAVING
OPTIONS THAT ALLOW INDIVIDUALS
TO- RESIDE IN THEIR HOME I WILL
BE CRITICAL AS WE CONTINUE
THROUGH. ON THIS A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. I WOULD NOTE
THAT THE MEDICAL SERVICES WOULD
INCLUDE SOMETHING SIMILAR TO
YOU AND IT'S THE WAY WE ARE
TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE THINK
ABOUT IT YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT
BUNDLING THIS VERY DIFFERENTLY
THAN WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN WITHIN
OUR BEER YES HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED WAIVERS OR EVEN THE WAY
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT IT WITH A
LOT OF SERVICES. ON IN OUR
PREVIOUS CALLIN PROPOSAL THIS
STEP BACK TO LOOK AT A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY WHERE WE WOULD
PROPOSE A HOSPICE LIKE BENEFIT
MINUS AND THE WIFE OF COURSE ON
THAT ALLOWS A BUNDLED PAYMENTS-
TO AN AGENCY TO PROVIDE ALL OF
THE RICH THE CORRESPONDING.
SERVICES I'M NOT. THE DIRECTOR
JUST A THAT PREVIOUS CRY THIS
BAND. CAN YOU JUST TELL US WE-
DO YOU. I MEAN IS THIS YOU'RE-
GOING TO IMPLEMENT THIS COMING
FISCAL YEAR OR- JUST TIME
TIMELINE WISE. YEAH SO- BE
WILLING OUR PROPOSAL IS TO DO
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT FOR THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS OR THROUGH THE
END OF JULY EXTENSIVELY
DEFEATED UP INPUTS THE METER.
IT THEN WITH CMS THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY GET RESPECTIVE
APPROVALS WITH THE GOAL OF
APPROVAL FROM CMS. WHERE TO GO
LIVE IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WE DO KNOW THAT AGGRESSIVE
BECAUSE WE DO WANT THE AGENCY
TO BE A LICENSED ENTITY WE HAVE
TO WORK WITH PUBLIC HEALTH TO
BE VERY AGGRESSIVE IN REGARDS
TO THOSE TIME LINES. BUT THAT
IS CURRENTLY. WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING FROM A TIME LINE. IT
IS THAT INCORPORATED INTO THE
MAY BUDGET PROPOSAL OR- WE ARE
NOT CLOSING THAT THIS WOULD BE
COST NEUTRAL GIVEN THE SAVINGS-
THAT WE WOULD HAVE. FROM
REMOVING OR TRANSITIONING
INDIVIDUALS FROM SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND ARE
PREVENTING. A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY STATE SO IT WOULD BE A
BUDGET NEUTRAL OUR PROPOSAL
OKAY WELL I'D- GIVEN THE LENGTH
OF TIME AND I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS GOING ON P. C. S.
I JUST WANT YOU KNOW. I THINK
IF IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
COMING UP AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION I HOPE THAT- BETWEEN
NOW AND LET'S SEE I GUESS THAT
WILL HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITY
EXPLORE SOME OF THESE THINGS
AND I'M SURE THAT. STAKEHOLDERS
ONE AWAY AND IT'S- NOT ONLY
WITH YOUR DEPARTMENT WITH US
ABOUT AS WELL SO I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR- DESCRIPTION
BUT I PROBABLY GONNA ASK THAT.
TRY TO KEEP IT ABBRVIATED AND
THEN TRY TO COVER THE REST OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU. YES ON THE LINE TO
THE NEXT QUESTIONS. I'M IN YES
AND HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS-
TO CONTINUE TO EXPLORE THAT WE
DID WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GAVE A
FULL DESCRIPTION OF IT TODAY AS
WE HAD JUST ANNOUNCED ON
FRIDAY. AND SO IN REGARDS TO
YOUR NEXT QUESTION FOR THE RISK
ORDER PROPOSED- WITHIN THE
BUDGET. IT WOULD BE FOR THE
BRIDGE. IT WOULD INCLUDE A TWO
SIDED AND SYMMETRICAL WHICH
MEANS. THAT BOTH MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE EQUALLY
PROTECTED AGAINST BOTH EXCEPT
THE- PLAN GAINS AND LOSSES. IT
IT WOULD BE CHEERED ON AND HAVE
A NUMBER OF COMPONENTS- IT
WOULD BOTH APPLY TO THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS AS WELL JUST
WANNA MAKE. SURE THAT THAT IT
IS NOTED AS WELL. I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE- CS WOULD BE.
WOULD BEGIN COLLECTING DATA FOR
THE RISK CORRIDOR NO SOONER
THAN JANUARY ONE. IN ORDER TO
ALLOW FOR ADEQUATE TIME FOR THE
PLAN TO BE ABLE TO REPORT SUCH
INFORMATION. I'M CLAIMS REPORT
OUT SO IT HAS A LONGER TIME
PERIOD ON IT. MOVING ONTO YOUR
NEXT QUESTION IN REGARDS TO THE
RATIONALE FOR PROCEEDING WITH
THE MEDIC HOW ARE EX PHARMACY
KERR OUTS. IN MAINTAINING. IN
WITHDRAWING THE SUPPLEMENTAL
AND HE MEANT FOR THE NON
HOSPITAL THREE FORTY B. AND B.
OVERALL PROPOSAL ON FROM
INSPECTION RESULTS IN GENERAL
FUND SAVINGS. FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR ALSO SEATED WITH POLICY
CHANGES RELATED TO THE PROPOSAL
ON THE GENERATE SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS. WITHIN THE BUDGET
YOU'RE IN OUT YEARS ESTIMATE ON
ANYWHERE FROM THREE TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
GENERAL FUNDS BABY. I'M NO
JEANETTE REVENUE LOSSES FOR THE
I'M NOT HOSPITAL THREE FORTY
CLINICS HOWEVER GIVEN THE CODE
NIGHT PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
IN OVERALL ECONOMIC SITUATION.
ON THE ADMINISTRATION HAD TO
MAKE SOME TOUGH DECISIONS IN
REGARDS TO MEETING THE BUDGET
SHORTFALLS. AND THEREFORE I'M
DCS REMAINS REALLY COMMITTED TO
HAVING CONVERSATIONS- WITH
IMPACTED PARTIES AND THE
ROLLOUT TO ENSURE A SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION. TO MEDICARE RACKS-
COME JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE NEXT I ON HAS TO DO
WITH THE NEW BECAUSE A REFORM I
WOULD JUST NOTE WE HAVE
RELEASED OUR TRAILER BELOW ON
THIS- STAKEHOLDER CONSENSUS IS-
IS. SOMEWHAT MIXED THOUGH WE
ARE STILL TALKING THROUGH A LOT
OF CONVERSATIONS WITH PEOPLE WE
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH APPS ON
THE FRAMEWORK ON AN OVERALL
APPROACH- THERE'S STILL A LOT
OF WORK TO BE DONE IN REGARDS
TO YOU IDENTIFYING QUALITY
METRICS AND BENCHMARKS. ON THE
ONE PIECE I WOULD JUST NOTE-
FOR SOME STAKEHOLDERS- I THINK
THAT IT IS- A LOT TO TRANSITION
FROM THE PREVIOUS KIND OF COST
ALL PAYMENTS TO QUALITY ADD
ON'S. ESPECIALLY SINCE WE DON'T
KNOW WHICH METRICS- AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND EXPLAIN
THE FRAMEWORK AND THE FACT THAT
MOVING TO QUALITY OVER COST-
WHICH IS DESIGNED TO BE VERY
PATIENT FOCUSED THIS THIS. IS
THE GOAL OF THE DEPARTMENT AT
THIS TIME. YOUR NEXT QUESTION
HAS TO DO WITH THE PROCEEDING-
WITH THE ELIMINATION OF THE
DENTAL MANAGED CARE- AND DURING
THIS THIS CALL THAT TIME
PERIOD. THE DEPARTMENT
RECOGNIZES THE CHALLENGE. YOUR
OVERALL KIND OF DELIVERY SYSTEM
IN PARTICULAR WITH DENTAL
SERVICES DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY- AND JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE WE NOTE THAT-
HOWEVER WE STILL- PROPOSED. TO
TRANSITION AWAY FROM DENTAL
MANAGED CARE DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD ESPECIALLY. AS WE HAVE
SEEN AND- OVER TIME AND
RECOGNIZE THAT- THE SERVICES
PROVIDED. I'M IN THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE AREA I'M LAG
BEHIND WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN OUR
FEE FOR SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. THE DEPARTMENT RELEASED
A TRANSITION PLAN FOR COMMENTS
OF STAKEHOLDERS. EARLIER THIS
MONTH- AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING PEOPLE'S COMMENTS ON
THAT. I'M MOST NOTABLY I WOULD
NOTE THAT ON THROUGH THAT
EVALUATION AND TRANSITION PLAN.
HE SAYS THERE IS A PRETTY
EXTENSIVE OVERLAP WITH EACH OF
THE FIRST SERVICE DENTAL
PROVIDERS AND THE MANAGED CARE
PROVIDERS- BUT THE DEPARTMENT
IS VERY COMMITTED- THAT THROUGH
THIS TRANSITION ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THE- A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH BOTH PROVIDERS AND
BENEFICIARIES- WE WOULD DO
BENEFICIARY NOTIFICATIONS FAQS
PROVIDER TRAININGS. IN
ENROLLMENT WHERE- THERE'S AN
OVERLAP FOR EXAMPLE IN
SACRAMENTO THERE'S 99% OVERLAP
WITH OUR FUTURE. GENERAL
PROVIDERS IN 85% IN LOS ANGELES
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD BE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THOSE
PROVIDERS IN COMMUNICATING.
VERY CLEARLY. TO BENEFICIARIES
DURING THIS TRANSITION. ON THE
NEW ITEM THAT I WILL AND IS
QUESTIONS REGARDS TO THE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS RELATED
TO FEDERAL CLAIMING. ON
CALIFORNIA PROVIDE STATE ONLY
FULL SCOPE- SERVICES TO CERTAIN
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS WHO MEET
ALL MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THEIR IMMIGRATE IMMIGRATION
STATUS. I'M UNDER THE STATE
ONLY A MEDICARE PROGRAMS
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE ONLY ALLOWED
TO BE USED FOR EMERGENCY AND
PREGNANCY RELATED SERVICES. AND
NON EMERGENCY AND NON PREGNANCY
RELATED SERVICES ARE COVERED
WITH THE STATE GENERAL FUNDS.
ON THE DEPARTMENT ID AT THE
DEPARTMENT IDENTIFIED A SYSTEM
ERROR- FOR CERTAIN DELIVERY
SYSTEMS I WHERE WE WERE DRYING
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS FOR NON
EMERGENCY AND NON PREGNANCY
RELATED. SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUIRED TO
RETURN THESE FEDERAL FUNDS TO
CMS- THAT WERE CLAIMED I'M
WITHIN A YEAR OF IDENTIFYING
THOSE PIECES. FURTHERMORE THE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO SEEK
FEDERAL APPROVAL FOR A GENERAL
FUND FEDERAL FUND PERCENT
PROXY. FOR MANAGED CARE
CAPITATION PAYMENTS TO INSURERS
ON ALL NECESSARY FISCAL
INTEGRITY. MEASURES HAVE BEEN
PUT IN PLACE. I DO UNDERSTAND-
THAT THIS IS A LARGE ADJUSTMENT
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY IN
DEFICIT BEFORE THAT- AND THE
DEPARTMENT- HAS TAKEN MULTIPLE
STEPS TO MITIGATE THE RISK IN
THE FUTURE. I'M I WOULD JUST
POINT OUT A FEW OF THEM- AS WE
ARE CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON OUR
SYSTEMS AND OUR OUR- OVERSIGHT
OF OUR FISCAL ON AREAS OF THE
DEPARTMENT. AND THE DEPARTMENT
DID CREATE THIS YEAR I KNEW-
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
POSITION REPORTING DIRECTLY TO
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND PROGRAM WE ALSO HAVE
REORGANIZED TO ALLOW THE
BEHAVIOR OUT FINANCING
FUNCTIONS. COME UNDER THE I'M A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
FINANCES ALL OF THESE ARE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION. TO OUR FINANCES WE
HAVE A VERY KEEN EYE ON THE
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT I'M
HOWEVER GIVEN THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF ON THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM- WE KNOW THAT THERE
WILL BE ERRORS AND SOMETIMES
UNFORTUNATELY THE SIZE OF OUR
PROGRAM MEANS THAT SMALL ERRORS
DO YOU HAVE A PRETTY LARGE-
PHYSICAL CONSEQUENCE. THE
DEPARTMENT IS VERY FOCUSED ON
UPDATING SYSTEMS MAKING SURE
THAT SYSTEMS ARE- ALLOWING FOR
US TO BE SIX- IN OUR FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT I'M MOVING FORWARD
AND STAY COMMITTED TO
IDENTIFYING AND FIXING ERRORS.
THEY ARE IDENTIFIED. BUT NOW I
WILL HAND IT OFF TO- DOCTOR
GILBERT ON THE DIRECTORS WHO
WILL ANSWER THE LAST QUESTION
IN REGARDS TO I. T. I'M IN ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS. FROM HIM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU J. C. DR
PAM MEMBERS OF THE THING YOU
AND GOOD MORNING SO I'M GONNA
ANSWER NUMBER THIRTEEN AND THEN
HAVE SOME JUST GENERAL COMMENTS
ON SHORT AND BRIEF ABOUT WHAT
IS PRESENTED. SO I THINK THE
COMMITTEE IS PROBABLY WELL
AWARE THAT WE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
THINK DIFFERENTLY ABOUT THE
DESPERATE- IT PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE THE T. H. YES AS YOU KNOW
THE DEPARTMENT AND N. C. M. S.
ARE VERY FOCUSED ON REALLY
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT MODERN
TECHNOLOGY IS USED AROUND. THE
MEDICAL RECORDS MEDICAL PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA BUT JUST TO
REMIND WE HAVE RELEASED THREE
BIG AREAS OF PROGRAMS OF THE
MEDICAID MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEMS OTHERWISE KNOWN AS MMI
US IN ROMANS AND ELIGIBILITY
SYSTEMS IN OUR HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY FOR.
ECONOMIC CLINICAL THEY'RE HIGH
TECH AND REALLY THE GOAL HAS
BEEN TO MERGE THOSE TOGETHER
INTO THIS MEDICAL ENTERPRISE
SYSTEM OR ANYTHING ELSE YOU
THINK ABOUT IT AS AN OVERALL
SYSTEM OF SUCH SYSTEMS WITH
COMPONENTS AND MODULES AS PART
OF THAT BUT THE IDEA BEING.
THAT IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT AS
AN OVERALL. IT'S A PROGRAM
CHEAPER. YOU LOOK AT A MUCH
WORSE USE OF RESOURCE JOINT IS
TO FUNCTION ONE. AND YOUR-
DON'T LOOK AT IT AS A SERIES OF
MODULES AND PROGRAMMES UNDER AN
UMBRELLA. AS YOU WELL KNOW DHS
AND MEDICAL INCREDIBLY COMPLEX
WE HAVE SOME VERY OLD SYSTEMS-
SOME AS OLD AS FORTY YEARS AGO
WHICH SORT OF BOGGLES THE MIND
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT. I MEAN
I'M NOT GOING TO CONCERTS. WHAT
WE'VE DONE IS REST AGENCY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CALIFORNIA PHARMA TECHNOLOGY
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS REALLY
CONSOLIDATED OUR IT
MODERNIZATION FFORTS WHETHER
THAT'S MEANT TO MODERNIZATION
M. I. S. MODERNIZATION HEY
RALPH. DATA MODERNIZATION
ETCETERA REALLY LOOK AT IT FROM
AN ENTERPRISE APPROACH BOTH
FROM A PLANNING AND DELIVERY
POINT OF VIEW- THIS. ARE IS
GOING TO BE ON THE- LINE A
SMALLER. OF THE FEDERAL DRAWN
REPORTING EFFORT THAT IS- A
PROGRAM THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE DEPARTMENT-
WE DO A LOT OF PAPERWORK WAS
HERE LAST THIS WILL ALLOW FOR
IT NOT ONLY TO BE. WE NEVER
REALLY MODERNIZE BUT IN TERMS
OF GOING FORWARD YOU KNOW THE
BETTER REPORTING MUCH MORE
ABILITY TO PROGRAM AND ADAPT
AND ADOPT. ENGINES THAT ARE
NECESSARY WELL THAT'S REALLY
GOING TO BE OUR FOCUS- THERE
WILL BE SOME POTENTIAL DELAY OF
OTHER PROJECTS. THAT FDR AS THE
CALL IS GOING TO BE REALLY THE
FOCUS FOR HER I. T. IN TERMS OF
THE AMBIENCE. AND
MODERNIZATION. THIS YEAR. IN
TERMS OF GNERAL COMMENTS OF
COURSE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
AFTERWARDS- DOCTOR PIANO WANNA.
I JUST JUST EMPHASIZE- ONE AREA
OF THE J. C. TALKED ABOUT WHICH
IS WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IN
TERMS OF REALLY MAKING SURE
THAT. WE'RE MONITORING OUR
NETWORK AND SO IN TERMS OF WHAT
JC TALKED ABOUT THE DAILY
REPORTING. IMMEDIATE FEEDBACK
AND DISCUSSION WITH PLANS ABOUT
ANY CHANGES THAT THEY TELL US
ABOUT IN TERMS OF SAYING OUR
MEMBERS ARE TO BE CARED FOR
WHERE ARE THEY GONNA BE CARED
FOR. HOW ARE THEY GONNA BE
CARED FOR IT IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF OUR
MONITORING. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
YOU KNOW. REALLY EMPHASIZED
THAT THE MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS OF STEPPED UP. THEIR
PAYING CLAIMS VERY RAPIDLY WHEN
WE DID A SURVEY. THOSE THEY
RANGE FROM FIVE DAY CLEAN
CLAIMS OF COURSE AS A
SUBDIRECTORY ARE MENTIONED.
FIVE DAYS FIFTEEN DAYS TWENTY
DAYS AMERICAN ALLIES ON A
TIGHTER- TIME FRAME AND THEN
THE GENERAL TIME FRAME UNDER
KNOCKS KEEN. THAT'S BEEN A BIG
PIECE OF MINISTRATION MENTIONED
THERE'S JUST BEEN A MULTITUDE.
OF DIFFERENT STRATEGIES THAT
PLANS. OF USED YOUR RANGING
FROM CHANGING TO FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO CALKINS. ADVANCING
CAPITATION I'M LOOKING AT
HISTORICAL PAYMENT LEVELS AND
MAKING UP THE DIFFERENCE BOTH
FOR SPECIALISTS AND HOSPITALS
AS YOU MENTION. AND OF COURSE
MANY PCPS ARE CAPITATED SO
THERE CONTINUED TO BE PAID.
SOME ALL PROS ARE COMPLICATED
BY SOME PLANS THAT THERE IS A
LOT BY PLANS. NUMBER OF COURSE
THEN THEY WOULD BE RECEIVING-
COMBAT INCOME AS WELL THEY'RE
JUST. REALLY UP. THE THING I
WOULD SAY TO THE COMMITTEE. WE
ARE REALLY LARGE AND FUND. AND
THE CHOICES THAT HAD TO BE MADE
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO REDUCE
OUR OBLIGATION FOR GENERAL FUND
GIVEN THE INCREASE IN CASELOAD
AND GIVEN THE NEED TO BALANCE
THE BUDGET I'VE BEEN EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT. AND THE CHOICES THAT
HAD TO BE MADE- WHETHER THEY
ARE ROUND THE ISSUES OF
OPTIONAL BENEFITS. OR A PROP
FIFTY SIX. ARE REALLY QUITE
DIFFICULT AS A PHYSICIAN AS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S BEEN ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THIS- WE REALLY
DO APPRECIATE. REALLY
UNDERSTANDS. THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT OF. SO WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WANT TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TURNED TO SEE WHAT
WHAT OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE- BUT
REALLY- WANTED TO JUST MAKE
THAT POINT SO LET IT GO AT THAT
AND BE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
THANKS MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS. I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF GROUND TO
COVER- WITH THIS DEPARTMENT WE
NORMALLY- I THINK TAKE TWO FULL
HEARING DAYS TO HEAR DCS IN THE
NORMAL COURSE OF BUSINESS.
WE'RE NOW TRYING TO DO IT AND-
ANNA OUR CONTRACT. OR SO. LMAO
COMMENTS. GOOD MORNING CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES OKAY BEN JOHNSON
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND- FIRST I'D LIKE TO
TURN TO THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND OUR
CASELOAD ESTIMATES- MISS COOPER
DID A GREAT JOB OF JUST BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZING THE MAJOR
DIFFERENCES BUT I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSCORE- THE SOME OF THE
REASONS WHY WE QUESTION THE
ASSUMPTIONS UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROJECTIONS SO
AS AS MISS COOPER SAID WE ARE
NOT FAR OFF AND WE REALLY DO
THINK THAT THEIR OVERALL
CASELOAD PROJECTIONS ARE IN
TERMS OF NEW ENROLLEES ARE
REASONABLE. BUT WHAT WE
QUESTION IS- THE AMOUNT OF
GENERAL FUND COSTS THAT THE
STATE WOULD ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE.
AS A RESULT OF THESE DO ENROLL
THE- AND IT'S HERE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ASSUMES THAT A
VERY SIGNIFICANT SHARE OF THE
NEW ENROLLEES- WOULD BE SENIORS
AND PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
AND THESE DAYS INDIVIDUALS HAVE
VERY HIGH COSTS OFTEN MORE THAN
TEN TIMES. THE COST OF OTHER
ENROLLEES IN THE PROGRAM UNDER
THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
PROJECTIONS SENIORS IN PERSON
WITH THIS. WOULD GROW AT A
ROUGHLY COMPARABLE RATE AS
ANOTHER POT LARGE POPULATIONS
THAT ARE THE THAT IS THE
CHILDLESS ADULT POPULATION THAT
HAS A LEGIBILITY THROUGH THE
OPTIONAL EXPANSION. WE QUESTION
THIS ASSUMPTION AS WE BELIEVE
THAT THE CHILDLESS ADULTS HAVE
R. WELL PARTICIPATE TOO MUCH
GREATER EXTENT IN THE LABOR
MARKET AND THEREFORE THERE ARE
THAT ECONOMIC VIEW THAT THE
CONDITIONS OF THOSE FAMILIES
ARE FACING IN THEIR INCOMES ARE
GOING TO VERY MUCH MORE. WITH
FLUCTUATIONS IN THE ECONOMY
THAN US SENIORS WHO MAY BE
RETIRED AND- INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO WHO MIGHT ONLY.
MAY NOT WORK FULL TIME. AND SO
WE BELIEVE THAT IN THAT. SOME
OF THE SOON TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PUTTING
INTO THE SENIORS AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES- CASELOAD
SHOULD REALLY BE SHIFTED TO A
DIFFERENT KEESLER CATEGORY.
SECOND WE FIND IS THAT- THE
STATE- THE ADMINISTRATION
ASSUMES THAT A VERY HIGH
PROPORTION OF NEW ENROLLMENT
WILL BE FROM- FROM INDIVIDUALS
WHERE THE STATE PAYS A HIGH
SHERIFF COST STATE PAYS A HIGH
SHARE OF COSTS FOR FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN. AND SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITY BUT THE
STATE PAYS QUITE A LOW SHARE OF
COST FOR THESE DOES CHILDLESS
ADULTS ARE SPEAKING IN
PREVIOUSLY AS WELL AS CHILDREN
FROM HIGHER INCOME FAMILIES.
CURRENTLY THE CASELOAD IN MEDIC
HOW- COMPRISE ABOUT 40% OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE THE LOWER
STATE SHARE OF COST. BUT UNDER
THE UNDER THE GUN UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ASSUMPTIONS
FOR NEW CASELOAD 80% OF NEW
ENROLLEES WOULD- HAVE THE
HIGHER STATE SHARE OF COST AND
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND. WHY IT
WOULD BE NECESSARILY SO
DIFFERENT THAN THE CURRENT
MEDICARE OKAY SO. MOREOVER WE
HAVE LOOKED AT. SOME OF THE
DATA ON- ON HOW MANY LOW INCOME
PEOPLE OR ADULTS TEND TO HAVE
CHILDREN WHICH IMPACTS WHETHER
OR NOT THEY BE PUT IN THE
OPTIONAL EXPANSION CATEGORY OR
IN THE FAMILY'S CATEGORY. AND
WE FIND THAT A MAJORITY ARE DO
NOT HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN IN THE
HOME AND THEREFORE WOULD LIKELY
BE PUT INTO THE- CHILDLESS
ADULT CATEGORY. SO THESE THESE-
DIFFERENT ASSUMPTIONS HAVE A
MAJOR GENERAL FUND MPACT AND
THEY INFORM WHY WE RECOMMEND
ADJUSTING MEDI CAL BUDGET
DOWNWARD BY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION ACROSS BOTH
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE'VE TRIED
ISSUE AS CLOSELY AS POSSIBLE TO
THE ADMINISTRATION'S GENERAL
ASSUMPTIONS ONLY ADJUSTING
REALLY WHERE SOME OF THE NEW
CASELOAD- NEW INNOVATIVE NEW
ENTRANTS INTO THE PROGRAM WOULD
BE PLACED AMONG THE VARIOUS.
CATEGORIES SO WE TRY TO DO OUR
WE DO OUR BEST TO ASSUME
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME COST PER
CASE AS A AS THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD AT LEAST WITHIN THE
CASELOAD CATEGORIES. WE HAVE
RECOMMENDED ADJUSTMENT THE END
THIS STILL INCLUDES A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN SENIORS
AND PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
AND ROLLING IN THE PROGRAM AND
ITS STILL ASSUMES A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THE
NEW ENTRANCE WOULD BE FAMILIES-
AND CHILDREN AS OPPOSED TO THE
LESS EXPENSIVE CHILDLESS
ADULTS. AS SUCH WE DO BELIEVE
THAT I RECOMMENDED IT
ADJUSTMENT IS CONSERVATIVE AND
CAN WITHSTAND SOME OF THIS-
PHYSICAL RISK THE STATE WOULD
FACE SAY IS- NEW ENROLLMENT
WE'RE ACTUALLY EVEN HIGHER THAN
WHAT THE. ADMINISTRATION IS
PROJECTING. NOW I'D TURN SOME
COMMENTS THAT WE SHARED WITH
THE LEGISLATURE LATE INTO THE
OPTIONAL EXPAND OUT EXCUSE ME
THE OPTIONAL BENEFIT
ELIMINATIONS AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE REDUCTIONS IN ELIGIBILITY.
THE FEDERAL LEGISLATION THAT
PROVIDED AN ENHANCED FEDERAL
SHARE OF COST FOR THE PROGRAM
UP TO A CERTAIN CONDITIONS ON
STAGE BUT THEY MAINTAIN
ELIGIBILITY LEVELS. IN READING
SOME GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE FIND IT UNCLEAR
WHETHER OR NOT FEDERAL RULE
THAT BANNED THOSE FEDERAL
CONDITIONS ON THE ENHANCED
FEDERAL FUNDING COULD ACTUALLY
YOU SORT OF AFFECTIVELY
PROHIBITED THE STATE FROM
MAKING BENEFIT. AND ELIGIBILITY
REDUCTIONS WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING
THE ENHANCED FEDERAL FUNDING
NOW THE ENHANCED FEDERAL
FUNDING BRINGS IN MUCH MORE
FEDERAL FUNDING THAN THE
REDUCTIONS TO THE OPTIONAL
BENEFITS SUCH AS THE SEA BASS
PROGRAM ADULT DENTAL SERVICES
AND I AND I AND OTHERS WOULD
THAT. WOULD RELIEVE THE GENERAL
FUND. AND SO WE DO HAVE
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS
ULTIMATELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
ON WHETHER OR NOT FEDERAL
RULES- WOULD PROHIBIT US
AFFECTIVELY FROM GETTING RID OF
THOSE- GETTING RID OF THOSE
ELIMINATIONS OR REDUCTIONS. AND
THEN- AND THEN HOW THE STATE
WILL ORT OF RE BALANCE THE
OVERALL BUDGET IF IN FACT THOSE
REDUCTIONS ARE NOT.
FUNCTIONALLY ALLOWABLE. NEXTEL
TURN QUICKLY TO THE- THE I. T.
SYSTEM CHANGES THAT ARE
PROPOSED IN IT IN MEDIC HAL- WE
WE'VE- ANALYZE THIS-
PRELIMINARILY AND FIND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ONLY RECEIVED
SO FAR PRELIMINARY COST
SCHEDULE AND SCOPE IN
INFORMATION FOR THE NEW
MODERNIZATION EFFORTS. AND SO
WE THEREFORE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT. A
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD DIRECT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REPORT BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND TIMELY
MANNER ON TOTAL COST AND
SCHEDULE AND SCOPE OF THE
MODERNIZATION EFFORT. NEXT TURN
QUICKLY TO SOME OF THE COVERT
RELATED- POLICY CHANGES SUCH AS
AN EXPANSION OF COVERAGE-
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE UNINSURED
FOUR COVE IN TESTING AND
TREATMENT AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE OTHER- NEW FLEXIBILITIES
HELLO AT THE END MINISTRATION
IS PURSUING- RELATED TO
TREATMENT INCLUDING SUCH THINGS
AS TELEHEALTH OR- A LONG TERM
CARE TEMPORARY RATE INCREASE-
THE- THE LET THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROPOSED TRAINABLE
LANGUAGE- THAT WOULD. AUTHORIZE
SOME OF THE FLEXIBILITIES FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION TO PURSUE
SUCH POLICIES AS THEY COME
FORWARD AND WHILE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT SUCH FLEXIBILITIES MAYBE
REALLY IMPORTANT IN THE CASE OF
SAY A SECOND WAVE OF HOPE IN
NINETEEN OVER THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR- WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
THAT THE- THAT THAT A TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE DOES NOT PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT LEGEND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. OF ANY NEW POLICIES
AND SPENDING THAT IS ADOPTED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION SO AT
MINIMUM THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER- SOME
ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO ANY
CHANGE POLICY CHANGES AND
FUNDING CHANGING CHANGES THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION. CHOOSES TO
ADOPT- AND THEN LASTLY WE DO
HAVE OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE- STATE ONLY CLAIMING
ISSUE THIS IS THE ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION THAT THE STATE IS
NEEDING TO REPAY TO THE STATE
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OUR
QUESTIONS ARE LARGELY ABOUT.
WHAT PORTION OF THAT IS ONGOING
VERSES OUT ONE TIME AND REALLY
RECEIVING A SCHEDULE ABOUT SORT
OF WHICH DELIVERY SYSTEMS THAT
OCCURRED AND OVER WHAT TIME
PERIOD THAT OCCURRED. BACK
INCLUDES MY REMARKS. AND I AM
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU THE OF. AND I
DON'T KNOW YOU CAN ALSO HELP
ANSWER THE QUESTION POSED BY
THE ELIO PARTY REMARKS. LAURA
YEAH NOT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
RESPOND TO FIRST AND THE
REQUEST REQUEST ABOUT
INFORMATION FOR IT PROJECTS AND
THE NEW- MODERNIZATION PROJECT
OFFERS AT DH CS AND THEN
SECONDLY ABOUT CASELOAD- THE
COVER RELATED CASELOADS SO.
FIRST WE ARE THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING- TO AMEND EXISTING
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO REFLECT
THE NEW- ENTERPRISE
MODERNIZATION EFFORT AT THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THIS BUDGET LANGUAGE
CURRENTLY- IS IN REFERENCE TO
HUMANS BUT WILL IT WERE
PROPOSING TO UPDATE IT TO
REFLECT THE NEW- ENTERPRISE
MODERNIZATION EFFORT. AND IT
REQUIRES- THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE QUARTERLY PROJECT
STATUS I THINK THE GREEN
CONTRACT INFORMATION ON
PROJECT. ON. PURPOSE AND COSTS
SO. WE THINK THAT THAT DRESSING
QUESTIONS ON THE PACKAGE AND
GREET NEW EFFORT. AND REGARDING
THE CASELOAD AND MACHINES THAT-
ELLIE- BROUGHT IN A RECURRING
CLICKBAIT WE USED THE REMEMBER
PER MONTH COST AVAILABLE AT THE
TIME THAT WE DEVELOPED OUR
ESTIMATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S WORKING ON
UPDATING THE SYSTEM AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL LEAD TO
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OUR
ESTIMATED IN THE EARLY HOURS OF
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION GENERAL FUND AND-
DOWN FROM THE CURRENT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE DOLLAR
DIFFERENCE. AND MAINLY WE WANT
TO JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT WE USED
DATA BASED ON THE LAST
RECESSION AND THE IMPACTS ON
THE POPULATION THAT WE REFLECT
THAT WE THINK WOULD BE A ROLE
IN. THAT IN MEDIC COW. IS JOHN
AVAILABLE AND ALL. ON THE ACA.
OPTIONAL EXPANSION POPULATION
THERE IS NO DATA AVAILABLE ON
THAT SINCE IT'S DIFFICULT AT
TWO ON MAKING ASSUMPTIONS IT'S-
DIFFICULT TO. ESTIMATE D. THE
TOTAL CASELOAD. IN EACH OF
THESE POPULATIONS HOWEVER AS
ELIA NOTED BECAUSE HESE ARE
CHILDLESS. SINGLE ADULTS THEY
ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE IMPACTED
BY UNEMPLOYMENT. HOWEVER I WILL
NO BECAUSE THEIR TALENTS OF
GOLD IF THEY DO RECEIVE THE
MAXIMUM UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
THEY WOULD BE ABOUT INCOME THE
INCOME ELIGIBILITY THRESHOLDS
FOR MEDI CAL. AND IF THE CHILD
A SINGLE GOAL IS EARNING
MINIMUM WAGE AND NOT WORKING
FULL TIME THEY'RE ALSO LIKELY
TO ALREADY BE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI
CAL. SO WE BELIEVE THAT OUR-
CASELOAD ESTIMATE IS REASONABLE
AND ANY- AND ANY CHANGES ANY
FURTHER CHANGES TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE WOULD
JUST. BE A PURELY RANDOM YES.
OKAY THANK YOU. CORRECT
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ST LOUIS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M JUST
WONDERING IF- WE CAN GET
COMMENT ON THE RATIONALE FOR
CUTTING. FUNDING FOR SOME OF
THE SENIOR PROGRAMS WHEN WE
HAVE KEPT FINDING- WE'VE LEFT
UNTOUCHED FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
RELATING TO THE MARKET TO LESS
VULNERABLE POPULATION BE
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD I
THINK UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH-
CONSIDERING. THE FORMER
POPULATION IS AT MUCH MORE
RISK- I'M JUST CURIOUS ABOUT
THE RATIONALE FOR THAT. OKAY SO
J. C. COOPER HERE I THINK YOU
KNOW WHAT- AS WE MENTIONED ALL
OF THE- PROPOSALS PUT FORWARD
WERE VERY CHALLENGING AND I HAD
TO PUT FORWARD AND ESPECIALLY
AROUND OUR SENIOR POPULATIONS I
THINK ONE OF THE GUIDING
PRINCIPLES OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS TO- HAVE
CLEAR ACCESS AND ELIGIBILITY TO
MEDICAL SERVICES AND NOT-
REMOVING THAT THE ELIGIBILITY.
AND TO THE QUESTION REGARDS THE
YOUNGER INDIVIDUALS AND THEN.
AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED BOTH
THE BASS AN MSSP ARE CONSIDERED
OPTIONAL BENEFITS AND I'MGIVEN
THE- RESTRICTIONS AND ABILITIES
AND DELIVERS THAT WE HAD
AVAILABLE TO US I'M TO MEET
THE- YOU KNOW THE SCOPE AND
SIZE OF THE DEFICIT AS WELL AS
HAVE A BALANCED BUDGET. WE HAD
TO PUT FORWARD A RECOMMEND SUMS
I'M VERY DIFFICULT PRODUCTIONS
INCLUDING BOTH THE BASS AND
THAT'S THAT'S THE- I THINK I
WOULD ALSO MENTION AS I.
HIGHLIGHTED IN MY EARLIER
REMARKS THAT. A LARGE NUMBER IF
NOT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE IN MEDICAID
MANAGED CARE MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE. AND YOU KNOW
COMPREHENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
AND WRAP SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO ENSURE. THAT
THEY ARE PREVENTING BOTH
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY AS
WELL AS HOSPITALIZATION. THANK
YOU AND I AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION THERE AGAIN
THOUGH I STILL HAVE KIDS I HAVE
GREAT CONCERN ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE CUT FUNDING TO THE
VERY POPULATION. THAT HAS BEEN
HARDEST HIT BY THIS PANDEMIC
AND IF. PERHAPS THERE IS A
SECOND WAVE- I JUST I'M NOT. I
JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
RATIONALE BEHIND IT BUT NONE
THE LESS I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENT TO BE LIKE TO ADD ON TO
THAT I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT-
IF NOT I DO HAVE ONE.
ADDITIONAL QUESTION UNLESS SHE
CARES TO RESPOND- TO MY
CONCERNS SURE I THINK THAT'S-
THE OTHER REASON WE ARE-
ANNOUNCING THE LONG TERM CARE
AT HOME NEW BENEFITS WHICH WILL
WILL GREATLY. ALLOW US TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE AT RISK
ESPECIALLY OUR SENIOR
POPULATION AT RISK IN THEIR
HOME- WHICH AT THIS TIME IS A
BETTER PLACE FOR US TO BE
PROVIDING CARE- AS A LARGE
NUMBER OF I'M SENIOR
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING IN. UNTIL VERY YES-
PROGRAM CENTERS AND SO THE
DEPARTMENT LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS
OVER THE COMING MONTHS. TO FINE
TUNE THAT BENEFIT- AND M.
PROPOSAL AND TO HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW WE
PROTECT OUR SENIORS. OKAY WELL
AND I KNOW YOU NOTED THAT THE
DETAILS OF THAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAM- HAVE YET TO BE WORKED
OUT SO I DON'T HAVE- AS MUCH
CONFIDENCE AS I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE A REGARDING THAT PROGRAM.
BUT I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION
IS THERE A CONCERN- ON THE
pPROVIDERS ARE GOING TO BRING
FORWARD A LAWSUIT BECAUSE OF
THE SWEEPING OF THE- PROP SIX
FIFTY SIX FUNDING. SO YOU KNOW
THE ELIMINATION OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS. AS WELL
AS THE VALUE BASED PAYMENT
PROGRAM- WORD SHE WERE
DIFFICULT RECOMMENDATIONS AND
WE DO FEEL THAT THE REDIRECTION
TO COVER THE ALLOWABLE OR THE
INCREASE CASELOAD- WITHIN THE
PROGRAM- IS IT WITH AN
ALIGNMENT OF THOSE STATUTES IN
THE- IN THE LOT AND SO THE-
BOWLING GAUGE WITH PEOPLE AS B.
AS WE CONTINUE THROUGH THIS.
THE BUDGET DISCUSSION. THANK
YOU SIR TACO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR. I'M DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT MANY OF THE PROS PROPOSED
CUTS THAT I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHERE TO BEGIN WITH. YOU KNOW I
I'D REALLY LIKE TO START WITH
AT THE HEALTH FOR ALL SENIORS.
AS YOU MAY KNOW I COME FROM
CENTRAL VALLEY WE HAVE. AT THE
AGRICULTURE BASED ECONOMY. WE
HAVE FARM WORKERS THAT. DO YOU
KNOW THERE ARE BUT THE AGE OF
FIFTY FIVE THEY'RE THE SOLE
PROVIDERS FOR THEIR FAMILIES
THAT THEIR CHILDREN ARE STILL
RELYING ON- TO YOU KNOW FOR
HOUSE SCENE AND FOOD AND- I.
YOU KNOW I KNOW I KNOW THAT THE
YOU KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION AND
YOURSELF- HAVE FOUND. YOU KNOW
CREATIVE WAYS. TO MAKE THINGS
HAPPEN AND I'M HOPING THAT. YOU
REALLY THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW
THAT THE. AND BEYOND THAT THAT
NEED HEALTH CARE NOW MORE THAN
EVER ESPECIALLY IF THERE IS. A
YOU KNOW AND- IN THE FALL WERE
EXPECTING A COVETED TO RAMP UP
AGAIN. I REALLY WANT YOU TO
CONSIDER THAT THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF NOT PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE. BEYOND YOU KNOW
WHAT WE HAVE AT THE MOMENT. SO
I THINK THAT THIS IS. AT A TIME
WHERE WE CAN REALLY GET
CREATIVE AND REALLY- PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE FOR OUR- OUR OUR
SENIORS THE OTHER THING I
WANTED TO COMMENT ON IS THE-
THE CLINIC FUNDING AND- I KNOW
WE TALKED ABOUT THE- THE
PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE AND- I'M
ALREADY BEGINNING TO SEE. OR
HEAR FROM FROM PEOPLE IN THE
DISCIPLINE MY DISTRICT- TALK
ABOUT- LAYOFFS AND- REDUCTION
IN HOURS AND WHEN YOU HAVE ONE.
CLINIC AND IN AN AREA FOR AN
ENTIRE COMMUNITY. THAT THAT'S-
BAD A MAJOR IMPACT. AND I KNOW
THAT THERE'S- A CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT TELL HELPFUL IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S IT THAT
DOESN'T ALWAYS NECESSARILY WORK
SO I JUST WANTED TO POINT THAT
OUT- THE OTHER THING IS THAT IT
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
I THINK. THIS IS SOMETHING ELSE
THAT I'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT IT
AT AT LEAST IN MY SENATE
DISTRICT AND I CAN IMAGINE
BEYOND. THE ENTIRE STATE. I
THINK NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED THIS TONIGHT I UNDERSTAND
THE ARGUMENT THAT YOU MADE IT
IN TERMS OF CORPORATE AND- IT
WHETHER OR NOT TO- FOLKS ARE
YOU KNOW. GOING INTO THOSE
PLACES BUT- THE REALITY IS
THAT- I THINK THAT THAT OUR OUR
AGENT COMMUNITY DESERVES TO
LIVE IN DIGNITY. AND THIS THIS
THEY WANT AND- I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE ADVOCATING FOR. AND
THEN LASTLY OFONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT I WANTED TO POINT
OUT IS. AS AS A CO AUTHOR OF
THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION. TO
ELIMINATE THE SENIOR PENDLETON
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM I. AM
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT OUR LOW
INCOME SENIORS AND- JUST
OVERALL OUR SENIORS AND HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT
THEM. I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THERE'S YOU KNOW TAKES MONEY
AND THERE IS. A DEFICIT AND BUT
I THINK THAT S. NOW IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY GET
CREATED TO REALLY CONTINUE TO
FIND AND EXPAND THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE. OKAY THANK YOU
SIR HELLO. RIGHT FROM. SO I'VE
SAID SEVERAL QUESTIONS AND SOME
COMMENTS AS WELL AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION TO
THE PARK HEALTH CARE SERVICES-
I APPRECIATE THAT- YOU ARE
TRYING TO PRIORITIZE ENSURING
THAT AS MANY PEOPLE AS WE CAN-
TO CURRENTLY HAVE COVERAGE-
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THAT I DO
I DO. YOU KNOW. YEAH WELL IT'S
THAT'S A BIG CONCERN THAT- YOU
KNOW THAT- PROPOSAL THAT WAS TO
EXPAND COVERAGE UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE OF- BUDGETARY SITUATION
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ON BEFORE
IN TERMS OF SENIORS. WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED BUT I GUESS AND I
AND I KNOW THAT YOU LOOK AT
THESE ISSUES CAREFULLY BUT NOW
I AM STRUCK THAT- WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL ITEMS HERE THAT IN MY
MIND- BUT WE SAVE WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO COMPARES WHAT'S THE COST
OF THE ALTERNATIVE. SO THE M.
S. S. P. PROGRAM AND SEA BASS
YOU KNOW AND THIS IS P. PROGRAM
AND WE HEARD A BIT OF A
PRESENTATION EARLIER THIS YEAR-
THESE ARE SENIORS THAT
ACTUALLY- ARE ELIGIBLE AND
WOULD OTHERWISE GO TO A NURSING
HOME WHICH BY THE WAY MEDIC
HOUSE ALSO PAYS FOR. IT'S MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE- AND SO WE'RE
CALLING ON ELIMINATING THAT
PROGRAM AND WELL I THINK-
APPRECIATE A NEW FOUND
CONFIDENCE WE HAVE IN OUR
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PROGRAMS
TO TAKE CARE OF THEM THAT
WASN'T THERE- EARLIER IN THE
YEAR WHEN WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THIS PROGRAM SO- I AM LITTLE-
I'M- SKEPTICAL ABOUT THE IDEA
THAT THE- MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
PROGRAMS WILL BE ALSO IN THE
GAPS AND THAT. MANY OF THESE
PATIENTS WON'T END UP IN A
NURSING HOME WHICH IT ACTUALLY
COST US MUCH MORE- YEAH- THE
SAME WITH CBS PROGRAM IS
SOMETHING THAT ALSO HELPS KEEP
PEOPLE OUT- WE'LL TALK ABOUT
IHS US LATER SO WE WON'T TOUCH
YOU KNOW WE'LL GET INTO THAT
BUT THAT'S KIND OF SIMILAR
QUESTION THERE- EVEN THREE
SAMPLE. SUBSAMPLE WE ALSO HAVE
NOT REALLY TO SENIORS BUT IN
THE E. OURS- THE- BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS IN THE E.
OURS AND TO HELP WITH THEIR
OPIOID CRISIS- AND I THINK WHEN
WE HEARD THAT. PRESENTATION FR
THAT INITIALLY. I THINK WE
HEARD ABOUT HOW OLD THE
RESEARCHERS PEOPLE HAD PILOTED
THIS PROGRAM ACTUALLY SAW COST
SAVINGS. SO I AM CONCERNED THAT
WE'RE MAKING CUTS- AND
CERTAINLY IT'S NOT THE MAJORITY
CUT IS ACTUALLY PROBABLY A
SMALL FRACTION OF THE CUTS BUT
THESE ARE CUTS THAT ACTUALLY
LEAD TO GREATER EXPENSES. TO
OUR STATE MOVING FORWARD-
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED IS WE'LL
HAVE PATIENTS SHIFTED
ESSENTIALLY FROM ONE PROGRAM OR
FUNDING THAT WERE ELIMINATING
OR CUTTING TO ANOTHER PROGRAM
THAT. WE HAVE THAT WE'RE PAYING
FOR AS WELL. SO IT I GUESS MY
IS THAT- HOW DID THE DEPARTMENT
EVALUATES A V. CUT THESE ARE
THE OFFSET TO THE CUTS IN TERMS
OF WHERE THESE PATIENTS MAY END
UP I MEAN IT DID YOU RESUME
THAT EVERYONE ON M. S. S. P.
WOULD NOT END UP IN A NURSING
HOME BECAUSE MANAGED MANAGED
CARE WOULD PICK UP OR WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF- THE SENIORS WHO
ARE ON M. S. P. BY ELIMINATING
IT WOULD END UP IN A NURSING
HOME THAT WAS OUR PROJECTION
MADE OF THAT IT DIDN'T MAKE A
DECISION TO MAKE A CUT TO THAT
ARE CENTRAL TO LIMIT THE
PROGRAM FRANKLY. AND A PROPOSAL.
HI SENATOR PAN SO- WE DID NOT
SCORE ON ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS
TIED TO- INCREASE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY WITHIN THE
BUDGET JUST TO BE CLEAR- I
THINK. THE COMBINATION OF BOTH-
THE MANAGED CARE PLAN WHICH THE
MAJORITY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
AS WELL. AS WELL AS THE OTHER.
I'M IN COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE. IN THE
PROGRAM THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO DO TRANSITION PLANNING- OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WITH. AND WE
DID NOT SCORE ADDITIONAL COSTS
AND THEN WOULD NOTE- WE THE
ADDITIONAL WORK AT THE
DEPARTMENT HAD BEEN WORKING ON.
WHICH WE UNDERSTAND WAS NOT A
PART OF THE MAY RELY A REVISED
RELEASE THAT HAS BEEN
SUBSEQUENTLY- AND NOW THROUGH
THE LONG TERM CARE AT HOME. I'M
EXPLORING THAT OPTION- FIRST
STATEWIDE AND JUST MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLEUNDERSTAND THAT
PROPOSAL WOULD BE A B. BEYOND
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
WOULD BE AN ONGOING. BENEFIT
THE COMBINATION OF THOSE THINGS
THIS. IS WHY WE DID NOT SCORE
THAT- BUT I UNDERSTAND YOUR
POINT IN REGARDS TO THE
VULNERABILITY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. AND IN IN THE
PROGRAM- AND- THE DIGIT DUE
DILIGENCE THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED DURING THOSE
TRANSITIONS TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE DO NOT. END UP- YOU KNOW
INAPPROPRIATELY IN INNISFIL
NURSING FACILITY WHEN IT COULD
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED. OKAY SO-
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SAID I
THINK THAT I GUESS WHAT I WOULD
SAY ASK IS THAT. WE NOT
ELIMINATE THIS PROGRAM BEFORE
WE SET UP THE OTHER PROGRAM SO
I. HEAR WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE
LONG TERM CARE AT HOME BENEFITS
IT'S APPRECIATE ANNOUNCING IT
LAST FRIDAY. I DO HOPE THAT-
THAT ENDED YOU MENTIONED IF I
WOULD ACTUALLY BE IMPLEMENTED
THAT EVEN ON A REALLY FAST
TRACK UNTIL. THE THIS FISCAL
YEAR BUT IT WOULD BE YOU KNOW
ESSENTIALLY IN THE SPRING OR
MAYBE WE'RE REALLY LUCKY A
LITTLE EARLIER IN THE SPRING-
SO BUT I THINK THAT- THAT MEANS
THAT WE SHOULD. HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VET THIS MORE
THOROUGHLY AS A SUBCOMMITTEE-
SO PERHAPS NOT PUT THIS INTO
THE MAY REVISE BUT- IN TERMS OF
EXPECTING THAT IT'S I. BE THERE
BUT FOR YOU KNOW WAS BEFORE.
LEAVE SESSION AUGUST THAT WE
HAVEN'T OF IT SOME OF THIS.
MEANTIME THOUGH SOUNDS LIKE WE
STILL NEED THE M. S. S. P.
PROGRAM THAT HAPPENS. SO EVEN
IF WE ARE ABLE TO PUT THIS
THING IN PLACE. IN JANUARY OR
FEBRUARY OR WHATEVER HAPPENS
WE'RE STILL GONNA NEED PROGRAMS
LIKE M. S. S. P. AND C. BASS.
AND I DO THINK THAT. I THINK IT
WOULD BE A REMARKABLE
ASSUMPTION TO BE ACHE THAT.
NONE OF THE PEOPLE WE ACTUALLY
ELIMINATE THE PROGRAM JULY
FIRST IS BEING PROPOSED IN THE
MAY REVISE. THAT NONE OF THOSE
PATIENTS WHO ACTUALLY. RECENTLY
MSP ALREADY QUALIFY FOR BEING
ADMITTED FOR LONG TERM CARE
SERVICES WILL NOT END UP IN A
NURSING HOME- I MEAN I THINK-
EVEN EVEN WITH MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE I'M SURE THAT- TRYING TO
SAVE SOME OF THEM- THAT. NONE
OF THEM WOULD ACTUALLY END UP
THERE AND CERTAINLY IT'S MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE THERE SO I THINK
THE COST OFFSET MAY TURN OUT TO
BE- AS EXPENSIVE AS THE- THE
ELIMINATION OF THE PROGRAM SO I
DID. SO LET'S LET'S FIGURE OUT
HOW WE PLACE THESE THINGS IN A
WAY TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE DON'T
FALL IN THE GAPS- I DO WANT TO
TOUCH ON PROP FIFTY SIX. SO
WHEN PROP FIFTY SIX PASSED IN.
WRAPS ELLIE- CAN COMMENTS ON
THIS AS WELL WE HAD THIS
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THERE WAS
ORIGINALLY A PROPOSAL SOMETHING
TO JUST ROLL PROPERTY SIX INTO
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE. AND I
THINK THAT IS CONTRARY TO THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS WHO PASSED
PROPERTY SIX. I CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE WE HAVE A BUDGET
ISSUE THIS YEAR AND CERTAINLY
WE WANT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO WORK IT BUT I THINK
SIMPLY TO ROLL IT BACK INTO-
MEDICO. I MADE THIS CLEAR
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED IS
CONTRARY TO WHAT THE VOTERS.
EXPECTED WHEN THEY VOTED FOR-
THIS REVENUE SOURCE AND- AND
THAT'S WHY WE EVENTUALLY IS-
LEGISLATURE AND- PREVIOUS
GOVERNOR AGREED THAT WE WOULD-
BASICALLY. THE SHIRT REDIRECT
TO ORGANIZE THE FUNDS IN A WAY
THAT- ADDRESSED WHAT THE VOTERS
WANTED AND SO- PERHAPS ELLIE
OKAY IT WOULD YOU CAN YOU
COMMENT IS- THE REMARKS I MADE
AND I THINK SOME OF YOU WERE
AROUND AT THE TIME- IS. THE
ACCURACY OF WHAT I AM SAYING IN
TERMS OF THE WAY PROPERTY
SIXES. IT WAS IT WAS- WRITTEN
AND PASSED BY THE VOTERS AND
THE EXPECTATIONS OF THE VOTERS
FOR PROPERTY SIX. BEN JOHNSON
AGAIN WITH THE L. A. L. I THINK
THAT DOES. YOU'RE RIGHT THAT
THE PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX- THE
PIECE FOR MEDIC HAL IS- WRITTEN
SO THAT IT'S IN YOU KNOW THE
FUNDING FOR MEDICARE AL IS
INTENDED TO INCREASE PAYMENTS.
IN THE FIRST YEAR THAT THE
FUNDING WAS AVAILABLE THE
ADMINISTRATION DID PROPOSE- TO
USE THAT TO OFFSET- GROWTH IN
THE PROGRAM GENERAL FUND GROWTH
IN THE PROGRAM. AND ULTIMATELY
A- AN AGREEMENT WAS REACHED
REALLY BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION WHICH
WOULD. PROVIDE A PORTION OF THE
FUNDING AND A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE FUNDING FOR
PROVIDER PAYMENT INCREASES.
WHILE ALSO PROVIDING SOME OF
THE FUNDING TO OFFSET GENERAL
FUND SPENDING ON GROWTH IN THE
PROGRAM. AT THAT ARRANGEMENT
WAS MAINTAINED FOR I BELIEVE
ONE MORE YEAR BEFORE ACTUALLY
ALL OF THE FUNDING HAS BEEN
USED FOR PROVIDER PAYMENT
INCREASES. US SINCE THEN- SO
THERE IS SOME LEGISLATIVE THERE
IS THERE IS A HISTORY OF USING
IT TO OFFSET GENERAL FUND
COSTING GROWS. AND IT YOU KNOW
WELL THERE IS A- THERE THERE
CERTAINLY IS A NONSTOP
PLANTATION CLOSET IN IN THIS
PIECE OF PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX-
IT'S UNCERTAIN WHETHER OR NOT.
WE WOULD THE STATE WE MAY HAVE
TO MAKE YOU KNOW OTHER. PAYMENT
REDUCTIONS ABSENT YOU KNOW. BUT
I'M USING THIS FUNDING TO
OFFSET. GROWTH IN THE PROGRAM
SO. NOW SUPPLICATION CLAUSES.
SEEM OUR OUR OUR DIFFERENT TO
EMPLOY BECAUSE BECAUSE IT'S
HARD TO ALWAYS ESTABLISH WHAT
THE BASELINE IS BUT- YOU'RE
RIGHT THAT SORT OF POINT OUT
THIS THIS ASPECT OF THE SORT OF
COMPLEX LEGISLATIVE HISTORY.
OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO WORK
DILIGENTLY TO WANT TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THIS
WOULD CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AND
I WAS AROUND TWENTY TEN- THAT
WE HAVE THAT YEAH WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE BUDGET DEFICIT BUT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
PROP FIFTY SIX INTEREST.
STRUCTURE WELL WE CERTAINLY CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO DRESSING SOME OF
THE DEFICIT SHOULD BE PRESERVED
AND IN MANY WAYS- BUT OBVIOUSLY
ADJUSTMENTS NEED TO BE MADE TO
FOR THE- CURRENT BUDGET%
SITUATION- BUT I THINK SIMPLY
JUST ROLLING INTO MEDICARE OUT
OF THE WAY THAT'S PROPOSED IS
CONTRARY TO THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS AND I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE- RESPECT THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS WHEN IT
COMES INITIATIVES. AND NOW MORE
SPECIFICALLY SOME OF THE ISSUES
WERE RAISED. REGARDING PROP
FIFTY SIX- I UNDERSTAND THAT-
SINCE LEADERS- ELIMINATION OF
THIS FAMILY PLANNING FUNDING
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY PART OF
PROP FIFTY SIX- IF I RECALL
CORRECTLY WE ACTUALLY GET A
NINE TO ONE MATCH FOR THAT- SO.
EVEN WITH THE INCREASED F. MAP
IF WE ROLL IT INTO THE OVERALL
MEDICAL PROGRAM THE MATCH I
BELIEVE DROPS IS. PERHAPS TEACH
YES COULD COMMENT ON WAS THAT
STATEMENT INACCURATE THAT WE
ACTUALLY LOSING MATCH BY
SHIFTING THE FUNDS FROM. FAMILY
PLANNING IN HOUSE ORIGINALLY
USED IN PROPERTY SIX AND-
PREVIOUS YEAR TO WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING NOW WE'RE GONNA BE
ACTUALLY DECREASING AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL MATCH WE'RE GETTING.
FOR THOSE FUNDS SO- WE DO
RECEIVE ON SOME SEARCH- SOME
PLANT FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES
AND WOMEN'S HEALTH SERVICES A
HIGHER AND HE ANSWERED F.
MA'AM- AND- REALLY THE PROPOSAL
WAS TO ELIMINATE ALL
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT- PIECES
WITH THE FEW REMAINING PIECES
THAT WERE- RESERVES THROUGH THE
PROPERTY SIX WHICH BE
IDENTIFIED AND BUT TURNED TO MY
FINANCE COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE. I OKAY FINANCE.
I'M SORRY WE CAN'T YOU'RE STILL
ON YOU TO OUR- J. OKAY THANK
YOU HERE- JUST A LOT OF
COMMENTS WITH THE- J. C. AND
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT REGARDLESS
OF THE FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE
FAMILY PLANNING AND WOMEN'S
HEALTH PROGRAMS THEY WOULD BE A
NINE TO TEN MATCH. OKAY SO
AGAIN TO ME UNLESS YOU'RE
TELLING ME THAT YOU DON'T THINK
FAMILY PLANNING'S IMPORTANCE
AND I WOULD STRONGLY DISAGREE
WITH THAT STATEMENT I'M NOT
SURE WHERE WE'RE REMOVING MONEY
FROM THE SYSTEM- BY DOING THAT
SO I HOPE THAT WE CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT RESTORING
THAT FUNDING- SINCE WE GET A-
THIS IS TO GET BETTER MATCH AND
CERTAINLY I THINK. THAT LET'S
SEE WHAT ELSE TO TELL ME THAT
THE DEMAND FOR THOSE SERVICES
IS NOT THERE BUT I THINK AGAIN
I WOULD STRONGLY DISAGREE AND I
THINK MANY OTHERS WITH AS WELL
SO I HOPE WE CAN HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION- THE OTHER THING
IS THAT YOU KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT THE CASELOAD INCREASE AND
WE HAVE THIS DISPUTE ABOUT HOW
MUCH MONEY WILL GET BUT- BUT
ALSO POINT OUT THAT WITH THE
CASELOAD INCREASE WE'RE GOING
TO NEED MORE PROVIDERS. HE JUST
HAVE PREVIOUSLY HEARD FROM THAT
WORK WE ACTUALLY HAVE BOTH
EXISTING. WHO ARE SUFFERING
FINANCIAL LOSSES AND ACTUALLY
TALK ABOUT CLOSING DOWN THE
PRACTICE IS 30% ACCORDING TO A
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATION SURVEY. SAME TIME-
YOU KNOW TRY TO GET MORE
PROVIDERS IN MEDIC HOW- PAID
THE LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM THAT
WE HAD IS PERHAPS ONE OF OUR
MOST SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS AND
GETTING A PROVIDERS TO TAKE
MEDICARE WHICH IS STILL A
FAIRLY POOR PAYER DESPITE THE
IMPROVEMENTS WE'VE MADE TO IT
OVER THE YEARS THROUGH PROP
FIFTY SIX THE ONES THAT WERE
ELIMINATED BY THE WAY.
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE. THE
THINGS THAT. HELPED US BOLSTER.
I MORE PROVIDER FOR NOW BUT-
EVEN SO THAT ASIDE I UNDERSTAND
THAT- FIRST COHORT WHICH WILL
CONTINUE TO BE FUNDED- ACTUALLY
EVEN THOUGH THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR MINIMUM 30% MEDIC HOW
THEY'RE TAKING CARE OF LIKE
SIXTY OVER 60% MEDICAL
PATIENTS- CERTAINLY OF.
TREMENDOUS RETURN ON OUR
INVESTMENT- I UNDERSTAND THAT
IF WE HAD FUNDED AND YOU'RE
PROPOSING FOR ELIMINATION
COHORT TO THAT WOULD PROBABLY
COST ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY FOR FIVE
YEARS BECAUSE THE FIVE YEAR
REPAYMENT SO IN ANY ONE YEAR
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE- ITS FIFTH
ACT. SO TO ME IF YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A- GREAT YOU KNOW IT COULD
CASELOAD INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE MEDIC HOW. WOULD
YOU WANT TO TRY TO GET AS MANY
DOCTORS AND OTHER PROVIDERS-
DENTISTS ADDRESS TO BE WILLING
TO TAKE THE MEDICARE PATIENTS.
BECAUSE THERE IT'S- THREE
THAT'S DOESN'T MAKE SENSE- WELL
LET'S THINK ABOUT WHAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO USE OUR MONEY SO-
SHE WE TAKE IF WE IF WE USE
THAT MONEY TO PAY FOR THE
HEALTH OF THE LOAN REPAYMENTS-
AND THEN YOU SPREAD OUT THAT
REDUCTION DEAL THAT. THE LOSS
OF THOSE I GUESS THAT
REINVESTMENT AS FUNDS IN THAT
OVER THE REST OF THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM WHEN WE STILL COME OUT
AHEAD. THE CONSIDERATION OF
THAT. SO SENATOR PENN I DON'T
KNOW THAT THE- YOU KNOW THE
BUDGET REDUCTIONS PUT FORTH BY
THE DEPARTMENT OUR DIFFICULT
INDEED- JUST UNDERSCORE THE
FACT THAT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
WE DON'T VALUE OUR OUR
PHYSICIANS AND OUR OUR WOMEN'S
HEALTH AND FAMILY PLANNING
SERVICES- I THINK THEY WERE
IT'S JUST DIFFICULT DECISIONS
ACCORDING AND I THINK WE AND
YOU KNOW PLAN TO ENGAGE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE- OVER THE
BUDGET DECISIONS AND I THINK
FOR US WE WILL BE. YOU KNOW
IT'S YES WE HAVE AN INCREASED
LOAD AND IN IN THE PROGRAM AND
WE WILL BE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
ACCESS TO SERVICES- IT WHICH IS
WHY WE WILL HAVE A HEIGHTENED
REPORTING PIECES TO MAKE SURE
WE ARE WATCHING THAT VERY
CLOSELY TO THIS PROCESS AND-
DOCTOR GILBERT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WANT TO ADD ANYTHING TO. A
DAY AND I JUST WANNA SEE THE
FOR DOCTOR BILLS WILL GO OVER
SPEAKS IS THAT I KNOW I AGREE
AND I YOU KNOW I SAID I WAS
AROUND WHEN WE HAD TO MAKE CUTS
BACK IN TWENTY TEN SO I'M NOT
PROPOSING WE DON'T MAKE CUTS
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE A
BALANCED BUDGET BUT WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT CUTS WE MAKE WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT WELL WHAT.
WHAT ARE THE TRADEOFFS RIGHT SO
THAT A TRADE OFF A NINE TO ONE
MATCH TO A ONE POINT SOMETHING
MATCHING LIKE WELL SHOULD WE
KEEP THE NINE A ONE MATCH
UNLESS THE SERVICES THAT WE'RE
GETTING NINE ONE MATCH OUR
SERVICES WE NEED RIGHT IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT INCREASING OUR-
CAN YOU SAY WELL FOR THAT
AMOUNT OF MONEY I GUESS SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DIVIDED BY FIVE-
YOU KNOW FOR THAT AMOUNT OF
MONEY IS IT BETTER TO. BRING.
PROVIDERS WHO CAN BUILD TAKES.
PERCENT PLUS MET. NOW GIVEN
THAT CREAM CHEESE CAKE OR WELL
USE THAT MONEY AND- YOU KNOW
MAYBE NOT REDUCE RATES QUITE AS
MUCH- OR SOMETHING OR WHATEVER
THE ALTERNATIVE NEST IN THE
MONEY ON SO IT IS ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT KIND OF TRADE OFFS
ARE MAKING AND OBVIOUSLY THAT
ARE ABOUT YOU KNOW THE VALUES
AND I THINK IT'S THE AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU
KNOW THE- THAT- OUR MEDICAL
DIRECTOR AT AND- THAT STARTS TO
PURR AND- AND- DOCTOR GILBERT
ARE. ARE DOING- BUT I DO THINK
THAT YOU KNOW MY QUESTIONS ARE
REALLY NOT SAY THAT WE CAN'T WE
DON'T WE'RE NOT GONNA CUT
ANYTHING I'D PREFER IF WE
DIDN'T I KNOW YOU WOULD PREFER
WE DIDN'T BUT IT'S REALLY ABOUT
WHAT WHAT ARE YOU GETTING FOR
THAT CUT RATE SO WE CUT. M. S.
S. P. THEN HOW MANY PEOPLE IN A
NURSING HOME IS THAT ENOUGH DO
WE END UP WITH FINANCIALLY
BETTER OFF OR NOT IN TERMS OF
ALSO GETTING THE SERVICES SO I
GUESS THAT THOSE ARE REALLY THE
DIRECTIONS OF MY QUESTIONS. AS
WELL AS OF COURSE YOU KNOW
ROUND PROPERTY SIX FEATURE WE
STICK TO WHAT THE VOTERS WANT
SO. A DOCTOR GILBERT DID YOU
HAVE A- DO YOU WANT TO COME. ON
THAT. YEAH I REALLY. THE YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT TRADE OFFS
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
WE'VE GOT TO KEEP THINKING
ABOUT. I WOULD MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS IN TERMS OF THE
NETWORK I MEAN ONE IS THAT. C.
H. CF- SURVEY DID SUGGEST THAT
THERE'S A REAL RISK OF- PC PEAS
YOU NO PROBLEM. NOT BEING ABLE
TO CONTINUE THEIR- THEIR
PRACTICE. WE'VE NOT SEEN THAT
VOLUME OF PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS. CLOSE YOU KNOW WE
ARE TRACKING ON A DAILY BASIS
SO- FOR EITHER BECAUSE OF
CAPITATION. OR SOME OF THE
THINGS THE MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS ARE DOING. TO YOU
KNOW. GIVE GRANTS. CHANGE THEY
PAY. PAY MORE QUICKLY YOU KNOW
ENHANCE THEIR CAPITATION
THAT'S- IN JANUARY TO PRESERVE
THE NETWORK. ALSO POINT OUT
THAT THERE ARE SOME HEALTH
PLANS THAT I'VE- WORKED IN THIS
AREA AND I'VE DONE. DIFFERENT
KINDS OF PROGRAMS TO ATTRACT
SOLUTIONS TO THEIR- PROGRAM-
BUT REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENT ABOUT TRADE OFFS BOTH
ON THAT- AND THE RISK OF.
INDIVIDUALS YOU KNOW GETTING
SICK BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
CERTAIN PROGRAM SO WE JUST WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU- PARTICULARLY AROUND. AREAS
LIKE DOES THAT MAKE SENSE ABOUT
YOUR COMMENTS. OKAY PREPARE PRE
SHEET THAT- I WOULD JUST MAKE
NOTE THAT- WELL WE HAVE MAY NOT
HAVE SEEN PRACTICES ACTUALLY.
CLOSE HELLO. BY MY FAMILY MY
WHAT MY WIFE IS PROVIDER AND SO
YOU KNOW EACH PASSING WEEK AND
I WAS TRYING TO HANG IN THERE
AND- AND I THINK THAT- AT LEAST
I'M HEARING FROM PROVIDERS BUT
ALSO HAVING PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES LIKE. EACH PASSING
WEEK WE'RE LOSING A LITTLE MORE
AND WE'RE HANGING ON A LITTLE
LESS SO PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KINDA
HANGIN IN THERE BUT THEIR
SITUATION IS GETTING WORSE AND
WORSE. I DO APPRECIATE BY THE
WAY DTS- WORKING WITH THE
MEDICARE PLANS TO REALLY TURN
AROUND TO GET THOSE PAYMENTS
OUT AND SO FORTH. AND I HOPE
THE COMMERCIAL PLANS CAN DO THE
SAME- ON THE COMMERCIAL SIDE.
BECAUSE THAT DOES IT'S OUR LIKE
SOMEONE SLIPS SLOWLY SLIDING.
OFF THE CLIFF ND ARE HANGING
ON BY THEIR FINGERS AND ONE
FINGER STARTING TO SLIP NOW SO
YEAH THEY HAVEN'T SOLVED THE
PHONE YET THIS TIME IS GOING ON
I THINK WE'RE GONNA SEE A
CASCADE. AND IF WE DON'T ACT
AND TRY TO PREVENT THAT. FROM
HAPPENING I DO APPRECIATE DTS.
THE DRESSING THE FLOW I TRY TO
MOVE HIM UP FROM MUCH MORE.
TURNING AROUND CLEAN CLAIMS SO.
THAT THAT'S CERTAINLY VERY
HELPFUL. HEY THERE'S SO MANY
OTHER QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO ASK
BUT WE ARE LIMITED IN TIME I
THINK THERE'S A PRIDE THAT
MAJOR ITEMS I WANT TO. TOUCH
ON- YEAH WE TALK ABOUT
PRACTICES HOSPITALS AS WELL. AS
THEIR CHALLENGES AS WELL I
UNDERSTAND IT WAS SOME PROPOSAL
TO. CAP THE- PAYMENT TO
HOSPITALS WHICH I THINK IT WAS
GONNA BE PROBLEMATIC AS WELL.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S
SPECIFICALLY PARDON ME REVISE.
BUT LET'S- MAYBE I'LL JUST
QUICKLY TOUCHING. AGAIN. ON
THREE FORTY B. REAL QUICKLY.
THE AGAIN HIGH YOU GET IT YOU
KNOW WE HEARD THE PRESENTATION
ORIGINALLY HINGE AND JANUARY
IT'LL SAVE THE STATE GENERAL
FUND. BUT THE COST OF THAT IS
ACTUALLY PULLING EVEN MORE
MONEY OUT OF SIR THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM IN TERMS OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO TAKE YOUR PATIENCE
FROM- I UNDERSTAND THERE WERE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY BEFORE. AND IN
FACT IN THE JANUARY PROPOSAL-
DIVERSITY OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT FULL HELP MAKE UP FOR
THE FACT THAT- THIS MONEY WAS
GOING TO BE PULLED OUT OF
CLINICS AND HOSPITALS AND
OTHER. PROVIDERS FOR SERVICES
FOR PATIENTS. BUT I THINK THE-
THE ELIMINATION STEP ON PAINFUL
AND- AND SHIFTING IT OVER WELL
CERTAINLY HAS GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS. THAT HAS A MUCHLARGER
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE TOTAL
OVERALL RESOURCES AVAILABLE
FOR. ASIANS ON MEDICARE OUTSIDE
DID WANT TO RAISE THAT ISSUE AS
WELL- BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S A
PARTICULAR CONCERN. OF MINE IN
TERMS OF SAYING WHAT KIND OF
SNOW WHAT'S THE TRADE OFF AGAIN
SO WHAT ARE WE TAKING OUT WHAT
WE GETTING FOR WHAT WE'RE
TAKING OUT NOW MILLIE THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT DEPENDS ON
WHO GETS THE MONEY SO- SO. I
JUST WANT TO DEPEND ON THAT AS
WELL. OKAY ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS AROUND DCS OKAY.
HELLO AGAIN THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH I KNOW IT'S A DIFFICULT
TIME- AND I KNOW DTS IS THAT
RIGHT YES THE COVER OF A THIRD
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
PROBABLY IN COMING UP FROM
THERE. AND HALF OF ALL KIDS AND
DELIVERIES- APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
HARD WORK AND LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR ON GOING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT. THE MEDICAL. AND OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE OVERSEEING
SO THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. CANADA IS A
STATE WE LOVE ALL OUR CHILDREN
BUT WE HAVE I THINK THIS IS THE
ONE THAT- THIS DEPARTMENT- YOU
ARE RIGHT NOW IN THE SCOPE OF
IT PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT
APARTMENT WE SHOULD BE TALKING
TO SO- WELCOME INTO THE
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION-
FOR. THE MAYBE VICE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH JEFFERSON. AND BUT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS REALLY
APPRECIATE DURING THAT TIME IN
PARTICULAR YOU'RE CAREFUL AND
THOUGHTFUL REFLECTION ON OUR
BUDGET AND QUESTIONS THEY WERE
VERY PLEASED TO ANSWER THEM I'M
GONNA TURN THIS OVER TO OUR-
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF-
ADMINISTRATION BRANDON NEWNESS
AND HE'S GOING TO GO THROUGH
THAT. ARE YOUR BANKING YOU HEAR
ME YES. PERFECT SO QUICKLY THE
FIRST FOUR QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA ADDRESS ARE FOR UPDATES
TO THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
DEPARTMENT- OUR AGE DRUG
SYSTEMS PROGRAM ARE WOMEN
INFANTS AND CHILDREN PROGRAM
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION AND
OUR GENETIC DISEASE SCREENING
PROGRAM FOR ALL OF THESE FOUR
ESTIMATES REALLY WELL WE'VE
DONE IT IN THE REGION IS JUST
PROVIDED AN UPDATE AS IT
RELATES TO MORE CURRENT%
PROJECTIONS RELATED TO CASELOAD
AND POSSIBLY BEEN EXPERIENCING
SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SO
JUST HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE FOR
AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
THE MAYOR VISIONS PROJECTING UP
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWELVE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WHICH IS
A SEVENTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR DECREASE AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT POINT FOUR
MILLION- WHICH IS A TWENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS INCREASE.
DECREASE RATHER- SENSE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THAT'S
SERVING CLIENTS OF ABOUT THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND AND 360-004-1920
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
RESPECTIVELY- MOVING OVER INTO
OUR WICK PROGRAM AGAIN NO MAJOR
REVISIONS OTHER THAN JUST
FLOATING COST AT THE EXPENSE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- WE'RE
PROJECTING- ROUGHLY A BILLION
DOLLARS. FOR BOTH NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND THE FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH
THE WICK ROGRAM- SERVES ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND CLIENTS AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SIXTY NINE THOUSAND CLIENTS
IN NINETEEN TWENTY- ONE THING
JUST TO HIGHLIGHT QUICKLY FOR
THIS- GIVEN I MEAN OF COURSE.
THE WORK ESTIMATE AT THIS
POINT- WAS DEVELOPED PRIOR TO
THE STATE HOMEOWNERS GOING INTO
EFFECT WE ARE WATCHING THIS-
PROGRAM CLOSELY BECAUSE WE DO
EXPECT THAT THE- CLIENTS- TO
SEE THE CASE FOR THE INCREASE
IN THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM AS
MORE CLIENTS COME UNDER THE
PROGRAM- SO WE'LL BE WATCHING
THAT AND PROBABLY HAVE. A NEW
ESTIMATE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR
NEXT YEAR THAT REFLECTS KIND OF
SOME OF THE IMPACTS OF THE.
CURRENT SITUATION TANAMI. FOR
THE MOVING ON TO THE GYM
DISEASE SCREENING. AGAIN NO
CHANGES CASE FOR THIS PROGRAM
WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION IN. HERE AND ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION ALSO IN
BUDGET YEAR- AND JUST A SLIGHT
DECLINES- SERVING ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CLIENTS ON- THIS PARTICULAR IS.
ONLY GENETICALLY SCREENING
PROGRAM. QUICKLY ON THE CENTER
FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY
ESTIMATE- AGAIN. SOME OF THE
CHANGES THAT OCCUR- IN THIS
AREA ARE RELATED TO A PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAD AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET POINT IN TIME ALL WE'RE
REALLY DOING IN A COUPLE OF
AREAS IS- WE'RE DEFERRING SOME
OF THE COSTS INTO THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO YEAR AND
SHIFTING SOME OF THOSE- SO WE
HAD- A PROPOSAL IN GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. TO PROVIDE ABOUT- TO
SUPPORT ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN POSITIONS ARE GONNA BE
PHASED IN OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD OR SIMPLY SHIFTING THE
PHASE IN OF THOSE POSITIONS ARE
STILL GOING TO RECEIVE A
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN BUT SOME OF
THOSE COSTS WILL SHIFT INTO-
THE BODY HERE AND SORRY INTO
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
RESULTING IN ABOUT SAVINGS OF
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. AND THEN ANOTHER
PROPOSAL WE REQUESTED ABOUT
FIFTY THREE POSITIONS REPORTER
CENTRAL LOCATIONS BRANCH WE'RE
STILL REQUESTING AND ARE GOING
TO RECEIVE THE FIFTY THREE
POSITIONS IN THE BUDGET YEAR
BUT THE COST TO SUPPORT THOSE
POSITIONS WILL JUST BE SHIFTED
OUT INTO THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FISCAL YEAR RESULTING IN
ABOUT SIX POINT FIVE MILLION IN
SAVINGS. SO THOSE ARE QUICK
UPDATES ON- BEFORE ESTIMATES WE
HAVE IN THE DEPARTMENT- MOVING
ON TO QUESTION FIVE THERE WAS A
QUESTION RELATED TO SOME OF THE
REVERSION THAT ARE OCCURRING IN
OUR BUDGET SPECIFICALLY SUMMER
VERSIONS FOR THE- SICKLE CELL
DISEASE PROGRAM THE FORMER
HEALTH STUDY. AND THE NON
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
FUNDING THIS WAS ALL FUNDING
THAT WE RECEIVEDIN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET. SO A
QUICK UPDATE ON THE FARM WORKER
HEALTH STUDY WE RECEIVED. ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION THERE. ONE
POINT. ROW ABOUT. WAS MEANT TO
BE PROVIDED TO THE U. OF.
MERCED TAK. IMPLEMENTING
CONDUCT THE STUDY THAT MONEY
WAS PUSHED OUT. THE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND THAT'S BEING
REVERTED WAS ESSENTIALLY A
STATE OPERATIONS HE'S HERE AT
THE DEPARTMENT THAT WAS MEANT
TO KIND OF SUPPORT THE
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THIS
PROPOSAL. BUT JUST CANCELING
THE FUNDING RELATED TO THE
STUDY ITSELF TO- UC MERCED HAS
GONE OUT. FOR THE- DISEASE
CIVIL TELL THESE PROGRAM
RATHER- WE RECEIVED A ONE TIME
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- FOURTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED TO
THE CENTER. FOR COMPREHENSIVE
CARE AND DIAGNOSIS OF INHERITED
BLOOD DISORDERS FOR THE BUDGET.
TO IMPLEMENT THE NETWORK-
PRIMARY AND SPECIALTY CARE
PROVIDERS. ON THAT MONEY TO GO
OUT AND DIDN'T THE PIECE THAT'S
BEING REVERTED- IN THIS
LANGUAGE IS SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AGAIN. ON A STATE
OPERATIONS SIDE TO SUPPORT
JUSTIN STATE OPERATIONS BRANDON
MINISTRATION ACTIVITIES- FOR
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM. AND
THEN FINALLY LAST TOUR VERSION
WAS FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES FUNDING THAT WE
RECEIVED LAST YEAR. EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS WAS PROVIDED IN
GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM- WE HAD
SPENDING AUTHORITY AVAILABLE TO
US ALL THE WAY THROUGH JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND SO WE'VE
BEEN DOING SOME PLANNING
RELATED TO THAT IN THIS FISCAL
pREVERSION- WE'LL PUT THAT
PROJECT. ON HOLD. TO QUESTION
NUMBER SIX RELATED TO SOME
FUNDING THAT WE ARE REQUESTING
AND THE MAYOR VISION FOR A
CHILDHOOD LEAD. POISONING
PREVENTION PROGRAM- BACK A FEW
BUDGET CYCLES AGO I BELIEVE IT
WAS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN- WE RECEIVE SOME
FUNDING FOR SOME- POSITIONS TO
EXPAND OUR CHILDHOOD LEAD
PREVENTION PROGRAM- AS WELL AS
SOME FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED
TO ARE PARTNERING WITH THE
FIFTY LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS. BUT ALSO
PROVIDE- PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR US- WHAT
WE'RE REQUESTING IN THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET REQUEST IS
SIMPLY- THOSE THOSE. THOSE
DOLLARS WERE LIMITED TERM
ESSENTIALLY INITIALLY WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS JUST TO
EXTEND THOSE DOLLARS
PERMANENTLY. AND THEN ANOTHER
TWO POINT- ONE MILLION DOLLARS-
AND IS BEING REQUESTED TO
ADDRESS- SOME OF THE FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE-
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITORS
TWENTY NINETEEN ON A REPORT- TO
ADDRESS THOSE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS- SPECIFICALLY
IN THE AREA OF. RESPONDING TO
INCREASE CASELOAD AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- REQUIRING ADDITIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL FORSMAN BY LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS AND THE
MORE ROBUST EVALUATION WORK-
HERE WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
THIS TWO POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS WILL ESSENTIALLY HELP
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
FINDINGS THAT WERE INCLUDED. IN
THE AUDITOR'S REPORTS. MOVING
TO QUESTION NUMBER SEVEN U. S.
QUESTION ABOUT THE AUGMENTATION
FOR THE PROPOSAL WE HAVE FOR
THE CENTER FOR LABORATORY
SCIENCES WILL APPROVE STAGE
TESTING CAPACITY- WE REQUESTED
FIVE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUNDIN THE MIRROR
VISION TO SUPPORT LAB CAPACITY
IN OUR RICHMOND LAB. SIMILAR TO
THE CHILDHOOD LEAD PROGRAM THIS
WAS ALSO COMBINING THAT WE
RECEIVED BACK I THINK IT WAS IN
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT.
THE POSITIONS WERE PERMANENT
BUT THE- THE DOLLARS THAT WERE
SUPPORTING THOSE POSITIONS WERE
LIMITED TERM THIS FUNDING WOULD
CONTINUE SUPPORT FOR THOSE
POSITIONS. AS WELL AS PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. TO ENHANCE
OUR LAB CAPACITY OUT THE
RICHMOND LAB PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO SOME PROBABLY THE
INSTRUMENT AND SUPPLIES THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO. HELP INCREASE
OUR- TESTING CAPACITY FROM
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND TESTS PER
DAY. TO ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND
TESTS PER DAY. AND THEN FINALLY
WITH QUESTION NUMBER EIGHT I
THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND AS WE DISCUSSED THROUGHOUT
THE HEARING ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AREAS RELATED TO-
LOANS WE DO HAVE FOUR DIFFERENT
LOANS IN OUR AREA THE ONE
THAT'S ASKED FOR IN THIS
QUESTION RELATED TO NUMBER
EIGHT IS THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR LOAN FROM OUR AGE DRUG
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM- I THINK
FINANCIAL ADDRESS SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS RELATED TO LONGER
PAYMENT- FOR US THIS PARTICULAR
FUND- DOES HAVE A HEALTHY
RESERVE WE DON'T ANTICIPATE ANY
IMPACT ON THE PROGRAM AS A
RESULT OF THIS FUN PROVIDING A
LOAN TO THE GENERAL FUND- FOR
THE JUST PARK THERE. AND THEN
WITH QUESTION NUMBER NINE- WE
HAVE OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS. AUSTRALIA COME UP
REAL QUICKLY. THANK YOU. YEAH
AND I DON'T KNOW BUT YOU CAN
HEAR ME I CAME HERE FOR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO BE
TODAY REGARDING AND THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING AROUND THAT
TODAY MAY TWENTY FOURTH WHICH
MARKS THE FOURTH MONTH BUT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK I'M ON BEHALF OF THE KOBE
NINETEEN RESPONSE JANUARY
TWENTY FOURTH AND TWENTY-
ACTIVATED OUR MEDICAL HEALTH
COORDINATION CENTER. IN
RESPONSE AND WE IMMEDIATELY
BEGAN A WEEKLY ALL FACILITY
CALLED ON JANUARY TWENTY EIGHT-
TO BE ABLE TO HEAR HOW THEY
CHEW A CONVERSATION FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO GET UPDATED
INFORMATION ALL OF. OUR TWELVE.
HUNDRED IN ADDITION TO ALL
LEVIN THEY- FACILITY THAT BE
LIKE AN EIGHTY EIGHT. THEY CAN
ALSO BE ABLE TO ASK. WE AVERAGE
ABOUT- A LITTLE BIT LESS THAN
TWO THOUSAND I'M OLD ALL OF THE
WEEKLY CALLED THE ENACTED ON
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHT. THE
DECISION ABOUT MAYBE ADDING A
THIRD DAY ALL THE LADY CALLED
FOR JOBS AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. SO THAT THEY CAN
HAVE. A QUESTION ABOUT ACTION
PREVENTION. INTO ANY WORRY WE
DESIGNED WEBINARS- FROM OUR
HEALTHCARE ACQUIRED INFECTIONS
STRIKE TEAM. THEY BEGAN DOING
WELL IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DO
I'M TRAINING TO ALL OF OUR
FACILITIES PARTICULARLY ARE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES. YOU
KNOW A LOT OF EXTRA INFORMATION
AS FAR AS HOW TO DON DON. AND
USE PVC CORRECTLY- AGAIN THE
CALL THAT. IN ADDITION TO BEING.
THE WEATHER R. THAT WEEKEND
THOSE IN FEBRUARY WE ALL
ATTENDED TO REALIZE THAT WE
NEEDED TO OUR IMPACT CONTROL
RIGHT. AND BEING THAT WE CAN
JUST INFECTION AND OVERNIGHT
OUT OF THIN AIR WE DECIDED TO
GO AHEAD AND RE DIRECT SOME OF
OUR STATE OUR END OF OUR AND
WHAT MANY PEOPLE NOW IN OUR
HAPPENS OR HEALTHCARE
UNDERVALUATION ARE SAID AND
TRAIN SOME OF THEM SHOULD HAVE
BEEN BACK UP THE PATH BUT THE
BIG IP COMPETENCIES THEY CAN
ALSO THEN. BE THE FACTION
CONTROLLED BY TEAMS TO BE ABLE
TO GO INTO ALL THE
TECHNICALITIES OKAY NOW BREAK
TO BE ABLE TO IMMEDIATELY
CHANGE THAT EXPOSURE AND
PROPERLY COHORT DOES WORK SAID
THAT YOU WEREN'T GOING TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH BARS JACKIE. I'M
IN ADDITION TO THOSE TRYING
TEAM WE ALSO AND FEBRUARY AND
MARCH RE DIRECTED ALL SIX
HUNDRED OF OUR HEALTHCARE
EVALUATOR NURSES FROM DOING
THEIR REGULAR. ONCE A YEAR AND
YOU MAY HAVE ALTHOUGH
INDIRECTLY ALL OF OUR
FACILITIES I THINK WE TARGET
OUR SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
PART FOR WHAT WE CALL.
INFECTION PREVENTION RIGHT AND
THEN FOR MADE FOR. BIG PLAY ON
ALL OUR PARTNERS TRYING TO
PREVENT OUTBREAKS BY ABLE GET
TIME IT. AND TRY GOOD MORNING
AGAIN THAT'S AT THE- PRIOR TO
ANY KIND OF OUTBREAK WE HAD A
HAD BOTH PREVENTS MATTER
MEASURED BE PRO I. AS WELL AND
ARE TRYING GOING OUT. STEEL TO
HELP MITIGATE THAT YOU ALSO IN
WE DECIDED WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO WORK. OR FLAG SPACE
CYBERSPACE FOR DOLLARS YOU CAN
DELETE THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
TOGETHER WHAT OTHER
DEPARTMENTS. TO CREATE OVER A
THOUSAND EXTRA BED SPACE IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY. AROUND
EIGHT AND THOSE CAN BE USED FOR
ABOUT A THIRD THERE IS A
POPULAR SEARCH FIRST AS WELL AS
THE FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A COUPLE OF POSITIVE
PATIENT CALL THE LEFT THERE ON
INTEL THEY ARE UNINTENDED
NEGATIVE TO WHETHER THEY COULD
GO. BACK TO THEIR REGULAR
RESIDENT IN ADDITION TO. IN
APRIL. READ AND READ. THAT WE
TO BE. THERE ON SITE. AS EARLY
AS POSSIBLE AND HOW CAN WE
START DAY. WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
OUT AND MAY HAVE- THAT NEED. SO
WE DECIDED TO START A AN ONLINE
DASHBOARD. WE HAD. THE LEAD
MANDATORY REPORTING THE BRAND
NEW ON PC. YOU OVER. JACK AND
ARE. AFTER BE ABLE TO DEAL OR
SPENT THIS WHITE HOUSE COME IN
PATIENTS THEY HAVE HOW MANY HOW
IT CONTRACTUAL. GENTLE PATIENT
THEY HAVE AS WELL AS
INFORMATION ABOUT P. P. E.
RESOURCES AFTER YOU READ FOR.
WHAT THE SITUATION AT FOR THE
HEALTH CARE WORKER. THE DAILY
REPORT BY NOON AND WHEN THEY
REPORT IT POPPED UP ON A
CALIFORNIA MAP DASHBOARD IT'LL
EITHER POP UP AT A RED LIGHT OR
GREEN LIGHT THE POP OF THE RED
LIGHT THAT OUR STAFF
IMMEDIATELY IN THE DISTRICT
OFFICE. WILL CONTACT THE
FACILITY TO SEE WHAT IS THAT
URGENT NEED AND WHAT IS GOING
ON THE FACILITY THEY ALSO
CONDUCT ON SITE IN THE
IMMEDIATELY. THE ISSUE IP TRAIN
ISSUE THAT MAY NEED. AMERICAN
ALL MAKE A REFERRAL TO OUR AGE
I DRINK THAT THAT. IT THERE ARE
ANY STAFFING OR P. P. AND THEY
NOT TRACK HELP THEM MAKE A BIG
PROPERLY HOW THIS REQUEST GO
OUT THROUGH THE MARKET. DEMAND
SYSTEM. IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
THEN PARTICIPATE- HISTORICAL
COMPLIANCE HISTORY. AND MAKE A
LOGARITHM WITH INFORMATION FROM
BOTH HISTORY AS WELL AS THE
CURRENT INFORMATION WE WERE
GETTING FROM THESE DAILY
DASHBOARD. TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
KIND OF A RUDIMENTARY-
PREDICTIVE ANALYTICS. AND SO WE
BASICALLY BASED OFF OF ALL THE
INFORMATION WE ACQUIRE WE DON'T
HAVE WHAT'S CALLED A HIGH RISK
LET NOT HIGH RISK LET'S GET
THAT OUT EVERY DAY. AND YOU ARE
JUST ADOPTED IN A CONTACT WITH
THE DELETE MAY BE AT HIGHER
RISK CATEGORY IF I TRANSLATE
WITHOUT RIGHT INTENTIONALLY
HAVE. ID ISSUE. AND THAT AGAIN
THE RESULTS THAT. YOU WANT BY
BACKTRACK ALTHOUGH IN ME WE CAN
PAINT EVERY. THAT HELPFUL AND
YOU'RE RIGHT. THAT THESE
OUTBREAKS. KILLER THINK THAT
THE ONLY. NOT A CALIFORNIA
ISSUE THE NATION ON ISSUE. AND
MET WITH THE DOES GOD WHAT ARE
YOU COMPLAINING AND CREATIVE
WAY THAT WE CAN EVEN CHANGE THE
QUALITY AND. OVERSIGHT PROCESS.
THEY AT THE END IT IS VERY IN
IN SEEING THERE ARE A CHANCE
HIGHER DO YOU THINK GOING
FORWARD AND INDUSTRY WITH THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY WE
RECOGNIZE THAT- THAT PANDEMIC
SHOULD HIGHLIGHTED THAT THE GAP
AND BETTER- THE INDUSTRY'S
ABILITY TO HANDLE INFECTION
PREVENTION AS WELL AS OUR
NATION WIDE APPROACH TO DOING
IT LICENSURE AND CERTIFICATION
AND. QUALITY IN THE OVERSIGHT
PROCESS. I OKAY. IS REALLY A
DEVICE. SIX NEW STRATEGIES AND
ONE OF THE STRATEGIES WILL
REALLY KIND OF OVERHAUL AND
REFORM HOW WE IMPLEMENT THE P.
OVERSIGHT- AND- KIND OF HIGH
LEVEL I WOULD BE. DOING AND
HAPPY TO GO AND I KNOW WE'RE IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME HERE BUT I
CAN DEFINITELY GO INTO THOSE
BIG STRATEGIES AND OR ANSWER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. WELL MAYBE WHAT WE'LL
DO IS APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE
VERY SHORT ON TIME AND- SO WHAT
I APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION-
IT WILL GO. ON AND COMES FROM
LA. CONSIDER BALANCE ON YOUR
CREDIT FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I HAVE JUST
THREE BRIEF COMMENTS- THE FIRST
IS ABOUT THE BLACK INFANT
HEALTH PROGRAM WHICH IS ON THE
AGENDA. IT WASN'T DISCUSSED AS
SPECIFICALLY VIA THE QUESTIONS.
I'M AS YOU KNOW THIS PROGRAM
MAKES EFFORTS TO REDUCE HEALTH
DISPARITIES BETWEEN AFRICAN
AMERICAN MOTHERS AND INFANTS
AND- MOTHERS AND INFANTS IN
OTHER RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS.
WE ALSO NOTE THIS TIME A COUPLE.
DISPROPORTIONATE EFFECT ON THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY SO
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
REMOVING FOR DOING IT OR A
PROGRAM THAT. INTENTIONALLY
PLAYING IMPORTANT ROLE AT THIS.
OUR SECOND COMMENT HAS TO DO
WITH THE LABORATORY- THE
REQUEST FOR FUNDING FOR THE
CENTER FOR LABORATORY SCIENCES
AND WE JUST SIMPLY WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT THE ADMINISTRATION TO
TRY TO SEEK FEMA FUNDS FOR
ELIGIBLE COSTS AT LEAST IN THE
FIRST YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND THEN OUR FINAL
COMMENT WOULD JUST BE RELATED
TO SOME OF THE SMALL LOANS FROM
SPECIAL FUNDS AND- THAT SERVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- THERE ARE THREE-
SPECIAL FUNDS THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THREE MILLION EACH TO
THE GENERAL FUND. AND THESE
THREE FUNDS ARE EACH RUNNING A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AND WHILE
THEIR FUND BALANCES IT APPEARED
TO BE ABLE TO EASILY
ACCOMMODATE THE LOANS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR- WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
PROGRAMMATIC IMPACTS IN THE OUT
YEARS IF- IF THOSE DEFICITS.
RESULTING A SHORTAGE OF FUNDING
SO THAT YOU KNOW SHORT OF
REPAYMENT OR OTHER CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS- THAT COULD BE A
CONCERN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FINANCE. THE GENTLEMAN FINANCE-
FIRST ALL DRESS THE- THE LOAN
SITUATION IN TERMS OF THE LOAN
REPAYMENT- OF COURSE IN
ADDITION TO THE SMALLER ONES.
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING TOWARDS
OUR REPAYMENT PLANS. IN LIGHT
OF. FUTURE FISCAL CONDITIONS
AND IF THERE ARE POTENTIAL
IMPACTS TO PROGRAMS I JUST
POINT. THERE'S LIMITED. TO THE
PROGRAMS WILL CONTINUE TO
FUNCTION AND AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE OUT OF THIS THE SECOND
REQUIREMENT AND ADDITIONAL
FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO- THROUGH PAYING
EIGHT APOLLON. I ALSO LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
AMENDED ARCHITECTURAL SPECIAL
LANGUAGE AS REGARDS. CURRENT
BUYERS REALLY FIND ANOTHER
FEDERAL FUNDS MAY COME INTO ALI
AND TURN THE REVIEW BY THE
LEGISLATURE I KNOW THAT SO THAT
WAS A CONCERN OF LEGISLATURE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH
YOU. ON THAT MATTER. THE BLACK
INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM. IT'LL
RUN A ROLL BACK OF A TWENTY
NINETEEN PROPOSAL. RAMS STILL
BE ABOUT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
HIGHER IN TERMS OF TOTAL
RESOURCES THEN. SHE TWO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I'M NOT NOT
SOMETHING WE COURSE. EXCITED
ABOUT DOING BUT LOOKING AT THAT
OVERCOMES BUDGET PROBABLY THERE
ARE VERY FEW PLACES WHERE TO
FIND GENERAL FUND SETTINGS AND
THIS IS A HARD CHOICE. THANK
YOU. QUESTION FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY SIR DAUDA. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS MY CONCERNS OVER THE
REDUCTION FOR BEATING UP BLACK
INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM AND DIED
YOU KNOW I'M NOT A DOCTOR BUT
FROM WHAT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT- DURING COVERT- YOU KNOW
pCOMMUNITY AND NOW WE'RE
LEARNING THAT EVEN CHILDREN ARE
BEGINNING TO. HAVE AT COVERT
RELATED IMPACTS TO THEIR HEALTH
I THINK THAT THIS IS NOW MORE
THAN EVER I'D NEED TO BE
PROTECTED AND INVESTED IN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE QUESTIONS.
SERMON THIS I DO IT IN AN
INTEREST OF TIME I WILL MAKE
THIS VERY BRIEF I'M JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT THE- THE TESTING
OF STAFFING- SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND- YOU KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S MANDATORY
IN EVERY FACILITY BECAUSE- I
THINK IT'S- MORE THE LEAST HALF
OF THE DEATHS AT THAT HAVE
TAKEN PLACEIN CALIFORNIA HAVE.
BEEN OF THOSE PATIENTS IN THOSE
FACILITIES SO IF WE'RE NOT
TESTING THEN HOW ARE WE
CONTAINING AND CONTROLLING THIS
VIRUS- AND THEN THE SECOND PART
OF THIS IS I RECENTLY LEARNED
THAT MY COUNTY IS RECEIVING
PATIENTS COVERED NINETEEN.
POSITIVE PATIENTS FROM OTHER
COUNTIES- WITHOUT ANY WARNING
TO THE HOSPITALS WITHIN OUR
COUNTY SO YOU KNOW PREPARATION
IS KEY AND WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE DASHBOARD. IS
IT IS EVERY COUNTY REPORTEDLY
ON A DAILY BASIS OR SOME KIND
OF FALLING OFF THE GRID. THE
END OF ACTUALLY IF YOU DON'T
MIND CENTERED ON THIS JUST
BECAUSE MY QUESTION SIMILAR TO
YOURS- SO YOU CAN ANSWER ALL
ONE TIME. I THINK YOU KNOW I
CERTAINLY ALSO IT'S ENGLISH
ABOUT TESTING AND- PARTICULAR
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES AS
WELL AS YOU KNOW BASICALLY
DOING THE FULL CONTACT RACE
ISOLATE- PROCESS FOR OUR LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE TO. THE ONLY TEST
BUT THEN- CONTACT RESOLVES ITS
GONNA BE WITHIN THE FACILITY IF
YOU HAVE SOMEONE'S CLOSET AND
THEN B. AND ISOLATE THOSE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE POSITIVE SO CAN
YOU ADDRESS. WHAT'S BEING DONE
AND ALSO PARTICULARLY WHAT
FUNDING ARE YOU ALLOCATING TO
THAT WHERE'S THE FUNDS GOING TO
COME TO THE- TO DO THIS- AND
OUR LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS. FIRST ON MAY
ELEVENTH WE DID SEND OUT AN ALL
FACILITIES LETTER REQUIRING
THAT EVERY COLOR YOU CAN
CONSOLIDATE- IN TWENTY ONE DAYS
I HAD A FULL MEDICATION COLBERT
CLAN ANY IN THAT PLAN THEY MUST
ALSO BE ABLE TO. SPEAK ON HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO CHAT AND IN
THEIR PROPERTIES AND WHAT THEIR
CASTING PLANT IS IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND ALTHOUGH THEY'RE DUE MAY
THIRTY FIRST AND THEN AT THAT
POINT OUR TEAM WILL GO OUT EACH
ONE OF THOSE FACILITIES. TO
WORK THROUGH THEIR ATTESTATIONS
OF ALL OF THE DIFFERENT PIECES
THAT THEY HAD MEDICAID CAPPING
CREDIT TESTING. ALSO ON FRIDAY
I JUST TWO DAYS AGO WE ARE
OFTEN PREVENTED THE AUTHORITIES
LETTER THAT. REVEALED WHAT THE
CASTING CLAN AND REQUIREMENTS
ARE FOR ALL THE DELETE AND ON
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY TO WORK.
IN THE PHILIPPINES AND IN ROUTE
PLANET DATE THAT WE WILL HAVE.
A BASELINE TESTING. EVERYONE
MUST HAVE ALL OF THEIR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS BASELINE TESTED IT
WILL BE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. ON
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ON A WEEKLY
BASIS AND I WILL BE ONGOING
ALTHOUGH FOR THE SURVEILLANCE
TESTING AS WELL. THANK YOU SO
THAT IS A RESPONSE OR TARGETED
TESTING. SO THAT IS GOOD IS
THERE ANYTHING JUST ONE CALL IT
POSITIVE IN THE FACILITY
WHETHER THAT IS A RESIDENT OR A
HEALTH CARE WORKER YOU WANT AND
REQUIRE THAT EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN THAT FACILITY. WHAT
ARE YOUR HEALTH CARE WORKER
WHO'S WORKING DIRECTLY WITH-
PATIENT RESIDENT OR WHETHER
YOU'RE SELLING AND ADMIN OR IN
THE FACILITY FOR SOME THER
REASON. BUT EVERYONE WOULD BE-
CHAPTER. AND THEN COHORT
APPROPRIATELY INTO KIND OF
THREE FACTIONS YOU HAVE YOUR
YOUR TRUE NEGATIVE YOU HAVE
YOU'RE NOT. EXPOSURE WHICH WE
WOULD HAVE A ONE SECTION
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY
WOULD BE TESTED AGAIN NEXT WEEK
ABOUT THE DENTURE COMMENT. AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO POP IT IN
THEIR CORE CORE APPROPRIATELY.
AND THEN ARE IN PAYMENT ON.
OKAY SENSE THAT MANY OF OUR
PATIENTS ARE COVERED BY
MEDICARE DOES THAT MEAN
MEDICARE WAS PAYING FOR IT.
CORRECT. I JUST WANT US TO BE
CONSCIOUS SINCE WE HAVE A HARD
STOP AT ONE WE START SEVERAL
DEPARTMENTS TO GO JUST ONE
OTHER VERY QUICK QUESTION FOR
THE PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
THEN. CONTACT TRACING I KNOW
THAT THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF YOUNGER
TRACING. TRAIN TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE. WHAT KIND OF FUNDING A
RE IS ARE WE GIVING TO COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS FOR CONTACT
TRACING A STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT- FOR CONTACT
TRACING. AND BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK IT WAS IN THE MAY REVISE-
SO. SO AGAIN. I THINK WE SHOULD
BE FIGURE OUT WHAT WE NEED TO
BUDGET FOR THAT HOPEFULLY MOST
OF ITS COMING FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- BUT CAN YOU SPEAK
TO BE SURE WE HAVE ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR THE- CONTACT RACING
WE NEED FOR BOTH COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN THE STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. HI THIS IS SUSAN
TALLY I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY ON
THE PROGRAM SIDE AND THEN.
WORKING ON THE CONTACT RACING
ON THE CULT LEADER CONTACT
RACING MARK. SO. REPORT TALKED
VERY WHAT WHILE I'M WE'RE DOING
A LOT OF THIS ON BEHALF OF OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING-
SPENDING DOLLARS TO HAVE A
TRAINING PROGRAM- UCSF AND UCLA
WE'RE ALSO BUILDING AND DATA
MANAGEMENT- FEMININE DEPLOYMENT
FOR THEM- AND LARGELY USING OUR
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT WE ARE
GETTING FROM CDC FOR THAT
PURPOSE. WE'RE STILL
DETERMINING WHAT THE COUNTY'S
EXACTLY WHAT PORTION OF THAT
FUNDING WILL GO DIRECTLY TO THE
COUNTIES WE HAVE ALREADY
PROVIDED THEM WITH ALLOCATION
FROM THAT CRISIS GOING ON WHICH
IS- FROM CDC. YEAH I'M ABOUT
FORTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS UNDER
THAT PROGRAM AND ANOTHER TWENTY
MILLION UNDER THE ELP GRANT
WHICH WERE ABOUT HOW IT CAME
OUT TO THEM OKAY WE ALSO ARE
GETTING. ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT CONTACT RACING- MET
LABORATORY AND THAT- TESTING
SURVEILLANCE ON A NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS AS WE MOVE.
TOWARDS A PROPOSAL OKAY SO I
CERTAINLY WANT TO BE SURE THAT
WE HAVE ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR
OUR TESTERS ISOLATE BECAUSE
WITHOUT THAT WE CAN'T GET OUR
ECONOMY BACK AND US. WE CAN GET
ALLTHAT MONEY FROM THE FED'S
THAT THE WONDERFUL BUT ALSO
WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE'RE
TAKING STEPS WE NEED AND THAT
WERE- THAT YOU'RE REPORTING
BACK TO LEGISLATURE AND EVEN IF
IT'SALL FEDERAL MONEY. EXACTLY
WHAT RESOURCES ARE BEING PUT IN
THOSE AREAS SO I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR DEPART PUBLIC
HEALTH OKAY THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK AND- SAY
THAT LOVE ALL MY AGENCIES BUT
FOR THIS ONE YOU ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT SELF. OKAY LET'S MOVE
ON TO. NEXT IS THE PART STATE
HOW. AND I ASK YOU TO KEEP
PRESENT VERY BRIEF. I KNOW THAT
WE HAVE QUESTIONS. SO RE READY
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON AND CHAIRS
AND MEMBERS THIS IS STEPHANIE
CLINTON AND DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
AND I JUST PROVIDE A REALLY
BRIEF INTRO AND THEN GO RIGHT
INTO THE QUESTIONS SO OVERALL
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED
A TOTAL BUDGET I'M FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FOR THAT
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS- OF
TWO POINT TWO BILLION THAT WAS
REVISED DOWN BY ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION-
WITH THE PROPOSED CHANGES TO
THE PARK OUR BUDGET THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
PROMOTE THE SAFETY. OF STATE
HOSPITAL PATIENTS AND STAFF
DURING COBIT NINETEEN WITH
RESPECT TO CASELOAD AS IN
PREVIOUS YEARS WE DO CONTINUE
TO EXPERIENCE REFERRALS OUT HIS
CAPACITY AS IT RELATES TO OUR
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
PATIENTS ARE PROJECTED SENSORS-
ENGINE THIRTY OTHERS INCLUDING
OUR STATE HOSPITALS CONTRACTED
PROGRAMS AND CONDUCT PROGRAMS
IS- SEVEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR SH AS OF MAY
EIGHTEENTH AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE HAD ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
PATIENTS AWAITING PLACEMENT IN
A STATE HOSPITAL PROGRAM OF
WHICH ELEVEN HUNDRED NINE WHERE
INDIVIDUALS FOUND INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL. AND HE
ESTIMATES PRIMARILY ADDRESSED
AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CAPACITY.
TO TREAT RELATIONS. IT'S GOING
INTO THE THAT RECALL. THERE WAS
ONE. TO OUR ROOFING PRIDE. AND
THERE'S THE PROPOSAL INITIALLY
A GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS TO
REPLACE SEVEN GROUPS- THE
REEBOK THE REVISIONS AND MAY
REVISION WORK TO REDUCE THAT
DOWN TO THREE GROUPS ONE FOR.
AT NOW METROPOLITAN. STATE
HOSPITALS. IS THE QUICKLY THE
QUESTION ASKED TO DESCRIBE THE
TIMELINE FOR THE ROOF REPAIR
PROJECTS IN PARTICULAR THE
COSTS AND TIMING FOR PLANNING
AND OTHER PREPARATIONS AS WELL
AS THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION.
AND EXPECTED START AND
COMPLETION DATES- IF APPROVED
OF THE PLANNING AND DESIGN
PROCESS WOULD PROCEED IN JULY
OF THIS YEAR AND WOULD INCLUDE
THE PREPARATION OF PRELIMINARY
DRAWINGS REGULATORY REVIEWS AND
FINAL WORKING DRAWINGS AND PART
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO LEAVE
YOU JUST CUT STRAIGHT TO THE
END WHEN DO WE EXPECT THE
ROOFS- IF WE DO THE THREE
ROOMS. AND A WEEK AFTER THAT
BIDDING ON PROJECTS WHERE WE
EXPECT CONSTRUCTION IS
ESTIMATED TO BEGIN IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WITH ME-
PROJECTS TO BE COMPLETED IN-
TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS
THEREAFTER OKAY SO NOT UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO ACTUALLY
START OKAY YES ALL RIGHT. HELLO
FROM THE DESIGN AND- BEING IN
AND PROJECT WORKING TIME OKAY
AND THEN I WITH RESPECT TO THE
OTHER PROPOSAL AND THE OTHER
RISKS THAT ARE NOT REPLACEMENT
FORWARD WE WOULD CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE RETURNS TO MAINTAIN THE
WRISTS AND TELL US THE FUNDING
TO REPLACE ROOFS. CAN BE
IDENTIFIED OR OBTAIN. THE
PURPOSE. QUESTIONS WERE RELATED
TO A STAFF STUDY AT THE FOR ONE
WAS RELATED TO- THE TREATMENT
TEAM STAFFING STUDY PROPOSAL
THIS WAS FOR TREATMENT IN A
PRIMARY CARE AND ASKED TO
PLEASE DESCRIBE THE CHANGES I'M
GONNA HIT REALLY HIGH LEVEL-
ARE NATIONALLY THIS PROPOSAL
PROPOSED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
CONDITIONS FOR A STANDARD
PROCESS FIVE YEAR PERIOD WITH-
BASIN AND- TREATMENT TEAM
RESOURCES- PRIMARY CARE
RESOURCE HAS- SOME. RESOURCES
FOR. DISCHARGE PLANNING AND
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE ALL COMING
IN IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND WE
HAVE NOW RE PRIORITIZE JUST
FOCUSING ON THE PRIMARY CARE
AND MEDICAL AND PHYSICIAN
LEADERSHIP- RESOURCES IN THE
BUDGET YEAR ALL OTHERS WILL
BEGIN TO PHASE AND BEGINNING IN
JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. OKAY
WITH RESPECT TO THE NURSING-
ESTIMATES. THIS WAS AN UPDATE
RELATED TO- THE DIRECT CARE
NURSING BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
THAT WAS APPROVED FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR. AND ULTIMATELY
THE CHANGES IN THIS PROPOSAL-
WE RECOGNIZING- OUR SHIFTING
PRIORITIES FOCUSED ON CURBING
NINETEEN RESPONSE- AND- TO HELP
ADDRESS THE GENERAL FUND
DEFICIT WE ARE PROPOSING TO
PHASE THIS PROJECT NOW. INSTEAD
OF OVER THREE YEARS OVER A
TOTAL OF FIVE YEARS- THE THERE
WAS AFTER HOURS- SUPERVISING
REGISTERED NURSE POSITIONS THAT
WERE ORIGINALLY PROPOSED. PHASE
AND INTO YOUR CELLS WILL BE
THREE YEARS AND THEN THE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
MEDICATION RAM PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY PLANNED TO IMPLEMENT.
OVER THREE YEARS WILL NOW BE
FIVE YEARS. OKAY I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTION THANK FOR
MUCH. ACCORDING TO SHIA LA-
JUST A FEW JUST ONE COMMENT
RELATED TO THE TREATMENT TEAM
PROPOSAL- ONE OF THE POSITION
TYPES THAT IS BEING REDUCED FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR IS-
PSYCHIATRISTS BUT THE
DEPARTMENT IS STILL PROPOSING
TO STAFF- A LARGE NUMBER OF
PSYCHIATRISTS AT THE END OF
THIS PROPOSALS- PHASE IN
PERIOD- WE'RE CONCERNED THAT A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THOSE
POSITIONS WOULD GO ON SALE. GO
UNFILLED GIVEN THOSE
DEPARTMENTS LONGSTANDING ISSUES
WITH HIRING PSYCHIATRIST- SO
THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO APPROVE
THIS PROPOSAL WE WOULD
RECOMMEND PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
REPORT BACK ON ITS ABILITY TO
FILL THOSE VACANCIES OKAY THANK
YOU CERTAINLY WANT TO BE SURE
THAT. WE DON'T WE HAVE PEOPLE
ALL RIGHT FINANCE. HE COMES
FROM FINANCE HI. IRAN IS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS- ONE SMALL
COMMENT IN RESPONSE TO THE
ALLEY- THANK YOU COREY AND THE
STATE HOSPITALS DOES PROVIDE A
AN ESTIMATE AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND I'M A REVISION.
LOCATION OF ALL THEIR BUDGETARY
CHANGES AND THERE ARE UPDATES
AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND MAY
REVISION FOR THE MISSION BASED
REVIEW PROPOSALS INCLUDING. HOW
STAFFING IS GOING IN AND HOW
HE- COUPLES ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED OKAY THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT OKAY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY.
NOW IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY CONVENTION.
COMMISSION CAN ASK YOU TO TRY
TO KEEP YOUR PRESENTATION VERY
BRIEF- JUST BECAUSE WE'RE ON
THE TOPIC OF A TIME CRUNCH BUT
CERTAINLY VERY IMPORTANT WHAT
YOU DO. SO YOU AN JUST SPEAK
TO HOW THE COVER THIS IMPACTED.
COMMISSION IN TERMS OF-
ALLOCATION. SIXTY THREE FUNDS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THAT
THE NUMBERS- IN TERMS OF THAT
ISSUEWE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT
THE- CURRENT FISCAL INCENTIVES
AROUND MHSAA ARE REALLY
DESIGNED TO ENCOURAGE COUNTIES
TO SPEND MY QUICKLY. AND THE
POLICY REALLY FOCUSES ON LONG
TERM LONG TERM PLANNING
FRAMEWORK WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
CURRENT PLANS MAY NOT BE
REFLECTIVE OF BOTH-
ORGANIZATIONAL PRIORITIES
RECOGNIZING WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
TERMS OF THE ECONOMY AND
OPERATIONAL REALITIES IN TERMS
OF THEIR ABILITY TO DELIVER
CARE IN WAYS THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY ENVISIONED IN THE
PLANS THAT ARE TOGETHER. THAT
THAT IS ALSO TRUE FOR THE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FINDS THAT THE
COMMISSION MAKES AVAILABLE TO
THE COUNTIES- THIS COMMITTEE'S
BEEN VERY HELPFUL IN THE PAST
FEW YEARS FOR EXAMPLE WE'RE
ABOUT TO RELEASE SCHOOL NO
HEALTH SIGNS THOSE PLANS WERE
PUT TOGETHER THROUGH A
COMPETITIVE R. F. P. THAT WAS
DONE AT THE VERY END OF THE
LAST CALENDAR YEAR WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THE SCHOOL
REALITY FOR EXAMPLE. MAY NOT
MATCH THE PLANT THE PROPOSALS
THAT THAT TAPPED JOHNNY'S ON
THEIR SCHOOL PARTNERS PROVIDED
THE COMMISSION SIMILAR CONCERNS
AROUND THESE DROP IN CENTRE
FINDING OUR TRIAGE FINDS. THE
FULL ARRAY LOCAL ASSISTANCE
FINDS THAT WE ARE MAKING
AVAILABLE TO THE COUNTIES THAT
THAT THAT MONEY IS SO IMPORTANT
TO THE COUNTIES. AND WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A MECHANISM TO
ALLOW THE STATE TO ADAPT THOSE
CONTRACTS IN WAYS THAT CAN
BRING THEM UP TO DATE WITH THAT
AGAIN BOTH THE FISCAL ME
OPERATIONAL REALITIES THAT
COUNTIES ARE FACING. WERE ALSO
WHAT WE ARE SEEING SOME
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITIES TO
BETTER PARTNER WITH OUR COUNTY
IS WE'RE DOING SOME GREAT
PARTNERING WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AGING STATE HOSPITAL
STATE CSPD PEOPLE REACHING OUT
FIRST FIVE. WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED AGAIN AROUND SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE SO ANY OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOME FLEXIBILITY TO SUPPORT THE
ABILITY OF COUNTY SCHOOLS ARE
CDOS AND OUR PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTNERS IN TERMS OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION WOULD BE IMPORTANT.
AS WE ADJUSTED TO THE RIGHT IT
IS THE CANCER TO FACE. AGAIN
BOTH FOR COVETED THE-
UNCERTAINTY THAT WE FACE. YEAH
ABOUT AS BRIEF AS I CAN BE I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY YOU MIGHT
HAVE OKAY THANK YOU LMAO
COMMENTS. WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT FINANCE. WE ARE
ALMOST A PERSONAL FINANCE WE
CANNOT SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
TODAY BUT WE ARE REVIEWING THE
REQUEST AND I HAVE HAD INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
COMMISSION AND SENATE STAFF.
OKAY THANK YOU. ACCORDING TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND OKAY I
GUESS I JUST DID IT. COULD COME
IN TERMS OF- CERTAINLY WANT TO
WORK WITH THE COMMISSION TO.
FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CREATING
MECHANISMS TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
ADAPT REALIZING THAT SERVE THE
GROUNDS CHANGED OUT FROM UNDER.
AND IN TERMS OF THE PROCESS AND
SO- LOOKING FORWARD TO YOUR
SUGGESTIONS IN THAT REGARD- MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO INCORPORATE
SOMETHING INTO THE G. JUNE
BUDGET BUT PERHAPS WHEN WE AS
WE LOOK AT THE BUDGET. IN THE
NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS AS WE MAKE
FURTHER ADJUSTMENTS PERHAPS TO
BE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES SO AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE WORK AND ALSO
MENTAL HEALTH CERTAINLY IS
GOING TO. IT'S NOT A IT'S WELL
IT'S- A MELT THE MANTLE THE
EXPANDED OVER TIME SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT OKAY LET'S MOVE
ON TO COVERED CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE. OKAY WELL COME. ASK
YOU TO. KEEP THE PRESENTATION
BRIEF. HELLO. BACKGROUND YOU
NEVER KNOW HOW FAR YOU GO OKAY
YOU'RE HERE YOU. VERY GOOD I
THINK I THINK THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS- FOR HAVING US. AGAIN I
DID NOT COVER CALIFORNIA
QUALITY ELIGIBILITY IN RESEARCH
DIVISION I'LL BE COVERING THE
SPEECH SUBSIDY PORTION AND
YOU'RE JOINED TODAY WITH MY
COLLEAGUE KELLY GREEN DIRECTOR
OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS AND WILL
DEFER TO HER ON THE TRAILER
BILL CLARK- PORTIONS. OF OUR
ITEM- YOU WILL TRY TO HIT THE
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS IN THE PREPARED REMARKS SO-
BUT DON'T HESITATE COURSE TO
INTERRUPT ANY PLACE WE CAN ADD
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION. JUST
A REMINDER THAT I DO KNOW THAT
WE HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS BUT
AGAIN ASKED THAT TRY TO KEEP
THE ANSWER IS VERY BRIEF SO
THANK YOU. YEAH FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY PLAN YOU'RE THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED IN THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED NEW STATE SUBSIDIES TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL HELP TO PAY
PREMIUMS FOR CONSUMERS TO
ENROLL THROUGH COVER CALIFORNIA
IN INDIVIDUAL MARKET I MEAN
THIS INCLUDED FIRST IN THE
NATION SUPPORT TO CONSUMERS WHO
EARN BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED AND
6100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY.
AND JUST OVER THAT ELIGIBILITY
LIMITS FOR THE FEDERAL
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT SUPPORTS A
CHANGE TO THE NEW FINANCIAL
HELP THE IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE
MANDATE TO COVER COVER
CALIFORNIA SAW NEW SIGN UPS
JUMP BY OVER 40% IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY OPEN ENROLLMENT. PERIOD
OUR- EXCUSE ME. THANK YOU THAT
OPEN ENROLLMENT ALSO SAW. OVER
SIX HUNDRED. CONSUMERS CHOOSE A
PLAN AND BENEFIT FROM THE NEW
STATE SUBSIDIES. IN PARTICULAR
THE PROGRAM IS HAVING A
DRAMATIC IMPACT FOR CONSUMERS
BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED TO SIX
HUNDRED PERCENT. WHERE WE SAW
ENROLLMENT OF OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND CONSUMERS. WHO ARE
RECEIVING ON AVERAGE OF FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER HOUSEHOLD
PER MONTH. I WILL- ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON AN
ANNUALIZED BASIS. KEEP IN MIND
THAT BASED ON THE ELIGIBILITY
CURVE THAT WAS SET FOR THE
PROGRAM BY THE COVER CALIFORNIA
BOARD. OF THESE CONSUMERS EVEN
AFTER THE SUBSIDIES ARE STILL
SPENDING BETWEEN TEN AND
EIGHTEEN PERCENT. OF THEIR-
ANNUAL INCOME ON PREMIUMS IT'S
REALLY A REFLECTION OF HOW HIGH
THE COST OF COVERAGE THEY WERE
FACING WAS BEFORE THIS PROGRAM.
WHILE THE ESTIMATED ENROLLMENT
AMONG THOSE WHO EARN LESS THAN
4100% OF FEDERAL POVERTY IN THE
STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM. TRACKED
PRETTY WELL TO WHAT WAS
ESTIMATED ORIGINALLY. TAKE UP
IN THE FOUR HUNDRED TO SIX
HUNDRED GROUP HAS BEEN BOTH
PICK UP AND- A GENERAL
UNDERSTATEMENT THE SPENDING HAS
BEEN LESS THAN WAS ANTICIPATED.
THEY'RE REALLY TWO MAIN REASONS
FOR THAT. FIRST THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELIGIBILITY LEVELS WERE
SET. BASED ON MODELING WE
REALLY DIDN'T KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE WOULD SIGN UP OR HOW
MUCH THEY WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR. AND IF IT TURNS OUT BASED
ON THE CURVE THAT WAS ADOPTED
BY THE BOARD AND AGAIN THE
LIMITS IN THIS EAR THAT YOU
HAVE TO SPEND IF YOUR INCOME ON
PREMIUMS TO BETWEEN TEN AND 18%
OF YOUR INCOME. IT TURNED OUT
THAT ABOUT HALF OF THE
CONSUMERS WHO ENROLLED BETWEEN.
FOUR HUNDRED AND 6100% OF
FEDERAL POVERTY ARE ALREADY%
ELIGIBLE FOR COVERAGE THAT.
COSTS LESS THAN THAT CUT OFF AT
TEN EIGHTEEN PERCENT. AND AS A
RESULT THOSE CONSUMERS WERE NOT
ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM A NEW
STATE SUBSIDIES. THE SECOND
REASON THAT ENROLLMENT HAS BEEN
LOWER IS THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
EARNING THIS INCOME RANGE.
ABOUT ARE CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN
THE OFFER EXCHANGE AND COVER
CALIFORNIA BELIEVES THERE ARE
QUITE A FEW OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS. WE THOUGHT THAT
THEY WOULD SWITCH TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THE SUBSIDY ON
EXCHANGE AND THAT REALLY BY AND
LARGE HAS NOT HAPPENED. WE SEEN
THAT IN THE MIDDLE OF OPEN
ENROLLMENT WE WERE WORKING WITH
OUR INSURER PARTNERS AND
BROKERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
IDENTIFY SOME INTERVENTIONS TO
ENCOURAGE. THOSE CONSUMERS TO
TAKE UP THE THIS NEW FINANCIAL
HELP. BUT WE HAD TO PUT THOSE
EFFORTS ON HOLD IN LIGHT OF THE
PAINT ENDEMIC. THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ESTIMATES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE DO
ANTICIPATE OUR RENEWAL OF THOSE
EFFORTS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OPEN ENROLLMENT. AND SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK TO MAKE SURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE SUBSIDY CAN BENEFIT. ONE
ISSUES REALLY HAVE HEIGHTENED
IMPORTANCE DURING THE RECESSION
WHEN TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE
FINDING THAT THEIR INCOME. IS
LESS THAN EXPECTED IT WOULD BE
RECALLED THAT IN BOTH THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT UNDER THE
FEDERAL RULES IN THE STATE
THAT'S THE PROGRAM. IF YOUR
INCOME ENDS UP LOWER THAN YOU
EXPECTED AT THE END OF THE YEAR
WHEN YOU FIND THE FILE YOUR
TAXES. YOU CAN ONLY CLAIM A
STATE SUBSIDY OR OR FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR YOUR PREMIUMS
RETROACTIVELY IF YOU ENROLLED
THROUGH THE MARKETPLACE AND
THROUGH COVER CALIFORNIA. I'M
SO PLEASED TO ATTACKS TOGETHER.
HAVE REDUCED STATE SPENDING ON
ON THE STAGE OF THE PROGRAM AND
ARE THE REASON THAT THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL REFLECTS A
SUBSTANTIAL SAVINGS OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED. MILLION DOLLARS
RELATIVE TO WHAT WAS. INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET ENOUGH BECAUSE FOR THE
MAY REVISE WE HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF THE ACTUAL ATTITUDES.
INFLUENCED AND INFORMED BEST
MAKE YOUR POLICY WE JUST LIKE
FOCUS ON A VERY BRIEF ANSWER TO
QUESTION. FOUR FIVE. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY SO WHAT IS A TO CAN
TO GROW PROGRAM. AND WITH
REGARD TO. WE HAD AN
ANTICIPATED THAT IN EARLY APRIL
WHEN THE ESTIMATES WERE
PREPARED THE PREMIUMS MIGHT
INCREASE BY OVER 10% IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. BUT WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW MUCH CARE
IS BEING DEFERRED WE CONTINUE
TO SEE THAT THE ESTIMATES FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE ARE
FALLING ON THE OTHER HAND IF
THE RECESSION GROWTH. TAKE UP
MAYBE INCREASING AND WE
CONTINUE NOW ON THAT ISSUE.
OKAY THANK YOU AND AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE BUT WE EVERY FUN TIME
AND THEN QUESTION NUMBER SIX I
THINK IS- IS MISS GREEN GONNA
BE ANSWERING. YEAH YES MATURE
NUMBERS THANK YOU. ON QUESTION
NUMBER SIX THIS IS AN ITEM THAT
PERTAINS TO ACTUARIAL VALUE
BRONZE PLANS THE COMMITTEE. HAD
ASKED FOR A DESCRIPTION OF THE
NEED FOR THE TRAILER BILL ITEM
AND 'LL TRY TO DO THAT
DISTINCTLY. THIS ITEM WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET IT IS NEW A NEW
PROPOSAL FOR THE MAY REVISION.
IN SUMMARY COVER CALIFORNIA IS
THAT IT'S BENEFIT DESIGNS FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE PLAN
HERE. HOWEVER WITH RECENT
UPDATES TO THE METHODOLOGY USED
BY THE FEDERAL ACTUARIAL VALUE
CALCULATOR WHICH IS. WHAT WE
MUST USED TO CALCULATE THE
ACTUARIAL VALUE OF OUR BENEFIT
DESIGN. WE DISCOVERED THAT THE
ACTUARIAL VALUE FOR STANDARD
AND HIGH DEDUCTIBLE BRONZE
PLANS FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WILL NOT MEET THE ACTUARIAL
VALUE TO MEN IN THIS RANGE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE SET FORTH
IN STATE LAW. SPECIFICALLY FOR
STANDARD BRONZE PLANS STATE LAW
ALLOWS THE ACTUARIAL VALUE TO
GO AS HIGH AS SIXTY TWO
PERCENT. FOR HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
BRONZE PLANS THEY CAN RANGE AS
HIGH AS 64% AND ACTUARIAL
VALUE. BUT BASED ON THE FEDERAL
ACTUARIAL VALUE CALCULATOR FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- THE
ACTUARIAL VALUE FOR BOTH OUR
STANDARD AND HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
BRONZE HEALTH PLANS WILL
EXCEED. SIXTY FOUR PERCENT. AND
THAT THEY WILL NOT COMPLY WITH
THE ACTUARIAL VALUE DIMINISHED
RANGE THAT SET IN STATE LAW.
FROM PLANT DO NOT COMPLY WITH
STATE LAW COVER CALIFORNIA
CANNOT OFFER BRONZE PLAN AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND SO THE
TRAILER BILL PROPOSAL THAT
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION.
WOULD SET THE MAXIMUM ACTUARIAL
VALUE FOR ALL BRONZE PLANS AT
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT. AND THIS IS
IN CONFORMANCE WITH FEDERAL
RULES- AND IT WOULD ALLOW
COVERED CALIFORNIA BROWN PLANS
TO COMPLY WITH STATE LAW THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD.
WITH THEM AND OFFERING FOR NEXT
YEAR- I WILL CLOSE BY SAYING
THAT THIS IS A SIMILAR ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR WE HAD A
SIMILAR PROBLEM WITH OUR- HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLAN- BRONZE
PLANS. AND THERE WAS A SIMILAR
FIXED MADE- THROUGH THE TRAILER
BILL THAT WAS ENACTED LAST
YEAR- SO WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A- SIMILAR. SOLUTION THIS
YEAR TO APPLY TO ALL OF THE ON
PLANNED. ON AND NEED FOR. IS
URGENT THAT TWENTY PLANNING
ABOUT EVER UNDER WAY WITH THE
GOAL. OCT RENEWAL I NEVER ONE
ENROLLMENT OKAY THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
COMES FROM LA. YES SAID MR
CHAIRMAN CHRIS MARTINELLI- JUST
A VERY QUICK COMMENT WE
REVIEWED THE SIGNIFICANT
PROPOSED DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENT IN
COST FOR THE STATE PREMIUM
SUBSIDY PROGRAM. IN FINDING
THE- YOU JUST NEED TO BE TO BE
REASONABLE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FINANCE. YOU YES SIR NO
COMMENTS OKAY RIGHT QUESTIONS
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY YES
SIR MELINDA'S OUT YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION RELATING TO THE
CLINICAL VOLUNTEERING
VOLUNTEERING TRAILER BILL AND
THIS LOOKS LIKE A POLICY BILL
TO ME SO I'M WONDERING- WHY
IT'S IN HERE. YES SENATOR KELLY
GREEN COVER CALIFORNIA YES THIS
ITEM IS- IT IS IN THE- PART OF
THE BUDGET- WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THE- IF IT WERE TO BE ADOPTED
THAT WOULD ASSIST US- IN
RECRUITING- STAFF MEMBERS WHO
WOULD WISH TO SERVE AT COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND- WHO MAY BE.
INHIBITED BY THIS PARTICULAR
PROHIBITION FROM SERVING AS A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER UNLESS
YOU'RE NOT COMPENSATED- WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
RECRUITMENT FOR A NEW CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER- AND SHOULD
WOULDN'T IT HAVE BEEN AN
ACCIDENT MAY HAVE ASSISTED US
IN THAT RECRUITMENT- OKAY SO
I'M HOPEFUL THAT IN CONJUNCTION
CERTAINLY IS A PHYSICIAN WHO'S
IN THE LEAD OUT. THAT MONEY
CHALLENGES IS THAT BASICALLY
THIS PROHIBITS A PHYSICIAN WHO
IS SERVING AS NON COVERED
CALIFORNIA FROM ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO PRACTICE EVEN IF THEY
WISH TO AS A VOLUNTEER EVEN
THAT BECOMES A PROBLEM SO YOU
KNOW PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST. AND
CERTAINLY GAIN COMPENSATION CAN
RAISE THAT. THE ISSUE IS THAT
BE EVEN JUST FALLEN AT
COMMUNITY CLINICS TO KEEP THE
CLINICAL SKILLS UP. THERE WE
GO- I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND
THAT I THINK MINE IS JUST FROM
MORE OF A PROCEDURAL ASPECT IT
JUST DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE IT IN HERE
BECAUSE IT. IT SEEMS VERY CLEAR
THAT IT'S A POLICY BILLS HAS
TRAINING UNDERSTAND- WHY WE'RE
DOING IT THIS WAY BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE EXPLANATION
THANK YOU. APPLE IS RESHAPING
THE FACT THAT OFTEN WE TALK
POLICIES AND- BUDGETS OKAY. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS JUST ONE OTHER
QUICK COMMENT FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND I THOUGHT WE
TOUCHED ON IT. ON TEAMMATE C.
AS WELL AS YOU KNOW BE SURE WE
HAVE ADEQUATE PROVIDER NETWORKS
IS WE'RE CONTRACTING WITH PLANS
SO THAT PEOPLE DON'T JUST HAVE
A- DAY CARD FOR. THE PLAN BUT
THEY ACTUALLY CAN SEE. SOMEONE
FURTHER. ISSUES SO I AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT COVERED
CALIFORNIA HAS. PROVIDED SOME
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN TRYING
TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. OKAY
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE THEN OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW IT'S TO MAKE NOTE
IS NOW TWELVE THIRTY NINE WE
HAVE A HARD STOP SO SINCE WE
GOT FIFTEEN MINUTES OF. PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR ALL OF HEALTH. AT
THIS POINT IN TIME. WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND- YOU KNOW- SO
BASICALLY- FOR TOILET THANK YOU
ALL THANK. EVERYONE IS
PARTICIPATING TODAY'S HEARING
I'D LIKE TO NOW INVITE THE
PUBLIC GOING TO PARTICIPATE TO
CALL AND NOW PLEASE DIAL THIS
TOLL FREE NUMBER. 977-336-4441
AND IT'S ALSO POSTED. ON THE
VIDEO AS WELL. AGAIN.
1-877-336-4441 AND WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE. NINE EIGHT FIVE. TWO SIX
ZERO. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
BE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING ANY OF THE ITEMS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA INCLUDING THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR. FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF YOUR ORGANIZATION THE
ISSUE OR ISSUES FROM TODAY'S
AGENDA THAT YOU ARE PROVIDING
COMMENT ON. DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARING
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
YOU CLING PROTOCOLS. WE WERE
INSTITUTING A TIME LIMIT ON
TESTIMONY. CURRENTLY EACH
PERSON PROVIDING COMMA BE
PERMITTED A MAXIMUM OF ONE
MINUTE AND YOU IN FACT ONLY
HAVE FIFTEEN MINUTES THAT'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE. DETAILED
TESTIMONY CAN BE SUBMITTED IN
WRITING TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THROUGH OUR WEBSITE SO WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE AND WE WILL KEEP A VERY
STRICT TIME LIMITS SO. PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND BEGIN.
CHAIR MEMBERS KELLY BEING. HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA A
CLOSE ASSOCIATION THING YOU FOR
YOUR- AND QUESTIONS TODAY. HE
MAY ASK VILLAGE TAKE THE
FOLLOWING ACTIONS PROTECT
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE MEDICAL
BY AGAIN REJECTING THE UNLAWFUL
USE OF ONE POINT TWO BILLION IN
PROPERTY SIX TOBACCO TAX
REVENUE. JEOPARDIZING ACCESS TO
DOCTORS DENTISTS CLINICS AND
SERVICES WE ALSO ASK THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
TO ELIMINATE THE PROPERTY SIX
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM. TO
SUPPORT THE INCREASING THAT
ACCOUNT REAL MEANT THE
LEGISLATURE MUST MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY YEAR TO ORTIZ. C. M. IS
IN SUPPORT OF THE GENERAL FUND
NEUTRAL PACIFIC BUSINESS GROUP
ON HEALTH PROPOSAL THE CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S INITIATIVE WHICH
AIMS TO PRESERVE PRIMARY CARE
NETWORKS. C. MAY ALSO PROPOSES
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRED
NONPROFIT AND FOR PROFIT
INSURERS AND HEALTH PLANS.
UTILIZE PLANT MEDICAL SERVICES
MONEY TO MAINTAIN ADEQUATE
SPECIALTY PROVIDER NETWORKS.
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IS
CENTRAL TO CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY
TO RE OPEN AND MAINTAIN AN OPEN
ECONOMY. THE MAY REVISE FAILS
TO RECOGNIZE THE NECESSITY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE OMIT
THE DETAILS UNDER AND WRITING
TO OUR WEBSITE THANKS VERY MUCH
NEXT. THANK YOU WELCOME GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RONALD KOEMAN YOUR BEHALF OF
HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO REJECT THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS THAT
DECIMATE HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
ALSO BENEFITS AND ALSO THE CUTS
THAT WILL IMPACT ACCESS TO CARE
FOR CONSUMERS. WE'RE
PARTICULARLY SHOCKED AND
DUMBFOUNDED AT HOW THIS BUDGET
HAS BEEN PROPOSED TO CUT
SENIORS COVERAGE WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL SENIORS REGARDLESS OF AGE
DISABILITY HOW THEIR INCOME IS
COUNTED WHATEVER ASSETS OR
SAVINGS THEY MAY HAVE OR THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. HAVE ACCESS
TO MEDICAL. YOUR OWN COVERAGE
AS A RELEASE COVER CALIFORNIA
AT A MINIMUM WE DO THINK WE
NEED TO KEEP THE CURRENT LEVELS
OF HELP MAINTAINED BUT WE ALSO
DO REJECT THE NOTION THAT ANY
UNSPENT MONEY SHOULD REVERT
BACK TO THE GENERAL FUND.
CERTAINLY AS THE BUDGET MOVED
FORWARD LAST YEAR ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR FOR
THREE YEARS WAS ALLOWED FOR
STATE SUBSIDIES BUT THAT WAS
ONLY ONE QUARTER OF THE MONEY
THAT'S REALLY NEEDED UP AND
DOWN THE INCOME SCALE. TO MAKE
COVERED CALIFORNIA MORE
AFFORDABLE RATHER THAN
HIJACKING THESE DOLLARS WE
ACTUALLY THINK THAT THEY SHOULD
GO BACK INTO COVERED CALIFORNIA
AND BE USED TO HELP MORE
PEOPLE. BUY COVERAGE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO PAY PREMIUMS
ADDITIONALLY WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO REJECT ALL CUTS
TO BENEFITS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. WELCOME.
JEFF HARDY KIA CAN YOU HEAR ME.
HI I'M A CONSTITUENT- THANK YOU
DR PAN IS A SENTENCE SENSELESS
AND BASS AND FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN THE CENSUS
PROGRAM THIS WEEK BUT FOR HERE
I WILL OFFER THE FIRST ITEM
SAYING I AM HERE REPRESENTING
CAR OF A MILLION PLUS SENIOR
CITIZENS THAT YOU KNOW HOW MANY
OR FIVE OR SIX AND WE'LL SEE
WHAT THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING
DOES NEXT FRIDAY. BUT ALSO WE
WILL OFFER TO YOU IS ON YOUR
RESUME INTO YOUR- BUT LIKE THE
OTHER PART BE IF YOU GO OUT FOR
A DAY BECAUSE I HAVE TO GO TO
ANOTHER COMMITTEE HEARING. AND
ANOTHER BOARD OF DIRECTORS BUT
YOU'RE A DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WOULD BE
INTERESTED INVOLVED WITH YOUR
STAKEHOLDER EFFORTS ON THIS NEW
PROGRAM I. DEFINITELY BELIEVE
THAT YOU SHOULD NOT BE PURGING
AND TOMORROW LETTERS WILL BE
SENT TO THE GOVERNOR AND AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PHONE IS BUSY IT'S
BECAUSE PEOPLE AREN'T AND THEN
DATE HIM WITH CALLS. REJECTING
THE MAY REVISIONS THE JORDAN
TWENTY BILLION YOU NEEDS TO
HAPPEN TO BE CHANGED. THANK YOU.
NEXT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY SIMILAR TO
THE LA- WE BELIEVE THE
ADMINISTRATION SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER ESTIMATE CASELOAD COSTS
WITH AN EXPENSIVE CASELOAD MIX
AND EARLY SURGE PEAK WE OPPOSE
EXPANSION OF MEDICAID THE STATE
RECOVERY WHICH WILL COST
SENIORS TO DESCEND ROLE FOR
FEAR OF LOSING THEIR HOME WE
OPPOSE CUTS TO CRITICAL MEDICAL
BENEFITS INCLUDING PARTIAL
DENTURES ATOMIC TREE PODIATRY
AT DAWLISH. G. PHYSICAL THERAPY
AND MANY MORE WE OPPOSE CUTS
THAT. IMPACT THE ABILITY OF
SENIORS TO LIVE SAFELY IN THEIR
HOME INCUDING SEA BASS AND MRS
P. AND OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AND
SAID THESE CUTS WOULD DRIVE
PEOPLE TO NURSING HOMES WHERE
I'M- MOST OF. THE NINETEEN
DEATHS HAVE OCCURRED WE OPPOSE
REINSTATING THEM SENIOR PENALTY
AND ALLOWING SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES TO
PLAY. OR WOBBLE ON AND OFFER
FREE MEDICAL DESPITE NO CHANGES
IN THEIR INCOME AND- WE BELIEVE
THAT CASELOAD SAVINGS- AND THE
SENATE APPROACH TO LOOK AT
REVENUES PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT OUR
ELDERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
PERFECT ANYONE ELSE HERE AND
FORTY TWO OH THREE SCENE AND WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES. TESTIFYING
IN ROOM AT TWENTY FORTY. ST
NINE NOW- I JUST WANT TO CHECK
WITH OUR- STAFF CAN WE EXTEND
THE PERIOD OF TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS A LITTLE BIT I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE. CLEAR ISSUES SO-
SECOND BE OKAY OKAY SO. SORRY.
OKAY THANKS TO THE STAFF AND
THE TEAM WE WILL NOW TAKE
TELEPHONE A COMMENT SO WE'LL
NOW BE EXTEND PUBLIC COMMENTS.
UNTIL SUCH LEAVE ONE TWENTY
FIVE AND BECAUSE WE'LL NEED
FIVE MINUTES TO VOTE N ALL THE
ITEMS SO- SO NOW FOR ALL THE
LISTENERS WE CAN GO ON TO ONE
TWENTY FIVE WILL START TAKING
TELEPHONIC COMMENT I ASK THAT
YOU AGAIN. RESTRICT YOUR
COMMENT TO ONE MINUTE- MAXIMUM-
AND AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO MAKE A
MORE DETAILED PRESENTATION
PLEASE SUBMIT THAT AND WRITING
TO R. WEBSITES SO. MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE- PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WE
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ANY
OF THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS- AND- WE
PLEASE IDENTIFY THE ITEM YOU'RE
COMMENTING ON AND AGAIN WE'LL
BE MOVING ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING THIS AND-
AGAIN IT'S A ONE MINUTE LIMIT.
ON PRESENTATION AND WE WILL
TAKE THAT UNTIL. TWELVE ONE
TWENTY FIVE AND THEN WE WILL
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO CAP THAT
OFF. SO MONARCHY TELL ME HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE WAITING ON THE
LINE. WE CURRENTLY HAVE OVER
SIXTY. OKAY WELL WE WILL SEE
HOW MANY WE CAN GET IN THERE
AND AGAIN YOU DON'T HAVE TO USE
A WHOLE MINUTE IF YOU CAN TO
HELP OUT YOUR OTHER FELLOW.
COMMENTERS ALRIGHT SO LET'S GET
ROLLING. THANK YOU BOTH BEGIN
WITH LINE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THIS JENNIFER SNYDER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES. REPRESENT OVER NINE
HUNDRED SCHOOLERS INTO PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA. OUT OF SUPPORT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO ADOPT
THE BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS ASSUMED
BY THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. TO
REFORM THE NURSING FACILITY
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT
STRUCTURE AND EXTENDED THE
NURSING FACILITY PROVIDER
QUALITY ASSURANCE SPEAK. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ADDRESSES
THREE KEY AREAS WHICH CAPITAL
PORT FIRST ACROSS THE LIVING
RATE INCREASE NECESSARY FOR
STUDENTS TO REMAIN VIABLE
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND INTO THE FUTURE.
TO SUPPORT NURSING FACILITIES
INCREASED COSTS RELATED TO
STAFFING AND GREATER
INCENTIVIZE THEIR SUITABILITY
SPENDING ON STAFFING AND GREED
DIRECTLY TIED FUTURE
CREDIBILITY INCREASES TO.
IMPROVEMENT IN QUALITY CARE AND
NURSING FACILITY EFFORTS
RELATED TO THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. I'M WELL CAST A
GREASY THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
THAT THAT TRAILER BILL REQUIRES
SOME ADDITIONAL REVIEW WE'D
LIKE TO TRY TO WORK THROUGH
THIS REVIEW AND DISCUSS ANY
NEEDED CHANGES PROVIDERS- PRIOR
TO THE JUNE FIFTEENTH DEADLINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES. THANK YOU
DOCTOR. THANK YOU RIGHT NEXT.
THIS CALL. NUMBER THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
TWO EIGHT TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MITCH
DURING MSSP QUITE THE MODERATE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND CARE
RESOURCES ARE CLIENTS IN BOOKS
AND BONITO MONTEREY AND SANTA
CRUZ COUNTIES- WE WOULD LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE THE ADOPTION OF THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR NOT
CUTTING THE AUTOMATED BAGGAGE
TO THE CRC HAS. PROVEN BENEFITS
TO SUPPORT THE CARE GIVER TO
KEEP THEIR FOLKS WITH DEMENTIA
AND ALZHEIMER'S. IN THE HOME AS
OPPOSED TO A NURSING. LIKE WHAT
WE YOU TO NOT. THE REST OF THE
GOVERNOR TO ELIMINATE THE MSSP
PROGRAM THIS IS A COST
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM. WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF NURSING
HOMES AT A FRACTION OF THE COST
WITH A MUCH HIGHER QUALITY OF
LIFE THE CARD BEING GENEROUS
WORK DO YOU GUYS DOING IN THE
DIFFICULTIES AHEAD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU LORD I DON'T
KNOW WHAT ALL THE. WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIX EIGHT. LINE SIX EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE
GO AHEAD SIX EIGHT. CAN YOU
HEAR ME HELLO YES I CAN HEAR
YOU PLEASE BEGIN HELLO HELLO.
OKAY THANK YOU SORRY- THE DATA
PRINTERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
TRADING AT THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR CUT WITH LONG BROWN AS
QUOTE NOT MOVING FORWARD WITH
AN EXPANSION IS NOT ACCURATE
THIS FUNDING WAS ALLOCATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO REPLACE
FEDERAL AND PRIVATE GRANTS.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO
pRESCUE PROGRAM WITHOUT IT MANY
WILL CLOSE OR REDUCE CLASS BUT
ALSO TO YOUR IMPORTANT QUESTION
MISTER CHAIR THIS WOULD
UNQUESTIONABLY AFFECT THE
INCOMING CLASS WITHOUT SOME
BROWN FUNDING PROGRAMS CANNOT
AFFORD FACULTY TO TEACH RATHER
THAN. MEANING CURRENT CLASSES
WOULD NOT HAVE THE FACULTIES
NOT ONLY GUIDANCE RESIDENCY BUT
SECONDLY ARE ALSO A MAIN SOURCE
OF PATIENT CARE WE'RE NOT
TEACHING I CANNOT STRESS ENOUGH
HOW DETRIMENTAL THIS SUMMER AND
I WILL BE THE CURRENT CLASSES.
ACCESS TO CAREAND THE PRIMARY
CARE WORKFORCE NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE IN ADDITION TO REJECT AN
CUT TO SOME BROWN WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO PROVIDE A LIFELINE TO
THE MANY PRIMARY CARE PRACTICE
WITH. THEIR CLOTHING AS A
RESULT OF HISTORICAL
UNDERPAYMENT OF PRIMARY CARE
AND THE EFFECTS OF THE COPA
NINETY CORRECT WE ARE HAPPY TO
BEWORKING WITH YOU B. G. H.
AND OTHERS URGING STATES
REQUIRE PLANTING A CHURCH WITH
WIDE PERSPECTIVE CAME INTO
THESE PRACTICAL. SOLUTION WOULD
NOT REQUIRE STATE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS THANK YOU. THANKS VERY
MUCH THANKS VERY MUCH. I THIRD
FOUR YOUR LINE OPEN. THREE
PLEASE GO HERE. LAST NOT BE
HAPPY TO. YOUR PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL URGING YOU TO REJECT
ALL TOMORROW NIGHT. MANAGED
CARE I DON'T KNOW ANYONE ON THE
BOAT CALENDAR. NUMBERS HELPS
YOUR BUSINESS PROGRAM- WE DON'T
BELIEVE THE ORIGINATION PROGRAM
ONCE NOTED ON MONEY. YOU WERE
TALKING POTENTIAL LEGALIZATION
ON. IT SHOULD NOT FEEL
PROCEDURES- IN CHINA CAN. TALK
ONE ON ONE WITH NONCRITICAL. HI
THIS. IT'S NOT GOOD UNION JOBS
LOOK WE WANT TO BE CLOSE TO
RECEIVER HAVING TROUBLE HEARING
YOU. JUST WE DON'T. KNOW HOW
MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED TO MOVE ON THE NEXT
CALLER. WHY ONE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE FOR TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MEGHAN TUBERS ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH ADVOCATES
FIRST ADMITTED AND NUMBER FORTY
THREE OF YOUR AGENDA THE MEDI
CAL PHARMACY TRANSITION TAKES
AWAY ALL OF THE THREE FORTY B.
SAVINGS OR HEALTH CENTER. AND
THEN A REVISED PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THAT SETTLED ON A
PAYMENT TO OFFSET THOSE LOSSES
FOR THESE REASONS WE REQUEST
THAT THE TRANSITION BE DELAYED
IN THIS BUDGET CYCLE AND
REGARDS THE NUMBER SEVENTY SIX
OF YOUR AGENDA THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE RATE CAR ABOUT A
CLINIC. IN COMBINATION WITH THE
PHARMACY TRANSITION WILL PERMIT
FURTHER LIMIT ACCESS THE
PHARMACY SERVICES AND HEALTH
CENTERS WE APPRECIATE THIS ITEM
BEING HELD OPEN AND WOULD URGE
YOU TO REJECT THE PROPOSAL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME ON
TELEHEALTH AND TELEPHONIC CARE
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AS WELL DIRECTOR COOPER
FROM DHS WHERE COMMENT IN THIS
AREA. IN ORDER FOR HEALTH
CENTERS TO REMAIN VIABLE THEY
MUST BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE NEEDED CARE- WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO COMMIT TO
MAKING ITS VIRTUAL BUSINESS
ALLOWABLE UNDER MY ACCOUNT
INDEFINITELY AND LASTLY. THE
PANDEMIC HAS COVERED THE GAPS
IN HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE AND WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PRIORITIZE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
SUCH AS TOM BROWN AND PROP
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER. QUESTION BE FROM.
NEXT TIME IT'LL BE FROM. ONCE
TOWARD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
DEVON REHAB TECHNOLOGY WHERE
THE PROVIDERS OF COMPLEX REHAB
TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS INTO THE
INDIVIDUALLY CUSTOMIZED
WHEELCHAIRS ADAPT QUICKER
SEVERELY DISABLED CHILDREN AND
ADULTS IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I WOULD JUST SAY WE'VE BEEN
SUFFERING UNDER THE EIGHTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. THANK GOD FOR THE
LAST TWELVE YEARS WE'RE ALSO
FACING A RECENTLY APPROVED
STATE PLAN AMENDMENT FROM PM AT
GONNA CUT OUR RATE EVEN
FURTHER- WE DON'T KNOW HOW
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO. SUSTAIN
THE PROVIDE IN OME. SERVICES
SO WE ARE HOPING THAT YOU WILL
CONSIDER SOME TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
REMOTE O. T. MPT EVALUATIONS
WHICH HAVE BEEN GRANTED TO IT
UNDER THE EXECUTIVE ORDER- WE
DON'T THINK IT WOULD IT WOULD
COST ANY. VERY MUCH MONEY AND
IT WOULD- PRESERVE OUR SERVICES
IN THE HOME AND NOT FORCE THESE
VULNERABLE PATIENTS TO COME TO
OUR FACILITIESWHICH WOULD COST
MEDIC CAL. THROUGH NON
EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECT
EXPIRATION. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
DONNA BENTON ON BEHALF O THE
SENSATION OF CALIFORNIA
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTERS. ON
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN WE ARE WE
WOULD LIKE YOU TO. MEET JACK
STATE GOVERNORS ELIMINATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS AND ACCEPT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF YOUR STAFF-
TO- REJECT THAT PROPOSAL CAN BE
UP TO FIVE MILLION CAREGIVERS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE THE BACKBONE
OF THE LONG TERM CARE SYSTEM.
AMY ARE MAINTAINING PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY- THEY'RE
UNDERPAID AND THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE KEEPING OUR OLDER
ADULTS AND THEMSELVES WHO ARE
OLDER ADULTS OUT OF NURSING
HOMES AND PLACING THEM AT RISK
FOR COLGATE DURING THIS TIME
AND IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. ONE ZERO FIVE LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT
OVER LAST KISS IT AND THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF SOUTHERN
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER I AM
A MEMBER OF THE ELEVEN
CALIFORNIA CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS IN THE STATE AND WE
REPRESENT BY OVER FIVE MILLION
FAMILY CAREGIVERS ACROSS THE
STATE I'M ASKING YOUR SUPPORT.
TO SUPPORT YOUR STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BUDGET OCTOBER
AUGMENTATION COULD SCARCELY
THAT ACTUALLY RESTORED THE CRCS
TO A LEVEL TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE INCREASED NUMBER OF
FAMILY CARE GIVERS IN OUR STATE
OUR PROGRAMS HELP FAMILIES STAY
HOME OUR PROGRAMS ARE THE ONLY
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DEDICATED TO
MAKING SURE THAT THE FAMILY
CARE GIVER GETS SUPPORT
SERVICES THEY NEED. TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE FAMILY CAREGIVERS
ARE PROVIDING ALMOST THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE PROVIDING
A COMPLEX MEDICAL CARE- WITH
OUT THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WOULD BE IN NURSING HOMES I
HAVE A DEAR FRIEND WHOSE MOTHER
WAS IN A NURSING HOME JUST
EARLIER THIS MONTH. THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH STARTED OUT AT A
TIME THANK THANK YOU YOUR
COMMENT WRITING FOR THE
FAMILIES THANK YOU OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON PAT
MEMBERS OF THE SUB MY NAME IS
BILL BECAUSE- EXECUTIVE FOR
HEALTH. AT THE PACIFIC BUSINESS
GROUP ON HEALTH. I'M COMMENTING
ON THE NEED TO ENSURE PROVIDER
NETWORK ADEQUACY AND PATIENTS
ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE
SERVICES. STICKER FOR
CALIFORNIA TECHNICIAN WHICH
COULD BE G. H. HAS DEVELOPED
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
WITH SUPPORT FROM CALIFORNIA
CALGARY FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND
WITH TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM
COVERED CALIFORNIA. OR TEXAS
CENTRAL PRIMARY CARE SERVICES
BY REQUIRING HEALTH PLANS TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY PROSPECTIVE
PAYMENT. DEPENDENT PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. THE TO PAY WITH
WHICH TO RELY TO CRY CARE
PROVIDERS WHO SUFFERED A SEVERE
RESPONSE AND REVENUE DURING THE
CALL THE PANDEMIC. AND AS A
RESULT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
FORCED TO CLOSE THEIR PRACTICES
OR BE ACQUIRED BY LARGE HEALTH
SYSTEMS. IT'S IMPORTANT- TO
THESE PAYMENTS WOULD BE MADE
FROM PREMIUM REVENUE THE HEALTH
PLANS HAVE ALREADY COLLECTED.
BUT NOT YET PAID OUT DUE TO
LOWER CLAIMS FAR DURING THE
CURRENT. CURRENT CODE PANDEMIC.
WE DELIVERED AID. OF THE CARE
FOR CALIFORNIA'S MR TO DOCTOR
PARENT ANOTHER LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS. EARLIER THIS WEEK AND
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE CHANGE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET TRAIL
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RIGHT NEXT CALLER. ONE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
SIX TWO. I REMEMBER THIS IS
KATHY MUST WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
NETWORK OUR HOMES ALSO
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES I
WANT TO MAKE A COMMON ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN OUR HOME
SIR ARE WE HAVE OVER A THOUSAND
HOMES DURING OVER OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO PEOPLE WITH I. D. D. WE
URGE YOU TO REJECT THE CUT TO
THE FACILITIES ARE SLOW WE HAVE
HAD FROZEN RIGHT AND- EIGHT OH
NINE WE ALSO ARE UNDER THIS
BUDGET IN THE TO BE READ BY
SUFFERING FROM SOME OTHER CUTS
ON THE GDS SIDE AND AGAIN WE
BELIEVE WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
PROTEIN RATE WE'VE DONE OUR
PART. YOUR BUDGET IN A PRIOR
RESEARCH AND WE YOU TO PLEASE.
NOT GO FURTHER WITH THIS CUT IN
THIS IN THIS MAY REVISE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN NINE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MATURE MEMBERS RIGHT
SPENCER ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA COULD YET GET
MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS YOU CAN
MAKE AN AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN
A COG SPEAKING FIRST YOU CAN
MAKE AN OPPOSITION TO THE CAT
IDENTIFIED IN ITEM NUMBER 74%
AGREE THAT PHYSICAL AND
STATUTORY CUT TO PODIATRIC
OPTIONAL BENEFIT NEVER A COG IN
OPPOSITION TO THE CUT IN ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY SIX WHICH IS THE
ELIMINATION OF THE FUNDING. AND
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO
EXTEND MEDIC OUT THE POST
PARTUM WOMEN WITH MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION AT THE
VERY LEAST AT THAT I ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE CONSIDER PRESERVING
THE STATUTORY AUTHORIZATIONS
FOR BOTH PROGRAMS SO THAT FUNNY
IF NOT MADE AVAILABLE THIS YEAR
MAY CONTINUE TO BE EXPLORED
FINALLY BROKE SPEAKING MAY IN A
CARGO POSED ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
SEVEN. THEIR GOAL A REDIRECT
YOU SIX MONTHS AWAY FROM
POSITIONS EVERY PAYMENT MORE
DETAILS HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED IN
A LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE I
THANK YOU GREAT SEPARATION.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER. FORTY
SIX. FOUR SIX ALLIED ASSAULT.
HI MY NAME IS- BARBARO WHICH IS
A QUARTER AND I'M CALLING TO-
SPEAK ON ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
I'M ASKING THAT YOU REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE AUGMENTED FUNDING
FOR THE KIDS GO TO RESOURCE
CENTER AND PLEASE ACCEPT STUFF
IN A COMMENDATION RICHER SINCE
THEIR DISPROPORTIONATE INJECTED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER. ONE SIXTY SIX ONE SIX
SIX JULY DOES OPEN. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
DOCTOR PENNANT SENATORS MY NAME
IS LYNN KIRSTY EMANATE AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR MATERNAL AND
CHILD HEALTH ACCESS WERE FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WE'VE BEEN IN
ROLLING TO HEALTH PROGRAMS AND
TROUBLESHOOTING ENROLLMENT IN
CARE ISSUES WHAT PART OF A
NETWORK OF OVER TWENTY AGENCIES
IN LOS ANGELES WE'RE ASKING
THAT YOU PLEASE REJECT THE CUTS
TO ENROLLMENT NAVIGATORS THESE
ARE FUNDS PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
IS MATCHED BY FEDERAL FUNDS.
THIS CUT THE TRIP TRUSTED
COMMUNITY OUTREACH AND
ENROLLMENT WILL EXACERBATE
HEALTH DISPARITIES ARE ALREADY
EXISTING MINORITY COMMUNITIES
NAVIGATORS ARE ENROLLING IN
CASH CARDS PANDEMIC CALFRESH
RENT PROGRAMS AS WELL AS HEALTH
CARE WE'RE RESPONDING TO THE
NEED TO ADDRESS SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH TO HELP
PEOPLE STAY ALIVE. WE'RE BEING
ASKED TO COME TO PROJECT ROOM
KEY MOTELS BECAUSE PROVIDERS
DON'T KNOW HOW TO ENROLL PEOPLE
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT COVERAGE
IS ALREADY THERE NOW IS NOT THE
TIME TO CUT THESE ENROLLMENT
NAVIGATORS ESPECIALLY IN LOS
ANGELES IN THE MIDDLE OF KOBE
TO- TO GET PEOPLE COVERED INTO
HEALTH CARE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU THANKS FOR. FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE RESULTS AND
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES WE
REPRESENT A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
NONPROFIT SERVING MORE THAN
HALF A MILLION VULNERABLE
CHILDREN FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE BUT ENDEMIC TO IMPACT ON
MENTAL HEALTH WITH
UNPRECEDENTED AND DEVASTATING
WE THANK THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE CLEAR LEADERSHIP AT
THIS TIME. OUR ORGANIZATION IS
ADVOCATING WITH CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERS FOR FEDERAL RELIEF FOR
CALIFORNIA AT THE SAME TIME
CALIFORNIA MUST RESOLVE TO
PROTECT THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SAFETY NET. DEGREE DECLINES IN
REALIGNMENT BY THE NEW COUPLE
WITH A DRAMATIC RISE IN THE
NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TRYING TO COLLAPSE ARE JUST NOT
CARE WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
BACKFILL REALIGNMENT DOLLARS
NOW TO AVOID GREATER COST IN
BOTH DOLLARS AND HUMAN RIGHTS.
ALLIANCE NEVER ORDERED ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES OF SUPPORTING
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR MOST BASIC
SUPPORT WE ARE LOOKING AT
DRAMATIC PROGRAM AND STAFFING
CUTBACKS AND PERMANENT DAMAGE
TO THE ESSENTIAL SAFETY NET FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK. YOU THANK YOU. IT'S
CALLED. ONE FIVE ZERO. ONE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON AT
THIS POINT YOUR NUMBERS IT'S A
PLEA ON RECORD HARVEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCY WE REPRESENT CBO'S THAT
SERVE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA SUFFERED
MENTAL HEALTH. DISORDERS THE
IMPACT OF THE NINETEEN ON
ARCADIA AND PROFOUND AND IT'S
GROWING WE MUST TAKE STEPS NOW
TO BACK FILL REALIGNMENT
DOLLARS TO DIVERT THE COLLAPSE
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM NOT
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE ITEMS
THAT WOULD BOLSTER THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
ITEM SEVENTEEN NINETEEN PROMOTE
BEHAVIOR HOW PARITY ITEM TWENTY
FOUR THE COURT DECIDED YOU
COULD ORDER SYSTEM ITEMS TWENTY
SEVEN AND THIRTY THREE. I
CELEBRATE THE ELEVEN FIFTEEN
WAIVER ITEM THIRTY AND PROMOTE
GREATER ACCESS TO MEDICATION
ITEM THIRTY NINE WITHOUT THE
MEDIC WRITTEN PROPOSALS FOR
SUPPORTING TO BE A GIRL AT
FIFTEEN AT THE TIME- BY DOCTOR
BILLING REALIGNMENT DOLLARS
ACCORDING TO. THE BORDER
WORKFORCE AND PROMOTING YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID
TRAINING IN SCHOOL THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME TO SHARE THE
COMMENTS ON. BEHALF OF THE BJP
MEMBERS. OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
CALLER. LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO. SOMETHING YOU TO THE MY
NAME IS MERRY SHERATON I'M WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS AND
WE REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTERS TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES. TO
UNPAID FAMILY MEMBERS PROVIDING
LONG TERM CARE AT HOME TWO
ADULTS WITH DEMENTIA AND OTHER
DISABLING CONDITIONS. EXCUSE ME
WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY ON THE AGENDA. THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE FUNDING APPROVED IN
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
FOR THE CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS WHICH PROVIDE SUPPORT.
TO UNPAID FAMILY CAREGIVERS OF
ADULTS NEEDING ASSISTANCE TO
ALLOW THEM TO REMAIN IN THE
COMMUNITY AND OUT OF NURSING
HOMES. THE NEW LONG TERM CARE
PROGRAM DISCUSSED IN THE
COMMITTEE MEETING DOES NOT
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF UNPAID
FAMILY CAREGIVERS WHO PROVIDE
THE MAJORITY OF LONG TERM CARE
TO VULNERABLE ADULTS AT HOME.
NOR DOES IT ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF THOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH HOW MUCH ISOLATED.
THANK THANK YOU. EXCELLENT. ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS WENDY **** AND I
WORK FOR HALF A SECOND WORK A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
PROVIDES MENTAL HEALTH AND
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES IN LA
COUNTY SH THE PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM IS
FACING A STEEP DECLINE IN THAT
FUNDING STREAMS NINETEEN NINETY
ONE REALIGNMENT TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT AND THEY DO PAY. AT
A TIME WHEN THE AFETY NET
SERVICES NEED TO BE
STRENGTHENED AS WE LOOK TO THE
WEEKS AHEAD WE WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE THE INDIVIDUAL AND
COLLECTIVE TRAUMA ASSOCIATED
WITH PELVIC NINETEEN AND THE
CON CURRENT ECONOMIC RECESSION
WHICH HEIGHTENED ANXIETY
ATTACKS OF ISOLATION FEARS
ABOUT THE FUTURE AND THE
UNKNOWN UNDERSCORE THE
CONTINUING NEED FOR CRUCIAL
SERVICES. WE'RE JOINING WITH
HUNDREDS OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CHAMPIONS TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN ALLOCATION OF THREE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CURRENT AND BUDGET YOUR TO
PROTECT THE CORE PUBLIC
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SAFETY NET
SYSTEM ACROSS THE STATE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANKS CALLER.
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO I AM I CALLING IN REGARDS
TO THE COURT FOR ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN I'M MICHELLE NEVINS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DEL ORAL
CARE GIVER BEATS FIRSTENERGY
AND MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER I
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. TO REJECT
ELIMINATION OF THE AUGMENTATION
GIVEN THE CONCERNS ABOUT
CUTTING NINETEEN OUT GREAT
GOVERNOR CAN CONTROL THESE
ALAMEDA ARE OLDER ADULTS IN
THEIR HOMES WE MUST MAINTAIN A
COURT THE OLDER ADULT FAMILY
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER ARE
THERE LIKE MINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER. ONE
EIGHT YEAR LONG IS OPEN. HELLO
I'M JOE BLUETOOTH SECOND OF
HEALTH PROJECT PLANNER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE DELMAR
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER IN
THE CENTER THE MINORITY AND THE
FIFTY. AT THIS TIME OF CALL BUT
WE HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION TO
KEEP AS MANY PEOPLE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AS POSSIBLE
ESPECIALLY THOSE MOST AT RISK
COURT. CALLED IT. ONE THIRD OF
THE DEATHS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. DO YOU RECALL THAT
HADN'T SKILLED NURSING. OPPOSES
THE ELIMINATION OF THE BENEFITS
P. AND- KEEP THOSE FOLKS SAFE
AND AT HOME. THERE ARE NOT
OTHER PROGRAMS IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT GOES AWAY THAT WILL KEEP
THEM SAFE. ALSO PLEASE SUPPORT
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS TO NOT
CUT THIS YEAR'S HE'S- FINALLY
CAME HE BATH IT KEEPS PEOPLE AT
THE HOME AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR. FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RENEE
NASH THAT I'M THE GRANDDAUGHTER
OF A YEAR TO UTILIZE THE BEST
SERVICES AND A PROVIDER OF
SERVICES I'M SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE ELIMINATION
OF THE BATH AND ADMIT THAT P.
ITEM SEVENTY ONE IN BENEFITS
REFERRED TO AS OPTIONAL
BENEFITS ARE IN NO WAY OPTIONAL
IF YOU'RE AN AGING SENIOR IN
CALIFORNIA WITH MULTIPLE
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS. ONLY
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF NOT NEEDING THE SERVICES CAN
EVER CONSIDER THEM AS OPTIONAL
PROPOSAL GAMBLES WITH THE LIVES
OF THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION THERE IS NO
REPLACEMENT PERCEIVE THAT THE
DRESS THE IMPACT OF SOCIAL
ISOLATION AND LONELINESS ON
OVERALL HEALTH LIKE FEEDBACK
THAT CONGREGATE CARE MODEL. IN
THE MEANWHILE WITHOUT SEA BASS
ARE PARTICIPANTS WILL MEDICALLY
DETERIORATE END UP IN HOSPITAL
AND REQUIRE LONG TERM CARE
PLACEMENT INCLUDING MY
GRANDMOTHER PASSED TWO WEEKS
AGO SHE HAD ALZHEIMER'S
DEMENTIA AND UTILIZE FEEDBACK A
GOOD FOR THE LAST YEAR OF HER
LIFE SHE PASSED IN OUR HOME IN
OUR COMMUNITY PLEASE DO NOT
TAKE AWAY THIS OPTION FOR TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND YOU HAVE
MY SYMPATHIES. I NEXT CALLER.
ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LIFE IS OLD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA AND
GOOD AND I ALSO WORK FOR HEALTH
PROJECTS UNDER DR TAN I HAVE
BEEN LISTENING TO THE HEARING
THIS MORNING AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR OPPOSING
THE ELIMINATION OF THE MSSP.
PROGRAM STORE FRAIL ELDERLY SO
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE WORKED- IN
AREAS THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED
TODAY DUE TO COVERT NINETEEN
XXL EMPLOYEES ONE QUESTION
WOULD BE WOULD BE WHY ARE WE
SPENDING TIME INVESTING IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW PROGRAM
LONG TERM CARE AT HOME WHEN WE
ALREADY HAVE IN MISSISSIPPI. I
WOULD ALSO THANK YOU FOR
OPPOSING THE REDUCTION IN THE
FUNDING FOR THE C. OR C.
PROGRAM WHICH HELPS KEEP
PEOPLE. AT HOME BEING CARED FOR
BY THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KAREN MEMBERS WHEN A KID LEARNS
OF THE LOCAL HEALTH CENTER
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST REGARDING
BURNING AND I'M EIGHTY THREE
THE BUDGET PROPOSES THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN INDICATION.
CARE HOSPITAL. ABSOLUTELY
HIGHER RATES FOR WHICH LOCAL
BRANCH WILL NOT BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR A TERMINATE THEIR CONTRACT
WHICH WILL HAVE DIRECT
IMPLICATIONS FOR NETWORK ACCESS
TO CARE. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THE REQUEST OF THE CHOIR EXCEPT
THIS WEEKEND ALL RIGHT. HOLD
LOCAL ISSUES. NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT AND OF THE PHARMACY CARD
THANKING FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE GIVEN THE STRAIN COOK PLACE
INCREDIBLE THEM AND THEN
CONDUCTING INDEPENDENT OVER THE
NEXT YEAR WE ALSO REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIALLY.
DESTABILIZING EFFECT ON
SPEAKING OUT. AS A RESULT OF
THE LOSS REPORTING PROGRAM
THIRTY THREE DOES AMERICA A
LETTER. TO THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER. I WOULD REMIND
PEOPLE ON A SPEAKER PHONE OR
SOME OTHER THING PLEASE TO TALK
DIRECTLY INTO THE RECEIVER SO
WE CAN CLEARLY HEAR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANKS CALLER. LINE
ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY I'M SPEAKING TODAY
IN OPPOSITION OF THE PROPOSED
ELIMINATION OF FEEDBACK AND
MSSP SERVICES ITEM SEVENTY ONE
MY NAME IS TERRA HOLLY AND I'M
AN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST
WORKING AT A FAMILY OWNED YOU
HAVE TO STILL EAT I'M ALSO
SPECIAL NEEDS MOM WHEN MY SON
WAS BORN AT THE SAME DREAMS
MOST PARENTS HAVE FOR THEIR
CHILD'S FUTURE. GRADUATING FROM
COLLEGE GETTING MARRIED MAYBE
EVEN HAVING KIDS OF HIS OWN I
STILL HAVE DREAMS BUT THEY'RE
MUCH DIFFERENT HE WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH AN EXTREMELY RARE GENETIC
DISORDER MY CHILD DOCTOR TOLD
ME THAT I WOULD MOST LIKELY
SPEND MY ENTIRE LIFE CARING FOR
MY SON THAT YOU ALMOST
CERTAINLY NEVER GO TO COLLEGE
GET MARRIED OR EXPERIENCE A
TYPICAL LIFE WE PUSH FORWARD
REGARDLESS AND HOPES THAT WE
CAN PROVE HIM WRONG. THE
REALITY IS MY SON LIKELY WILL
REQUIRE CARE FOR THE REST OF
HIS LIFE TIME SO WHAT WILL
HAPPEN WHEN MY HUSBAND AND I
ARE TOO OLD TO PROVIDE THE CARE
YOU NEED WHAT WILL HAPPEN WHEN
WE'RE GONE AS MY CHILD OF THE
COMPLEX MEDICAL CONDITIONS I
TAKE RELIEF KNOWING THAT THE
BACK EXIT. NOW THESE BUDGET
CUTS THREATENED TO TAKE THE
BATHROOM OVER TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND ANOTHER THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND WITH MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES HOW CAN
PARENTS GO TO WORK THANK YOU
WELL CHILD AT HOME ALONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE PLEA SEEKING
TESTAMENT RENDER YOUR TESTIMONY
IN WRITING THANK. YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE. LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU DR CANNON
SENATOR DICKENS AND GAVE THE S.
AND P. A. U. CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF OUR SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES BUT
MAYBE BY PROPOSAL IS
ESSENTIALLY AN ALL CUT PROPOSAL
WE ASK YOU TO NOT MAKE THE SAME
MISTAKE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
DID TEN YEARS AGO DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION WE ASK YOU TO
NOT BALANCE THE BUDGET ON THE
BACKS OF OUR FRONT LINE IF
CENTRAL WORKER THEN ON THE
WORKING POOR. AND WE ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER SOLUTIONS THAT ARE NOT
JUST BASED ON GOVERNMENT'S ROLE
OF CUTTING CRITICAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS GOT IT TO GET AT THE
SHORT TERM SAVINGS BUT HAVE
LONG TERM NEGATIVE IMPACT
SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE WILL
HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION ON
REVENUE SOURCES NOT JUST
FEDERAL REVENUES AND WE ASK YOU
TO CONSIDER REVENUE PROPOSALS
THAT INCLUDE AN ALL IN APPROACH
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY WE PREVENT
CUTS AND STATE PROGRAMS LIKE
HEALTH FOR ALL SENIORS. MEDIC
HOW OPTIONAL BENEFIT THE TOM
BROWN PROGRAM I JUST SAID IN
OTHER EAST CENTRAL PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMS WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT FUNDING GOES THAT
SAFETY NET SERVICES LIKE PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS WE CANNOT
PERPETUATE THE INEQUITY WE HAD
SEEN EVER SO CLEAR IT NEARLY
INDEPENDENT BANK FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
NEXT CALL PLEASE. BLIND PLEASE
GO. GOOD AFTERNOON SANDERS AND
STAFF AND THEN YOU FOR THE TO
ADDRESS THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
TODAY MY NAME IS TOM ALEXANDER
PRESIDENT CEO FRED FINCH YOUTH
ND FAMILY SERVICES A CHILD
FAMILY SERVING AGENCIES
PROVIDING TRAUMA INFORMED
SPECIALTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO OVER A THOUSAND OF
THE MOST HORRIBLE KIDS AND
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE. WE
ARE GOING TO NATION OR WHETHER
YOU NEED A FINANCIAL IMPACT OF
THE KOBE NIKE MOSTLY DUE TO OUR
PARTNERSHIP WILL COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLAN WITH WHOM WE ARE
CONTRACTED IN THE LIMITED
SUPPORT SHARES OF FEDERAL
PROGRAMS I'M VERY CONCERNED
OVER THE PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL.
HEALTH LIBERTY MOMENT AT WHICH
SHOULD BE IT IT WOULDN'T SHOULD
BE. AND I THINK. OF BEHAVIOR
THE AND MEDIC. WE'RE PROPOSAL
OF STATED BECAUSE OF COUNTIES
AND THE CHILD AND FAMILY CHILD
IN. CALIFORNIA DID NOT TELL
THEIR FAMILY SERVICES TO
PROTECT THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SAFETY NET RIGHT BACK ONLY THE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE TWENTY
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR. THE
CALL. WHY DON'T. BLIND EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JUSTIN RANDALL THE JUGGLING
PARTNERSHIPS EVEN WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS LEADERSHIP HAD
RETAKEN MORE ETHNIC OR CHECKING
AND THEIR FAMILIES AS OTHERS
HAVE SAID WE ARE. DISAPPROVAL
THAT AND WALK A FUNDING FOR
HEALTH NAVIGATOR THAT'S OFTEN
CONNECT FAMILIES WITH RESOURCES
THAT MIGHT NOT AND HAD
PREVIOUSLY WE ALSO ARE THAT OF
THE LACK OF FUNDING FOR HEALTH
WEALTH IN YOUR EYES MEET THE
PANDEMIC- AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY. IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND ART.
WHAT THAT BUT THE BIKE OF MANY
CAL ENROLLMENT WE ARE. HE TOOK
THE COURT FAMILY BY USING BY
IMPLEMENTING OUR MEDICARE QATAR
ROMANCE BUT ALSO VERY KIND BY
THE A SIXTEEN YEAH CARE WITH
YOUR THAN SHARING THE DOCTOR
PRACTICES AND ALL FURTHER.
HINDERED THERE. ARE NO. ME
THERE WERE OF BUSINESS AND
THERE THE DENT. EVEN IF
SOMEBODY A MAN IN BE ALWAYS TO
KEEP DOCTOR. HE DID OR THE A
HEALTH CARE VIRTUAL OTHERWISE.
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORK WHAT
WHAT IS ON THE ISSUE OR
QUESTION YOU. SHUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK. THANKS CALLER. LINE
ONE ZERO TWO ENJOY. BY INGRAM
THE EIGHTH OF CALIFORNIA WE
URGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO ACT BY
INCLUDING A HUNDRED MILLION
FROM POCKET THE SEX AND THE
BUDGET FOR PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES THE FAMILY PLANNING
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. THESE PROGRAMS
ENSURE HIGH QUALITY CARE IS
ACCEPTABLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF INCOME AND HELPS
PREVENT THE CLOSURE OF HEALTH
CENTERS WHICH FURTHER
EXACERBATE EXISTING GEOGRAPHIC
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS BUT THE
NINETY ONE FEDERAL MATCH
CUTTING NEEDS GREATLY MILLIONS
IN FEDERAL MATCHING DOLLARS
BEHIND WE ALSO URGE YOU TO
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET CUTS AND WORK WITH
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS TO ENSURE
ALL SENIORS BACK WITH THE
HEALTH CARE AND SERVICES.
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS THANK. YOU THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER. BLIND ONE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CAMILLE
SCHRADER ON THE PUBLIC POLICY
OFFICER FOR REDWOOD COMMUNITY
SERVICES WE PROVIDE B. EVER
HEALTH AND FOSTER CARE SERVICES
FOR LAKE MENDOCINO AND HUMBOLDT
COUNTIES I AM CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE- SAY THE SAFETY NET
DOCUMENT FROM THE CALIFORNIA-
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA LINE TO CHILD
FAMILY SERVICES AND THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES. ALL
OF THE PROVIDERS AND HEALTH.
POURED THE AND RESPOND TO THE
TSUNAMI OF NEED THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN BEHAVIOR HEALTH AS WE
ARE NOW OPENING UP COMMUNITIES
WE NEED TO HAVE THE REALIGNMENT
COUNTY. TO DRIVE DOWN THE 5295%
FEDERAL FINANCING THAT WILL
SUPPORT AND WILL BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO SUFFER PLEASE
TAKE CARE OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. ONE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DEFINITELY THE
TWO CHAIRMEN MEMBERS CARL
WANTED NEW BLOOD IN EXHAUST
ADVOCACY REPRESENTING THE NINE
THOUSAND PLUS MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TO NOTRE
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE. A COLDER P. SERVICES
FOR THE MEDICAL PROGRAM. THE
PROPOSAL FOR PHYSICAL THERAPY
SHOWS FIVE POINT SIX MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS TO
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THIS RESULT
RESULT IN A LOSS OF FOURTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION IN FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS TO THE SERVICES
WHICH ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
IN CORPORATE CORRELATE.
DIRECTLY TO OUTCOMES TYPES OF
SERVICES INVOLVED INCLUDE
SERVICES TO MEDICAL PATIENTS
WITH CEREBRAL PALSY EMMAUS
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS INJURIES
OF ALL KINDS STROKES IT
INJURIES BURN VICTIMS JOINT
REPLACEMENTS AND SO MUCH MORE
WE URGE YOU TO REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH HAS BEEN
REJECTED REPEATEDLY IN A
BIPARTISAN BASIS OVER THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. NINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS LINDA
TOMORROW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK WE
ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REINSTATE FUNDING FOR THE
HEALTH NAVIGATORS PROGRAM HELP
NAVIGATORS ARE CURRENTLY
HELPING PEOPLE GET INTO
HEALTHCARE IN THE FACE OF A
MAN'S JOB LOSS ECONOMIC
STABILITY AND CONFUSION WHERE
DO YOU THINK FUNCTIONS PROGRAM
ALL THE PEOPLE WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED. TO GET
ACCESS TO DESPERATELY NEEDED
HEALTH CARE FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES WE ALSO WOULD ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
REINSTATING THE ADULT DENTAL
BENEFIT AND IN ADDITION. TO
SUPPORTING HELP FOR ALL
UNDOCUMENTED. UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC. WE ALSO
ASK. CRITICAL THE EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS GOING TOWARDS THE HELP.
REDUCTION FUND ON I DO KNOW
THAT MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS ARE
GOING TO EXACERBATE. OTHERS
OVERCOME IT NINETEEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON EVENT
THAT HAPPENS WITH UGLY FAMILY
SERVICES COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SHOULD RECEIVE THE WHITE PAPER
MY COLLEAGUE WROTE ENTITLED THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT OF CODE
NINETEEN BEHAVIOR HEALTH VITAL
ROLE IN THE RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY IT IS A WELL
DOCUMENTED AND AWFUL A WHITE
PAPER THAT SHOWS CLEARLY SHOWS
THE INCREASED BURDEN OF MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS DURING. AND
AFTER THE PANDEMIC- WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
BACK THOUGH NINETEEN NINETY ONE
AND TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN
ALIGNMENT IN ORDER TO COVER THE
SIGNIFICANT LOSS IN BOTH OF
THOSE REVENUE STREAMS. AND AS
YOU KNOW THAT- WE WOULD BE
LOSING FEDERAL MATCHING DOLLARS
IN ADDITION TO THE LOSS OF
REVENUE AND SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO INCLUDE- THE ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS IN YOUR REQUEST. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
BLIND WHY TWELVE TO USE AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMERICA CALLING
TO COOK TO HER CHILDREN AND
FAMILY YOUR THANK YOU MY
COMMENTS ARE ON THE IMPACT OF
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC TO THE
PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED AT THIS CRITICAL
SAFETY NET IS BEING THREATENED
AT THE VERY MOMENT WHEN IT
SHOULD BE STRENGTHENED IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE
SKYROCKETING THE IT GIRL HELPED
ME. IN A WEEK A MONTH A WEEK.
THE AND COLLECTIVE TRAUMA
ASSOCIATED WITH ONE.
UNPRECEDENTED GLOBAL CAN. THE
NEED FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES WILL INCREASE. WE ARE
ALL WELL AWARE SOCIAL ISOLATION
ECONOMIC DISTRESS RESULTING
FROM OUR EFFORTS. TO CURB
GLOBAL NINETEEN. HAVE HAD A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE PUBLIC'S
MENTAL HEALTH. ANY CALIFORNIAN.
YOUTH AND ADULTS ALIKE THE
INCREASE SOCIAL ISOLATION AND
LONELINESS CORRELATE INCREASES
IN THE HOPELESSNESS AND SUICIDE
RISK. FOR PREVENTION EFFORTS
DEMAND OUR IMMEDIATE ATTENTION
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE NECESSARY
NECESSARY EARLY SCHOOL CLOSURES
ARE HAVING A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
CHILDREN THANK YOU THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU NICE COLOR PLEASE.
LINE ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND I THINK IF YOU NO
LONGER HAVE THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP TO TALK ABOUT HOME
VISITING AND MOVING FORWARD
DURING THE TIME WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING TO SECURE AS MUCH
FEDERAL FUNDING AS POSSIBLE FOR
ALL STATE MCALLEN VIDEOS WE'VE
BEEN VERY CLEAR TO WORK BUT
APARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO IDENTIFY HOME
VISITING SERVICES. WERE PART OF
LAST BUDGET LAPAROSCOPIC
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE MATCH WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING MORE
ACCORDING TO PUBLIC HEALTH ON
THE PROGRESS TO DATE. AND READY
TO ATTORNEYS AFTER. WOULD ALSO.
ENCOURAGED TO USE THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED HE PH
LAST YEAR FOR HOME VISITING THE
STUDY NEW HOME VISITING MODEL
BUT USE THAT FUNDING NOW. BEING
IMMEDIATELY DISPERSED TO
COUNTERFEIT OR NOT APPROVED BY
THE CALIFORNIA HOME VISITING
PROGRAM. IN OUR COUNTY BUT-
POTENTIALLY LOOKING AT CUTTING
SERVICES. ON HOME VISITING
WHICH IS ALSO PART OF THE
CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. WE DO ALSO SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO BOLSTER THE STATE'S
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE AND WE
MUST OPPOSE. THE CUT TO BLACK
INCOME HEALTH PROGRAM THE
RECISION OF MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH ASSISTANCE AND THE
PRECISION I'M NOT A CALLIN WILL
NAVIGATORS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. WE HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT LYING TO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TO
CONCLUDE THAT AND WITH THE
CALGARY CRAFTER CONNECTICUT
COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS. I DON'T NEED TO GET
A- WE'RE ACTUAL CREDIT TO
REJECT THE REVISED PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE FUNDING TO PLACE OUR
CALL DRUG COUNSELORS EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU DR GRANT
OR COMMENT ON THIS PROGRAM WE
ARE SEEING A- CHARACTER IN A
MORE CRITICAL. WITH THE COVERT
PANDEMIC METAL HEALTH NEEDS ARE
INCREASING INSTRUCTIONS USE
COLUMNS. ARE ALSO INCREASING.
THE WILL HAVE AND IN MERCER.
PLACING DRUG CAL AMER UPON
WHOLE HELL DIRECT PATIENT
SERVICES THEY TRULY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU- WILL TRY TAKE MAYBE ONE OR
TWO OTHER COMMENTS AND FORTUNE
WILL BE OUT OF TIME AT THAT
POINT BUT- BUT WHEN WE GO AND
TAKE THE NEXT CALLER. PLEASE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME'S MICHELLE THE MOM AND
COACH OUTLET CALIFORNIA KIDS
HERE GOVERNOR NEWTON CUT ITS
PROPOSED HEARING AID PROGRAM
FOR CHILDREN AND IT MAY REVISE
THE ONES THAT YOU PROPOSE AN
ALTERNATIVE TO EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT EVERY EVERY
LEGISLATOR I THOUGHT. IF THE
GOVERNOR IS NOT WILLING TO
INCLUDE IN THE BUDGET YOU
SHOULD SET ASIDE EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT AND A LOT OF
CONTINENTS NAMELY THAT WOULD
MANDATE HELP THEM PAY FOR IT
YOU COULD BUY PERMANENT
COVERAGE THE CHILDREN. STUDIES
SHOW THE COST A ONE MILLION PER
CHILD WE DID NOT RECEIVE EARLY
INTERVENTION SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND OTHER MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS
BECAUSE THE FUND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROGRAM OR SIGN EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT IS MINIMAL BUT THE
ABSENCE OF POLLUTION TO ADDRESS
THE DEVELOPMENTAL EMERGENCY
WILL CONTINUE TO COST HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THE
IMPACTED THEM SAYING THE
NEWBORNS NEED BE AIDED BY SIX
MONTHS IS ABOUT THE SAME RATE
AS. THEIR HEARING PEERS HOW
THEY'RE GOING. OUR TOP READING
RELATED FOUNDATION THE GREAT
ABOUT MY- AND THE SCHOOL AGE.
LIKE MY WHO NEEDS. THEIR
TEACHERS AND CLASSMATES MIGHT
BE ABLE ATTEND SCHOOL. WITHOUT
HERE A BOOK. AND PUT THEIR
FUTURE IN. IT DOWN. COOL BE OUR
STATE AFFORD EXACTLY KIND OF
LIKE. WHEN YOU KEEP YOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE TELL
ME HOW. MANY PEOPLE ARE WAITING
ON THE LINE RIGHT NOW ALL ARE
QUITE A FEW- THAT TOO MANY TO
COUNT TOWARDS THEIR NUMBER YOU
CAN GIVE ME FIGHT IT TO GIVE
YOU A ROUGH GUESS HERE SIR
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE. FIFTY
FIVE OKAY SO UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVE COME TO THE END OF OUR
TIME CAPSULE I WAS ACTUALLY
EXTENDED IT THANKS TO THE
STAFF- THERE LOOK AT THE LADY
TO BE ABLE TO. DO OTHER TASKS
SO THAT WE CAN SHORTEN OUR
RECESS PERIOD I DO WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PEOPLE FOR TO
SUBPOENA OTHER TESTIMONY TODAY-
I KNOW THERE'S MANY PEOPLE
STILL ON THE LINE. PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE- WEBSITES-
YOU'LL HAVE A LINK TO THE EMAIL
ADDRESS I KNOW MANY PEOPLE
ACTUALLY ARRAY EMAILED OUR
COMMITTEE BEFORE EVEN THIS
HEARING IN APPRECIATE AND
WELCOME THOSE. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE STILL ON THE LINE
APOLOGIZEWE ARE YOU KNOW WE'RE
TRYING TO CONDENSE ESSENTIALLY%
WHAT WOULD BE A MONTH AND A
HALF OF SMALL HEARINGS AND UP
HEARINGS ON THESE ISSUES. IN A
SENSE THE ONE HEARING COVERING
ALL OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. SO I THINK AT THIS
POINT IN TIME UNFORTUNATELY WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO TAKE ANY
ADDITIONAL. THE PUBLIC COMMENT-
ACTUALLY COMES UP FOR A QUICK
PAUSE TALK MY STAFF.
YEAH.
WELL
WHAT I CAN DO IT. OKAY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE JUST SO
WE CAN ACKNOWLEDGE THE PEOPLE
ARE STILL WAITING ON THE LINE
IF YOU'RE STILL ON THE LINE
WE'RE GOING TO DO IS ASK YOU TO
SIMPLY SEND YOUR NAME IF YOU
REPRESENT ORGANIZATION THAT
ORGANIZATION AND THEN WE ASK
THAT YOU SUBMIT YOUR COMMENT
AND- RIGHT. OKAY OKAY. SO AGAIN
WE ASK THAT YOU JUST GIVE YOUR
NAMEAND IF YOU REPRESENT
ORGANIZATION THE ORGANIZATION
SEVEN DOLLARS THAT YOU WERE
WAITING ON THE LINE PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS IN WRITING
TO US I UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
PEOPLE HAVE DROPPED OFF THE
QUEUE BECAUSE IT PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED AGAIN FORTUNE WE ARE
GETTING A TIME CAPSULE- SO YOU
CAN PLEASE HAVE THE MODERATOR
PLEASE REACH TO THE PEOPLE BUT
AGAIN I'M JUST GONNA ASK YOU
JUST NAME AN ORGANIZATION- WE
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
YOUR COMMENTS AND WRITING. THAT
YOU WILL SEND TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SO- MODERATOR- CAN
YOU PLEASE ASK PEOPLE TO REACH
YOU AND AGAIN I'LL JUST TAKE
THE NAME AN ORGANIZATION AND
THEN- WE WILL- IT IS IT
KNOWLEDGE MEANT AS YOU. DESIRE
TO TESTIFY AND THEN WE WILL
LOOK FOR YOUR WRITTEN COMMENTS
TO OUR TO OUR STAFF SO
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE FIND
THAT UP PLEASE. ALRIGHT FOR OUR
CONFEREES THAT NEED TO GIVE
THEIR NAME AND INFORMATION
PLEASE PRESS THE ONE FOLLOWED
BY THE ZERO ARE YOUR FALL ONE
ZERO C. MAY SUBMIT YOUR NAME
AND INFORMATION. OKAY SO FOR
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO EXPRESS.
PLEASE MODERATOR PLEASE- LET'S
OPEN UP THE LINES AND AGAIN
JUST NAME AN ORGANIZATION. ALL
RIGHTY. ONE MOMENT THANK YOU.
TWO FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS JEANETTE WILSON AND
I'M WITH YOUR MONEY CAREGIVER
FOR CENTER THANK YOU THAT'S
FINE. LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CAN BE VERY QUICK TO
HELP OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. TWO SIX
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO
SIX TWO. EARLIER ONE NOW ALL
RIGHT. NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. ONE NINE TWO SEVEN
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE FIFTY TWO. THE NEW QUAKER
CHEMICAL PLANT MSF BESIDES THE
STATION THANK YOU. SIX ONE
SEVEN TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KATHY QUITE YET HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
SEVEN. ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WELL I'M NOT
MARRIED TO INDIAN MUSIC FAN
RIGHT THE BASS AND CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ADULT DAY
SERVICES. THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
THREE. WHAT HAPPENED YOU CAN
BEGIN YOUR JOURNEY AT WORK IN
AN OFFICE P. PROVIDER. THANK
YOU. TWO NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHEN THE OVERNIGHT THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. TWO SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BRANCH OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HOW
TRADITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY TWO. YEAH. THANKS.
THANK YOU MY LINE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT. ONLY MAC MILLAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION CHILDREN'S
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION AND
ROADS CLEAR BRIGHT SPRING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
ZERO NINE. TWO ZERO NINE. HIS
NEAR MORTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. LINE TWO SEVEN FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON BLANCA CASTRO
WITH A RP CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU. TWO FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE GAMES THAT YOU'RE
AT YOUR WIT'S ACHALA HOW CAN
HELP COLLABORATIVE IN THE FIFTY
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FORTY. MICHELLE GIVEN BUT THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE THE
FIXATION OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES THE NAMING
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. I'M CHERYL
BROWN FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIAN LEARN EMPIRE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE CENTER.
THANK YOU TWO EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. AMY
BLOOMBERG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES CONFERENCE. THANK YOU.
BLIND THIRTY. BY THIRTEEN.
THREE WITH RELEASE OF THE OKAY
HEALTHCARE PROGRAM IN LOS
ANGELES THANK YOU. FIVE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DIANE
PACKET WITH THE PAIN KILLER
CENTER FOR ADULT DAY HEALTH
CARE AND SEA BASS IN BUTTE
COUNTY THANK YOU BLIND BLIND
TWENTY SIX. CHRISTIAN HEY MAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR ADULT DAY SERVICES. THANK
YOU. BY FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES NAME
OR POSITION PLEASE OKAY YES
THANK YOU THIS IS DEBBIE TOLD
WITH CHOICE AND AGING WE ARE A
FEW BASS A MSSP PROVIDER IN
SACRAMENTO NAPA SOLANO AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. THANK YOU.
TWO FORTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SERENA ONE AND I'M
WITH THE ASIAN RESOURCES AND
HELP CUSTOMERS NETWORK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. BY
SIXTY SIX. SIXTY SIX YOUR LIGHT
IS OPEN. TWO SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. UNDRESSING A
GAL ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES IN
CALIFORNIA REGARDING
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. TWO FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DR KATHERINE FLORES AND
A PRACTICING FAMILY POSITION
AND ALSO THE DIRECTOR. OF THE
CENTER PER UCSF FRESNO. THANK
YOU. ONE TWENTY FOUR. AFTERNOON
I NEED RAIN BACHELOR THE CEO OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY FIVE.
ACTOR SO JI WHAT CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE SEVENTY TWO. WHEN
YOU'RE ALL RIGHT. PETER
REPLACEMENT YOU KNOW. THANK YOU.
THREE ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARK HE'LL I'LL PUT THE
HAWTHORNE EDUCATIONAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND HARBOR REGIONAL
CENTER. THANK YOU. TWO EIGHTY
TWO. CARLOS SANCHEZ HOW TO MAKE
HEALTH SERVICES CORPORATION M.
S. S. P. AND C. BANK PROVIDER.
THANK YOU. NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DAVE MEADOWS LIBERTY
DENTAL PLAN THANK YOU. FIFTY
EIGHT. EIGHT POINT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. THANK
YOU. ONE ZERO SIX. ROBIN
LEVINSON I'LL BE OFF OF WEST
COAST CHILDREN'S CLINIC IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
TWENTY ONE. DON MYERS THAT
YELLOW DOT THE HEALTH CENTER
SERVING YOLO COUNTY THANK YOU.
TWO FIFTY. ABIGAIL REMAINS WITH
THE LATINO COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THIRTY FOUR. THREE MICAH BUTLER
DIRECTOR BAYVIEW HUNTERS POINT
ABOUT THE HEALTH CENTER IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND ALSO CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ADULT DAY
SERVICES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
TWO SEVENTY ONE. TWO SEVENTY
WHAT'S YOUR LINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON BOB CAN PATEL
COMMUNITY HEALTH COUNCIL THANK
YOU. TWO SEVENTY FOUR. HELLO
DOCTOR LAURA HYNES CEO STANFORD
YOU SOLUTIONS- STANFORD SIERRA
YOUTH AND FAMILIES AND
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
LAND. THANK YOU. TWO FIFTY
NINE. TWO WEEKS LATER WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE. THANK YOU.
NINETY FIVE. THIS IS LOIS OWN
D. BRIDGES ELDER DAY IN SANTA
CRUZ THE BASS AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF ADULT
DAY SERVICES THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINETY SIX. THE MAIN
TOPICS WHEN NOT SURE OF THE
BOARD OF THE FAMILY CAREGIVER
ALLIANCE AND AREA CAREGIVER
RESOURCE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TWO SEVENTY. GOOD AFTERNOON TIM
ALL AROUND WITH THE WHITEMAN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF MANIFEST
MADAX DOCKING THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO REACH OUT TO GET YOU SEVENTY
EIGHT THE REDUCTION PROGRAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE
MINERALIZATION PLEASE PUT YOU.
THANKS FOR. TWENTY FIVE. HI I
AM JENNIFER HER LEBANON AFTER A
WORKING CAREGIVER WHOSE MOTHER
UTILIZES THE BEST SERVICES IN
SAN DIEGO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THREE FOURTEEN. THREE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JAMIE MORGAN
WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE MODERATOR HOW MANY PEOPLE
DO YOU STILL HAVE ON THE LINE.
QUITE A FEW. RIGHT THEY'RE
STILL QUEUING UP OKAY. WE DO
HAVE YEAH WE ARE RUNNING INTO A
TIME CAPSULE I'M GONNA KEEP
GOING THROUGH THE NAMES OR ASK
PEOPLE TO TELL SPEAKER QUICKLY
BUT WE ARE GONNA HAVE TO TRY TO
WRAP THIS UP SO WE CAN DO OUR
VOTING- SO BASICALLY TRY AND-
GIVE PEOPLE ANOTHER FOUR
MINUTES. OF JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. TWO FORTY SEVEN.
MICHAEL EIGHT CHILDREN NOW
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
ELEVEN. I AM WORKING WITH
PARENTS OVER THE RIGHT TO
EDUCATION NETWORK THANK YOU
THANK YOU. TWO THIRTY FOUR.
BARBARA GLASER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
ISSUE EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. TWO FIFTY SIX. YEAH
HAMPTON CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH PLANS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE GALLIERA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT CLARION CARES ABOUT
CENTER IN NAPA CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. FIFTY NINE. MONICA
MILLER RECORD IN OCTOBER TWENTY
EIGHT- ALZHEIMER'S ORANGE
COUNTY ALL COMERS LA CAR AND GO
TO CALIFORNIA THAT FEATURED A
NURSE ANESTHETIST. THANK YOU.
NINETY EIGHT. HEY I NEED YOUR
NUMBER. I THINK IT'S THIRTY
EIGHT OR NINE EIGHT NINETY
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHEN THE MY HARMONY AND HANDED
IN A SECOND PLAYERS NETWORK AND
INTERNET FACILITY ACTION OF SAN
FRANCISCO. THANK YOU. TWO ZERO
FIVE FOUR FIVE. READ OUR UNION-
BUT WITH- YOU CAN WRITE A
BESTSELLER. THANK YOU YEAH.
THREE TWENTY ONE. THREE TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS SERRA DEL I'M CALLING FROM
THE INSTITUTE ON AGING AND THEN
HE PROVIDER IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THANK YOU. THREE NINETEEN.
THANK YOU MARTY AMADO FAMILY
MEMBER IF YOU CAN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THREE FIFTEEN. COULD
YOU TELL GOD ALL THE APPLICANTS
TO TALK TO THE LEADERSHIP FORUM
ON ITEM EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU.
THREE THREE THREE THREE ZERO.
JENNIFER HOWELL DIGNITY HEALTH
CONNECTED LIVING AND THAT HE
AND THE BEST PROGRAMS. IN THE-
COUNTY THANK YOU. THREE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH
WILL BE OUT MARCHING DIVES ITEM
SIXTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A LIVE FROM KIM PLEASE
STATE YOUR INFORMATION YOUR
FULL NAME. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CANBERRA EXTENDED FAMILY BASED.
THANK YOU. THREE THIRTY FIVE.
YEAH MONTANA WITH SENIOR AND
pSCHOOL. THANK YOU. THREE
SEVENTEEN. KAMPALA WITH MSSP
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY. THANK YOU.
THREE EIGHTEEN. OKAY WELL
CURRENTLY JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE
LOS ANGELES M. S. S. P. THANK
YOU. TWO SIXTY EIGHT. HE LOOKS
TO BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. BLIND TWELVE. BLY
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CORINNE JANET CEO FAMILY
BRIDGES HE BACKED CENTERS
ALAMEDA COUNTY THANK YOU. NINE
THREE TWENTY. OUR PROJECT
CENTER HERE HE AND EMMA'S PEACE
AND CRUZ AND MONTEREY COUNTY.
THANK YOU. TELL ME MORE LEFT.
ONE FOR SURE OKAY MELISSA SICK
THAT ONE THREE THREE THREE
THREE THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND SO IT SEEMS AND
WE'LL TELL YOU HOW MUCH BETTER
THANKS OKAY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT SO AGAIN- I JUST WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INDIVISIBLE TO
SUPERIOR APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE. I KNOW THAT IT'S
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ABLE TO TAKE
THE VERBAL TESTIMONY BUT I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE. AS YOU
KNOW AS PEOPLE AT YOUR NOTES-
CLIVE ITEMS ARE STILL BEING
HELD OPEN TYPICALLY THE ONES
THAT PEOPLE HAVE COMMENTED ON
SO THERE'S- YOUR CONTINUED
INPUT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT-
AND- WILL BE TRUE WE INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN AN OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD SO WE CAN DO
THAT BY WRITING SO THANKS SO
MUCH. FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION WE
ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR
VOTES. CALENDAR HERE- SO WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IS- WE HAVE.
A SET OF ITEMS- PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT WE HAVE ITEMS PREFERS
FOR VOTING CALENDAR. A WHICH
WOULD BE I THINK. TO ZERO
SENSHI TO ZERO AND THEN FOR
CALENDAR BE WHICH WOULD BE TWO
ONE- BASED ON INPUT FROM THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS I WOULD MAKE
NOTES THAT. WE HAVE HERE A
TOTAL OF A HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
ITEMS. ON OUR VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR- SO. WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND START WITH- THE CALENDAR
HEY AND I UNDERSTAND THERE IS
ONE EXTRACTION- SIR MELINDA'S
YOU WANTED YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
I JUST THERE IS ONE CHANGE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN WILL BE
MOVED FROM. BUT CALENDAR A INTO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR OKAY SO
WE'LL MOVE SIXTY SEVEN TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ANY OTHER
CHANGES TO THE ACCOUNT UNDER A-
OKAY SO- THOSE ARE ITEMS.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
NINE FORTY SIX FIFTY TWO TO
FIFTY THREE. SEVENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX NINETY
THREE ONE OF THE THREE ONE OH
NINE ONE TWENTY ONE AND ONE
FIFTY EIGHT- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CALENDAR A-
BEN. HI HELLO I BELINDA'S
ABSTAIN. OKAY SO LEVEL CALENDAR
A IS OUT TWO ZERO NEXT WE'LL
MOVE THE VOTE CALENDAR BE ARE
THERE ANY EXTRACTIONS FROM THE
CALENDAR BE. FACING ON THOSE
ARE ITEMS NUMBER. ELEVEN
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN SIXTY NINE  ONE TWENTY TWO.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL M.
HI HELLO HI MELINDA'S. OKAY SO
THOSE ARE OUT TO ONE AGAIN
THOSE ARE THE VOTES ON THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FINALLY
WE HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FORD STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS IS-
ON ITEMS ONE THROUGH TEN TWELVE
SEVENTEEN THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN.
293-363-8402. FORTY TO FORTY
FIVE FORTY SEVEN TO FIFTY FIFTY
FOUR TO FIFTY SEVEN.
596-267-7070. NINE EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE NINETY
TWO NINETY FOUR NINETY EIGHT
NINETY N
1-421-151-1721 212-321-5150 TWO
TO ONE FIFTY SEVEN AND ONE
FIFTY NINE. DANNY EXTRACTIONS
C. NINE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE CONSENT CALENDAR
YEAH HI ALTHOUGH I WELL IT DOES
HI. THE ONSENT CALENDARS OUT
THREE ZERO SO THIS CONCLUDES
THE AGENDA FOR PART A OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES.
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO RECESS BECAUSE WE ARE
RESETTING A LITTLE LATER THAN
EXPECTED WE WILL THEN RESUME.
FOR PART. B. C. HOW MUCH I'M
DOING HERE. TO CAN WE CAN WE
BRING BACK PART B. AT TWO
THIRTY. AFTER A TIME OF FORTY
FIVE MINUTES IS TWO THIRTY FIVE
I GUESS OKAY SO AND FORTY FIVE
CENTS TO THIRTY FIVE WILL
RECONVENE BACK HERE AND FORT
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE FOR
PART B. OF OUR AGENDA SO WE ARE
NOW IN RECESS. THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOW
RANKED RECONVENING FROM RECESS
FOR THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. I'M GONNA BRING BACK
THIS BACK INTO ORDER- GOOD
AFTERNOON NOW AND IN RESPONSE
TO THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE SENATE
STAFF. YOU MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING. HAS BEEN
HELPING A SENSUAL HEARING AND
HAS MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
TO NORMAL PRACTICES TO IN. IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
CONDUCTING A HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. AS WE COMPLY WITH
THESE ORDERS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL OF TESTIMONY BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
BEING PROVIDED REMOTELY THROUGH
THE USE OF THE VIDEO CONFERENCE
SYSTEM. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
PLEASE MAKE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS. PARTICIPANTS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING AND ON
MUTING THEMSELVES SO THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THIS WILL GREATLY AID
AND ELIMINATION OF ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASKED EVERY TIME
YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR QUESTION
YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM WHICH-
MONITOR HERE. ONCE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AN AGENDA ISSUE TO WHICH YOU
ARE REFERRING. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO ACCEPT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE OF IS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TUESDAY. WE MOVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL DEFY
YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE
AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE THOUSAND AT THAT
IF YOU ARE USING A SPEAKER
PHONE OR SOME OTHER DEVICE.
PLEASE TRY TO SPEAK DIRECTLY
INTO THE RECEIVER. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR AFTER
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESSING CONDUCTED HEARINGS
IN AS CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY TO MAYBE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW. HE USED
TO THE NEW ONLINE TECHNOLOGIES
AND TOOLS PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
AND PATIENT SO THAT ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. LOUD MAKE NOTE THAT WHAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE DOING TODAY
IS WE ARE GOING TO. BE SHARING.
FROM SEVERAL AGENCIES BELIEVE
EIGHT. ISSUES FOR DISCUSSION
FROM A DIFFERENT AGE FROM THE
AGENCY'S RELATED TO HUMAN
SERVICES. WE WILL FIRST HEAR
FROM EACH OF THOSE AGENCIES
WITH COMMENTS FROM THE DELEO
AND THAT FINANCE WILL THEN TAKE
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
AFTER WE COMPLETE THE ENTIRE
AGENA WE WILL THEN OPEN IT UP
FOR ONE PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION
SECTION. DURING PUBLIC COMMENT
WE ASK THAT YOU INTRODUCE
YOURSELF BY NAME IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION. AND THEN AND THEN
A FIGHT WHICH ITEMS ON THE VOTE
CALENDAR SO WE HAVE. IN OUR
ISSUE LIST. FOR ABOUT ONLY
CALENDAR. WE HAVE JUST DOUBLE
CHECK THANK ONE HUNDRED ITEMS
SO NUMBERED IN THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR SO PLEASE INDICATE
WHICH ITEM. OR ISSUE NUMBER ON
THE DAILY CALENDAR. AND YOUR
POSITION ON THAT ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THERE WE ASK
THAT YOU RESTRUCTURED COMMENT
AGAIN TO YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION THE- ISSUE NUMBERS
THAT YOU WISH TO ADDRESS AND
YOUR POSITION ON THAT ISSUE. WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE
PHONE LINES WE WANNA TRY TO GET
THROUGH AS MANY AS POSSIBLE
UNFORTUNATELY WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO GET TO EVERYONE AND THE
TIME LIMIT. THEREFORE I ALSO
ASK AN URGE THAT YOU SUBMIT
WRITTEN COMMENTS WHAT DO YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY PERHAPS
ELABORATE ON YOUR POSITION TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE BY EMAIL. AND
THERE'S AN EMAIL LINK ON OUR
WEBSITE TO DO SO ALSO I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT IT IS- IT'S- A
PRIOR SPEAKER HAS RECENTLY
EXPRESSED THE SAME POSITION AS
YOU. ARE YOU'RE COMING FROM THE
SAME ORGANIZATION OUR GROUP-
PLEASE INDICATE THAT YOU JUST
ANY GREEN MEANT OR PERHAPS
AGAIN TO BE SURE THAT WE CAN
HEAR FROM EVERYONE BECAUSE WE
HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT ISSUES
OR HEARING. THAT HAVE THAT YOU
WILL COMMENT VERBALLY BUT WE'LL
JUST COMMENT V. THE- NO EMAIL
SO I GUESS WE'RE TRYING TO THIS
OPEN TO. AND HERE MANY OF USE
AS POSS. AND WE DO WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU SO AGAIN I WANT TO PRE
I APPRECIATE THAT. SO WITH THAT.
THEN AFTER PUBLIC COMMENT WE
WILL BE AND THEN BE TAKING
VOTES ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS AS IS INDICATED
AND WILL BE TO AS WELL SO- SO
WITH THAT- WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE AGENDA ITEM NOW WE HAVE- WE
HAVE TO RESUME A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM IT TO BE A
HEARING. SO WE'RE JUST BACK
FROM RECESS SO WE DO NOT NEED
TO RE ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED.
WE WILL FIRST BEGAN WITH THE-
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. WE HAVE. OKAY
THE PART OF AGING SO OKAY SO WE
BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING AND- IT CAN WHAT WE WHAT
YOU DO IS JUST FOCUS WE HAVE A
LOT OF AGENCIES GO THROUGH SO
WE HAVE. THREE QUESTIONS THAT
WE ASK THAT YOU SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
POSED IN THE- AGENDA. AND THEN
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE
COMMENT FROM LA L. IN FINANCE
SO- WELCOME PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOUR NAME YOUR TITLE FROM THE
PART OF AGING AND LOOK FOR TO
YOUR ANSWERS TO THE QUESTIONS
WE POSE ON THE AGENDA. THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KIM ACQUIRE WEIGHT ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. AND I WILL
BE VERY BRIEF I'M PLEASED WE
ACTUALLY HAD OUR- USUAL BUDGET
HEARING EARLY IN MARCH. BEFORE
WE ALL ENTERED THIS. NEW AND
DIFFICULT TIME. OTHER THREE
QUESTIONS HERE FOR THAT
APARTMENT EIGHT BEIJING ALL
ABOUT THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS THERE ARE TWO
ELIMINATIONS. ARE WITH OUR
PARTNERSHIP PARTNER- DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. AND THREE
CUTS. QUESTION ONE FOCUSES ON
THE MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM. ARE AT YOUR
CORRECT SENATOR THIS IS AN
ELIMINATION BOUT WOULD SERVE. I
WOULD HIT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SERVED BY THIS PROGRAM SOME OF
THE OLDEST YOU FAIL AS YOUR
RECEIVING BOTH HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SUPPORT. AT HOME I
BELIEVE AS YOU HEARD AND
DISCUSSED THIS MORNING- WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THIS IS THAT. OUR OUR
RESULTS SOLELY OF THE BUDGET
PRESSURES PARTICULARLY ON
MEDICAID ON THE APPROACH OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING AGENCY
WIDE. TO REALLY FOCUS ON
KEEPING ELIGIBILITY OPEN- AND
IN MEETING THE NEW NEED WITH
THE WITH THE RECESSION AND-
LIMITING LIMITING AND
ELIMINATING OPTIONAL BENEFITS.
AND M. S. S. P. L. HER CATTLE
DESIGNATION IS AN OPTIONAL.
BENEFIT I. WANT TO CONTINUE TO
OFFER QUESTIONS. THE ABSOLUTELY.
QUESTION TO YOU. ABOUT THE
DOCKING NEED FOR YOUR AND BY IT.
AND THEY SENATOR WE AGREE HOW
THE OLDER MAN ACT PROGRAMS THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING IS RUNNING
IT. ARSENE NEED AN INCREASED
VOLUME THE MOST RECENT WEEK.
MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED NINETY
TWO THOUSAND MEALS ARE PROVIDED
BY THE ACCOUNTING COMMUNITY. I
AGENCY ON AGING SERVING OVER A
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
THESE ARE BOTH PEOPLE WHO WERE
ALREADY SERVING YOU MAY NEED
MORE MEALS BECAUSE OF THE STAY
AT HOME ORDERS. PEOPLE WHO USED
TO GO TO COMMUNITY AND SENIOR
CENTERS WHO NO LONGER I SHOULD
DO NOT AND OF COURSE SOME
PEOPLE WHO ARE NEWLY IMPACTED
ANNUALLY NEAT SO AGAIN THIS IS
NOT A- PROPOSAL BASED ON THE
THIS IS A PROPOSAL BASED ON THE
ENORMOUS BUDGET PRESSURES WERE
ALL FACING. AND THE THIRD
QUESTION IS TO. TO ESTIMATE
WHAT THE IMPACT WOULD BE OF
THIS EIGHT A HALF MILLION
DOLLAR REDUCTION- BUT THE
METHODOLOGY THAT WE USE IN THE
REPORTING OF OUR NETWORK. THIS
WOULD RESULT IN SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE FEWER
MEALS- AND REACHED YOU ARE. A
REDUCTION OF PEOPLE SERVED AT
NINE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY OLDER ADULTS. I HOPE
THAT'S HELPFUL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR. YOUR COMMON
AND ANSWERS AS COMMENTS FROM
LA- EXPRESS YOUR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE- AS WAS NOTED IN
THE HAND OF THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING I'M CONSIST OF ONE
ELIMINATIONS TO BENEFIT AND
THEN TO REDUCTIONS TO STATE
FUNDING LEVELS FOR CERTAIN
PROGRAMS. IN THE CASE OF THE
BENEFIT ELIMINATIONS FOR BOTH
AND MRS PNC BASS I'M SIMILAR TO
CONCERNS THAT WE RAISED IN THE
HEALTH PORTION OF THE HEARING
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THERE IS
SOME UNCERTAINTY AS TO WHETHER
THE STATE HAS THE ABILITY TO
ELIMINATE BENEFITS WITHIN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM. IN LIGHT OF
RECENT FEDERAL RULES AROUND
STATE CONDITIONS- WHEN DRIVING
DOWN THE TEMPORARY FEDERAL
MATCH INCREASE ADDITIONALLY AND
SPECIFICALLY TO THE M. S. S. P.
ELIMINATION WELL THE
ADMINISTRATION ASSUMES FULL
YEAR SAVINGS WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THAT IS ON- POSSIBLY UNLIKELY
GIVEN THAT ONE WE WOULD REQUIRE
FEDERAL APPROVAL TO ELIMINATE
THE PROGRAM BUT THAT ALSO THEY
WERE PROBABLY. REQUIRE AND I
HAVE A NEED FOR TIME TO FULLY
TRANSITION RECIPIENTS OF THE
PROGRAM AND RAMP DOWN
OPERATIONS. ALTERNATIVES TO
ELIMINATIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER IS RATHER THAN
ELIMINATING THE PROGRAMS ALL
TOGETHER ASKING THE INFORMATION
ADMINISTRATION IF THERE ARE
WAYS IN WHICH WE COVERAGE-
REDUCE COST PRESSURES EITHER
THROUGH WORKLOAD RELIEF OR
PROGRAM FLEXIBILITIES. AN
EXAMPLE AND I MISSED AS HE IS
THAT AS A PART OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET THERE
WAS AN AUGMENTATION MADE TO
INCREASE AND THIS IS P.
PROVIDER RATES ACROSS THREE
YEARS- AND ALTERNATIVE TO
ELIMINATING THE PROGRAM
ALTOGETHER COULD BE JUST.
PULLING BACK THOSE UNSPENT
FUNDS FROM- THE BUDGET YEAR AND
THE FOLLOWING YEAR- WHICH WOULD
RESULT IN ABOUT A TEN MILLION.
DOLLAR ONE TIME SAVINGS. IN THE
CASE FUNDING WERE DONE IT'S
INTEREST. THAT THE ADMINS FOR
SOME OF THE PRO AT LEAST EXPECT
THAT THE WE'RE DONE. COULD BE.
BY DISH ONE FEDERAL FUNDS THE
STATE IS RECEIVING I'M DUE TO A
CORONAVIRUS. I'M MEETING THAT
TOTAL FUNDS WITHIN THESE
PROGRAMS WOULD REMAIN
RELATIVELY FLAT. WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THE STATE REDUCTIONS ARE
PROPOSED TO BE ONGOING WHEREAS
THE FEDERAL FUNDS. ARE ONE TIME
AND ADDITIONALLY IT IS UNCLEAR
TO US HOW QUICKLY THOSE FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE BEING SPENT BY LOCAL
PROGRAM PROVIDERS. I'M IN LIGHT
OF THE POSSIBLE COLBY NINETEEN
RESPONSE EFFORTS WHICH WOULD
ALSO HAVE IMPLICATIONS FOR ON
THIS- EXPECTATION OF FEDERAL
FUNDS POTENTIALLY. OFFSETTING
STAGE PRODUCTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CUT. SORRY OKAY. I
JUST NOTING. ONLY A FEDERAL
FUNDS SO. FEDERAL STIMULUS
PACKAGES SPECIFIC FUTURE SHE
HAS PROVIDED AN ADDITIONAL
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
BETWEEN THE TWO. I'M OUR AGING
I SERVICES WELL AS- FUNDS FOR.
THE OMBUDSMAN GRAHAM AND DINO
WORK THAT WE DO THAT THIS IS
THE OR ISSUE EMPLOYMENT THESE
WERE. ARE PARTIALLY OFFSET BY
THE FEDERAL FUNDS RECEIVED
THANK YOU. HEY THANK YOU OUR
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBER. SIR TOM
L. IT YOU PRETTY MUCH MY
QUESTION RICK B. EIGHTY ARE. I
WAS GOING TO IF YOU KNOW THE
ONE TIME FUNDED IT COULD OFFSET
THE REDUCTIONS THERE- JUST WANT
TO STRESS HOW IMPORTANT THIS
PROGRAM ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
TIME WHEN W JUST NEED TO MAKE
SURE THE SERVICES ARE WHEN A
TEEN SERVICES FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. THANK YOU THE
QUESTIONS SO- ACTUALLY QUESTION
FOR- BUT ITS AGING OR FINANCE
SO. IS NOTED BY ELIO WE'RE
LOOKING FOR ONE TIME FEDERAL
FUNDS BUT- THESE CUTS ARE ON
GOING WHY IS THAT THE CASE WHEN
NOT JUST- MAC MATCH THE
FEDERAL. THE HOPE FOR FEDERAL
FUNDS AND HAVE IT IS A ONE
YEAR. CONTRACT. FIND US AGAIN I
THINK AND LOOKING AT THE BUDGET
STRUCTURE WE ARE FACING A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN THE OUT
YEARS UP TO SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS. NECESSARY TO MAKE
THESE REDUCTIONS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS BUT CERTAIN SOME OF THESE
ARE SUBJECT TO FEDERAL TRIGGER
SO HOPEFULLY THAT'S NOT
NECESSARY- JUST REITERATING THE
POINT ABOUT THE STRUCTURAL.
DEFICIT THIS BEFORE US. NO OPEN
TO WORKING WITH LEGISLATURE THE
COMING WEEK. OKAY AND THEN IN
TERMS OF A FINE. TERMS OF THE
HOPES FOR FUNDS WE TALKING
FUTURE FEDERAL. OR WE LOOKING
AT FUNDS THAT BEEN BY. TO OR
HOPE TO CELSO WHICH WHICH
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE WE A TWO BACK
FILL THESE. TO SAY THE
NUTRITION PRO OR A DISPLAY
RESOURCE IT'S A- PERSPECTIVES
FUN OKAY SO THE FUND WE RAISE.
OUR DATA DATA BEEN PASSED
CONGRESS THE THOSE WITH THOSE
ALREADY CARRY. FOR HELP YOU
HEAR ME. FINANCE ARE YOU HONEST
YES OKAY. SOME STATE OR THE
FEDERAL FUNDS SEPARATE BEEN
ALLEN- TEMPORARY BAN PASSED BY
CONGRESS AND SIGNED BY THE
PRESIDENT THOSE ARE ALL
ACCOUNTED FOR SO WE'D HAVE TO.
THESE ARE. IN TERMS OF THESE
PARTICULAR YOU KNOW FUNNY THAT
MIGHT HELP SUPPORT THESE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS. THE ANSWER
DEPENDS ON THE VARIOUS PROGRAM
THE DEPARTMENTS IN VARIOUS
STAGES OF ALLOCATING THE
DOLLARS FOR INSTANCE I BELIEVE
FOR THE- FAMILIES FIRST.
FEDERAL STIMULUS PACKAGE THAT
ALLOWED TWENTY FIVE ALL PRICE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FROM THE
TRASH HEAP PROGRAM THOSE HAVE
GONE OUT. HARPING ON WHERE
THEY'RE OUT WITH. ME DOLLARS
WERE. YEAH OKAY AGENCY DO YOU
WANT THAT. YES THAT IS TRUE
THANK YOU BEING IN IN YOU STILL
WITH THAT OF IN. ACTED OUT TO
AGENCIES AND JUNE OKAY BUT THAT
THEY'RE FINE WITH NOW. THIS S
MARK BACK AWAY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PART OF AGING ON
THAT YOU'VE GOT THE DIRECTOR
YEAH THE FUNDS THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IS- YOU KNOW ALL
FEDERAL FUNDS SO EIGHT POINT
FIVE MILLION- IS MR HOUSER
NOTED WERE RECEIVING AT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION THROUGH THE
FAMILY'S FIRST ACT AS WELL AS
ANOTHER. FIFTY MILLION UNITS
RESPONDING TO THE CURES ACT SO
WE- ARE RECEIVING ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS OKAY SO THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD CONDEMN IS
THAT MONEY CAN BE USED TO HELP
MAKE UP FOR THE CUTS THAT.
WE'RE PROPOSING HERE MAY REVISE.
RADIO FOR. IT YEAH I MEAN IN
THAT WOULD I MEAN WOULD SERVE
SORT OF A OFFICER. I MEAN IT
HAD WEAKENED WITH POINT FIVE
MILLION. WE COULD OF. AS INTO
THE- BUT- YEAH THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING DOES HELP OFFSET. I'M
THE POINT FIVE MILLION OKAY.
ALL RIGHT AND THEN I THE. OTHER
ISSUE DAY. AND A GUIDE RATE WE
DISCUSS THAT EARLIER THIS BUT-
HE OFFERS A AND THEN AND THAT'S
P. I. OUT DC. I DON'T KNOW
THERE'S ANY ESTIMATE FOR AGING.
IN TERMS OF THE I. BECAUSE SO
WE TAKE AWAY THIS PROGRAM WE
HAVE HAVING PEOPLE. MAYBE NOT A
HUNDRED AND IN A NURSING HOME
BUT I HARD TO BELIEVE THAT ZERO
AND UP TO THE NURSING. SO THESE
ARE PEOPLE RIGHT HOME. AND ARE.
SO WE ACCOUNT YEAH SO AGAIN. I
DON'T THINK WE'RE COUNTING THAT
OFFSET THE IN THE C. INTO OF
THAT COST WILL OCCUR FROM
ELIMINATING PROGRAM. BUT
PERHAPS YOU SPEAK TO WHAT'S OF
RESTARTING THESE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING TO SENSUALLY
RICH ELIMINATE BOTH CBS AND
MSSP. IF WE DO GET FEDERAL
FUNDS WHAT KIND OF. EFFORT YOU
KNOW WHAT WOULD IT TAKE
ACTUALLY. THE PROGRAM AGAIN AS
IT. GOING TO BE BETTER TO KEEP
THEM. SINCE CAN'T REALLY CLOSE
AND RIGHT AWAY UNLESS YOU
REALLY PLAN TO TELL EVERYONE TO
UNITE AND JULY FIRST WE JUST.
EVERYONE BUT I CAN'T IMAGINE
THAT. THAT'S SOMETHING WE'D
ACTUALLY DO OR MAYBE I
SHOULDN'T SAY THAT. IS THAT.
WOULD MAKE MENTION OF THAT SO
MAYBE AGING CAN ADDRESS THAT I
MEAN. IF EVEN IF THIS WAS
PASSED. ARE WE JUST. GONNA DO
JULY FIRST. YES THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING HAS BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES- AND OUR LOCAL
PROVIDER NETWORKS OF BOTH A
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES AND
MULTI PURPOSE ADULT SERVICES
ABOUT- WHAT A TIME LINE WOULD
BE AND YOU ARE CORRECT THAT IT
WOULD TAKE SEVERAL MONTHS BOTH
FROM A- REGULATORY PERSPECTIVE
WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
PARTNER CMS YOU GET APPROVAL
BUT ALSO FROM A HUMAN
PERSPECTIVE HAVING TRANSITION
PLANS FOR THE PEOPLE. WHO ARE
BEING SERVED- AND THE CENTRIST
THEMSELVES. IN OF THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE LAST TIME THE
SHUT DOWN I WOULD. A DIRECTOR
COURSE OF THOSE ASSOCIATIONS
WHO CAN WHO CAN POWERFULLY TELL
THE STORY OF THAT HISTORY BUT
ALSO THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
A SUBCOMMITTEE ON LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. I DID DO
A REPORT. THE MANY
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDING
STRENGTHENING THESE NETWORKS
AND ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT THEY
CITE IS THAT- IT HAS TAKEN
ABOUT A DECADE TO REBUILD. ON
THE NETWORK SO THESE ARE AGAIN-
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS AND- TRADE OFFS
AND I BELIEVE OUR FINANCE
COLLEAGUES CAN SPEAK TO WHETHER
THOSE. OTHER COSTS YOU MENTION
THIS MORNING AGAIN RACE HERE
ARE ARE IN THE ESTIMATE. OKAY
FRAN. YES CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
OUR COLLEAGUE AT THE ACS AND JC
COOPER OTHER COSTS FOR- ALSO.
ARE NOT BUILT TEN NOW WE DON'T
KNOW THAT NUMBER WOULD BE AN
IT'S IN THE BUDGET OR CURRENTLY.
NOTHING OR PERCENT OKAY WELL I
WOULD SO SOUNDS LIKE WE MORE I
READING OF WHAT THE TWO SAVINGS
WE BE IF WE TOOK SO A POLICY
SET UP WITH I NOT SURE A GOOD I
BUT MORE ACT. WE NEED TO BE IN
THE TRANSIT TIME WHERE WE HAVE
CONTINUED FUNDING WE NEED TO
BUILD IN THE OFFSET. OF THE
COSTS TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE'RE REALLY REALLY TRULY END
UP IN TERMS OF SAVINGS IT MAY
TURN OUT THAT IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
WORTH THE EFFORT. TO ELIMINATE
THE PROGRAM FROM A BUT EVEN
FROM A SIMPLY BUDGETARY POINT
OF VIEW I THINK MY POLICY POINT
OF VIEW THERE'S A LOT OF
REASONS TO SAY WHY THIS WOULD
BE A BAD IDEA BUT EVEN FROM A
BUDGETARY STANDPOINT WE NEED TO
HAVE AN ACCURATE ACCOUNTING. OF.
WHAT WE SHOULD DO WE COULD
REALLY EXPECT. SO OKAY ANY
OTHER. OR ON A- OKAY WELL. FOR
MUCH LET'S NOW. O TO THE
APARTMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. AND AGAIN ASKED THAT-
FOCUS THE PRESENTATION ON THE
QUESTIONS IN THE AGENDA. THANK
YOU THANKS THANK YOU SENATOR
AND THIS IS NANCY BARTON
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES THANK YOU COULD
SEE YOU THANK YOU SO DOCTRINE-
YOUR ATTENTION TO. THE ISSUES
THAT ARE OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA
IF YOU WANTED TO- SO START ON A
PAGE SIX- THIS- CORRECTLY NOTES
IN THE QUESTION AND THE SUMMARY
OF THE QUESTION IS THAT- WE HAD
IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. A PROVIDER
RATE INCREASE OF EIGHT POINT 2%
FOR CERTAIN SERVICE PROVIDERS-
AND AT THAT TIME WE HAD-
REQUESTED AND HAD APPROVED A
SUSPENSION OF THOSE RATE
INCREASES- DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS YEAR
PROPOSED TO EXTEND THAT
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE
SUSPENSIONTO BE EXTENDED OUT
TO JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE- MAY REVISE CONTINUES
WITH THAT PROPOSAL. ON THE
QUESTION BEFORE US IS ASKING
ABOUT HOW THEY EAT THE RATE
INCREASE AND TWENTY NINETEEN
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE RAISING
THEIR RATES CUT TWICE SO
QUESTIONING AT THAT EIGHT POINT
TWO PERCENT. IF WHAT WERE ABLE
TO DO AND THE PROJECTION. OF
THE PROPOSED. REDUCTION THAT
WERE GOING TO BE COUNTING
REDUCE. MORE ONCE SO TO ANSWER
THE I'M GONNA GOING TO WALK YOU
THROUGH THE AT ALL THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT FOR THAT. READ THAT
WE PROPOSED A BEFORE I THAT AND
TO JUST MAKE A CAR. POINT SO ON
THESE HOLE ON SEO IT TALKS
ABOUT WENT DOT APPROACH. RATE
AND READ OF THE- TREND. FOR A
TOTAL OF THREE MILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL STATEMENTS AND THAT
IS ACCURATE- JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT ACTUALLY IT'S TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE THE- GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS THAT WE HAVE PROPOSED
FOR THE PAYMENT REDUCTION. AND
THEN SEVENTY MILLION FOR THE
ADDITIONAL REDUCTIONS THAT ARE
RELATED TO- EXPENDITURE REVIEWS
AND- UTILIZATION REVIEWS AND
STANDARDIZING SERVICE AS- AND
SO ON ME DAY THAT THE APPROACH
THAT WE TOOK IN IDENTIFYING THE
STATUS FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION. WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THREE DIFFERENT TIER
LEVELS IT WAS INFORMED BY THE
RATE STUDY THAT WAS UPDATED AND
RELEASED EARLIER THIS YEAR. AND
BASED ON THAT WE IDENTIFIED
THOSE SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF INCREASES.
THEREFORE GIVEN AN INDICATION
OF THE DELTA BETWEEN WHAT THEIR
CURRENT RATE IS AND THEN HOW
MUCH THEY WOULD BE NEEDING TO-
HAD IS AN INCREASE THOSE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF INCREASE FOR
THOSE THAT ARE IDENTIFIED AS
NEEDING THAT- THE GREATEST
RELEASE- ON A PAYMENT
REDUCTION. AND THEREFORE THEY
WOULD BE THE PROVIDERS THAT
WOULD BE RECEIVING A SEVEN
POINT. FIVE PERCENT- PAYMENT
REDUCTION AND- GROUPS WE HAVE
OUR LIVES IT JUST TURNED OFF
SORRY ABOUT THAT. AND THEN THE
ELEVEN POINT 5% WAS- FOR THOSE
IN THE MID RANGE AND THEN FOR
THOSE SERVICE PROVIDERS- THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED AS EITHER
RESEEDING- HELLO UP FIVE
PERCENT. INCREASE AT THE
UPDATED RATE STUDY REFLECTED OR
ACTUALLY HAD A DECREASE THEY
WERE- GOING. TO BE RECEIVING A
GREATER LEVEL I THAT YEAR FORT
PER AND CLARIFY. THE EIGHT
POINT TWO PER WHAT WE DID IS
THAT WE HAVE A POINT TO PROVE.
PAYMENTS INK THE IS IN OUR BASE.
AND SO THE BASE RATES THE HAVE
THE PAYMENT READ. ON TOP FOR IT
IS NOT EIGHT. THAT WE I DO WANT
TO NOTE THAT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE HAD PROPOSED THREE
ADDITIONAL SERVICE CODES TO BE
INCLUDED. I'M IN A SUPPLEMENTAL
RATE INCREASED TWO OF THEM WERE
WITH AN EARLY START WHEN WAS
WITH. INDEPENDENT LIVING SKILLS
AND WE HAVE WITHDRAWN THAT
PROPOSAL FROM THE AND IN THE
MAY REVISE- I DO WANT TO MAKE
NOTE. IN OUR PROPOSAL FOR THE
PAYMENT REDUCTIONS THAT WE
ACTUALLY DO MODIFY THOSE. THREE
DIFFERENT SERVICE CODES TO
ACCOUNT FOR THAT EIGHT POINT
TWO PERCENT- AND SO THEY WOULD
HAVE EIGHT EIGHT. RELATED
REDUCTION AND THEREFORE THERE
ARE- PAYMENT REDUCTION WOULD
BE- FACTORING THAT EIGHT POINT
TWO PERCENT- I'M GOING TO THE
QUESTION ON AND ON IT THE- THE
SOURCE OF THE ESTIMATE FOR. THE
REVIEW OF THE EXPENDITURE
TRENDS- I WANT TO ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT THE EXPENDITURE
TRENDS AND ALSO UTILIZATION
REVIEW AS A PART OF THAT
SEVENTY MILLION THAT WE'RE
IDENTIFYING- WE DO HAVE
PROPOSED IN THE TRAILER THE
LANGUAGE FOR JULY FIRSTTWENTY
TWENTY ONE FOR THE EFFECTIVE
DATE. THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
START IDENTIFYING SAVINGS THIS
YEAR- AS I NOTED THERE'S THREE
DIFFERENT AREAS IN WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO BE TARGETING- THAT
SEVENTY MILLION AND IDENTIFIED
SAVINGS. THE FIRST A
STANDARDIZATION OF TARGETED
SERVICES SO WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT OUR TRENDS
FOR SERVICES. THAT ARE ACROSS
THE STATE FAMILIES HAVE HAD
SOME GOOD. ABOUT
INCONSISTENCIES RACIAL CENTERS
AND DIFFERENT POLICIES AND I'LL
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE FOR RESPITE
WE BELIEVE BY TAKING A LOOK AT
HOW WE INSTEAD. SPITZER AS MY
TO. THAT THAT WOULD BE A TO
AFFECT SOME SAVING. BUT ALSO BE
ABLE TO SOME TRY. AND CLEAR
INTO SERVICE. OF THOSE SIR. THE
OTHER ONE IS TAKE A LOOK AT A
FISH SEES WE DO KNOW THAT FROM
THE RISK. WHEN WE HAD OTHER
SAVING MEASURES AT THEIR WORST
GROUP THAT WENT FORWARD THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY SOME
SAVINGS. WE BELIEVE
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF THOSE
THAT- ALLOW FOR GREATER
FLEXIBILITY WILL ALSO BE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE SOME SAVINGS AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT WOULD BE THE
TABOR DAY SERVICE SAYS. THIS IS
WHERE YOU HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO CAN HAVE A PERSON CENTERED
APPROACH TO THEIR DAY- AND SO
IT CAN BE- BASED ON IF THEY'RE
RECEIVING- SIX HOURS A DAY OF
SERVICE DURING THE WEEK THEY
MAY ACTUALLY HAVE A MUCH.
REDUCED NUMBER OF HOURS SERVICE
BUT THE FLEXIBILITY. TO BE ABLE
TO. A DRIVE THEIR DATA TO HOW
THEY WANT TO HAVE THEIR SERVICE.
WOULD ABOUT TO THE- THIS IS
PARTICULARLY INTERESTING
BECAUSE A COUPLE AS WERE HOW TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE KHAN.
SETTINGS AND REDUCING THE
EXPOSURE OF INDIVIDUALS. THIS
IS- LIKELY GOING TO BE AN
OPTION THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO EXPLORE NOT ONLY FOR
COST SAVING MEASURES BUT ALSO
FOR THE SAFETY OF INDIVIDUALS.
AS WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO NAVIGATE- LARGER
CONGREGATE SETTINGS. THE FINAL
ONE IS ON UTILIZATION. FOR
INDIVIDUALS- FOR UTILIZATION
AND SERVICE UTILIZATION WE HAVE
SEEN AN INCREASE OF OUR AVERAGE
COST PER CONSUMER WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THAT MUCH OF THAT HAS
TO DO WITH THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
WE SERVE. BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE
BY TAKING A LOOK AT. THE
UTILIZATION PARTICULAR FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
HIGHEST COST. ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS- FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WE'VE
ACTUALLY STARTED SCENE AND- A
COUPLE OF INDIVIDUALS AND QUITE
A FEW THAT ARE ACTUALLY GOING
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. IN EXPENDITURES
AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
A LOOK AT NOT TO REMOVE THE
SAFETY. NOT TO REMOVE THE
SUPPORTS THAT ARE NECESSARY BUT
BUILDING AND- A REVIEW TO MAKE
SURE THAT ON AN ONGOING BASIS
IF THE SUPPORTS ARE NEEDED ON
GOING THAT WE'RE TAKING A LOOK.
AND TO VERIFY THAT THOSE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ARE
NEEDED- FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
I'M WORKING WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS ON THE PLANS WE DO HAVE
EXPENDITURE TRENDS THAT WE WANT
SOME- TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE WE
MOVE FORWARD THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
IDENTIFYING. IS THAT WHAT ARE
THOSE EXPENDITURE TRENDS THAT
ARE OUTSIDE OF. THINGS THAT CAN
BE EXPLAINED BASED ON POLICY OR
THINGS THAT CAN BE EXPLAINED
BASED ON CASE LAW CHANGES- WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE MOVING FROM SCHOOL AGE
TO EDUCATION. THAT OFTEN TRY
AND STRIPES ARE ARE TRENDS IN
OUR CHANGES AND EXPENDITURES.
BUT IF WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
THINGS- BASED ON THOSE
EXPENDITURES BY REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT CANNOT BE
EXPLAINED. THAT IS WHERE WE'RE
GONNA WANT TO FOCUS THE
REGIONAL CENTERS- PLANS AND
IDENTIFYING EXPLAINING THAT AND
THEN- BUILDING A PLAN TO BE
ABLE TO MITIGATE. ANYTHING THAT
IS NOT. NECESSARY OUTSIDE OF
POLICY. AND NEEDS OF END OF
CERTAINLY. THE CONCERN AS WE
MOVE OPERATE. WITH A PROPOSED
FOR THE RE. OF OPERATE. FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTERS OUR PROPOSAL
AS A REDUCTION IN GENERAL FUND
OF THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL
FUND OF FORTY MILLION- WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE HEART AND
THE THAT THE FOCUS OF WHAT WE
DO. FIRST SERVING INDIVIDUALS
IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE SERVICE
COORDINATORS. AND A VERY LARGE
SHERRIN PORTION OTHER REGIONAL
CENTER BUDGET. IS WITH THE
SERVICE COORDINATION- WE DO
KNOW HOWEVER THAT. IN TAKING A
LOOK AT THIS CURRENT YEAR- FOR
ME REVISED. WE HAVE PROPOSED
FOR BUDGET YEAR- THE GROWTH OF
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS.
THAT WE ANTICIPATE GROWING
ABOVE OUR CURRENT- CASELOAD-
AND WE DO HAVE PROPOSED IN THE-MAY REVISED TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THAT CASE ON GROWTH. WE
ALSO HAVE- PROPOSED TO SUPPORT
THE EXPENDITURE GROWTH THAT
GOES ALONG WITH THAT- AGAIN NOT
MINIMIZING THE IMPACT OF A
REDUCTION OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IT DOES REPRESENT
BETWEEN FOUR AND FIVE PERCENT.
OF THE REGIONAL CENTER CASE.
REGIONAL CENTER OPERATIONS
DOLLARS- CERTAINLY MEANINGFUL
BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE BASED ON
THAT AND BASED ON THE OTHER
SUPPORTS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
INTO- THE REGIONAL CENTER
BUDGET THIS NEXT YEAR THAT THAT
WOULD BE ACHIEVABLE WITHOUT
REDUCING SERVICE COORDINATORS.
THIS WILL TAKE SOME- HARD WORK
BY REGIONAL CENTERS IN LOOKING
AT THEIR EXPENDITURES
IDENTIFYING WAYS- TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THOSE SAVINGS. ALONG
WITH AN EXPENDITURE PLAN WE'RE
GOING TO BE ASKING REGIONAL
CENTERS TO SUBMIT TO THE
DEPARTMENT AN OPERATIONS PLAN
THAT'S GOING TO BE IDENTIFYING.
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ACHIEVING THOSE SAVINGS BECAUSE
WE ARE ALSO GOING TO WANT TO
MONITOR. HOW WE'RE DELIVERING
SERVICES TO THE INDIVIDUALS I'M
CONSIDERING ALL OF THE OTHER
ACTIONS THAT ARE HAVING TO
BEAT- IMPLEMENTED ON TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ECONOMIC. THE.
PUBLIC PRICE. SO IN ADDITION TO
OF THAT WE ARE GOING TO WORKING
WITH OUR DS FORCE AND I DON'T.
WHAT ARE THE MAIN AND A- THAT
WE NEED TO. IT FOR HAVE REST
FOR END OF. SO WE START MY-
SOME OF THOSE FOR EARLY ON. A
WE'RE EXPLORING THINGS SUCH AS
SURVEYS FAMILY WORKING TO BE
I'M GOING TO. OUR CONTRACT WITH
REGIONAL. WE'RE CONTINUE OUR
DASH AND I. INDICATE AND MAKING
THAT. THE THINGS THAT WE ARE
OUR MONITOR TO INCLUDE
COMPLAINTS AND WHISTLEBLOWER
COMPLAINTS UP FORTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE WHICH ARE THE-
COMPLAINTS THAT FAMILIES CAN-
SUBMIT OR- DENY ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA WANT TO CONTINUE TO
ATTRACT THOSE- ACTIVITIES TO
SEE A PRISTINE INCREASES. AND
BE ABLE TO WORK ON IT LASTLY I
WILL NOTE THAT WE HAD- PRETTY
MUCH IMPLEMENTED OUR
RESTRUCTURE WITH ADDITIONAL
LAYERS ON THAT ARE OUT WORKING
WITH REGIONAL CENTERS- AND THAT
WILL BE REALLY BENEFICIAL TO
REALLY TRACK IN HERE WHAT THE
CONCERNS ARE. BY ATTENDING
BOARD MEETINGS OF REGIONAL
CENTERS BY ATTENDING. DIFFERENT
MEETINGS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY TO SEE
WHAT IS IMPACTING THOSE- THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE.
LASTLY I'VE BEEN OUT. TO
RESPOND THE- CONCERNED
REGARDING THE PER. TO MY- OUR
FEDERAL PARTICIPATION AND
SERVICE JOBS TO MAKE KERR. AND
THAT WAY IS TWO AND- INDIVIDUAL
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE HEALTH
THROUGH INSTITUTIONAL DEMAND.
SO IT'S NOT INCOME ELIGIBLE BUT
ON GETTING THEM ON MEDIC HOW
BASED ON INTEREST INSTITUTIONAL
DEMAND AT THAT POINT. WE DO
HAVE ABOUT FORTY THREE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS THAT- REALLY MAY
QUALIFY WE RECOGNIZE THAT NOT
ALL OF THEM WELL- WE ALSO HEARD
FROM ADVOCATES THAT MUCH OF THE
CONCERN AS THE COMPLEXITIES OF
COMPLETING THAT AND NOT WANTING
TO HAVE. A UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF PEOPLE NOT
RECEIVING SERVICES IF THEY
DON'T COMPLETE THAT
APPLICATION. WE DO BELIEVE THAT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
MAXIMIZE FEDERAL DOLLARS
PRICKLY AT THIS TIME. SO WE DO
WANT TO WORK WITH OUR ADVOCATES
WE'VE ALREADY STARTED A SMALL
WORKGROUP. IDENTIFYING WAYS
THAT WE CAN HELP FAMILIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
NAVIGATE THE PROCESS OF THE
APPLICATION AND WE CAN REMOVE
THOSE BARRIERS- TWO THINGS ON
THAT ONE IS THAT IF WE CAN DO
TRAINING WAS SERVICE
COORDINATORS MAYBE TRAINING WAS
STATE COUNCIL REGIONAL OFFICES-
LOOKING AT OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. SO WE CAN HAVE
OUR FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS TO
BE THERE TO SUPPORT FAMILIES.
BUT ALSO THE CONCERN IS THAT
THERE IS NOT A DUE PROCESS TO
BE ABLE TO HELP FOR FAMILIES IF
THEY DISAGREE WITH THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY AS WE HAVE BROAD
AUTHORITY WE HAVE BROAD
LANGUAGE IN OUR STATUTE. FOR
THE FAMILIES THAT CAN END
CONSUMERS CAN APPEAL- ANY
DECISION BY THE REGIONAL CENTER
AND THIS WOULD FALL UNDER THAT
STATUTE. I'M SO HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ON ANY OF THESE
ISSUES. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH-
COMES FROM. HELLO HEY. PIANO
THEN OTHER SENATE SOON YOU PAY
FROM THE- ANALYST'S I JUST HAVE
MAIN. TO MAKE A THE DUTY
THROUGH BUT FOR. THAT WAS. I'M
THE FIRST IS THAT IT'LL BE
REALLY. TO KEEP AN EYE ON. THE
COMBINED EFFECTS OF ALL OF THE
VARIOUS ACTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED ON THE INDIVIDUALS
SEARCH THE INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES SH
SO FOR EXAMPLE- THERE ARE
PROPOSALS TO REDUCE. PAYMENTS
TO PROVIDERS FIND EFFICIENCIES
IN FORCE THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE ALL OF THESE TARGET
THE SERVICE IS PROVIDED TO
CONSUMERS TO FIND SAVINGS. AT
THE SAME TIME THE BUDGET
PROPOSES TO MAINTAIN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER RATES
THAT WENT INTO EFFECT IN
JANUARY. AND TO INCREASE
FUNDING- RELATED TO COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AT THE SAME
TIME SOME OF THE FLEXIBILITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND REGIONAL
CENTERS DURING THE PANDEMIC
WILL BE ENDING IN JUNE SH AND
THERE HASN'T BEEN. A LOT OF
GUIDANCE PROVIDED IN TERMS OF
THE TRANSITION TO RE OPENING-
ONCE. ONCE IT'S DEEMED SAFE.
FOR PROVIDERS TO DO SO. IT'LL
ALSO IMPORT TO LOOK AT OTHER
AREAS OF THIS BUT THE WILL
AFFECT. CONSUMER SO DOES TO
GIVE YOU EXAMPLE DDS. RELY ON
IN SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AS A
GENERIC RESOURCE THEY MUST
EXHAUST THIS A GENERIC RESOURCE
BEFORE ACCESSING SUPPORTED
LIVING SERVICES. IF THE- IF THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVES THE
PROPOSED REDUCTION TO IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES HOURS THEN
WE WILL LIKELY SEE AN INCREASE
IN THE DDS BUDGET- AS THOSE
CONSUMERS ACCESS MORE HOURS IN
SUPPORTED. LIVING SERVICES AND
TO OUR KNOWLEDGE THOSE- SORTS
OF IMPACTS HAVE NOT YET BEEN
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE STATE
BUDGET. OUR SECOND POINT IS
THAT WE RECKON THE VILLAGES AND
ADMINISTRATION- RECOMMENDED THE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZE AND
ENSURE CONTINUED SERVICES THAT
ARE REALLY NEEDED DURING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE SH- SO
FOR EXAMPLE- IF IT WILL BE GOOD
TO GET MORE CLARITY INTO THE
TYPES OF SERVICES THAT ARE MOST
IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN CONSUMER
HEALTH AND SAFETY- AND TO KNOW
WHAT ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITIES
THAT MIGHT BE NEEDED. IN THAT
RESPONSE AND JUST TO GIVE ONE
EXAMPLE. EVEN IF IT COULD TAKE
THE ENFORCEMENT OF THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE AS AN EXAMPLE
EVEN IF IT MAKES SENSE FROM A
FISCAL PERSPECTIVE. TO ENFORCE
THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
IT'S UNCLEAR TO US THAT
REQUIRING THOSE FOURTEEN DAYS
TO BE THE SAME FOURTEEN DAYS
ACROSS CONSUMERS AND ACROSS-
SERVICES IN ACROSS THE STATE-
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE IT
MIGHT WORK AT CROSS PURPOSES
IF- IF PROVIDERS ARE TRYING TO
STAY UNDER SERVICES ON
DIFFERENT DAYS AND DIFFERENT
HOURS AND THAT SORT OF THING.
OKAY THE THIRD POINT I'D LIKE
TO MEET IT'S ABOUT THE ROLE OF
REGIONAL CENTERS HE- REVISED
BUDGET PROPOSAL. BECAUSE A
SINGLE TINA REDUCE FUNDING
REGIONAL. WHILE INCREASING
THEIR WORKLOAD SO FOR EXAMPLE
REGIONAL CENTERS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO CONDUCT A
UTILIZATION REVIEW. DEVELOP AN
EXPENDITURE PLAN- DIRECTOR
MARGARINE JUST MENTIONED THAT
THEY WOULD ALSO BE REQUIRED TO
DEVELOP AN OPERATIONS PLAN. AND
THEY WILL BE EXPECTED TO HELP
FAMILIES ENROLL IN MEDICARE SO-
IT SOUNDS LIKE THE PERFORMANCE
CONTRACTS MAY BE REVISED
SLIGHTLY- TO TARGET CONSUMER
OUTCOMES- IN THERE WILL BE A
TEN MINUTE- IT MINISTRATION
ASSOCIATED WITH. ENFORCING THE
FAMILY THE NEW FAMILY FEE
STRUCTURE- SO THE DEPARTMENT
HAS INCLUDED A COUPLE OF
FLEXIBILITY IS TO- SORT OF-
THAT. IS SOME OF THE WORKLOAD I
GUESS YOU'D SAY OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS ONE IS TO REMOVE A
CASELOAD. RATIO REQUIREMENT
THAT'S CURRENTLY IN STATUTE FOR
CONSUMERS WHO ARE NOT ENROLLED
IN THE MEDICAID WAIVER. AND WHO
ARE NOT REALLY START CONSUMERS
ANOTHER IS TO- PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY WHEN IT
COMES TO PROVIDING REMOTE
SERVICE COORDINATION OR OR TELE
SERVICE COORDINATION- WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE-
PROPOSAL TO REMOVE THE CASELOAD
RATIO REQUIREMENT. AND ALTHOUGH
WE AGREE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
THAT CASELOAD THIS IS WHAT IT
IS THE ONLY WAY TO. ENSURE
QUALITY OF SERVICE PROVISION
THE DEPARTMENT MAINTAINS THAT
REMOVING THIS RATIO WOULD ALLOW
REGIONAL CENTERS TO APPROACH
SERVICE COORDINATION MORE AND
MORE INNOVATIVE FASHION. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT WITH THIS-
SIMULTANEOUS REDUCTION OF
FUNDING THAT IT'LL SIMPLY
RESULT IN HIGHER CASELOADS AND.
NOT INNOVATIVE APPROACHES.
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO MENTION
THAT THE MAYOR OF. INCLUDE A
LOT OF THE STORY TO THE- IN
TERMS OF. THE ACT DETAILS ASSOC
WITH FINDING THE EFFICIENT. IN
THE BUDGET I. AS WELL AS IN THE
OF G. THAT WILL BE MADE
REGIONAL CENTER. TO ACHIEVE THE
SAVINGS A LOT OF THOSE DETAILS
ARE TO BE DETERMINED. SO WE
HAVE JUST A COUPLE OF-
RECOMMENDATIONS- ONE IS THAT IF
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVES THE
PAYMENT REDUCTIONS IN SOME OF
THESE OTHER ACTIONS WE
RECOMMEND THAT IT ADOPT BUDGET
LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT. TO REPORT BY MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ON HOW THOSE
ACTIONS HAVE IMPACTED-
CONSUMERS ACCESS TO SERVICES.
AND IT SOUNDS. I GLAD TO HEAR
THE JUST DIRECTOR BY MAY THIS
THAT THEY BE WORKING WITH THE
D. S. TASK. TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXPERIENCE OF
FAMILIES AND CONSUMERS DURING
THIS PERIOD SO THAT TYPE OF
INFORMATION INCLUDING THE
NUMBER OF DATA ON THE NUMBER OF
CONSUMERS IN EACH CATEGORY
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE. THAT
CONSUMERS ARE STILL GETTING
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED- WE ALSO RECOMMEND
SHOULD REQUIRING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE- ONCE DDS IS MADE
SOME OF THE KEY DECISIONS THAT
ARE YET TO BE DETERMINED SUCH
AS- HOW EFFICIENCIES WILL BE
FOUND IN THE PURCHASE OF
SERVICE BUDGET. AS WELL AS
THEIR SPECIFIC- CHANGES THAT
WILL BE MADE TO REGIONAL
CENTRES OPERATING- BUDGETS
MOVING FORWARD. AND THEN-
FINALLY I WOULD JUST MENTION
THAT WE DO RECOMMEND APPROVING
THE PROPOSAL TO IN TRYING TO
ENROLL MORE FAMILIES IN A
MEDICAID WAIVER PROGRAM SAYS
THAT WILL ALLOW THE STATE TO
DRAW DOWN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH
FINANCE. YOUR BROWSER. FINANCE
LIKE A- COUPLE OF POINTS BASED
ON RECORD. SINCE TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY. BUT FIRST. SINCE THE
PAYMENT REDUCTION. ALL THE
TOTALS THREE HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL. DEPARTMENT PROVIDE. A
PLAN FOR CHEATING SAVINGS AND
TWENTY TWO ONE BUT FULLY
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO ENGAGE.
AND FUTURE SHOW THE. ON THE
SITUATION AND THEN MAKING THE
CONSEQUENCES ASKS SO IT WANTED
TO PARTNER PROVIDES A- AND
BUDGET YEAR ALWAYS OPEN TO
ENGAGE STAKE TO IDENTIFY IT OR
IS ABOUT STRATEGY AND A FEW
YEARS ON THE NEXT I WILL ITS
THE DEPARTMENT DOES. SWITCHING
THE SAVINGS AT THE END. YOU THE
RESULTS ARE. WORK OR CONSUMER.
AND THE LAST POINT I. UNDER
THAT I ND DIFFICULT SEARCH OF
TO REDUCE RESULTS OUR
OPERATIONS THAT. POSIBLES WE TO
INITIATE THAT PATIENTS THESE
PERHAPS MAYBE NOT IN THE MEDIA
SHORTS BUT IN THE LONG TERM
SUCH. THE RESTRUCTURE OF THE
COSHAM THAT. THE OUR MAN
HEADQUARTERS WILL COLLECT SOME
OF THOSE HE SO I DO THINK THAT
THERE SOME EFFICIENCIES BE
GAINED KNOWLEDGE OF THE YES
WORK WITH X. REVIEWS YOUR.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU A
QUESTION FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT SAY NO QUESTIONS FOR
CREAM. EIGHT THE PRESIDENT. I
GUESS. HELLO BUT I GUESS
ANOTHER I KNOW OF WE HAVE A
WEIRD WITH SOME BY ISSUE WE
WERE FOR SOME I WOULD MAKE NOTE
SOMEONE WITH A BACKGROUND
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT IS THAT
WELL CERTAINLY- REDUCTION IN
RESOURCES MAY STIMULATE SOME
CREATIVE THINKING OFTENTIMES
CHANGE IN BEHAVIOR ACTUALLY
REQUIRES INVESTMENT MORE
RESOURCES. AND I THINK WE SEEN
THIS ON REPEATED OCCASIONS
WHERE SOMEONE SAID WELL IF WE
ONLY DID THIS WE COULD ACTUALLY
REDUCE BUT ACTUALLY WHAT THEY
DID INVEST IN ACTUALLY MAKING
THE BEHAVIOR CHANGE SO I JUST
PUT THAT CAUTION OUT THERE
THAT- CERTAINLY I THINK IT'S
GOOD TO ENGAGE THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND THINKING MORE
CREATIVELY ABOUT WAYS THEY CAN
BE MORE EFFICIENT SIMPLY TAKING
THE MONEY AWAY UP FRONT. MAY
ACTUALLY DENIED THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO MAKE THE KIND. OF
CHANGES THAT THE- CENTER MAY
MAKE THAT LEAD TO SAY AS A SO
THERE MAY BE THOUGHT OF. HAVING
SOME TO BE A TO MAKE AN- WHEN
THERE'S A CLEAR DIRECTION AS TO
WHAT MAY BE. A CHANGE THAT
COULD LEAD TO A GREATER
EFFICIENCIES IN THE FUTURE
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WEWANT TO
TRY TO PUSH FOR- I SEE THE-
TERMS OF. THE PARTS OR SERVICES
YET DELEO HAD SUGGESTED FOR
EXAMPLE I MEAN WE ARE TRYING TO
DEAL WITH SOME BUDGETARY
ISSUES- THE- FOR EXAMPLE THAT
ANY WEEDS. NOT NOT A BIG FAN OF
THE FOURTEEN. DAY HOLIDAY FEES
BUT. AGAIN YOU KNOW WHAT I.
GIVE SOME FLEXIBILITY BECAUSE
OF SAMPLE FOR. WE IT MADE IT
MADE BE HIGHER TO BUILD
IMPLEMENTED FEES IT HAD TO BE.
FOURTEENTH DAYS AND PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE TO DO A SOCIAL
DISTANCING OUR- PHYSICAL
DISTANCING OR SOME OTHER.
SCHEDULED ARRANGEMENT TO TRY TO
MINIMIZE- EITHER EXPOSURE OR
TREATING THAT FLEXIBILITY. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS OPEN TO. HELLO.
OKAY I SEE DIRECTOR PARCHMENT
ON THERE OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME
OKAY NOW SAID OKAY I CAN HEAR
YOU NOW YES YEAH SORRY ABOUT
THAT LITTLE TECHNICAL ISSUE- SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF
THINGS AND RECOGNIZE THAT- THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE IS ONE
THAT HAS BEEN A PROCESS THAT
WAS USED IN THE PAST AND UNDER
CURRENT CONDITIONS- WE'RE STILL
SEEING IT AS A COST SAVING
MEASURE THAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT-
WE'RE GOING TO BE CONTINUING
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ONE OF THE AREAS
FOR- THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE THAT WE CHANGED OUR
PROPOSING AS A DIFFERENCE THAN
WE HAD IN THE PRIOR
IMPLEMENTATION- WAS WITH
EMPLOYMENT WE ASK THAT- WE
WOULD EXCLUDE THOSE WHO AREN'T
COMPETITIVELY IN. INTEGRATED
EMPLOYED BECAUSE RECOGNIZING
AND THIS WAS- BASED ON
STAKEHOLDER INPUT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS IS THAT THOSE WHO
HAVE JOBS YOU KNOW THEY THEY
HAD JOBS ON SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
AND THERE'S JUST DIFFERENT
TIMES SO WE WERE EXCLUDED THAT
TRYING TO DO SOME POSSIBILITY
INTO THE APPROACH THIS TIME-
SOME OF THE COST SAVING
MEASURES HAS TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT THINGS ARE IN
ALIGNMENT AND THAT'S WHERE SOME
OF THE ASSUMPTIONS ARE MADE SO
IF YOU HAVE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE ATTENDING A PROGRAM AND
THEN THERE'S RELATED COSTS
THAT- COME ALONG WITH THAT- BUT
WE DO- HERE AND ARE OPEN TO
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW IT IS-
EVERYTHING ALIGNED WITH.
CONSIDERATION OUR APPROACH TO-
RESPONSE TO KOBE. OKAY WELL
ANYTHING A TO SHOW. AS WELL
LINE MAKES SOME SAY PUBLIC MAY
DEMAND THAT THAT WOULD BE
DANGEROUS SO. AND BY THE THAT
MY REFLECT ON THE FACT THAT
THAT MAY BE DRIVING COSTS UP
EVEN YOU KNOW. THIS RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN. MYSTERY
MOST. LINEUPS BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRYING TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
THAT WOULD MAKE NOTE THOUGH
THAT- THE FOURTEEN DAY HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE YOU KNOW IS IN SOME
WAYS AS I THINK THE ADVOCATES
WOULD POINT OUT IS A SORT OF A
FURLOUGH OF SORTS BECAUSE THE
NEED FOR THE SERVICES DON'T.
SUDDENLY STOP ON THOSE FOURTEEN
DAYS. THE OTHER THING IS THAT I
IT'S ONLY PRETTY SURE YOUR
EXPLANATION BUT I. THINK IN.
TERMS OF THE- HELP THE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SUSPENSION. MMHM
YOU KNOW WE'RE MAKING CUTS NOW-
WE SHOULD PRAY ELIMINATE THE
FUTURE SUSPENSION AND IF WE
HAVE TO MAKE CUTS IN THE FUTURE
WE SHOULD DELIBERATE ABOUT THAT
SORT OF MAKE THEM AUTOMATIC. AS
WELL SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
CONSIDER THAT THAT'S WERE READY
MAKING CUTS UP FRONT- ARE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMEY
ASSEMBLE AND THIS YES THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN. I JUST. OUR WE HAD
WE RUNNERS ON IN A C. NOW WHERE
SOME OF THE AUTHORITY THERE WE-
WOULD BE EXTRA. RIGHT WAS WITH
PERSON SO I JUST WOULD LIKE FOR
SOMEONE TO ADDRESS WHAT I SEE
IN HERE WHICH IS THAT IT LOOKS
LIKE THE DEPARTMENT HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO MAKE ADDITIONAL
CUTS ON WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL AND MIGHT NOT. I
UNDERSTANDING THAT CORRECTLY
AND IF AND IF THAT IS THE CASE
I'M JUST CURIOUS AS TO YOU KNOW
HOW WHAT DROVE THE
LEGISLATURE'S GOING TO PAY TO
PLAY. IN ANY ADDITIONAL CUTS IF
ANY. THANK YOU CENTER THIS IS
NANCY PARCHMENT DIRECTOR DDS- I
BELIEVE YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS
A PART OF THE THREE HUNDRED.
MILLION PROJECTED GENERAL FUND-
AND THAT SEVENTY MILLION IS
WITH THE UTILIZATION
STANDARDIZATION AND
EXPENDITURES. THE PROPOSAL.
FORMER REALLY WITH THE INTENT
OF MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
IDENTIFYING THAT. SO YOU KNOW
IN ABSENCE OF THE SEVENTY
MILLION WORKING ON THE ABILITY
TO STANDARDIZE SERVICES AND
LOOKING AT THE EXPENDITURE AND
UTILIZATION SAVINGS- HAVING OUR
OUR COMMUNITY WAY N. ON THOSE
PRIORITIES- WAS WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US- AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO YOU KNOW REPORT BACK
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
CERTAINLY WOULD WANT TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
TRANSPARENT. AND CONVERSATIONS
AND ALSO WITH- HOW THAT WOULD
BE IMPLEMENTED- SHORT OF NOT
NINETEEN SEVENTY MILLION IN
THESE THREE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES- AND LOOKING AT COST
SAVING MEASURES- WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT HAVING THAT AS
A DIGEST ALL- PROVIDER PAYMENT
REDUCTIONS. ON THOSE THAT WAY
JUST SAY LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT IS IT THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
AND BUDGET YEAR AS WERE AS-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAD
IDENTIFIED THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
HAVING UP A PRETTY. ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
TO TALK ABOUT- THE OUT YEARS-
AND SO IN IN WANTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE STILL- DID THAT
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT THAT WE
WANT TO DO THAT AND MEDIATE
LADY WITH- WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
A BUDGET YEAR. OKAY WELL LET'S
PUT IT THIS WAY- CERTAINLY I
THINK THAT- RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S A PROPOSAL FOR AN
OVERALL REDUCTION HI SHE TEN
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL BUT I
THINK IN THE END. OBVIOUSLY FOR
OUT YEARS WE WILL BE HAVING
HEARINGS FOR THE OUT YEARS SO
WE WILL CERTAINLY BE WEIGHING
IN. BUT ALSO PERHAPS WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT AND- PERHAPS ELLIE
THERE'S SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT
THIS TOO. IN TERMS OF FITTING
IN THE CONTROLS IN PLACE SO
THAT THE THERE'S LEGISLATIVE
REVIEW OVER. MORE SPECIFIC CUTS
I NEED A QUICK CERTAINLY
WELCOME STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT'S
ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS AND
DIDN'T FIGURE THAT OUT. BUT
ALSO I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO WEIGH IN AND SOME
OF THE FINAL. DECISIONS ABOUT
PAYMENT RATES. OKAY ANYTHING
ELSE. ON OKAY JUST WOUND ONE
FINAL COMMENT ON. BEFORE WE
MOVE ON THE ISSUE TOO. IS THAT
I DO WANT TO TAKE DOWN THE
HAULAGE AND RECOGNIZE THAT- YES
WE HAVE A BUDGET ISSUE BUT WE
ALSO DID THIS. RATE STUDY WHICH
WE- YOU KNOW WHICH FOR MANY
YEARS WE SAID WE TOOK A RATE
STUDY WE TOLERATE SAY NOW WE
HAVE THE RIGHT STUDY THE RATE
STUDY SHOWED THAT EVEN PRIOR.
TO THESE PROPOSED CUTS. WE HAD
WE OVER TREMENDOUSLY
UNDERFUNDING DD SERVICES SO-
I'D RECOGNIZE YOU KNOW HAVING
BEEN ELECTED WHEN WE HAD A
BUDGET DEFICIT- IN BUT
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS GOING TO BE
VERY CHALLENGING BUT
RECOGNIZING WE ARE. TAKING AN
UNDERFUNDED SYSTEM AND CUTTING
IT EVEN MORE. AND SO WELL WANT
TO WORK TO FIGURE OUT FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN AS SOON AS WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO. TURN
THAT AROUND AND- AND AGAIN KEEP
IN MIND THAT WE DO HAVE THIS
RATE STUDY- THAT WAS ACTUALLY
PERFORMED BY THE DEPARTMENT
THERE THE CONSOLE THEY SELECTED
THAT SHOWED US THAT. THERE WAS.
THAT THIRD THAT THE PROGRAM IS
OVERLY. OVERALL AND FUN
UNDERFUNDED. ALL RIGHT LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS THE- BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR THE INCUMBENTS. STAND TRIAL
CAPACITY. THANK HI THIS IS.
BARR TWENTY. I DIRECTOR DD. AND
I HAVE ALSO ME ACTING DEPUTY.
NORM CREAM. RATE THIS DATA. SHE
THERE BE AN FOLLOW UP. THAT I
HAVEN'T BEEN IN TO COVER YOU
TODAY THE PORTABLE SECURE
TREATMENT PROGRAM JUST BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND JUST WANT TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT TO
AN OLD. DEFINITELY GET RIGHT TO
THE THREE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
PROPOSED BEFORE US TODAY- IT IS
OVER AT PORTER BILL- IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA SERVING INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE BEEN CHARGED. WITH A
FELONY FELONY AND ARE COURT
ORDERED TO PORTER VILLE.
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER. UNDER THE
SECURE TREATMENT PROGRAM. AND
REQUIRING COMPETENCY TRAINING
SO THERE'S REALLY TWO AND I'M
TOO TIRED A COURT COMMITMENT
INTO PORTABLE SECURE TREATMENT.
ONE IS A THIRTEEN SEVENTY POINT
ONE WHICH ARE THE INDIVIDUALS I
JUST DESCRIBED. THAT ARE
CHARGED WITH A FELONY AND THAT-
COMPETENCY TRAINING.
DETERMINATION NEEDS TO BE MADE-
ONE THIRD THIRD TRAINING OCCURS
AND SOMEBODY IS DETERMINED
COMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL THEN
THEY CAN- THEY WOULD THEN
RETURN TO JAIL AND- GO AHEAD
AND MOVE FORWARD AND- THAT YOU
JUST PROCESS- IF THEY'RE
DETERMINED INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL THERE. THEIR COURT
COMMITMENT IS CHANGED AT SIXTY
FIVE HUNDRED. AND THEN THERE-
AT PORTER BILL AND THEN WE CAN
START WORKING ON TRANSITIONS TO
THE COMMUNITY- BUT- THE- AGENDA
IT CORRECTLY NOTES THAT HARD
WORK THAT CERTAINLY THAT
APARTMENT A COMMITTEE IS DONE
IN REDUCING RELIANCE ON
INTEREST. INSTITUTIONAL
SETTINGS. AND THIS KIND OF GOES
COUNTER PRODUCTIVE TO WHAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IN
REDUCING. OUR STATE OPERATED
FACILITIES THAT ARE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS- I'LL
JUST MAKE NOTE THAT THIS IS A
TEMPORARY PROPOSAL. FOR SO AT
TEN FLARE THAT I WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS. AND REDUCING THOSE JUST
OKAY CAN PASS. AND GET R. R.
OUR OCCUPANCY BACK DOWN TO TWO
ELEVEN. AND I'LL WALK YOU
THROUGH THOSE YOU'RE QUITE THAT
YOU PROPOSED. SO WHEN I DO. THE
TREAT OPTIONS BEING. AND
COMMUNITY THANK PLACE PLAN
WHICH WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY MILLION. OF FOR START AT
EVERY YEAR TO DEVELOP. AND
COMMUNITY RESOURCE. MUCH OF
THAT. THAT BEEN FOCUSED ONLY ON
THE CLOTHES OF FAIRVIEW PART OF
THE- GENERAL TREATMENT AND SO
NOW MUCH ABOUT CENTER OVER THE
LAST NUMBER IF. WE HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPING RESOURCES IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE IN THE SECURE TREATMENT
PROGRAM OVER AT PORTER BELLE.
WE HAVE PART OF OUR SAFETY NET
PLAN THAT WAS APPROVED A FEW
YEARS AGO WE HAD PROPOSED OR
STEP DOWN HOMES. DISTURBANCE OF
VISUALS MOVING FROM THE SECURE
TREATMENT PROGRAM TO THE
COMMUNITY- THOSE FOUR HOMES ARE
IN VARYING DEGREES OF
DEVELOPMENT IF THERE ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE UP TO
TWENTY INDIVIDUALS. MOVING OUT
OF THE SECURE TREATMENT
PROGRAM- ONE OF THE HOMES IS
READY TO GO AND IT JUST
FINALIZING THE LEASE AND
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT SIDE OF THE
OPERATIONS OF THAT HOME.
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE THAT IS
PROJECTED TO OPEN AND BE READY
TO SERVE INDIVIDUALS AND
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
THEN WE HAD TWO ADDITIONAL
HOMES THAT ARE. JUST SHORTLY
BEHIND THAT IT WILL BE READY TO
SUPPORT THOSE TRANSITIONS.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE ANOTHER-
FOUR DIFFERENT HOMES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO START TRANSITION
OF INDIVIDUALS TO THE COMMUNITY
THAT IS NOT A STEP DOWN HOME
BUT MORE OF A FOREVER HOME. AND
THOSE AGAIN ARE OVER THE NEXT
TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS IN
READINESS- WE ALSO HAVE
PROPOSED AND- THAT BUDGET IS A
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL ENHANCED
VEHICLE SUPPORTS HOMES TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS MOVING TO
THE COMMUNITY. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS BEFORE US IS THAT HOW
WE ESTABLISH ANY COMMUNITY
RESOURCES. TO HELP WITH-
COMPETENCY TRAINING- THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT HAVE PROPOSED TO
THE DEPARTMENT. THE USE OF C.
DOLL TO. IT REESE. FOR
COMPANIES. TRAINING THEY CAN
AND WE BEEN ABLE TO. APPROVE
THOSE WE HAVE TO PROJECTS THAT
HAD BEEN APPROVED. TO SUPPORT
THE COMPANY TRAIN THEN THEY CAN.
ADDITIONALLY WE DO HAVE. A
NUMBER OF HOME THAT ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO COME. IN THERE DID
COMING UP THAT IS GOING TO BE
FOR INDIVIDUALS- WHO- WILL BE
ABLE TO HAVE COMPETENCY
TRAINING IN THE COMMUNITY. I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE NOTE THAT
SOME OF THE STRATEGIES THAT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE
IDENTIFIED IS DOING ADDITIONAL
TRAINING OUTSIDE. OF COMPETENCY
TRAINING DOING FRIENDS THAT
CONFERENCES DOING SOME
ADDITIONAL WORK TO BUILD UP.
THEIR EXPERTISE WITHIN EACH OF
THE REGIONAL CENTERS TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THE COURT. ON
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES AS OPPOSED
TO HAVING INDIVIDUALS GO TO
PORTABLE SECURE TREATMENT. BUT
AND IN TURN TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
THE COMMUNITY- INDICATES THE
AGENDA IT NOTED THAT WE HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO BUILD FOR
CAPACITY OF FIFTY INDIVIDUALS
I'LL JUST MAKE NOTE. THAT IS
FOR- ACTUALLY THE ABILITY TO
DEVELOP A MAXIMUM. UP OF TWO.
FIFTY BEDS FOR HOMES THAT HAVE
A DELAYED EGRESS WITH A SECURE
PERIMETER AROUND IT AND WHILE
WE WE'VE NOT DEVELOPED THOSE
UNDER THAT THAT- PARTICULAR-
CAN EARMARKED AMOUNT- WE HAVE
STARTED DEVELOPING- WITHIN SOME
OF THE OTHER RESOURCES- SOME OF
THE NEEDS. WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE THAT ON GOING-
DEVELOP MAY NEED THAT IS BY
EACH INDIVIDUAL- WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF TRANSITIONING
THIRTEEN INDIVIDUALS OUT OF
PORTER BILL- SECURE TREATMENT
INTO THE COMMUNITY. WE ALSO
HAVE A NUMBER ANOTHER TWENTY
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN VARIOUS
STAGES OF. HAVING THEIR
TRANSITION REVIEW PLANS-
IDENTIFIED AND REVIEWED AND
MATCHING TO THE PROVIDERS IN
THE COMMUNITY- AS I. STARTED
OFF WITH SAYING THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR- THAT THE ABILITY
TO DEVELOP THOSE TWENTY BEDS TO
BE ABLE TO GIVE. US THE TIME TO
MOVE PEOPLE OUT. YOUR OUT OF
JAIL. WE CURRENTLY HAVE A WAIT
LIST ABOUT FIFTY THREE IN WHEN
WE AT A LOT RESTRICT SETTINGS.
MOVING FROM JAIL TO PORTER BILL
BE ABLE TO GO THROUGH THE
COMPANY COMPETENCY TO. AND BE
ABLE TO KNOW BE A TO I DON'T
CAN THEY TO THE- WHAT REDUCE.
THAT RELIANCE ON THE JAIL AND
WE- DEVELOP THOSE. AND THEN
BRING BACK THE POPULAR DOWN TO
TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS. I'M SO HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU CARDS FROM OHIO. YES HI OUR
OFFICE RECOMMENDED- APPROVAL OF
THIS PROPOSAL AND BACK IN
FEBRUARY IN PRIMARILY BECAUSE-
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT IDEAL TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
SERVED AT THE PORTER BUILDING
ELEMENTAL CENTER- HAVING PEOPLE
IN COUNTY JAILS IS LIKELY. NOT
THE APPROPRIATE PLACE- FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES SO IN THE NEAR
TERM- WE SAW THIS AS A AS A
GOOD THING FOR. MOVING THOSE
FOLKS OUT OF OUT OF COUNTY
JAILS. OKAY THANK YOU FINANCE.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU ACCORDING
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NASSAR
MELINDA'S- THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN WHAT IS THE- COST PER
PERSON IN THIS PROGRAM. HI
NANCY BERGERON I DON'T HAVE THE
COST PER PERSON- AVAILABLE
GIVING GAS WE'RE HAPPY TO GO
AHEAD AND- GET THAT INFORMATION
PROVIDED THAT. YOU HAVE LIKE A
ROUGH ESTIMATE I MEAN. TOTAL
AND- OUR FLIGHT TICKETS A
MINUTE TOGETHER NOT FOR YOU
OKAY IT'S FINANCE SO THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY AVERAGE COST PER
PERSON OR A SPECIFIC QUESTION
AS DIRECTOR MARGIN MENTIONED
HAPPY ALL. OKAY I'M- IN THE
IT'S A LITTLE. THE I JUST I AS
SOON YOU WOULD HAVE THEM THIS
IS THAT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT A NEW
PROGRAM SO JUST HAVE SOME SORT
OF IDEA OF HOW MUCH WE'RE
SPENDING ON THIS PARTICULAR-
PROGRAMS BUT TO. LOOK FORWARD
TO GETTING THAT INFORMATION
FROM YOU. OKAY SIR TARA. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION. KIND OF I GUESS TIED
INTO IT THE COST PER PERSON BUT
REALLY I NOTE THAT YOU
MENTIONED- BEDS AND I KNOW THAT
RECENTLY THE PORTERVILLE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER WAS USED
AS A SEARCH SITES I WAS JUST
WONDERING IF. ANY OF THOSE BEDS
THAT THAT WERE USED IF THEY'RE-
GOING TO BE USED AS PART OF
THE- YOU KNOW. THE TRANSITION
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR. THANK
YOU SENATOR D'AMATO- B. THERE'S
TWO SIDES TO PORTABLE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER THERE'S A
SECURE TREATMENT SIDE WHICH-
WHEN WE REFER BEHIND THE FENCE
THAT REALLY IS LITERALLY BEHIND
A FENCE SO THAT SAID SECURITY
AREA- THAT IS- UNPROTECTED- AND
THEN THERE'S WHAT WE HAD JUST
MOVED EVERYBODY FROM THE
AIRPORT TO BUILD GENERAL
TREATMENT AREA WHICH IS.
OUTSIDE THAT IS NOT A SECURED
OR LOCKED SETTING AND SO ON
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE
HAD JUST OVER TWO HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE GENERAL
TREATMENT AREA OVER AT PORTER
BILL THAT WE HAD MOVED TO THE
COMMUNITY AND AS YOU CORRECTLY
NOTED THAT WE HAD DEVELOPED FOR
SURGE CAPACITY OVER A PORTABLE
IN THAT GENERAL TREATMENT AREAS
SO IT WASN'T BEHIND THE FENCE.
SO IT WASN'T A SECURED AREA SO
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE IN AND
THAT GENERAL TREATMENT AREA
WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD THEN
BE MOVING ON TO A SECURE
TREATMENT SETTING- TO DETERMINE
COMPETENCY SO USING THAT-
RESOURCES OUTSIDE WOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE BUT WE DO HAVE
EXISTING UNITS BEHIND THE FENCE
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO- GO
AHEAD AND DEVELOP WITH THE USE.
OF STAFF FOR THOSE TWENTY
INDIVIDUALS. THANK YOU. SAY NO
QUESTIONS- AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION I THINK WHAT
WE YOU KNOW BUT- BUT SEE THAT.
GETTING SOME OF THE FOLKS WHO
SERVE THREE WITH L. L. DON BACK
UP INTO THE JAIL ALSO THOUGH WE
TO. PERHAPS MOVE MORE EXPERT.
AND TO MOVE US OF THE FOLKS WHO
ARE IN THAT FOR BILL AND THE
COMMITTEE SETTINGS WHICH I
BELIEVE IS THE FINAL CALL FOR.
FOR THEM AS WELL AND THEREFORE
FREE UP BEDS FOR MORE PEOPLE
TO. TRANSITION OUT THERE THE
COUNTY JAIL SO AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
CASELOAD THAT LET'S MOVE ON
THEN TO THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES SO THANKS SO
MUCH AGAIN DR APARTMENT FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION FOR. THAT
PART OF THE SERVICES. ALL RIGHT
SO LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
APARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES WE HAVE- JUST ONE
ISSUE WHICH IS RELATED TO AGAIN
PLEASE ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS.
RELATED TO THE MAY- MAJOR MAY
REVISE CHANGES. SO IF TWO
QUESTIONS THERE THANK YOU. MR
STERN COMMITTEE THIS IS
DIFFICULT WORK DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES. ASIANS THAT WERE
ASKED OF US WAS EXPLAIN THE
IMPACT OF WITHDRAWING BEING.
PROPOSED FUNDING SERVE FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. M. AND
THAT'S BASICALLY- NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS SON GENERAL
FUND THAT THE THAT THE COUNTIES
WERE EXPECTING TO GET THIS
YEAR- AS WELL AS THE NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS THAT THEY GOT
LAST YEAR. NOW WITH THE FEDERAL
MATCH THAT'S FIFTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. ORIGINALLY THIS MONEY
WAS TARGETED TO- BRING THE
LOWEST FUNDED TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES UP TO THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY. WITH THIS
REDUCTION WE DIDN'T WANT TO
GIVE IMMEDIATELY GO RIGHT BACK
TO THE UNDERFUNDED COUNTIES AND
PULL THAT AWAY SO FROM THE
METHODOLOGY PERSPECTIVE WE'RE
TAKING TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THOSE COUNTIES
THAT WERE OVER THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY. AND THE BALANCE ON
ABOUT THIRTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THEM TO FIND IT. WE
THOUGHT THAT WAS A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION OF THE OVER FUNDING
COUNTIES WITHOUT OVERLY.
BURDENING THEM. UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE THE SMALLER PORTION OF
THIS OVERALL STATE BUDGET. ONLY
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE. PERCENT OF
THE LOCAL TRANSPORT FUNDING SO
WE CAN FULLY. EXPLORE THEM TO
COVER THE FULL AMOUNT SO THAT'S
THE EXPLANATION BETWEEN HOW
WE'RE BREAKING DOWN. AND RICK
PULLING OUT FIFTY SX MILLION
DOLLARS BACK THE SECOND
QUESTION IS ABOUT THE REPORT
THE LEGISLATION EFFICIENCIES
THAT WERE IMPLEMENTING. THERE'S
SEVERAL INITIATIVES THAT WE
HAVE GOING ON RIGHT NOW- THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD THE LARGEST THOSE IS
THE MIGRATION TO THE CLOUD- OFF
OF OUR LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HERE
WHICH WE EXPECT AND HOPE WILL-
SEE THE SAVINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR. I'M CERTAINLY
WORKING WITH THE COURTS AND
THROUGH OUR ELECTRONIC PROCESS
WE'RE TRYING TO SYSTEMATICALLY
CHANGEOVER FORMS TOWARDS THE
SIGNING AND GETTING ELECTRONIC
DELIVERY OF DOCUMENTS BACK AND
FORTH TO MINIMIZE- MALAN. AND
SPEED UP THE DISTRIBUTION AND
RETURN DOCUMENTS. WE
IMPLEMENTED TEXT MESSAGING IN
JANUARY WHICH WAS TO IMPROVE
THE COMMUNICATION BETWEEN US
AND OUR CONSTITUENTS- AND WE
HAVE A FEW SMALLER ITEMS THAT
ARE GOING FORWARD AS WELL.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
AND YOUR QUESTIONS. AND ANSWER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FIRST A COMMENT FROM
LMAO. I THANK YOU VERY YOU
AGAIN WITH LUNCH PANELISTS
OFFICE WAS IN. WHILE THE- IS TO.
LOCAL TRANSPORTED FUNDING BY
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR THAT REALLY JUST
TRANSLATES TO A NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION IN
THEIR CURRENT BASE FUNDING
LEVELS AND THE REASON THAT IS
BECAUSE- IT'S THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS CONSISTS. OF
TWO DISTINCT COMPONENTS ONE
BEING A WITHDRAWAL OF THE
PROPOSED FUNDING INCREASE MADE
IN JANUARY WHICH SINCE IT
HASN'T GONE OUT YET IT WAS A
PROPOSAL DOESN'T ACTUALLY.
AFFECT CURRENT BASE FUNDING
LEVELS. THUS THE REMAINING HALF
OF THE THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL IS TRULY A BASE
FUNDING REDUCTION BECAUSE IT'S
NOT IT'S AN ELIMINATION. OF
NINETEEN MILLION. OF A NINETY
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING
AUGMENTATION THAT WAS PROVIDED
LAST YEAR AS A PART. OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BY JACK.
GIVEN THE DIFFERENT END OF
THESE TWO COME. ON THE LEDGE
MAY WANT TO APPROACH BOTH OF
THEM DIFFERENTLY IN THE CASE OF
THE BASE FUNDING REDUCTION AS
THE DEPARTMENT DESCRIBED. THEIR
APPROACH IS TO MINIMIZE THE
REDUCTIONS WITHIN THOSE LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED TO BE
UNDERFUNDED PER THEIR NEW
BUDGETING METHODOLOGY AND WHAT
THAT I ESSENTIALLY TRANSLATES
TO IS. YOU WOULD SEE LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED TO BE
OVERFUNDED OR TO HAVE ACCESS
FUNDS ABOVE THEIR CALCULATED
FUNDING NEED YOU WOULD SEE A
GREATER REDUCTION IN THEIR
BUDGETS- RELATIVE TO THE
UNDERFUNDED LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES. IF THIS WERE DONE IF
THE REDUCTION OF THE BASE
FUNDING WERE TO GO THROUGH WE
GENERALLY AGREE WITH THIS
APPROACH- IN THAT IT BOASTS
TRIES TO REDUCE THE- THE
FUNDING GAPS WITHIN THE
UNDERFUNDED. LCS STAYS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY BUT IT ALSO MAKES
PROGRESS TOWARDS RIGHT SIZING-
FUNDING LEVELS FOR THOSE LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED TO HAVE EXCESS
FUNDS ABOUT THEIR CALCULATED
FUNDING NEEDS. AS PREVIOUSLY
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA THIS
SPECIFIC REDUCTION- WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE FEDERAL TRIGGER
LANGUAGE- THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO ASK THE ADMINISTRATION.
IF FEDERAL FUNDS WERE RECEIVED
AND THESE FUN THE BASE FUNDS
WERE REINSTATED- HOW WOULD
APPROACH READ ALLOCATING. THOSE
DOLLARS SPECIFICALLY- WOULD IT-
PRIORITIZE THE FUNDING NEEDS OF
THE UNDER FUNDED LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES AND RE
ALLOCATING THOSE DOLLARS AND
MAKING FURTHER PROGRESS AND
ITS- OWN BUDGETING METHODOLOGY.
AS FOR THE SECOND COMPONENT OF
THE PROPOSAL WITHDRAWING THE
PROPOSED FUNDING INCREASE MADE
IN JANUARY- AGAIN REITERATING
THAT THIS HAS NO PRACTICAL
EFFECT RELATIVE TO CURRENT BASE
FUNDING. NEEDS ARE CURRENT BASE
FUNDING LEVEL I DID ARE OFF.
CAN TO HAVE KIND WITH THE
OVERALL. OF THE BUDGET METHOD
ON. THAT WAS USED THE CITY FUN
OF MY- PROPOSED ENJOY BUT ALSO
AS MENTIONED YOU HAND DOWN.
THERE WAS A SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME TO CONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL
AS A PART OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS DUE TO CULVERT
NINETEEN AND DUE TO THESE
FACTORS- REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE PROVIDED THE
LEGISLATURE MAY STILL WANT TO
CONSIDER. BECAUSE AND PUSHING
OUT THE CONSIDER. OF THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AUGMENTATION- AND
CONSIDER IT AS A PART OF THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FINANCE.
DOESN'T GREATEST DEPARTMENT
FINANCE- NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
TO MAKE BUT IT'S OUR OPENING.
RESPOND YEAH. OKAY YOU
QUESTIONS CONFIRM MEMBERS. K.
C. NINE I WHAT THE LA US AND I
THINK THAT NOW. THIS IS MY ROOM
A PRESENTATION FOR PERCEIVE IS
COME FROM. ELDRED THE NINETEEN
MILLION SAID- FROM TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET WHICH HASN'T BEEN
RECEIVED IN THE NINETEEN NINETY
TO TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET BUT
THE LOSS WAS A HE SAYS TOTAL
FIFTY SIX MILLION. IS THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S WE LOST SOME
MATCHING FUNDS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. REX 66% MATCHING
FUNDS. OKAY ALL RIGHT. YEAH AND
AGAIN THESE THESE ARE CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS SO WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF FIFTY SIX MILLION
THAT WERE LOSING ACTUALLY ENDS
UP IN THE HANDS OF FAMILIES. SO
THEY'RE A LITTLE DISCONNECTED
THEM WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE HANDS OF FAMILY SO THIS
IS CHILD SUPPORT OFFICERS THAT-
ARE WORKING ACROSS THE STATE
AND THE CHILD SUPPORT ORDERS
ARE STILL IN PLACE THOUGH THEY
ARE BEING AFFECTED BY. THE LOSS
OF JOBS AND UNEMPLOYMENT
DANCING US MONEY IT'S GOING UP
IT'S GOING DOWN YEAH AND SO FAR
THERE HASN'T BEEN A DRASTIC
DECLINE IN TOTAL OVERALL
COLLECTIONS BUT WE DO
ANTICIPATE APPROXIMATELY 56%
DECLINE IN COLLECTIONS OVER THE
SCORE COURSE OF THIS YEAR. OKAY
WELL I GUESS MY CONCERN. IS
THAT NOT ONLY OF COURSE WITH
MISSING AT THE FEDERAL MATCH
FOR ALSO TAKING AWAY RESOURCES
FROM PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY ARE
GOING TO GET. HOPEFULLY MORE
MONEY INTO THE HANDS OF
FAMILIES- I RECOGNIZE THAT WITH
THE YOU KNOW SCIENCE SPIKE KIND
OF PLANE AND THERE MAY BE LESS
MONEY OUT. THERE FOR CHILD
SUPPORT FROM TELLS OF ORDERS.
BUT IN ARE. YOU KNOW FOR. OF
CHILD'S. HAS RE. IN YOU KNOW
RESULT IN ACTUALLY MORE FUN TO
FAMILIES. I THINK WE NEED TO
EXAMINE THAT VERY CAREFULLY.
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY AND WE'LL BE
TALKING LATER ON ABOUT CAL
WORKS AND OTHER TYPES OF
PROGRAMS WHAT STATE PROVIDES
DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO. FAMILIES
BUT THIS IS ALSO ANOTHER MEANS
BY WHICH WE PROVIDE. ASSISTANCE
TO OUR FAMILIES AND- THAT WOULD
BE SURE THAT- YOU KNOW WE
UNDERSTAND THE TRUE COST OF
WHAT WERE. ACTUALLY DOING HERE
SO. YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
NINETEEN MILLION GENERAL FUND
FIFTY SIX MILLION TOTAL FUND
EXACTLY HOW MUCH MONEY DOES
THAT FINALLY TRANSLATE INTO
TERMS OF LOSS OF FUNDS TO
FAMILIES WHO NEED TO NEED THESE
FUNDS. THAT HELD IT
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN SO I JUST
WANNA BE SURE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS VERY CAREFULLY-
IN TERMS OF EXACTLY WHAT IS THE
END RESULTS OF THESE
REDUCTIONS. AND THEIR ULTIMATE
IMPACT. ALL RIGHT SO HOPEFULLY
WE CAN GET SOME DATA OR
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND MAKING OUR
FUTURE BUDGETARY DECISIONS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WITH THAT- IT'S
ACTUALLY IS THERE ANY. FINAL
COMMENT FROM AGENCY ABOUT ABOUT
THAT I MEAN IS THERE A WAY TO
TRY TO GET THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION. SO THE DECLINE IN
FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
FEDERAL AND STATE MONEY AT AND
DROP THIS TO R. EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET WHICH IS WHAT
WE WERE WORKING ON FOR ALMOST
FIFTEEN YEARS UP TO THAT POINT
SO WE'RE PRETTY FAMILIAR WITH
THAT PROCESS AND THE AMOUNT OF
SOME SUPPORT THAT I CAN PROVIDE
THE CONSTITUENTS. THE VERY
LOWEST FUNDED COUNTIES ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE A LITTLE
BIT BETTER THAN THEY WERE
DURING THOSE YEARS THAT DECADE
OF FLAT FUNDING AND THE HIGHEST
FUNDED COUNTIES ARE GOING TO BE
COMING DOWN SO THEY'LL HAVE TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS AND CERTAINLY
NOT THE BEST SITUATION OR JUST
SITUATION WE WANTED TO BE AN
BUT- WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE.
ADJUSTMENTS AND MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE COUNTIES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. OKAY AND I KNOW THAT
AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE-
CHILD SUPPORT THE COUNTIES CAME
TOGETHER TO COME UP THE NEW
METHODOLOGY THAT'S MORE
RATIONAL- AND I WAS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT- AND I'M
GLAD TO KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
PRESERVE THAT AS WELL. BUT
AGAIN- I JUST KNOW THAT BACK
THEN BEFORE WE DID THE
AUGMENTATION WE STILL HAD
OPPORTUNITIES TO COLLECT MORE
MONEY AND GET IT PLEASE. AND SO
WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT THAT IN
TERMS OF THINKING IT. MONEY
SMART. AND I SPEND A CUTS AND
REGARD SINCE WE'RE ALSO IS
FEDERAL MAY. THAT ENDED YOU
KNOW I'M AND- I THINK WE SHOULD
BE A TRY TO MAKE A. BETTER TO.
OF THAT MEANS TO CLASS OF FUN
STUFF. CELL I APPRECIATE THAT
WE DIDN'T KNOW WE WERE DOING
THINGS BEFORE BUT I THINK A
EVEN BACK THEN THAT'S ACTIVE
THE SETTLED WAS GO AFTER A FOR
NOT BECAUSE AS MUCH MONEY AS
THEY WE SHOULD IN THOSE FRONT
THIS ONE LEVELS. ALL RIGHT OKAY
THAT AGAIN PRESS LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE PART SOCIAL STARTING
WITH ISSUE ONE WHICH IS CHILD
WILL SERVICE AND CUT CONTINUE
OF CARE OF. A ACTION IN SHARED
MANY YEARS YOUR CHANCE CALIBER
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL. ARE JUST
VERY. SO THAT AS WE HAVE RECORD.
THAT COULD NOT. IT'S NOT.
SOMETHING SHE'S. JUST VERY EVEN
WERE. AND HAVING THIS REPORT.
AND ON THE THAT ARE LIVING. TO
PAY. SO OUR STATE NET FOR. I
THAT WEIRD MINISTER IN WITH
PARTNERS WITH CAL. IN A KEY.
PART AS- AS TO. AND AT
INDIVIDUAL AND FOR. IN THIS ARE
VERY VERY TO. I OUT MUCH OF
WHAT. FULL WAS GOING INTO. TOWN
THE CONVERSE. WERE TRYING TO
MAKE. L. THRESHOLD ARE CROSSED
SAFETY NET. AND ALL MAINTAIN
THE LEVEL AND SO. I THAT WAS AS
A MARKETING. AT THESE ISSUE. I
HAVE KALI THAT ARE OUT HERE I
WOULD THROUGH THE PART AND ALSO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT I
WILL TRY IT OVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS. S. IN
YOUR- THANK YOU. OKAY BUT THANK
YOU SIR JUST FROM TO FIND SO IN
REGARDS QUESTION ONE THINK ONE
OF THE WHERE I CAN ENTER FORTY.
IS THE GREAT ON ONE OF ONE
TRAINING TO MANAGE COINCIDE
WITH YOUR AND I'M RECOVERY SO
WHY IS HE MISSED PROPOSED.
REDUCTIONS FOR THE SHORT TERM
RESIDENTS TREATMENT AS AN ARMED
AS THE GOVERNORS EXPRESSED ON
THE DURING THIS RESEARCH IN
EUROVISION AND THIS WAS JUST IN
SEVERAL OF THE HARD OF PART A.
AS WITH ALL THE REDUCTIONS AND
SOLUTIONS THAT WERE INCLUDED IN
THE MAYOR OF BEIJING. WE ARE
LOOKING AT AN OUT YEAR DEFICIT
OF APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE
BILLION SO THAT'S WHY I'M
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS CASE WE'D
BE LOOKING AT AN ONGOING
REDUCTION IN THIS CASE AND NOT
LOOKING A IT AS- A ONE TIME
AND SOMETHING TO LOOK AT. LATER
ON IT'S IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN A
BALANCED BUDGET AND CONTINUE
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO MAINTAIN
ELIGIBILITY FOR PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS- MAINTAINING AT LEAST
SOME SORT OF LEVEL OF GRANTS
FOR. PROGRAMS ALREADY
EXISTENCE. THIS IS THE APPROACH.
IT NEEDS TO TAKE UNFORTUNATELY.
I'LL LEAVE IT TO WHAT I'M
TRYING TO DO IS I'LL TRY TO
ANSWER. QUESTIONS THREE AND
FOUR WHERE WHAT'S RELATED TO-
WHAT I CAN ACTUALLY I'M SORRY
ALTHOUGH I DON'T TRY TO.
RESPOND THE QUESTION NUMBER TWO
AND- DIRECTOR JOHNSON IF
THERE'S ANYTHING YOU NEED AT
LEAST- CREATURE BUT- OTHER
QUESTION WITHOUT PROPOSES
SPECIAL ON THE LEVEL OF CARE
RATES. AND IF THOSE ARE FACTORS
CURRENTLY RECEIVING THOSE RATES
THE RESPONSE TO THAT IS NO- THE
SUSPENSIONS ONLY GONNA BRING
NEW CASES IN THE EXISTING CASES
WILL MAINTAINING OUR- RATES-
FOR THE DURATION OF TIME. THAT
THEY ARE IN FOSTER CARE.
QUESTION THREE YOU CAN JUST
READ ACROSS SYSTEMS THE INTO
CARE REFORM RECONCILIATION
METHODOLOGY. SO I'M GOING TO
WHAT THE MAIN REVISION IS JUNE
AND THEN- ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S GOING TO THE
SPECIFIC- METHODOLOGIES THAT
WORK WITH WITH THE ACCOUNT OF
OUR DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
ZHANG ASSUMES FOR THE CONTINUED
OUR REFORM RECONCILIATION WORK
LOAD THAT WAS CONSIDERED NOT
RELYING ON. TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
REALIGNMENTS- SO FOR THIS
PURPOSE IS WHAT WAS LOOK AT
WHAT IS THE ATUAL COUNTY
COSTING IMPLEMENTS OR TO WORK
WITH THAT THAT NEW REQUIREMENT
WHICH IN THIS CASE WAS
IDENTIFIED AS THE- CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAMS REQUIREMENT OF THE
CONTINUING CARE OR. OR SO.
ASIAN ASSUMES THAT THE RESPONSE
OF FOR SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES
THAT ARE EITHER I WORK WITH
THEM EVEN IDENTIFIED BY
STAKEHOLDERS THE- UPPER
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION SUCH AS
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL AND
THE FOSTER PARENTS ARE
RECRUITMENT RETENTION SUPPORT
THAT THOSE. ARE ALSO A REAL
CONCERN IN THE REAR INCLUDED
EXCUSE ME IN THAT YOU'D ALSO
LIKE TO REALIGN. SO BEING THAT
THEY WERE INCLUDED ON THOSE
WORK STATEWIDE REQUIRED
IMPLEMENTATIONS AND CHARLOTTE I
MEAN SHE WAS NOT. SO THAT'S
THE- WHERE THE MEETING MAY
REVISION METHODOLOGY- ADDRESSES
THE RECONCILIATION- IN REGARDS
TO WHY THE FAMILY OR THE
RESPONSE SYSTEM IS PROPOSED FOR
ELIMINATION- SAY STATEMENTS
BOSSES EARLIER- THE- UNIVISION
AT. OPPOSES TO MAINTAIN
ELIGIBILITY AND GRANTS FOR
PROGRAMS ARE IMPLEMENTED AT THE
TIME THIS PROGRAM HAS NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED- SO IT WAS JUST ONE
OF THOSE DIFFICULT DECISIONS AS
YOUR CALL AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THIS WAS SOMETHING TO
BE FUNDED BY. THE OKAY AND I
THINK IN MY ARM AND I WAS JUST
REQUIRED THE GOVERNMENT TO MAKE
SOME DIFFICULT DECISIONS HE'S
COMMENTED. ON PUBLICLY. DURING
HIS MAY REVISION DISCUSS WITH
TO HOW MUCH FUNDING WILL BE. TO
MANAGE LEADERS THE PRO. I'M MY
SON IS A WERE TO THE TRIGGER IT
THAT. THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
MAIN REVISION. IF WE'RE WE'RE
BASING EVERYTHING OFF OF THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING WAS FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY WHICH IS
FIFTEEN MILLION GENERAL FUNDS
AND THEN ONGOING THIRTY NINE
GENERAL FINDS THAT SCENE I
WOULD LOOKING AT. I WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT A FEDERAL
WAIVER HAS NOT BEEN APPROVED
YET. AS YOU GET OLDER- DRAW
DOWN FEDERAL RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT THE FIRST PROGRAM SO
UNLESS I GET A LEADERSHIP
DIRECTOR JOHNSON CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG ON THIS BUT- GENERAL
FUNDS- FIFTY MILLION AND ONE
YEAR AND THEY ARE GOING TO BE
NECESSARY. TO MAINTAIN THIS
PROGRAM. WITH REGARDS TO THE
QUESTION OF PRIVATIZING THE
FEDERAL FUNDING THE MISSING
THIS MEANS THE TRIGGER FUNDING
I. THE RESPONSE TO THAT IS IT-
THEY WERE VISION ASSUMES THAT
FULL FEDERAL FUNDING WOULD BE
PROVIDED TO SUPPORT ALL THE
ISSUES ARE LISTED AS TRIGGERS
ARE STRUCTURE IN THE FEDERAL
FUNDING IN THE REVISION. TO THE
EXTENT THAT ADEQUATE FUNDING IS
NOT PROVIDED THAT YOU PROVIDE
RESOURCES FOR ALL THE ISSUES OR.
SOLUTIONS INCLUDING THE
MARRIAGE AND- THAT WE NEED TO
WE CAN CONVERSE. WITH ALLEGED
AND THE MINISTRY. ON OUR PRIOR
TO THE STREETS. OKAY I PREFER
PREACHER I JUST CLARIFY SO. AND
THE FIRST IS PROBABLY JUST AN
EXAMPLE EXAMPLE WHEN WE DO HAVE
SOME PROGRAMS ARE BEING CUT
RATE. OTHER PROGRAMS BEING
ELIMINATES THE FERS BEING
PROPOSED FOR ELIMINATION SO
WHEN YOU ELIMINATE A PROGRAM
RESTARTING IT. TAKES TIME STAFF
AT CETERA SO I GUESS THIS IS
THE CLARIFY THAT PART OF THE
QUESTION FOR FINANCE. IS THAT
OKAY WE'LL LEMONADE THE PROGRAM
IS PROPOSED AND THEN WE HAVE
FEDERAL FUNDS WE SAY OKAY LET'S
START IT UP ARE YOU SAYING THAT
WE CAN JUST INSTANTLY BRIE
BRING BACK THE PROGRAM WITH- IF
WE HAVE FIFTEEN MILLION BACK TO
ITS YOU KNOW FORMER STATE OR-
WITH SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
ACTUALLY NEED TO BE COMMITTED
TO AGAIN ADMINISTRATIVELY YOU
HIRE THE PEOPLE YOU NEED ALL
THE OTHER STUFF. TO GET THE
PROGRAM STARTED AGAIN SO THAT'S
REALLY THE QUESTIONS LIKE ARE
WE USUALLY WHEN YOU. PLAY
SOMEONE OFF. HIRING EVEN HIRING
THE SAME PERSON BACK COSTS
MONEY VERSES IF YOU JUST GET
THEM EMPLOYED. NOW COURSES OF
THE COST TO CONTINUE TO PLAY
SOMEONE BUT I MEAN WHEN YOU LET
SOMEONE GO YOU MEAN ARE YOU
ELIMINATE A PROGRAM AND TRY TO
BRING IT BACK. THAT ACTUALLY
TAKES MONEY AS WELL AND THAT
ACTUALLY DRAWS MONEY AWAY FROM
THE SERVICES BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO MR DO IT SO CAN CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT. THAT SITUATION.
ABSOLUTELY AND ALL OF OUR LAND
GEORGIA JOHNSON IN CASE I
MISREPRESENT ANYTHING TO LEASE
THE LAND BUT- IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT. THE FIRST
PROGRAM IS NOT IMPLEMENTED YET
THE APARTMENT LIST ON THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING A
FINALIST THE CONTRACTS SO WITH
RUNS REGARDS YOUR QUESTIONS ON.
WHEN YOU'RE LAYING OFF STAFF
THE NEED TO BRING THEM OUT MY
DAY MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT-
THE- ONLY WANTS TO BE INCLUDED
IN. THE BUDGET FOR THIS OR
LATER ON DOWN THE ROAD- BASED
ON THAT WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. WOULD BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THAT AT. A MUCH FASTER
RATE THAN- WE TYPICALLY OFFER A
PROGRAM IT'S. AND THEN
ELIMINATED BECAUSE- HE HAS
REALLY. START YET OR ARE. I
READ ON THIS BUT AGAIN ALL THE
FURNITURE JOHNSON IF I MISSED.
OKAY DIRECTOR JOHNSON. THAT'S
CORRECT. YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO MAKE IT
TO THE ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS
FROM FINANCES PRESENTATION. NOW.
DOCTOR JOHNSON ANY OTHER
COMMENTS- IN RELATION TO THE
FOUR QUESTIONS CORRECT THERE'S
NOTHING ELSE TO ADD OKAY THE
SPURS IS NOT YET IMPLEMENTED SO
THAT'S THAT DISTINGUISHING
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BETWEEN THE
ISSUE OF ELIMINATION OKAY THANK
YOU HI- QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SIR MELINDA'S
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN. I SO THE
LEVEL OF CARE RATES ARE
DESIGNED TO I GUESS HELP WITH
THE FOSTER YOUTH YOU HAVEMORE
COMPLEX ISSUES WHETHER IT'S
PHYSICAL OR ORDERED
PSYCHOLOGICAL MENTAL CHALLENGES
SO IF FOR LOWERING THESE RATES.
I'M JUST CURIOUS IF WE CAN GET
COMMENT ON HOW PARENTS HERB
FOSTER PARENTS ARE SUPPOSED TO.
ME AND BE ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
THESE USED TO I JUST WANTED.
SEE THEM PUT IN MORE PERIL THAN
IS NECESSARY AND HAS THAT BEEN
CONTEMPLATED GIVEN THE FACT
THAT I GET I GET IT EVERYBODY
HAS TO MAKE CUTS BUT THIS IS A
GROUP THAT IS- YOU KNOW MORE AT
RISK THAN PERHAPS. SAY SOME
OTHERS. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER TRY YEAH- WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- I JUST WANTED TO
COMMENT THAT THE LEVEL OF CARE
RATES- ARE A PART OF THE-
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
INITIATIVES. AT THEY WERE IN
INCREASED BETTER RATE OVER WHAT
EXISTED PRIOR TO C. C. R. FOR
ALL FAMILIES SO THE BASIC LEVEL
OF CARE RATE AND THAT IS. NOT
BEING CHANGED BY THIS PROPOSAL
IS ALREADY AN INCREASED RATE
FROM WHERE WE WERE A FEW YEARS
AGO- AND HOPEFULLY IT'S HELPFUL
FOR THOSE PURPOSES AT THE SAME
TIME I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
OTHER ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF KERR
READ WERE INTENDED TO- TO
DISTINGUISH AMONG FAMILIES
WITHIN THAT AND THAT THAT
CONVERSATION CAN. YOU WORK WITH
TIME BUT RIGHT NOW IT WOULD NOT
BE USING A HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE
GREAT AND- IT DISTINGUISH BUT
ALL FAMILIES HAVE RECEIVED AN
INCREASE. BASED ON CPR. I THINK
YOU I GUESS WHAT I'M GETTING
THOUGH IS REASON THAT THERE'S
RATES WERE AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM WAS
IMPLEMENTED WAS BECAUSE IT WAS
THOUGHT TO BE NECESSARY TO CARE
PROPERLY FOR THESE PARTICULAR-
YOUTH SO. TAKING IT AWAY IS
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF NEGATIVE EFFECT ON THEM
AND I JUST AM CURIOUS ABOUT HOW
WE EXPECT PARENTS IN THE
RECRUITMENT EFFORT FRANKLY TO
RICK YOU NEED TO RECRUIT
PARENTS TO TAKE ON. HE'S WITH
CHALLENGES LIKE THESE SO THAT
THEY ARE IN THE HOME AND THEY
CAN THRIVE AND BE SUCCESSFUL
AND BUT THE PARENTS ALSO HAVE
THE AT THE RESOURCES TO CARE
FOR THEM PROPERLY. I APPRECIATE
THAT THE ONE THING I- WAITED
CLARIFY. IS THAT NO ONE WOULD
BE RECEIVING A RATE. REDUCTION
AS A RESULT OF WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING I'M HERE WITH THE
LEVEL OF CARE RATE. WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IS THAT SOME OF THE
HIGHER RATES THAT OTHERWISE
MIGHT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED TO
ADDITIONAL FAMILIES. THEY WOULD
NOT BE RECEIVING THAT INCREASE-
BUT THEY WILL NOT BE RECEIVING
A DECREASE AS A RESULT OF. THE
OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU
SIR VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION LET'S MOVE ON THEN
TO ISSUE TWO WHICH IS THE- SSI
S. S. P. UP. COLA. OKAY SO- I
THINK ELLIE IS GOING TO PRESENT
ON THIS. THIS IS ANGELA SHORT
FROM- FROM THE LA OKAY- I
ACTUALLY JUST WANTED TO MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S- PROPOSALS FOR
CHILD WELFARE- OKAY BOTH OKAY
YEAH PLEASE DO THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SO BEFORE WE MOVE ON SS I
WENT BACK TO- YES PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU- SO FIRST
CONCERNING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE THE DEATH
OF A SOCIAL WORKER RATE
INCREASE THAT WAS PROVIDED IN
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET- WE JUST WANTED TO NOTE
THAT SINCE MAY REVISION- WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS COULD BE DRAWN
DOWN COULD BE DRAWN DOWN FOR
FFA'S BASED ON RESULTS OF A
FEDERAL TIME STUDY- AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE ADMINISTRATION
IS WORKING ON THE DETAILS. OF
JUST HOW MUCH COULD BE
AVAILABLE AND WHETHER THAT
MIGHT BE ENOUGH- TO ACTUALLY
PAY FOR THE CONTINUATION OF THE
FSA. SOCIAL WORKER RATE
INCREASES NEXT REGARDING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE S. T. R. T. P. RATES BY
FIVE PERCENT. IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES CHOOSE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS REDUCTION- WE
KNOW THAT THE LARGEST
LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WISH-
TESTED MINISTRATION IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITIES THAT COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED TO ALLOW STR
TEEPEES TO SAFELY OFF. COSTS
AND MITIGATE THESE LOWER RATES.
MOVING ON TO THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE FERS. IF THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO REJECT
THIS PROPOSAL AND INSTEAD WANTS
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE SYSTEM. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO- TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHETHER THE
PARENTS ANONYMOUS HOTLINE AND
THIS IS A HOT LINE THAT WAS
RECENTLY FUNDED UNDER AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN RESPONSE TO
COOK BUT NINETEEN. OF WHETHER
THIS HOTLINE COULD BE USED- TO
SUPPORT FIRST IN SOME WAY AS A
COST SAVING MEASURE. THE
LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WISH TO
ASK THE ADMINISTRATION IF THERE
IS A WAY TO US STILL BACK THE
PROGRAM RATHER THAN ELIMINATING
IT ENTIRELY- GETTING TO THE
POINT THAT YOU ADMIT SENATOR
PAM. AND FINALLY I JUST WANTED
TO COMMENT. ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
SUSPENDS THE LEVEL OF CARE-
RATES TWO THROUGH FOUR- SO JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT THIS
PROPOSAL REALLY HAS TWO
DISTINCT COMPONENTS THE FIRST
COMPONENT RELATES TO FF EIGHT
PLACEMENTS. YOU'VE PLACED WITH
FFA CURRENTLY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
ELLIS SEES TWO THROUGH FOUR
UNDER THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL- AT THAT THEY IS ALL
ABOUT THEY USED ALREADY
RECEIVING THOSE RATES WOULD
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THEM BUT
NEW FSA PLACEMENTS WOULD NO
LONGER BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
THEM IN THE BUDGET YEAR. AND
THEN THE SECOND STAGE COMPONENT
RELATES TO COUNTY APPROVED
FAMILY HOMES USE IN THESE
PLACEMENTS ARE NOT YET
RECEIVING LOC STRAIGHT THROUGH
FOR- BECAUSE THE LOC PROTOCOL
TOOL HAS NOT YET BEEN.
IMPLEMENTED FOR THIS PLACEMENT
TYPE. I AND IN FACT FOR THE
ROLL OUT OF THE LOC PROTOCOL
TOOL HAS ACTUALLY BEEN DELAYED
INDEFINITELY. SO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
REALLY IT WOULD SOLIDIFY THAT
THIS ROLL OUT WOULD NOT BE
HAPPENING FOR COUNTY FAMILY
HOMES IN THE BUDGET YEAR. I'M
GIVEN THESE TWO DISTINCT
COMPONENTS ONE ALTERNATIVE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
WOULD BE TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE- LOC SKEWED THROUGH
FORTS AT THAT THEY USE- SO IN
OUR VIEWTHIS WOULD CONTINUE
THEIR CURRENT POLICY- WELL
SUSPENDING THE ROLLOUT OF LOC
ISSUED THROUGH FOR. TO NINE
OTHER DAY PLACEMENTS AND AGAIN
THIS IS ALREADY BEEN DELAYED
AND LIKELY WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED WITHIN THE BUDGET
YEAR- ANYHOW. WHILE THIS
ALTERNATIVE WOULD ACHIEVE LESS
SAVINGS THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL- AND
ARGUE IT WOULD CONTINUE CURRENT
POLICY AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
UNDERSTAND JUST HOW MUCH THIS
ALTERNATIVE COULD COST SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS I CAN. THANK YOU
I APOLOGIZE I THINK WHEN WE
WENT TO FINANCE I GOT THROWN
OFF MY RHYTHM THERE. ALL RIGHT
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY WE
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
FROM LA OF THE AND HOPE WE CAN
NOW WORK ON THE THOSE-
SUGGESTIONS RECOMMENDATIONS. AS
WE WORK THROUGH. THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE ON THE BUDGET.
RIGHT C. NINE THEN THAT'S A ON
THEN TO IS NUMBER TWO. RICK S.
S. I. S. S. P. PRESENTING ON-
GO AHEAD AND TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MR LEE RELATED TO THE
ONGOING QUESTION. ALL RIGHT
FINANCE AND THEN WE'LL GO TO LA
AFTER THAT. HERE IS THE GAME
FOR US OKAY. X. SO ON THIS
QUESTION OF WHETHER. THAT'S WHY
WE CHOSE TO MAKE THIS ON GOING
BACK TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
JUSTIN IS ELOQUENT STATED
EARLIER. WE HAVE A BUDGET
DEFICIT THAT'S REJECTED ME ON A
MULTI YEAR BASIS SO WE NEED AN
ONGOING SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
THAT PROBLEM SO THAT'S THE
REASON WHY MAY REVISION NEXUS
WILL HOLD ON CALLING THIS. TIME
OKAY. THANK YOU L. L. COMMENTS.
YEAH AND JACKIE WERE CERTAINLY
I'LL- WHICH I WOULD JUST WANT
TO MAKE THE POINT THAT S. ISIS
P. CONSISTS OF BOTH THE STATE
PROVIDED US IS P. GRANT AND
THEN ALO THE FEDERALLY
PROVIDED ASSISTS I GRANT SO
YOUR AGENDA MAKES NOTE OF THE
ESTIMATED TOTAL LOSSES ISIS P.
GRANT LEVELS AS ESTIMATED BACK
IN JANUARY- RELATIVE TO THE
JANUARY ESTIMATES THE MAY
REVISION- SHOWS THAT TOTAL
SIZES S. S. P. GRANT LEVELS-
ARE ESTIMATED TO BE LOWER. AND
THIS IS IN PART DUE TO THE
PROPOSAL TO NOT PASS THROUGH
THE FEDERALIST ASIDE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT OR COLA IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH
ESSENTIALLY MEANS REDUCING THE
STATE S. S. P. GRANTS ARE BY-
THE AMOUNT OF THE FEDERAL SSI
COLA IN THE PAST RECESSIONS THE
STATE WAS ABLE TO REDUCE AS P.
GRANT LEVELS BY THE FULL AMOUNT
OF THE FEDERALIST COLA WHICH
WOULD RESULT IN GRANT LEVELS
REMAINING FLAT YEAR TO YEAR-
HOWEVER IN THIS CASE WE WOULD
NOTE THAT BECAUSE OF THE
FEDERALLY REQUIRED. MINIMUM
GRANT AMOUNT TOTAL SIZE IS P.
GRANT LEVELS MAY ACTUALLY STILL
SEE A SLIGHT INCREASE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE RELATIVE TO TWENTY
TWENTY LEVELS- I'M CURRENTLY IN
THE STATE S. S. P. GRANT LEVELS
ARE SLIGHTLY ABOVE THE
FEDERALLY REQUIRED MINIMUM- FOR
THE MAXIMUM INDIVIDUAL GRANTS
WERE ABOUT FIVE DOLLARS ABOVE-
WHEREAS FOR THE MAXIMUM COUPLES
GRANTS FOR ABOUT ELEVEN DOLLARS
ABOVE THE FEDERAL MINIMUM. I'M
SO BASED OFF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE OF
THE FEDERAL SSI COLA IT IS OUR
SIZE MEANT THAT THE STATE CAN
ONLY DECREASE S. S. P. GRANT
AMOUNTS BY A PORTION OF THE
FEDERAL INCREASE TO THE SSI
GRANTS IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
FEDERAL REQUIRED IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN GRANT LEVELS AT THE
FEDERALLY REQUIRED MINIMUM
AMOUNT. SO AS A RESULT WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THE TOTAL IS A
SCIENCE IS P. GRANT LEVELS WILL
STILL EXPERIENCE AGAIN A SLIGHT
INCREASE IN TWENTY. TWENTY ONE
ALBEIT BY A LOWER MOUNT OPTION
OF THIS FOR. HOWEVER WE WOULD
NOTE THAT OVER WE ASK KNOW THE
AND OF THE FEDERAL A CYCLE AND
DOES THE FINAL OF STATE S. S.
P. GRANT RIGHT UNTIL THE FALL
OF TWENTY TWENTY. HEY THANK YOU
QUESTIONS REMEMBERS RIGHT. SO I
WOULD JUST MAKE THE OBSERVATION
I NOTICED SOMETHING WE'VE DONE
BEFORE PASS BUDGET TIMES- BUT I
DO. FIND IT- AND- AROUND EXTRA
RATE WORD THAT ON ONE HAND
WE'RE HOPING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL PROVIDE US
FUNDS- TO FILL AND YOU KNOW WE
HAVE DISTRIBUTORS WERE GOING TO
PUT IN PLACE IN THE BUDGET. AND
YET AT THE IMES WHEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES GIVE US
MORE MONEY FOR A PARTICULAR
PURPOSE IN THIS CASE TO THESE-
PEOPLE ON. SSI THEN WE TAKE THE
MONEY AND WE PUT IT SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT KIND
OF MESSAGE WE'RE SENDING WE DO
THAT- SO I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
WE HAVE A BUDGET CHALLENGE AND
WE'VE GOT TO WORK ON THAT- BUT
I ALSO KNOW THIS IS A- AREA
WHERE WE'VE SPENT UNDER FUNDING
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO LOOK AT
STRUGGLING WITH TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET MORE
FUNDING TO THESE. THESE
INDIVIDUALS. WHO HAVE
DISABILITIES. AND FINALLY WHEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY
GIVES US SOME MORE MONEY WE ARE
THEN AT LEAST TAKING A PORTION
OF IT AWAY. TO FOR OTHER THINGS
SO- I'D- JUST A- TROUBLED BY
THAT LET'S JUST LEAVE IT AT
THAT. FOR RIGHT NOW OKAY AND-
HOPEFULLY ACTUALLY JESSICA SO I
UNDERSTAND LOL USED YOU SAID
THAT WE WON'T ACTUALLY KNOW
UNTIL THE FALL AS TO EXACTLY
HOW MUCH BUT- YOUR-
DETERMINATION BASED ON WHAT YOU
JUST PRESENTED THAT WE'RE
PROBABLY NOT REALLY GOING TO
GET. THE THIRTY THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION- GENERAL FUND BY
SHIFTING IS PROBABLY NOT. AS
PART OF THE LESSON THAT IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. I KNOW WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS WE CAN PRODUCE
S. S. P. GRANT LEVELS BY THE
CURRENT ESTIMATE OF THE TOTAL
FEDERAL SSI GRAIN WHAT. I'M SO
THAT THIRTY THREE REALLY
REFLECTS ON THE MAX AMOUNT OF
SAVINGS WE CAN ACTUALLY GET OUT
OF THE S. S. P. GRANTS ITSELF
DO YOU DO TAT FEDERALLY
REQUIRED MINIMUM THRESHOLD.
THOSE THINGS ARE LIKELY TO GET
LESS THAN THAT RIGHT BECAUSE OF
THAT MINIMUM CORRECT. NO I'M
THE THIRTY D. REPRESENTS THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF SAVINGS WE
COULD GET OKAY. OKAY SO THAT SO
THAT WE COULD WE WILL GET THAT
SERVICE THE THIRTY SEVEN
REPRESENTS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE MINIMUM WE NEED TO
GET AND THIS AND HOW MUCH WELL.
PREVIOUSLY PROVED WRAPPERS FOR
S. S. P. I YES BETWEEN CURRENT
LEVELS AND THEN THE FEDERAL
MINIMUM AND THE DIFFERENCE IS
HOW MUCH WE'RE GONNA THEN
REDUCE GRANT AMOUNTS WHICH IS
ABOUT THIRTY THREE MILLION- BUT
WE WOULD NOTE AGAIN THAT. WE
WON'T KNOW THE ACTUAL SIZE OF
THE SSI COLADA OR THEN THE
CORRESPONDING REDUCTION TAXES
P. GRANTS UNTIL THE FALL SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE COLON IT IS
REALLY SMALL IN THE SSI. FOR
THE AS A SIDE PORTION OF THE
GRANT. AND THEN YOU COULD MAYBE
SEE LOWER SAVINGS BUT AGAIN- WE
COULD ALSO SEE THAT THE CALL
WAS STILL IS HIGH ENOUGH WHERE
WE'RE STILL MAXIMIZING. THE
SAVINGS ON THE S. S. P. SIDE.
ALL RIGHT WELL AGAIN. TROUBLING
OR EVEN THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THIS ANYWAY SO OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. NO THE QUESTIONS AND
LET'S MOVE ON T ISSUE NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES. SO WE HAVE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE SITE
TO ASSESS. SO. WHO'S PRESENTING
ON THAT. FINANCE. THAT'S FINE
IS PRESENTING ON ISIS. HEARING
YES I WAS GOING TO RESPOND TO
ONE OF THE QUESTION BUT I THINK
JENNIFER YOU WERE ARE YOU. OKAY
DID. SO I CAN GO IN RESPONSE TO
THE SECOND QUESTION OKAY YOURS
BY THE SECOND QUESTION AND
WE'LL GO BACK TO AGENCY FOR THE
OTHER TWO. ALL RIGHT. SO ON
THAT QUESTION IT'S- FURTHER
MAYBE VICE WE DID NOT ASSUME
ANY. COSTS TO OFFSET THE
MARINES WHO ARE THE PROPOSALS
AND THE X. YES TO ELIMINATE SEA
BASS AND ALSO MISTER SPEAKER-
THERE WAS NO. ASCENSION AS TO
WHETHER THERE WOULD BE ANY.
INCREASED COSTS IN THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM FOR NURSING HOME CARE
OKAY. ALL RIGHT I WILL COMMENT
ON THAT LATER AFTER WE HEAR THE
ANSWERS TO THOSE QUESTIONS.
OKAY AND MISTER KERR AT GENTRY
AGAIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
ON THE FIRST QUESTION WITH
RESPECT TO BE ENHANCED M. F.
MAP AT WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO TRY TO IDENTIFY
WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS OF THAT
IF THEY CAN'T ACT THAT MIGHT BE
ON ANY OF OUR REDUCTIN
PROPOSALS AT THIS POINT THIS IS
THE PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD AND- ARE HOPEFUL THAT
IT WOULD BE AN OPTION- BUT AT
THE SAME TIME WE RECOGNIZE
THAT- BUT THERE IS AN
INTERACTION THERE AND ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH EACH YEAH
WHO. HAD THE GREATEST EXPERTISE
WITH RESPECT TO THE IMPACT AND
THEN ON THIRD QUESTION. ABOUT
THE PAYROLL FUNCTIONS THAT
WOULD TRANSFER FROM THE COUNTY
THROUGH THE STATE. UNDER THAT
PROPOSAL- WHAT WE READ-
MENTIONED. OUR OUR EXISTING
VENDOR I'M ALREADY PROVIDES A
HELP DESK THAT BY THE NUMBER OF
RELATED FUNCTIONS AND THAT WE
WILL BE ADDING TO THOSE
OPTIONS. AT WHAT WOULD BE ADDED
IS THEIR ABILITY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS RELATED TO-
SUPPLEMENTAL TIME SHEET IF
THERE ARE HOURS AVAILABLE- THAT
W. TO NW FOR TAX FORMS. AND
PAYMENT INCREASE THE
REPLACEMENT WARREN. AND ASK
SOME OF THE FAIR LABOR
STANDARDS ACT'S REQUIREMENT AT
LONG WITH THE ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION TIME SHEET RELATED
QUESTIONS AND TRAVEL LANE. AT
THE AGAIN THESE WOULD BE-
WORKLOAD BETTER RELATED TO
WORKLOAD THAT THEY ALREADY
PERFORM. AT IT WOULD BE ADDED
TO THEM AND ADD THE IMPACT OF
THAT ON COUNTY STAFF WOULD VARY
AT. EACH COUNTY. BECAUSE THE
COUNTIES EACH USE THEIR PAYROLL
STAFF IN DIFFERENT WAYS
CURRENTLY AND THEY MAY BE
PROVIDING MULTIPLE FUNCTIONS
BEYOND THE ONES THAT. I EIGHT
CHIP REID. OKAY THANK YOU LA
COMMON. HI JUST WITH REGARDS TO
THE 7% REDUCTION- JUST KEY
QUESTIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED ONE-
WHETHER THIS WOULD BE ALLOWABLE
UNDER THE NEW FEDERAL RULES
THAT DICTATE THE CONDITIONS IN
WHICH STATES NEEDED HERE TO IN
ORDER TO DRAW DOWN THE FEDERAL
F. MAP OR FEDERAL MATCH FOR
MEDICAID PROGRAMS ALSO GETTING
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
STEPS THE DEPARTMENT- WOULD
TAKE TO MITIGATE ANY POTENTIAL
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON THE- SAFETY
AND HEALTH I JUST AS
RECIPIENTS. AND LASTLY- GETTING
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING HOW A
POSSIBLE LITIGATION ON THIS
POINT COULD AFFECT THE TIMING
OF THE SAVINGS THEMSELVES. OKAY
THANK YOU- AND FINANCE ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS CENTER YOU
ANSWERED QUESTION NUMBER TWO.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON ONE
AND THREE. NO I DIDN'T ASK HER
OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY GOING TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO ALL RIGHT.
SO THE FIRST OF ALL. I THINK
SIMILAR TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
I MADE ABOUT THE M. S. S. P.
PROGRAM AT SEA BASS SAME WITH
HSS. WE DO HAVE- INFORMATION
THAT- ISIS S. REDUCES
INITIALIZATION LOUD PEOPLE TO
STAY AT HOME- WHICH IS LESS
COSTLY THAN. BEING
INSTITUTIONALIZED AND THAT'S A
AND THE LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
AND I THINK THAT IF WE'RE TRULY
GOING TO IDENTIFY WHAT THE
ACTUAL SAVINGS ARE FROM A
REDUCTION IN SERVICE HOURS WE
ALSO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE WHAT'S
THE COST OF THE ALTERNATIVE SO
THE ALTERNATIVE IS YOU KNOW
WEEDS NOW WE'RE LIMITED THE
HOURS AND SELF A CERTAIN
PORTION. OF PEOPLE WHO THOSE
HOURS OF A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THEM BE ABLE TO STAY AT HOME
VERSUS BEING INSTITUTIONALIZED
WHICH IS MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE WE
NEED TO FACTOR THAT COST IN. SO
AND CAN BE HARD TO DETERMINE
BUT- I THINK WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT THEN
BECOMES A VERY REAL COST. THE
OTHER ISSUE- AND GUESTS ARE
SIMILAR TO WHAT I SAID ABOUT A
SOCIETY IS THAT YES ON ONE
LEVEL WERE HOPING FOR FEDERAL
MONEY TO HELP MAKE UP SOME OF
THE GAPS. AND SO WE WERE DOING
THIS TRIGGER THING. BUT SAME
TIME TO THROW MONEY AT THE
FEDERAL. WELL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS PROVIDED US AN
ENHANCED. F. MAP THAT RELATE TO
THE DISASTER. AND WE'RE TAKING
SOME OF THOSE FUNDS AND THEN RE
DIVERTING IT SOMEWHERE ELSE. SO
THE FEDS COULD COME AND SAY
WELL BY THE WAY WE DID GIVE YOU
MORE MONEY HE JUST DIDN'T SPEND
IT ON WHAT YOU CHOOSE TO SPEND
IT ON THE ITEM WE ACTUALLY GAVE
YOU THE ENHANCED PAYMENT FOR.
SUCH AS I. HSS OR BETTER CAL OR
SO FORTH YOU DECIDE TAKE THAT
INCREASE AND SEND IT SOMEWHERE
ELSE. AND I THINK THAT WEAKENS
OUR POSITION TO BE ABLE TO ASK
FOR EVEN MORE FUNDING SO- SO I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S A BIT
CHALLENGING AS WELL I MEAN- YOU
KNOW WE'LL SEE WHAT CONGRESS
AND- AND SO FORTH THAT. DO AND
THEN THE OTHER PIECE CERTAINLY
IS- THE FEDERAL RULES AROUND IT
AS WELL I KNOW THAT- IS BROUGHT
THIS UP TO MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
BUT- WELL I JUST ASK- FINANCE-
IS DEAD. I MEAN WHAT'S THE
LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THE
PROPOSED CUTS THAT YOU'RE
MAKING- PARTICULARLY TO.
CERTAIN PROGRAMS- DON'T VIOLATE
THE PARAMETERS DASHED WISH FOR.
US WE THE ENHANCED MAPS A
RESULT OF THE DISASTER SO WE-
AS EARLIER POINTED OUT THERE
ARE OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE TO
MEET. DOOR TO GET THAT ENHANCED
F. MAP- CAN YOU SPEAK TO. THE
MINISTRATIONS- WELL. CONFIDENCE
THAT- THAT WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED A DOESN'T VIOLATE
THOSE CONDITIONS. BURLINGAME
REFINANCING AND MEAN THERE'S
NEVER A GUARANTEE UNLESS UNTIL
WE HAD A CONVERSATION WITH OUR
GOVERNMENT SO UNTIL THEN IT'S
HARD FOR US HELLO WHAT IS THE-
PERCENTAGE OF WHAT THE FED'S
GONNA DO BUT I MEAN WE'LL KEEP
YOU GUYS IN THE LOOPAS WE HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND TO
ACCEPT THAT WE DO FIND THAT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DUES-
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR THIS PURPOSE
WILL HAVE TO YOU KNOW THIS IS
THIS ISSUE AGAIN BUT FOR THE
TIME BEING WE ARE MAKING THOSE
ASSESSMENTS WERE TALKING TO.
DCS AND HOPEFULLY WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION. AND
PERHAPS ASK WE WERE HEARING
FROM DHS THAT. THAT ENHANCED F.
MAP REPRESENTS HOW MUCH IN
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WERE
RECEIVING. CANCEL THAT
QUESTIONS ARE FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR IT'S UP IT'S OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND FOR
THE CURRENT KNOWLEDGE AGAIN
SORRY I DIDN'T QUITE GET. THE
DOLLARS. OKAY SORRY IF WE CAN
GET A GOOD PICK UP ON THAT SEE
REPEAT THAT. FURTHER IN THE
CURRENT YEAR DELIVERED OVER
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION OKAY. THE
BUDGET YEAR WORKS AND NOW WE'RE
A LITTLE A LITTLE OVER A
HUNDRED. I JUST I JUST OKAY
THAT'S JUST FOR RIGHTEOUSNESS
ALONE RIGHT. IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT FOR- THE OTHER MEDICAID
PROGRAMS SO I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION OKAY SO JUST POINT
OUT JUST FOR IHS US ALONE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION- BUT IF WE DO IF WE BUT
IF THERE'S A DISAGREEMENT AND-
WE LOSE THE F. MAP IT'LL BE
MUCH MUCH LARGER SO I THINK WE
NEED TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT THAT.
CORRECT THAT IS RIGHT. OKAY SO-
I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE AT A
CONSIDERATION. IN OUR BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS OKAY. RIGHT NOW
THE- YES CENTER MELINDA'S OKAY
I THANK YOU OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
YEAH I GUESS THE- SO OKAY SO I
MEAN I THINK THOSE ARE- SO
CERTAINLY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE- 7% CUT- BY THE WAY- I
THINK WE ARE THERE. ARE THERE
OTHER FUTURE TRIGGERS CUTS THAT
WERE PUT IN PLACE AND REMEMBER
ANOTHER 7% WAS OUT THERE. YEAH
I'M SORRY TO JUST OVER 7% THAT
WE HAD INITIALLY SUSPENSION OR
SO YOU JUST MOVE THAT UP TO
NOW. THERE'S NO FEATURES
TRIGGER CARD RIGHT. NOW OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL HOPEFULLY WE CAN
TALK ABOUT- DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS. ALL RIGHT LET'S
MOVE ON THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR CAL WORKS. AGAIN KIM
JOHNSON CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES I'M GOING TO
TURN TO MY COLLEAGUES AT MISTER
WOULD THAT FINANCE FOR THIS
QUESTION. THIS IS JENNY ****
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR
YOU OKAY THERE YOU ARE. SO AND
YOUR FIRST QUESTION WHICH IS TO
DESCRIBE THE RATIONALE BEHIND
THE ASSUMPTION THAT TAKE UP IN
COST PER EACH RELATED TO
COOLING NINETEEN HE'S- WILL BE
LOWER THAN AVERAGE. SO THESE
CHANGES WOULD RESULT IN SAVINGS
OF SIX HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
THE BUDGET YEAR- THE NAME OF
ASIA STUDENTS NOT FINDING WHERE
EXISTING HOW WORKS SAID EIGHT
BTC ON CRAIT SERVICE
UTILIZATION AND COST FACTORS OR
THE NEW CASES COMING ON TO THE
PROGRAM YOU WILL BE NINETEEN
CRISIS AND THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN NEW YOU HE KNEW HE
SAID. ON R. RECENTLY I MEAN
FORTY AND ARE CONSIDERED MORE
WORK READY REQUIRING YOUR CASE
MANAGEMENT AND REMOVAL SERVICE
I FOR THE CHILDCARE YES YOU
WERE WORKING FOR CHILD CARE YOU.
TOO WAIT. HE AND COOLING
SERVICE OR DID LEARNING FROM
THE FROM. IN A LIMITED NUMBER.
OF SURPRISING HOW. I BUT YOU
WANT ME TO MOVE ON TO THE PART
OR YES YES PLEASE CAN TO UNTIL
YOU AN ALL EACH OF COURSE. OKAY
SO YOUR SECOND QUESTION IS TO
DISCUSS THE RATIONALE BEHIND
THE PROPOSED REDUCTION IN
SUBSIDIZING KLEENEX IN RESPONSE
AFTER ASSERTION THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS THE LIKELY PATH WHEN
YOU'RE IN AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD RESULT IN
SAVINGS OF A HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN THE BUDGET YEAR
WE FIRST LIKE YOU KNOW NIGHT WE
RECOGNIZE THE CONCERNS OF
OBJECTS AND THIS PROPOSAL WAS
NOT MADE LIGHTLY HOWEVER GIVEN
THE STATE. BUDGET RIGHT THE-
PRIORITY IS PRESERVE. AND HASH
LEVEL FOR. MOST VULNERABLE. IN
ORDER TO DO THAT SOME
REDUCTIONS WERE NECESSARY IN
HOW IT WORKS SERVICE. THE NAME
OF ASIAN REDUCES ALL BUT THE
BASE FUNDING FOR THE POWER
SUBSIDIZED. GRAHAM I'M VERY
QUESTION WHICH IS HOW HOW WORKS
RECIPIENTS CURRENTLY ENROLLED
IN A SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAMS BE AFFECTED BY THIS
PROPOSAL WILL PROTECT YOU YOUR
NAME WAIT UNTIL LIKE ONE TWENTY
TWENTY- IF THIS PROPOSAL IS
FREE WE KNOW THAT THE NEIGHBOR
VISION INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE POWER TO
IMPLEMENT SERVICES FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR. WE'LL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE DISCRETION. TO
DETERMINE WHAT SERVICES TO
DELIVER CHEAP HIGH. INCLUDING I
THINK. IT IS POSSIBLE THAT. ME
TO THESE THANK YOU PROPOSALS
HOW WE LIKE ALSO THAT ALSO
POSSIBLE THAT WHEN BUSINESSES
REVEALED RATIONS THE EMPLOYERS
WILL HIRE PARTICIPATES WITH THE
JOB SKILLS AND JOB EXPERIENCE
IS. BEING FROM THEIR PREVIOUS
STUFF AND I THINK. WE MET.
ADDITIONALLY SOME SUBSIDIZED
EMPLOYMENT PARTICIPATE YOU ARE
CONTINUING TO COLLECT WE- EVEN
HAVE WORKSITE FOR SHUT DOWN.
REGIS IN THE BUDGET YEAR. YEAH
AND INSTEAD SEEK UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS OR BEGIN
COLLECTING HIGHER POWER WORKS
GRANTS. TO COMPENSATE FOR THE
LOSS YES. NOT QUESTION WITH
REGARDS TO THE WHOLE VISITING
PROGRAMS TO YOUR QUESTION IS
HOW WILL BE ARMY'S CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN THE POWER OVER
THE PROGRAM YEAH IT'S LIKE A
REDUCTION IN FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM. THE REVISION RATE
WOULD YOU SAY- THE WHOLE MAKING
PROGRAM BY THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET YEAR. HI
IT'S CURRENTLY PARTICIPATING IN
THAT HOW IT WORKS PROGRAM WILL
VERY LIKELY NOT BE AFFECTED BY
THIS THE SPENDING REDUCTION.
CHANGING THE ECONOMY NEEDS ME
PREVIOUSLY PROJECTED FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. PROXIMALLY A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL INCLUDES
FINDING NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS IN LINE WITH WHAT IT'S
CRACKED ME UP THANK YOU FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR FOR EXISTING
CLIENTS. WE KNOW THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS STILL RELATIVELY NEW
AND. IT'S STILL IN THE FACE.
AND I'M BACK NO OTHER QUESTIONS
FOR US OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
COMMENTS FROM LA L. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON- RYAN ANDERSON WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE JUST A FEW COMMENTS.
FIRST ON THE REVISED
ASSUMPTIONS REGARDING
UTILIZATION OF EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES AND CHILD CARE. WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT MINISTRATION
HAS PROVIDED A COMPELLING
REASON. FOR THIS REVISED
ASSUMPTION WHILE IT MAY BE TRUE
THAT- MANY OF THE NEW CASES
THAT WILL SEE IN CAL WORKS ARE
AMONG THOSE WHO ARE RECENTLY
UNEMPLOYED AND THEREFORE I HAVE
A LOT OF WORK READY SKILLS
ALREADY- A LOT OF COUNTIES AND
ADVOCATES MADE THE
COUNTERPOINT. THAT MANY OF
THESE FOLKS WILL BE COMING FROM
INDUSTRIES LIKE HOSPITALITY
SECTOR THAT MAY TAKE A VERY
LONG TIME TO RECOVER FROM THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC COLLAPSE BUT
IN THE US MAY REQUIRE INTENSIVE
SUPPORT TO RETRAIN FOR OTHER
DISTRICTS- IT ALSO LOOK BACK AT
THE STATES EXPERIENCED DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION AND SAW
THAT THERE WAS ONLY A MODEST
DECREASE IN THE REALISATION
IMPLEMENT SERVICES AT THAT
TIME. AND THAT REALLY WASN'T
EVEN AN ORGANIC DECREASE THAT
WAS SPURRED ON BY DELIBERATE.
DECISIONS MADE ON THE POLICY.
WITH YOUR TO THE- EMANATES NO
FUNDING FOR EXPANDED SUBSIDIZED
EMPLOYMENT OR YOU THINK THIS IS
AN AREA WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WISH TO CONSIDER MORE
MODEST REDUCTION OF ONE OF THE
CRITERIA THAT WE EMPHASIZE IN
ANALYZING MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS WAS THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTEREST IN NOT MAKING POLICY
DECISIONS THAT MIGHT WORSEN THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC DOWNTURN OR
DAMPEN FUTURE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT
IS ONE OF THE OF THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT HAS GENERALLY BEEN SEEN TO
HAVE A POSITIVE MACROECONOMIC
SACKED THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PUT A LOT OF MONEY INSTEAD
CAUSING SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT
DURING THE LAST RECESSION IN
STUDIES OF THAT- EXPENDITURE
THAT GENERALLY BEEN POSITIVE SO
THE LEGISLATURE MAY BE BASED TO
AT LEAST CONSIDER ARE CAUGHT IT
IS NOT. A COMPLETE ELIMINATION
FINALLY WITH REGARDS TO THE
ELIMINATION OF FUNDING FOR THE
CAL OR PROGRAM THERE'S SORT OF
A DELICATE BALANCING ACT OF THE
LEGISLATURE. NEEDS TO BE AWARE
OF HERE THE US STATE AND MANY
STAKEHOLDERS INVESTED YEARS
INTO DEVELOPING IMPROVED
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
SYSTEM THIS WAS TO BE THE FIRST
YEAR WHEN THAT REALLY. HIT THE
GROUND AND STARTED RUNNING.
EVEN WITHOUT THIS FUNDING
REDUCTION COUNTY ARE UNDER SUCH
A- PRESSURE RIGHT NOW DEALING
WITH EXISTING WORKFLOW. AND
THAT THIS MAY NOT BE THE RIGHT
TIME TO- VOICES NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES UPON THEM BUT
AT THE SAME TIME BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT ARE WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN SOME OF
THAT MOMENTUM THAT WE BUILT AND
SO IT'S JUST ABOUT FINDING THAT
BALANCE OF WHAT IS PRACTICAL
GIVEN THE REALITIES OF.
ACCOUNTING WORK. AND THAT WOULD
BE MY REMARKS THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU OUR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ACTUALLY REFER TO A FINANCE ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
I KNOW YOU DID INITIALLY ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR FINANCE. OKAY
I THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I KNOW
YOU PRESENTED DIRECT QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I'M SO THE DEPARTMENT
EXPECTS AN INCREASE IN THE
CASELOAD SOUNDS LIKE SO BUT IF
THAT CASE LOAD DOES NOT RISE AS
SIGNIFICANTLY AS THE DEPARTMENT
EXPECTS IS. HAS THERE BEEN
GIVEN THOUGHT TO- KIND OF RE
YOU KNOW RE EVALUATING MID YEAR
SO THAT THAT FUNDING CAN GO TO
PERHAPS OTHER RECIPIENTS LIKE
SSI RECIPIENTS OR- YOU KNOW
GOING TOWARDS COAL OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THERE'S AT. LEAST IT'S
BEEN THOUGHT ABOUT TO PIVOT-
SHOULD THIS NOT TURN OUT THE
WAY THEY'RE EXPECTING. SERVICE
CENTERS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. I
WAS A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
THINK WE JUST KNOW THAT-
EXPANDED SUB STARTED QUITE AND
SOME OF THESE OTHER REDUCTIONS
YOU'RE SEEING REPOSE HOURS
PROGRAM ARE IN LINE WITH OUR
FEDERAL TRIGGERS AND WE ARE
EXPECTING THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WILL STEP DOWN IN
THE SYSTEM PROVIDING FUNDING
FOR SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS BUT
TO YOUR POINT OUT SHOULD
CASELOAD NOT REACH THE LEVELS
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY PROJECTING
WE DO CONTINUE TO RETAIN THE
ABILITY TO MAKE. MODIFICATIONS
IT. WAS A PROVISION AUTHORITY.
BUDGET BILLING. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. A THIRD TITLE. SIR
JUST ONE EXPRESS- YOU KNOW OUT
OF CONCERN OF PERSONAL HEALTH
AND DUE TO LOSS OF JOBS THAT
CALIFORNIANS ALL OVER THE STATE
ARE SEEKING FOOD ASSISTANCE
AND- I KNOW THAT WE'VE ALL SEEN
THAT THE LONG LINES- YOU KNOW
THE FOOD BANKS AND DIFFERENT
PLACES AND FOLKS JUST IN SEARCH
OF. A FISA. TRYING TO ACCESS
FOOD. SO WHEN IT COMES TO TWO
ARE ALTERED IN OLDER ADULTS-
THAT ARE YOU KNOW HIGHEST RISK
IN. THEIR ABIDING BY THE STATE
HOME ORDERS I'D YOU KNOW I
JUST. REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE REDUCTION IN UNDER
NUTRITION PROGRAM AND- REALLY
WANT TO JUST EMPHASIZE AND
HIGHLIGHT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
FOR US TO. AT MINIMUM BE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN THAT THE FUNDING
LEVELS THAT WE HAVE AT THE
MOMENT BUT IF POSSIBLE EXPAND.
SO JUST WANTED A STORY
REITERATE THAT IN AND THE NEED
FOR IT. COMING FROM THE FARM
SOCIAL SERVICES ABOUT PROPOSED
CUTS TO SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS. YES CORRECT. OKAY
SORRY ABOUT THAT ATKIN JOHNSONDEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THERE'S NO AFTER POSE REJECTION
TO THAT THE PROGRAMS THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ADMINISTERS AND TRACKS THE FOOD
BANK SUPPORTS THAT'S
PARTICULARLY WE HAVE A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE AFTER
POST YOUR KNEE REVISION FROM
THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WAS. PROPOSED IN JANUARY FOR A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN BUDGET YEAR AT
SPECIFIC REDUCTIONS RELATED TO
THE PROGRAM I DEFER. MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT
BEIJING. OKAY THAT WAS JUST MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT. UNDER THE
NEW MAY REVISION PROPOSALS THAT
THERE WOULD BE REDUCTIONS AND
TRICIA PROGRAM SO THEY'RE
TEACHING. THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING. IF ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OKAY. SO I THINK A
COUPLE QUESTIONS RELATED TO
SOME THE COMMENTS FROM LA- SO
IF- CERTAINLY WITH CAL OR WITH
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCUSSION
WITH CONNIE'S PERHAPS MAYBE
SOME COUNTIES WANT TO TRY TO
MOVE AHEAD GIVEN THE PROGRESS%
WE'VE MADE TO DATE OTHER
COUNTIES MAY SAY I CAN
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND SAYING
LIKE THIS IS NOT THE YEAR TO DO
IT BECAUSE- WE'RE DEALING WITH
BECAUSE OF IT- SO IS. THERE
BEEN SOME CONSIDERATION IN
TERMS OF CAL OR WHETHER IT'S-
IN TERMS OF. WORKING WITH
COUNTIES AND SEEING WHICH
COUNTIES MIGHT STILL BECAUSE
THEY'VE- GIVEN WHERE THEY ARE
MIGHT WANNA STILL CONTINUE WITH
WITH THAT SO ARE YOU ARE YOU
JUST LOOKING AT A BLANKET-
SUSPENSION FOR- FOR THE COMING
YEAR. AND ACTION MAYBE CAN
TOUCH ON WHAT WOULD YOU EXPECT
TO START MOVING FORWARD AGAIN.
SURE CAN JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES SO THE-
PROPOSED OUT LANGUAGE HERE WITH
THE REJECTION OF THAT. FINES
WOULD STILL ALLOW AS YOU HAVE
OUTLINED CHAIR AT THE ABILITY
FOR COUNTIES TO CONTINUE. ARE
THERE ARE CERTAINLY CERTAIN
MEASURES AND METRICS ARE. CAN I
PROVIDE AND CONTINUE TO POST
PUBLICLY AND WORK WITH COUNTIES
DIRECT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
EFFORTS WITH THE CHARACTER.
THAT WOULD CONTINUE FOR THE
OPTION WOULD REMAIN JUST
RECORDS ACTUALLY SHE WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE FORWARD AND PROVIDE THE
ADDITIONAL DAY THAT THE SELF
ASSESSMENT PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT
PLAN. AT TWO FORTY THREE THANK
YOU. OKAY WE SHOULD THAT. THE
OTHER COMMON I GUESS WAS SAY I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH- ELYAS
ASSESSMENT THAT. MY GUESS MMHM
MY GUESTS ALSO GUESS- IS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SEE SOME FAIRLY.
A SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES IN THE
WORK FORCE EVEN WHEN THE
ECONOMY COMES BACK SO I THINK
IT'S POINTED OUT THE PREY
LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY IS BY
NOT GOING TO COVER AS QUICKLY
AS IT THE OTHER SECTORS AND-
WOMEN ASSISTANCE IS SOMETHING
THAT I THINK. IT'S GONNA BECOME
VERY IMPORTANT TO HELP PEOPLE
GET BACK ON THEIR FEET. SO NOW
ON ON THE FLIP SIDE A GUEST- I
GUESS MY HOPES THAT WE HOPE
WILL GET FEDERAL FUNDING AS
PERHAPS A LITTLE HIGHER FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT GIVEN THAT
STRAP PRIEST PAST TRACK RECORD
BUT- DO. AGREE WITH LA- THAT-
WE- SHOULD LOOK TOWARD L. GIVEN
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM- IN THE
PAST IN THE PAST- THAT WE
SHOULD CERTAINLY LOOK TO- TRY
TO FIND A WAY TO FIND THOSE
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES I THINK TO
YOU LET'S SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO END UP ON CAL WORKS WHO.
MAY HAVE HAD PREVIOUS
EMPLOYMENT EXPERIENCE BUT- IN
DIFFERENT FIELDS AND- WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO HELP THEM- IF WE
CAN GET THEM RE EMPLOYED AN OFF
COLOR WORKS AGAIN- IN BEING
RETRAINED- FOR OTHER TYPES OF
WORK COME NOT SURE THEY CAN
JUST GO BACK TO THE SAME FIELD.
SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIND SOME
OPPORTUNITIES TO- FOR HELP FUND
FUND- THAT EMPLOYMENT- THERE'S
A FOOT DEPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
THROUGH- PROVIDING THE
EMPLOYMENT- SUBSIDIES. OR
ASSISTANCE. RIGHT ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY ANNEX ANY
OTHER QUESTION MEMBER QUESTIONS
RELATED TO ANY OTHER ITEMS ON
OUR BOAT ONLY CALENDAR. OKAY I
DON'T SEE ANY OKAY SO AGAIN- WE
SURFED HIGHLIGHTED THE MAJOR
ISSUES HERE OKAY LET'S THEN
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
WITH PUBLIC COMMENT- SO. I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WANTING
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS ASK PEOPLE TO
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES NAME IF
YOU REPRESENT ORGANIZATION
ORGANIZATION. WE HAVE A VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR THAT HAS. ONE
HUNDRED ITEMS. ARE THERE- I'M
ASSUMING- AND SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA ASK YOU TO DO IS
INDICATED WHICH ITEM NUMBER OUR
NUMBERS THAT IS A YOU- HAVE THE
POSITION ARE YOU WISH TO
EXPRESS POSITION ON AND THEN-
INFORM US AS TO WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR THAT ITEM
SO. I BELIEVE YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO- THAT'S FROM THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR FOR PART B. HUMAN
SERVICES SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU
WOULD SAY THAT- ITEM NUMBER JIM
PICK ONE THE ITEM NUMBER TEN I
SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION SO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE A FULL- TESTIMONY
IN TERMS OF- WE HAD THE
RATIONALE AGAIN WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SUBMIT ANY LETTERS OR
EXPLANATIONS TO OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF VIA THE WEBSITE VIA
EMAIL. BUT FOR TESTIMONY
BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY PEOPLE ON
THE LINE TO NOR TO TRY TO HEAR
FROM AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
THROUGH EVERYONE. ON THE ORGANS.
ISSUE NUMBER AND POSITION- IN
REGARDS TO THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AS DESCRIBED IN
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR. SO
HOPEFULLY THIS EVERYONE'S CLEAR
ON THAT WE HAVE A HARD STOP.
AND I DO MEAN HARD STOP BECAUSE
OF. THAT WE WON'T HAVE THIS
HEARING ROOM OR THE PHONE
LINES- AND YEAH I THINK SO
WELL- IF WE DON'T GET TO
EVERYONE BY. LITERALLY BY SIX
TWENTY FIVE- THAT IS REALLY THE
HARD STOP BECAUSE THEN WE HAVE
TO VOTE. AND THEN- I THINK- WE
DON'T HAVE TO LEAVE THIS ROOM
SO HOPEFULLY WE HAD LOOKS LIKE
WE SHOULD HAVE REASONABLY AMPLE
TIME TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE. OVER
AN HOUR ABOUT AN HOUR AND A
HALF. OF THE US AND IT IS A LOT
OF PEOPLE ON THE LINE SO- AND
SO THAT THAT'S BASICALLY HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS. OKAY SO
WHAT I FIRST DO IS TAKE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- OH THREE. SEEING
NONE HERE LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE IN
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR. ASK YOU
TO TELL PEOPLE TO CONNECT ON.
THE TELEPHONE LINE AND SO AGAIN
I WAS- NOW WHAT SO OKAY SO NOW
I WANT TO INVITE THE PUBLIC
WANTING TO PARTICIPATE TO CALL
IN NOW. PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL
FREE NUMBER. 977-336-4441 AND
THAT'S ALSO I SHOULD BE I'LL
SEE IT ON THE SCREEN TWO AGAIN.
1-877-336-4441 PROMPTED USE THE
ACCESS CODE NINE EIGHT FIVE.
TWO SIX ZERO. RIGHT SO WE CAN
MAKE REFERENCE TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR WILL NOT TAKE WHEN WE
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AND- WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO ALSO DO THIS DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
YOU CLEAN PROTOCOLS WE WILL
HAVE TO END SOME DUDES. TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY AND SO
PLEASE TESTIFIES I. DESCRIBED I
WILL PUT A TIME LIMIT A TOTAL
OF ONE MINUTE ALTHOUGH I THINK
THAT- YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO IF
YOU STICK TO THE DESCRIPTION I.
TRIED TO KEEP IT WITHIN ONE
MINUTE- AND THEN- SO AGAIN-
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF THE
ONLY ITEMS. AND. AND IF YOU CAN
ALSO GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. SO MODERATOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. AS A
REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AIDS PLEASE RESPECT ONE MINUTE
TIME FRAME ONCE AGAIN ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. OKAY AGAIN
NAME ORGANIZATION ITEM NUMBER
AND THEN YOUR POSITION RELATION
TO THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
OKAY LET'S GET GOING. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE A QUICK FOLLOW LINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
LINE FOUR SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS ELSA I'M- I AM
THE CEO IT COSTS THE
CERTIFICATE YEAH S. T. R. T. P.
INVENTOR COUNTY. I BELIEVE S.
T. R. T. P. DOES NOT HAVE AN
ITEM NUMBER AT. JUSTICE EVERY
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THIS AND
THEN MAKE AN ABOUT WHO ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE APPEALED
WORKERS WHO HARVEST CROPS
GROCERY STORE CLERKS TRASH
COLLECTORS. ALSO YOUTH CARE
WORKERS TO PROVIDE CARE AND
TREATMENT FOSTER YOU USE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS REQUIRE THE
HIGHEST THOROUGHLY JUST
INDICATE YOUR POSITION SO S. AS
IN RELATION TO S. T. R. E. T.
WHAT'S YOUR POSITION ON THAT
THE PROPOSAL COUNTERPROPOSAL
READER. OF CLOSE TO THE
GOVERNORS 5% RATE CAP OKAY
THANK YOU SO VERY. MUCH SIR A
POST. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NEXT.
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SIX THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HI THIS IS JENNIFER
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF MEALS ON
WHEELS CALIFORNIA AND ARE MORE
THAN FIFTY LOCAL AGENCIES
SERVING OVER EIGHTEEN MILLION
THEY'LL BE HERE WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR ITEM FORTY
ONE SEVENTY ISSUE ONE TO REJECT
THE PROPOSED CUTS TO CD EIGHT
NUTRITION PROGRAMS AND INSTEAD
IMPROVE THE PROPOSED EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION IN GENERAL
FROM THE PORT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER.
SIX THIRTY SIX SIX THIRTY SIX
HI MY NAME IS MARTHA YES I'M
CALLING FROM AND THE FIFTEEN
MONTEREY COUNTY AND REGARDING
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR- I OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANKS CALLER. SIX THIRTY
FOUR. MR HER NUMBER'S GONNA
SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP IN REGARDS
TO DISCUSSION ITEM REGARDING
HOW WORKS MODIFICATIONS TO
ENSURE TO OPPOSE THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION ON
PUBLIC SOME BEGINNING PROGRAM I
HOPE YOU CAN REJECT THAT
PROPOSAL WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT
THANK. YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER. SIX THIRTY FIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS HOPE HE MERRY
AND I'M CALLING CONCERNING CAT
FAMILY OF AGENCIES SENECA
STRONGLY. AFTER FAMILY AGENCIES
AND THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM THE SENATE APARTMENT
FIFTY ONE EIGHTY ISSUE ONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER. SIX ZERO SEVEN
SIX ZERO SEVEN. HELLO I'M JANET
HE'S SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
IMMERSIVE PIECE BY THE
SOCIALIZATION WITH OTHER
SOLUTIONS AND STRONGLY OPPOSES
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO
ELIMINATE SOME OF THOSE P. M.
C. DOT. SEVENTY FOUR AND ALSO
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RECOMMENDED REPLACEMENT OF
THESE PROGRAMS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION LONG TERM CARE.
HOME COOK COLD COLD THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER.
ON LINE FORTY FIVE. HI I'M
KOREAN JNCO FAMILY BRIDGES
SERVING TEN THOUSAND ASIAN
IMMIGRANTS EACH YEAR WE ARE
PROTESTING AND OPPOSING THE
ELIMINATION OF FEEDBACK AND
ANNA CHRISTIE. OKAY THANK YOU
THANKS FOR. THREE FORTY THREE.
HI MY I'M A POSTAL WORKER WITH
PENNY PINCHING YOUR KERR
NETWORK I'M CALLING- TO URGE
YOU TO OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE THE AND
ACTUALLY P. PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER. THREE
ZERO. HI THIS IS JUSTIN GATLIN
SEE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES- WE'VE
SUBMITTED A LETTER THAT DETAILS
ARE DETAILED POSITION BUT ALL
OF THESE THINGS- FIRST TWO
WOULD BE- THE REALIGNMENT PAXIL
COUNTIES. ADMINISTER THESE
PROGRAMS IN PARTNERSHIPWITH
THE STATE AND I LOOK IN A
DEVASTATING THE ALIGNMENT CUT-
SO WE HAVE LOTS OF INFORMATION
THAT LETTER. OUR SECOND ISSUE
IS- REDUCING THE ICE AND
INFLATION FACTOR FROM FOUR
PERCENT. 2% GIVEN THAT THE
REALIGNMENT REVENUES ARE
DECLINING AND THEN A COUPLE OF
THE SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED ON THE AGENDA- ARE
WE OPPOSED THE CUT TO THE COW
WORK SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT
WHICH SOME DISCUSSION ISSUE
PORTER CDS THAT. WE POSE THE
LIMITATION OF THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM ISSUE NINETY
EIGHT AND WE OPPOSE THE- MAY
REVISE PROPOSAL TO REDUCE LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY FUNDING
WHICH WAS ISSUE NUMBER ONE ON
THE DISCUSSION FOR CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK. YOU THANKS CALLER.
WHY SEVEN EIGHT. SH GOOD
AFTERNOON ABOUT THAT ACCESS
FROM A GOOD FAMILY SERVICES I
AM CALLING ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE
AND URGE YOU TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CUT THAT
TO THINK THE SHOW WORKER- RATE-
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKERS CAREFUL WITH THIRTEEN
THOUSAND FOSTER CHILDREN USE
EVERY DAY OR A THIRD OF AUGUST
YOU CULDN'T CHILDREN LIVING IN
FOSTER HOMES AND A 100% OF ALL
TALK YOU CAN INTENSIVE
SERVICES. FOSTER CARE PROGRAMS
THANK. YOU THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. WHY. THREE EIGHTY
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT.
HELLO THIS IS MITCH MATTHEWS
CALLING FROM HEALTH PRODUCTS
OPPOSING THE ELIMINATION OF THE
MSRP A PROGRAM NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR THE ECONOMICS ALONE DON'T
MAKE ANY SENSE CROCKERY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR TO
KEEP SOMEBODY OUT OF A NURSING
HOME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU TO DO
ANYTHING OTHER OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER. ONE THIRTY
THREE. OKAY WE CAN'T HEAR YOU.
SURE WHAT HELLO. FINE ONE
THIRTY THREE. WINDS SIX
FOURTEEN. NINE SIX FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE AND
NUMBERS JORDAN THEN HE WILL BE
ARGUING. HOLDING NOBODY
COLLABORTIONS GUARDS THE THREE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICE HOLD. THE
YES WALLED BE FAMILY CULTURE IN
THE DATA AUCTION WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE TO KEEP OPEN THE THAT
THERE ARE WAYS TO. WE REJECT
THEM BUT- WHAT'S WHAT'S
ACTUALLY MITIGATE OUR FAMILY.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU THANKS
FOR. BLIND THREE FORTY EIGHT.
MY NAME IS LAURA COULD NO BE- A
PROVIDER OF SERVICES REGARDING
THE RATE CUT- THE REDUCTION IS
HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME THAT
MINIMUM WAGE GOES UP SO THIS IS
GOING TO INCREASE THE HEART YOU
FOR PROVIDING THAT PLEASE
INDICATE THE ITEM THAT YOU'RE
DO YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON AND
YOUR POSITION ON THAT ITEM. I
REACHED I OPPOSE THE POSITION
IS I DIDN'T WANT TO AND I
OPPOSED THE RATE CUT THE
PERCENTAGE OF RECORD. WE ARE
GOING FOR RECONSIDERATION ON
THE AMOUNT OF ON THE PERCENTAGE
OF OUR RATE. REDUCTION OKAY
THANK YOU FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS. RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER. SIX TWENTY
FOUR. SIX TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN PAT A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LAUREN
HARRINGTON I'M CALLING IN
REGARDS TO ITEM FOUR ONE SEVEN
ZERO ISSUE ONE I AM A CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER AT HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL DAMAGED SITE AND I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR HOLLY
MITCHELL I DON'T QUITE HAVE THE
COMMITTEE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF MSP. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR. SIX
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME WHEN DICK MAN I'M CALLING
ABOUT ITEM FOUR ONE SEVEN ZERO
ISSUE NUMBER ONE I WORK AT
UNTINGTON HOSPITAL BENEFITS
THE SITE I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO
WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
DISCUSSED AND URGING KERR YOUR
SUPPORT CANNOT ELIMINATE MSP
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. THANKS CALLER. FOUR
SEVENTY THREE. FOUR SEVEN THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PROBABLY IN
THE NEXT TEN NOW POINT TO- AND
REJECT THE ELIMINATION OF THE
FAMILY OR GERMS SPONSORED FORM
ISSUE NUMBER NINETY EIGHT AND
NINETEEN. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. SIX FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SENATOR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- ANGELA
MCCORMICK WITH THE CHILDREN
BOSTON ARE CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT I AM FIFTY
FOUR FIFTY FIVE AND FIFTY SIX-
WHERE IN THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECT THE
MAY REVISION AND APPROVED
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT EIGHTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTEEN. AND EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE. BRIEFLY WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT WE DO NOT THE
EXTENDED PROTECTION FOR YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE- THAT THE
GOVERNOR AT THAT POINT AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER BUT ARE NOT
CONTAINED IN THE BUDGET. WE ARE
WORKING WITH SENATOR BELL ON IN
A COALITION. OR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AS WELL AS F. B. NINE
TWELVE DRUG DRUG PRODUCTION FOR
EXTENDED BERNAMA. IN EXTENDED
BOXES YOUTH AND HOPE WE CAN
COUNT ON THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLED. SIX TWO
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
SENATOR CANNON AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON DR LAURA HYATT CEO
OF STANFORD'S HERE YOUTH AND
FAMILIES AND I'M HERE ON THE
ISSUE- AT FIFTY ONE EIGHTY YES
THAT'S NUMBER ONE- IN
PARTICULAR I'M DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
SOCIAL WORK GREAT IN DECREASED
AND THE DATE THE PROPOSED
INCREASE FOR THE S. T. R. T. T.
RIGHT- WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR
FOSTER YEARS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I CALLED. SIX FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS PATTY
WALKS AND FUN AND INTERESTING
TO PROVIDER AT HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL SENIOR KERR NETWORK AN
ITEM FOUR ONE SEVEN ZERO ISSUE
ONE I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE ELIMINATION OF THE MSSP
PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER. SIX
FORTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LADY SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF S. T. I. U.
CALIFORNIA. CALLING TO URGE THE
COMMITTEE IS REJECTION FOR ITEM
NINETY EIGHT AND NINETY NINE IN
SECTION FIFTY ONE EIGHTY
REGARDING OUR LIMITATION OF
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
PROGRAMMING ALSO URGED THE
COMMITTEE TO REJECT
CONVERSATION I DONE WHAT
KARTING PRODUCTION AND HOW WORK
AND 7% REDUCTION IN I. H. AT
THAT. THANK YOU THANKS FOR. SIX
FIFTY SIX FIVE ZERO. HI THIS IS
KARN I'VE GOT EMAIL FROM FROM
WORKER FROM HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE SITE I
STRONGLY URGE THE COMMUNITY TO
OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION OF MSP
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER. FOUR NINETY ONE. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU HEAR ME. I CAN HEAR
YOU HI. THIS IS SHELLY RILEY
AND WITHOUT THE ARTIFACT STOCK
CONSUMERS PROVIDERS AND
ADVOCATES UNITED OP FACEBOOK
GROUP THAT HAS SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND CONSUMERS AND
PROVIDERS ON H. AND R. I WANT
TO FIRST ANSWER QUESTION WHICH
WAS WHAT IS THE AVERAGE COST OF
AN EYE TO SUCH RECIPIENT. FOR
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THAT WAS
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS. A MONTH AND SHOW OFF I
WANTED TO OPPOSE- D. R. LET'S
SEE ITEM OFF FIVE ONE EIGHT
ZERO ISSUE THREE THE 7% FRIDAY
TO STAFF I ALSO WON ALL CLOSE.
ODDS HE BACKED AN SSP WHICH I
THINK IS FOUR ONE SEVEN ZERO
ISSUE LAUNCH AND I WAS HOPING
THAT WE COULD HAVE A LIKE A
TASK FORCE THAT COULD TRACK AND
SHARE THE DATA OF PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT GOING TO NURSING HOMES
FROM THE REDUCTIONS WITH
ARTIFACTS. AND IF THEY COULD
NOT SHARE THAT DATA AND ALSO-
YOU KNOW KEEP PEOPLE FROM GOING
INTO INSTITUTIONS OKAY MY GOD A
GROUP OF SOCIAL WORKERS THAT
ARE FLEXIBLE STATEWIDE WHICH
THEY CAN GO COUNTY TO COUNTY
AND HELP PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO
MAKE SOME FIRE AND- THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU GET THE.
IDEA THANK YOU OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SIX FIFTY THREE. HI
THIS IS JACK REPLIED THERE AND
I CALLING FROM THE CALIBER LINE
THE FIFTH INNING THAT BEGAN
UNDER AND FORTY. NATIONAL
ACCREDITED AGENCY DROP STATE
SERVING A 100% OF FOSTER YOUTH
WE OPPOSE THE CUTS A FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS
THE CUTS TO ACTUALLY KEEP SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS. AND THE CUTS TO THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM
PLEASE SUPPORT OUR SPONSOR
CHILDREN THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN
TRAUMATIZED WE NEED TO PROTECT
THEM FROM FURTHER HARM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
THREE NINETY FOUR. HI MY NAME
IS ANDREA CHAPMAN CEO OF UNITY
CARE NEARLY TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
WE HAVE SERVED THOUSANDS OF
FOSTER CHILDREN YOUTH YOUNG
ADULTS THROUGHOUT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WRITING TRANSITIONAL
PERMANENT HOUSING WE'RE TOLD AN
ITEM FIFTY ONE EIGHTY ISSUE ONE
ENCOURAGING INVESTMENT IN THE
HOUSING SUPPLEMENTS TO GIVE
THESE YOUNG ADULTS A FIGHTING
CHANCE TO SURVIVE AND ELIMINATE
THE JOURNEY OF HOMELESSNESS AND
INCARCERATION THE CURRENT
CURRENT TEENAGE PRE RATE DOES
NOT SUFFICIENT TO COVER THE
REASONS THANK YOU ROBERT
HOUSING COSTS. THANK YOU HELP
US OKAY THANK YOU I WANT TO ASK
THE PEOPLE NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ON SPECIFIC ITEM
JUST PEOPLE ARE SHORT ON TIME
OKAY- SO PLEASE IF YOU HAVE ANY
EXPLANATIONS OR DETAILS PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO EMAIL THEM TO OUR
COMMITTEE- AT CELL. RIGHT NEXT
CALLER. FOR FORTY FOUR. SH HERE
AGAIN CEO OF SIDE BY SIDE-
REGARDING ITEM FIFTY ONE EIGHTY
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ISSUE ONE THAT WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS ITEM PARTICULARLY
THE 5% CUT IN THE YARD TO BE
GREAT AND THE SUSPENSION OF L.
AT THE RATE TWO THREE FOUR ALSO
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
YOU INCLUDE THE PREVENTING COST
YOU ALMOST PROBABLE TO SUPPORT
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR YOUTH
AGING OUT OF CARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER. FOR OH
SEVEN. OKAY. WHEN THEY'RE
MOVING UP. THE FULL LINE. SIX
SIX ZERO SIX SIXTY. CAN LEWIS
AND I REPRESENT AT YOU'RE NOT
AND THE COMPANY COLLISION PER
YEAR AND WEEK BUT STOCK MARKET
MEDITATION HOLD OPENING ITEMS
AROUND. AND THE FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKER RATE- AND
WE ALSO OPPOSE THE LOC YOU-
CHANGE AND I ALSO WANTED TO
NOTE THAT CHILDREN NOW IT'S UP
THERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE CUT
TO THE COW WORK HOME BETWEEN
PROGRAM DFS ISSUED FOR. OKAY
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER. SIX
SIXTY ONE. RESEARCHER CURTAIL
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WERE OPPOSED TO THE ASSETS
ARE YOU LOOKING TO SPEAK UNDER
THE PASTORAL- THE IHS US A 7%
REDUCTION IN HOURS AND- WE
SUPPORT THE PROTECTIVE
SUPERVISION PROVISION FOR IHS
US WHICH IS- ITEM EIGHTY FIVE-
WE ALSO OPPOSE- UNINSURABLE DUE
TO WHICH SHE HAS THE REDUCTIONS
TO THE INDEPENDENT. LIVING
CENTERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANKS CALLER. SIX SIXTY
FOUR. GOOD EVENING PARENTS THIS
IS ANNA JOHNSON WITH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU
APPRECIATE THE REJECTION OF THE
MAY REVISION ON ITEM FORTY
EIGHT AROUND THE CONTINUED
OVERSIGHT OF PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATION AND FOSTER CHILDREN
AS WELL AS ITEM FIFTY FOUR FOR
THE FOSTER YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS
I WANT TO ECHO COMMENTS MADE
PREVIOUSLY BY IT THE CHILDREN'S
LAW CENTER AROUND. EIGHT AM
EXTENDING PROTECTIONS FOR YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE THROUGH THE
EXTENDED EXECUTIVE ORDER NOT
EXIT DURING A PANDEMIC A COOK
AT NINETEEN AND THEN FINALLY ON
THE HOUSING COMMENTS MADE ABOUT
THE T. T. P. EN M. DE HOUSING
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER. FIVE NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
AUDREY RAINY AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF RANCHO
SAN ANTONIO BOYS TOWN A LARGE
S. T. P. AND BETTER IN
CALIFORNIA REGARDING DEPARTMENT.
FIVE ONE EIGHT ZERO ISSUE ONE I
OPPOSE THE BUDGET CUTS AT THE
R. T. P. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU. THANKS FOR. SIX
SIXTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS
MATTIS DEL WEBB WHICH HUMAN
SERVICES ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE
THE TOTAL ELIMINATION OF MSP
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS FOR.
SIX SIX EIGHT. IN KEEPING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES INTERESTING
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY ONE EIGHTY
ISSUE THREE ON YOUR DISCUSSION-
AGENDA WERE OPPOSED 7% CUT
CONCERNED ABOUT THE REDUCTION
THE COUNTY AND PUBLIC AUTHORITY
ADMIN FUNDING BUT I REALLY WANT
TO WEIGH IN AGAINST THE PAYROLL
SHIFT TO A PRIVATE SECTOR
VENDOR THAT WASN'T DISCUSSED.
WITH THE COUNTY AND WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER. SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX. YEAH MY NAME IS
HOLLY KELLY ZERO I'M WITH THE
HEALTH PROJECT CENTER SPONSOR
OF THE M. S. P. THIRTEEN
INCREASE IN MONTEREY COUNTY HI
I'M CALLING TODAY BECAUSE I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE MSRP WHICH I
BELIEVE THAT I AM SEVENTY FIVE-
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE AGAINST
THAT ELIMINATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER. FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS
JASON DEL AND I'M A FOSTER CARE
PROVIDER AND I'M URGING YOU TO
VOTE AGAINST ELIMINATING THE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKER RATE INCREASE OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE LIFELINE AND THERE
IS A C. T. S. ALSO PROBABLY
AGENCY STUDY BRINGING
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS. FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS IDEAL RESTORED
THAT FUNDING PORT THANK YOU
YEAH NEXT CALL. SIX SEVENTY
TWO. MY ANGER I'M A FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR AND
FULL FUNDING FOR THE ONE
CALIFORNIA LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAM ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
DUE PROCESS OF DETENTION
PROGRAM TO INTERACT WITH THE
COUNSELOR PEOPLE HOUSED IN
THESE FACILITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR. SIX
THIRTY NINE. MY NAME IS RUSSELL
RICE WITH RIVER STONES S. T. R.
T. P. IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGARDING IT AT FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY ISSUE ONE I OPPOSED TO
THE 5% RATE CUT AND FOSTER CARE
FUNDING TO S. T. R. T. PIECE TO
THE CHILDREN WHO HAVE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF EMOTIONAL AND
pMENTAL HEALTH NEEDS RECEIVING
TREATMENT AND ENERGY ARE TWO
PEAS PLEASE SUPPORT OUR FOSTER
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TME. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. SIX THIRTY ONE. HI MY
NAME IS DAVID NOW MAY NOT BE A
CREATIVE DIRECTOR AT LATINO
FAMILY EITHER BCAUSE I THINK A
COMMITTEE MEMBER- WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE- I DON'T BUY ONE EIGHTY
ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE. AIRCRAFT
ARE T. P. AND CUT THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER.
FOUR FIFTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME
IS FLORENCE CHRISTIAN M. I.
AGENTS AT HOME CARE PROVIDER
FROM MOST ACCOUNTING I'M
CALLING REGARDING ITEM NUMBER
THREE A DISTRICT COURT SHARE OF
UW I SPEAK TO YOU ON BEHALF OF
A HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND I
DETECT PROVIDER ON TWENTY ONE
COUNTY. I CAN'T CALL MY BROTHER
EDWARD WHO HAD SCHIZOPHRENIA I
GET THAT MAKE THAT POSSIBLE AND
WE'RE TO LIVE AT HOME OKAY
THANK. YOU TO ALEX THERE HAS
BEEN A SENSE WE ARE IN THE
OPPOSITION AS SEPARATE
BACKPACK. OKAY THANK. YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT.
NEXT CALLER. SIX SEVENTY FIVE.
HI LINDA CAMPBELL IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICE RECIPIENT AND I
HSS ADVISORY COUNCIL MEMBER IN
TEMPE CALIFORNIA. I DON'T KNOW
FOR SURE THE ITEM NUMBER WOULD
BE UNDER FIFTY ONE EIGHTY ISSUE
NUMBER THREE AND I'M OPPOSED TO
THE BUDGET. THE EXPANDED ONE
TWENTY THREE POINT 38% OF THE
F. B. L. AS IN TERMS OF CAROL
DIDN'T TURN. MANY IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES. THANK. YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR. SIX
SIXTY NINE. HEY MY NAME IS LISA
MIKE WATERS WITH HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL SENIOR KERR NETWORK M.
S. S. P. WITH REGARD TO ITEM
FOUR ONE SEVEN ZERO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE I OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF EMPHASIS P. AND
ASK YOU TO PLEASE DO THE SAME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. THANKS CALLER. SIX TWENTY.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS BRANDON
AND I'M THE CEO OF TRANSITIONS
CHILDREN'S SERVICES I'M CALLING
REGARDING ISSUE ONE IN
DEPARTMENT FIFTY ONE EIGHTY
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES I
OPPOSED THE CUT TO THE FSA
SOCIAL WORKER RAKES THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER. SIX
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU MARTY
MOTO FAMILY MEMBERS FEEDING CAN
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY INCOME
ACTION NETWORK POSE A TRUE CUTS
TO HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES IN
BOTH AGENDAS INCLUDING M. S. P.
SINGH BATCH REGIONAL CENTERS I
COULD SET THAT ASIDE AND-
BECAUSE THIS IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
PANDEMIC THANK YOU. FOR DOING A
HEARING. THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER. FOUR EIGHTY. HELLO MY
NAME IS KARL MARX NUMBERS I
CHECKED THAT PROVIDER AND
COUNTY REP FOR UNITED LAST WEEK
WORKERS UNION BUTTE COUNTY- I'M
CALLING ABOUT ITEM FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY ISSUE THREE- I CARE FOR
MY FATHER IN LAW ALBERT HE'S IN
HIS LAST EIGHT OF THE BALL TIME
I'M SURE THE STATE AND THE
FAMILY MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA
OKAY MA'AM I DON'T ITHER.
SORRY I'M JUST ASKING PEOPLE
THE NAME ORGANIZATION AND THEN
THE ITEM THAT THEY'RE EITHER
SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING SO I
PRESUME- ARE YOU OPPOSING. THE
RIGHTEOUSNESS CUT. YEAH FIFTY
EIGHT. OKAY I AM THREE ARE
EXCELLENT THANK YOU EIGHT AT
THAT HOUR CUT IN MSP ANOTHER
MEDICAL FUNDING PROGRAM OKAY
THANK YOU SOVERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU OUR NEXT
CALLER. SIX NINETY ONE. GOOD
EVENING JOINT HELP CRITTENTON
SERVICES SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THIS IS REGARDING FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY ITEM NUMBER ONE WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE
ELIMINATION OF THE FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL WORKER
RATE INCREASE AS WELL AS A
REDUCTION IN OUR CHURCH UP
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR. SIX NINETY TWO.
HELLO DEBORAH TEXEIRA HERE
POSTAL WORKER AT SANTA CRUZ AND
THEN HE STRONGLY OPPOSING THE
GOVERNOR'S. EMANATION OF THE
AMNESTY PROGRAM- ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU THANKS
FOR. SIX NINETY FOUR. HI MY
NAME IS MICHAEL CREED THAT
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER FROM
HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL SENIOR KERR
NETWORK I'M CALLING REGARDING
ITEM NUMBER FOUR ONE SEVEN ZERO
ISSUE NUMBER ONE AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION OF MSP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS
FOR. SIX NINETY SEVEN. THE
GENTLEMAN WITH SENIOR AND
DISABILITY ACTION CONSIDERING
THAT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
LIVING IN POVERTY AND I THOUGHT
I WAS DYING IN NURSING HOMES
AND I'M CALLING TO URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE HAD CRITICAL SENIOR AND
DISABILITY PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY
PLEASE REJECT ATTACKS ARE
STRUCK BY A CAR HE URNED
AROUND THEN HE ASK FOR MUCH OF
T. THE TREASURY PROGRAMS PAGE
OUTSIDE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER. FIVE SO. ONE FIVE
THIRTY FIVE. HI YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES I CAN PLEASE
CONTINUE. I THANK YOU MY NAME'S
AMBER BUSH AND I AM AN S. C.
ARE YOU A MEMBER I AM A PARENT
PARTNER PROVIDER AND I HSS. AND
I AM ALSO AN SS I SS P.
RECIPIENT YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
WHY I AM OPPOSED TO- I AM FIVE
ONE EIGHT ZERO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE ON CUTTING 7% TO HSS
PROGRAMS. I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THE PROTECTIVE SUPERVISION.
ACTUATION AND I AM OPPOSED TO
THE SS I SS PICCOLA CHANGES.
THANK YOU. THANKS THIS CALL.
ONE SEVENTY TWO. ONE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN ALL I'M
SORRY I RUINED YOUR OWN FLIGHT
DIRECTOR OF THE MESSAGE PETER
REPLACEMENT BETWEEN ACCOUNTING
I URGE THE REJECTION OF THE
ELIMINATION OF ITEM. FOUR ONE
SEVEN ZERO. ISSUE ONE. EXCEPT
FOR OR DEMOCRAT PETER RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS FOR.
SIX NINETY EIGHT. YEAH HELLO MY
NAME IS ERIC DOLPHY JACKAL AND
THE DIRECTOR OF THE PROGRAM
EACH AT THE INSTITUTE ON AGING
IN FACT BUT I'M ALSO CALLING TO
ACCORD- ISSUE FOUR ONE SEVEN
ZERO ISSUE ONE ELIMINATION OF
THE AND THE PART B. PROGRAM AND
I ASK THAT YOU DO THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. VERY MUCH THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER. THREE NINE.
I MEAN THIS IS DEBBIE I AM THAT
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF CHOICE IN
AGING I'LL PLAY A MEMBER OF THE
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
TO THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF MSN AND THE BACK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. MY
NAME IS EILEEN A NO I'M A
MOTHER OF A TWENTY YEAR OLD
WITH SEVERE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY REQUIRING TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN CARE. EARNING ISSUE
NUMBER ONE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
AND DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. ANY OF THE PROPOSED
CUTS TO THE ELDERLY AND
DISABLED AND FOSTERS SHOULD BE
PRECEDED BY MATCHING CUTS TO
LEGISLATORS SALARIES. THE IDEA
THAT EITHER WE EITHER MIGHT GETEUROS LEGISLATION PASSED OR
START OUT ARE MOST VULNERABLE
IN THE FALL AND CRUEL IDEA AND
SHOWED SKEWED PRIORITIES THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALL. SIX
NINETY NINE. I GET AFTERNOON DR
CANDICE IS CAROLINE UNDER THE
COMMAND OF THE COUNTY MEDICAL
SERVICES PROGRAM I'M SPEAKING
ON NUMBER NINETY THREE- DON'T
REGARD IT OFFERED AN
ALTERNATIVE TO ARE ASKING FOR
YOU TO REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND WORK WITH HIM IF
HE ON AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE
FIFTY NINE DOLLAR PER YOUR
SWEET AND I THINK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION THANKS THANKYOU.
NEXT CALLER. FOUR ZERO EIGHT.
HI MY NAME IS CATHY TIPTON. I
REPRESENTTHE WORKERS BENEFIT
COUNCIL PRESIDENT HELLO I
REPRESENT OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE IN A LOT OF THEM ARE
IN HOME CARE WORKERS RECIPIENTS
AS WELL AS LOCATED WE REPRESENT
LOW INCOME PEOPLE ALL AROUND
AND WE NEED TO SAVE ALL
SERVICES. ALBEIT MISSISSIPPI.
YEAH ARE YOU JUST. SITTING
THANKS HOW WERE ALL THESE NEED
TO BE MAINTAINED AND- PRIEST
AND MAYBE GO AFTER BIG
GOVERNMENT OKAY TAX CUT PEOPLE
THAT HAVE NOTPAID TAXES IN TEN
YEARS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER. SIX EIGHTY FIVE.
CHRIS BURNS. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF BOISE PUBLIC S. T. R. E. T.
T.'S THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. RESPECTED
DEPARTMENT FIFTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT ISSUE ONE WE OPPOSE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED RATE CUTS
THE S. T. R. T. P.'S AND
ENCOURAGING THIS BODY TO LOOK
AT CASE LAW ESTABLISHED IN THE
ALLIANCE VERSUS WHERE YOU TURN
ROSE THANK YOU FOR THE FEDERAL
COURTS HAVE ALREADY GERMANS
THANK.
HELLO MY NAME IS CLAIRE
RAMSEY I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
JUSTICE IN AGING AND I'M
CALLING TO OPPOSE ALL THE CUTS
THAT WOULD INCREASE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION INCLUDING
DEPARTMENTS EXCUSE ME FOUR ONE
SEVEN ZERO ISSUE ONE DAY
ELIMINATION OF EMESIS PNC BASS.
CUTS TO- DEPARTMENT FIVE ONE
EIGHT ZERO- ISSUE THREE DHS
REDUCTIONS AND I'M ALSO OPPOSED
TO- FIVE ONE EIGHT ZERO ISSUE
TO THE SS I SS P. CUTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANKS CALLER.
SIX SEVENTY NINE. SIX SEVEN
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ANYONE
ALIVE ZERO TWO. HI MY NAME IS
CONNIE BARKER I'M A HOME CARE
WORKER AND A MEMBER OF SEIU
TWENTY FIFTEEN- AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO ITEMS
FIFTY ONE EIGHTY NUMBER THREE
THE IIHS TEST COUNTS NUMBER-
FORTY ONE SEVENTY- ONE- THE
LIMITATION OF MSF HE HAD ALSO
OPPOSED TO THE COUCH TO EXCESS
I SP AND THE CUTS TO FUNDING
FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I CALLED.
THREE TWO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE TWO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS LINDA
CREDIBLE AND NON WITH THE READ
TWELVE AGENCY ON AGING MSN
PROGRAM AND I. AND HER ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY FOUR I STRONGLY
OPPOSE ELIMINATION OF BENEFITS-
THAT WORD THE BARELY HURT OUR-
SENIORS WHO ARE AGED. SIXTY
FIVE TO ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR. TIME THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. FIVE FORTY NINE. HELLO
MY NAME IS RACHEL LOWER I
REPRESENT I AM AN IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICE WORKER AND A
MEMBER OF SEIU TWENTY FIFTEEN
I'D LIKE FOR YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THE PROPOSAL CUT FOR NUMBER
FIVE ONE EIGHT OH THREE- THAT'S
FINE I H. AT AT 7% DOWN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANKS CALLER.
SEVENTY FIVE. HELLO HELLO HI WE
CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE CAN YOU
HEAR ME. OKAY MY NAME IS TRULY
DECREE. AND I AM A RESIDENT OF
SHASTA COUNTY WHERE. MOST OF
THE- OINTMENT IS IN I. HSS. AND
WE ARE THIS IS WHAT I'M CALLING
ABOUT ITEM NUMBER FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY ISSUE NUMBER THREE. AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE CUTS- TO
I. HSS AND- I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT WE ELIMINATE THE CORPORATE
TAX BREAKS. AND I DON'T I THINK
IF WE HAD ANOTHER HEARING ON
ALL THESE ITEMS THAT ARE ON
THAT VITAL VITAL INTEREST TO
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU SO I
pRIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER. WE GOT
THERE GOT A YOU KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE. I DON'T KNOW NEXT
CALLER OUR NEXT CALLER IS. SIX
SEVENTY ONE SIX SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SENATOR PAT
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CARLOS LAUNCHES MANAGE SOCIAL
WORKER WITH THE MFA PROGRAM
WITHOUT A MAN HOUSE SERVICES
CORPORATION IN THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE MSSP AND HE
BACKED AND BELIEVE. WHAT ONE
SEVEN NO ISSUE NUMBER ONE OKAY
THAT NUMBER ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER YEAH
BECAUSE WE BUT- I. WHAT WAS.
HELLO MY NAME THE COLORS LINE.
THREE SEVENTY THREE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY BUT
HELLO THIS IS DR ROGERS HELLO
YES PLEASE READ A LINE. I'M
TRYING THANK YOU MISTER ROGERS
OF THE EARLY LEARNING INSTITUTE
REPRESENTING IN THE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE
WOULD LIKE TO BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO
LEAVE OPEN ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
THE INCREASE RATE TO INVENT AND
KEPT THEIR GIGS AT SERVICES WE
BELIEVE THIS ITEM SHOULD BE RE
INTEGER AND SHOULD WE NOT MAKE
THE CUT THAT ARE RECOMMENDED
RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR.
NEXT CALL. PARDON ME THE NEXT
COLOURS LINE SEVEN HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND PARDON ME
AREN'T OUR NEXT LINE NUMBER IS
LYING SIX SIX SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LISA
KRAMER IN THE SOCIAL WORK CASE
MANAGER WITH THE CHOICE IN
AGING MSSP FOR NAPA SOLANO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION
OF MSP THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR. OUR NEXT CALLER
WILL BE LINED THREE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND PART
OF ME JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. WE
SEEM TO HAVE LOST THE CALLER
JUST A MOMENT.
AS WE'RE TRYING
TO FIND THE COLOR AGAIN
REMINDER IT'S NAME ORGANIZATION
AND THEN BUT THE USE FOR
OPPOSED ACCURATE
RECOMMENDATION. ON ANY
PARTICULAR ITEMS THAT YOU WISH
TO ADDRESS. OKAY. MODERATOR
EVERY. BLIND SIX SEVEN ONE FOUR
SIX SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ENGINE PARDON ME OUR NEXT LINE
IS LYING. SIX FIVE SIX SIX FIVE
SIX OR ONE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN TAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR BARBARA
PORTER THE MSSP DIRECTOR AT
CHOICE IN AGING CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I'M ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO THE ELIMINATION OF
THE SEA BASS PROGRAM AN MSF
EIGHT NUMBER FOUR ONE SEVEN PM
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER. OUR NEXT CALLER
WILL BE LINE SEVEN OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUDGET CALL
YOU TO OPPOSE. I THINK WE LOST
SORRY AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE- INTERFERENCE THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING AT THE MOMENT JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DELAY HERE- THE NEXT CALLER IS
SEVEN SIXTEEN SEVEN SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU.
HELLO. ONE SIX SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PERSON IN
LINE SEVEN THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE ONE SEVEN SEVEN
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BEVERLEY SIDELINED JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE THANK. LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN FIFTY TWO B. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL CHECK ON
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
FAMILY BUILDERS BY ADOPTION AND
THAT THERE WAS A SKILLED AREA
WE NEED TO GET KIDS IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM HOME AND OUT
OF FOSTER CARE AND THEREFORE
OPPOSE CUTS TO FAMILY AGENCIES
AND THAT'S YOUR TWO PIECE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANKS CALLER.
WELL NEXT GO TO THE LINE OF SIX
TWENTY THREE SIX TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE MORE
MOMENT CORRECT THANK YOU. LINE
SIX FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NUMBER FOUR ONE SEVEN
ZERO ISSUE ONE THIS IS DIANE
PACKET WITH THE PEG TAYLOR
CENTER. BUT LINE SIX FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS STILL OPEN.
JUST A MOMENT OKAY AT THAT
POINT YOU BACK HERE JUST A
MOMENT. ONE MOMENT SORRY NEXT
QUITE A COMMENTER THANK YOU.
ONE SEVEN FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SHE
REMEMBERS MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY FROM BLAKE IS VERY
QUICK- WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
CRACKS IN THE COW WORKS PROGRAM
THE SINGLE ALLOCATION FUNDS
SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT- CALOR-
AND WE ALSO JUST WANT TO-
SUPPORT I THINK THE CHAIR'S
COMMENTS EARLIER ABOUT THE KIND
OF SOCIETY- AS YOU KNOW WE'VE
BEEN BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR.
MORE THAN A DECADE NOW TRYING
TO GET CUT BACK THAT WERE MADE
IN THE LAST RECESSION THIS
WEEKEND TAKING US BACK OUT OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO WE TO
OPPOSE THESE CUTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER. OUR NEXT CALLER IS LINE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. EXACTLY
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR COMMITTEE
CALL BY HE GETS NATION AND
THAT'S THE KEY ITEM FOR ONE
SEVENTY ISSUE ONE THANK. YOU
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER. ONE
TWO SEVENTEEN. HELLO HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LORN A
LITTLE AND ON THE FIELD HEY MAN
AND MARK ANGELA- WE PROVIDE
CRITICAL MENTAL HEALTH EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND R. S.
P. R. T. P. THIRD YOUNG PARENTS
AND THEIR BABIES I'M SPEAKING
IN REFERENCE TO FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY ISSUE ITEM ONE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE 5% COPPER.
AT THE R. T. P. WE UNDERSTAND
THE CAR AFTER CHALLENGES BUT I
BELIEVE THE 5% FUNDING CUT TO
F. B. F. P. R. T. P.
CONTRADICTS THE LAW PROVIDED AN
ALLIANCE FORTY FIVE YEAR LOW I
JUST. WANTED TO BE CAREFUL THAT
WE TAKE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
DID YOU ANY OTHER YOU WISH.
EXPRESS A POSITION ON. OKAY SO
YOU PROCESSED YOUR AD CUTS TO
STFU OKAY- MIX COLOR. NEXT LINE
IS SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO AND
THANK YOU MY NAME IS SANDRA
BETONTE AND I AM THE SUPERVISOR
AT THE HEALTH PROJECTS CENTER
AT MISSISSIPPI IN SANTA CRUZ
THE HEALTH PROJECTS CENTER AND
THIS IS PETE SANTA CRUZ AND
MONTEREY STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF MSP ITEM FOUR
ONE SEVEN ZERO ISSUE ONE AND WE
DEEPLY URGE YOU TO DO THE SAME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER. ONE
SEVEN TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION- CALLING
IN WITH IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN CANADA FOR SERVICE
IN THE MIDDLE BUT ID D. AS WELL
AS A PROPOSAL INSTRUMENTATION
OF THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
AND APPRECIATE YOUR RECOGNITION
OF THE CHALLENGES IN OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER. NEXT CALLER IS
LINE SEVEN EIGHTEEN. POINT
SEVEN EIGHTEEN. I'M SHEILA GUNN
CUSHMAN WITH HAND IN HAND AND
THE DISABILITY ACTION NETWORK
I'D LIKE TO ECHO JESSICA LEHMAN
OF SENIOR AND DISABILITY ACTION
BUT I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT I DO
NOT WANT TO SEE UNITED HEALTH
CUTS LIK THE DIET TREE AND
DENTAL- DOES BOTH AFFECT ME
DIRECTLY. THANK YOU I THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. OUR NEXT CALLER IS
FLYING. SEVEN TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY WEST
PLAYING I AM FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCY APPRECIATE FOR STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD ITEM ONE
AND ITEM FORTY THREE HUNDRED
DDS OPEN FOR FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND ALSO APPRECIATE RECOGNITION
OF THE LA- THAT BE- EMAIL
WHATEVER ASPECT OF ALL THE
VARIOUS HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES CUTS WILL HAVE ON
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANKS CALLER. OUR NEXT
CALLER IS SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
THIS IS LISA WITH R. M. S. T.
SITE DIRECTOR FIRST SOURCE WIDE
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY I'M
CALLING AGAIN- ON ISSUE SEVENTY
FOUR AGAINST THE ELIMINATION OF
M. S. P. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR.
OUR NEXT CALLER IS FLYING SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
NANCY WALTER I'M A JEWISH
FAMILY SERVICES OF LOS ANGELES
YEAH I AM. WRONGLY OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF AND THAT'S THE
KEY- FEEDBACK UNDER FORTY ONE
SEVENTY ISSUE ONE HE ALSO
OPPOSED THE CUTS TO NUTRITION
AND ADR SEES- AT THIS TIME OF
NEED. AND FINALLY WE OPPOSE
FIFTY ONE EIGHTY ISSUE TOO WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD
BE ANY FURTHER CUTS AND SS I SS
T. THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS
FOR. ONE SEVEN THIRTY. MY NAME
IS TRICIA SIGLER I'M A NURSE
WITH SANTA CRUZ AND MONTEREY
COUNTY MSSP I STRONGLY OPPOSE
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE ELIMINATION
OF MSP AND ASK YOU TO DO THE
SAME FORMER WALKING OUT OF THE
NURSING HOME. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. X. COLOR. ONE SEVEN THIRTY
FIVE. PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT.
ONE SEVEN THIRTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATHY
KOREA AND I WORK AT HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL IN YOUR NETWORK URGE
YOU TO HELP KEEP OUR SENIORS
SAFE AT HOME BY POSTING
ELIMINATION OF THE M. S. P. AND
C. THAT PROGRAMS. THE COURT
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER. BLIND.
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS EILEEN KUHN
DIRECTOR OF HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL
YOU CAN NETWORK AND END UP WITH
PEOPLE WRITER AND I'M CALLING
ABOUT ISSUE FORTY ONE SEVENTY
ITEM FORTY ONE SEVENTY ISSUE
NUMBER ONE AND THEN I ASK YOU
TO OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION OF
THE M. P. AND V. DOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER. ONE
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAD AND-
MEMBERS MARKED THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
I'M SPEAKING ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICE ITEM RELATED
TO CHILD WELFARE FOR THE FOSTER
PARENT RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION AND SUPPORT PROGRAM
AND THE RESEARCH FAMILY
APPROVAL PROGRAM WE URGE THAT
YOU REJECT THOSE REDUCTIONS
AND- REBATE ALSO FOR THE CHILD
SUPPORT DEPARTMENT THE CHILD
SUPPORT REDUCTIONS WE URGE YOU
TO REJECT THOSE PRO- THOSE CUTS
AS WELL. WE SUPPORT- UNDER THE
CHILD WELFARE PROGRAM THE TRUE
UP COSTS FOR THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANKS CALLER. ONE SEVEN
FORTY FOUR. YES THIS IS CHUCK
CARTER DEAR CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN WONDERFUL- I AM- MANY OF
THE THINGS THAT I'VE HEARD
BEFORE. BUT I WILL ALSO YOU SAY
YOU WENT TO THE SENATE WELL
MEANS YOU'RE BETTER I COULDN'T
GET ON UNTIL FIVE O'CLOCK
ANYTHING FOR THE SECOND SESSION
SO I HOPE IT IS RECORDED. BUT
AGAIN THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
COALITION'S BUT I'M A PART OF
YOU WILL SEE ME AGAIN WHEN I
WILL WAIT FOR THE NEXT ONE CAN
TAKE PLACE BUT GO BACK TO THE
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET AND REALLY
EXAMINE IT THERE'S GOT TO BE
MORE IN IT THAT CAN BE WORKED
OUT. THANK YOU THANK YOU AND- I
BELIEVE THIS HEARING IS BEING
RECORDED AND WILL BE POSTED FOR
PEOPLE WHO WISH TO LISTEN TO
THIS HEARING. ONLINE THE NEXT
CALLER. ONE SEVEN TWO SERVICE
ON TO THE TRUE OF A CALL THIS
AFTERNOON AND ARRIVED IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE LONG TALK ON
YOUR FINDINGS WHICH IS ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN AND ALSO THE
ARTISTIC COUNCIL DETENTION.
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. OUR NEXT CALLER'S LINE.
FOR SIXTY SEVEN. YEAH. FIVE
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS SHERRY
WILLIAMS ON ACCOUNTING AND
INTERNAL DEPARTS TERRORISTS
PROVIDED AN IDEAL APPROACH
COULD BE ONE EIGHTY ONE ITEM
NUMBER THREE. THANK YOU THANKS
FOR. LINE FORTY FIVE. HI MY
NAME IS EMILY GALLIANO AND
MCQUEEN THAT PROVIDER AND I
OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER.
LINE SEVEN OH SEVEN. HI MY NAME
IS MARLENE LUECK I'M A PARENT
PROVIDER AND THE OWNER OF THAT
STAND OUT IN MY AGENT THAT
ADVOCACY GROUP IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THE
ITEM FIFTY ONE EIGHTY ISSUE
THREE PRINT I HAD THAT- HAD AS
WELL AS THE CURRENT U. SS I SS
P. AND THE REGIONAL CENTER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER. WINE. SEVEN FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD DAY MY NAME IS BILL
TINSLEY WHAT CAN TECH MEDICAL
AND THE ORANGE COUNTY AREA-
JUST CALLING TO SAY THAT I.
OPPOSE ANY PROPOSAL BY THE
GOVERNOR TO ELIMINATE THE M. S.
S. P. AND C. BEST PROGRAMS-
PLEASE CONSIDER- THE
CONTINUATION OF THOSE PROGRAMS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR. ONE SIX FIFTY
EIGHT. BUT ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU HI THIS
IS DIANE POCKET- I'M CALLING
TO- REGARDING ITEM NUMBER FOUR
WHEN SEVEN ZERO ISSUE ONE I'M
WITH THE TECH PAPER CENTER FOR
ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE PROVIDING
C. BESTED THREE WORLD NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES AND I'VE
HAD TWO FAMILY MEMBERS SERVE BY
SEA BASS. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE ELIMINATION OF SEA BASS AND
MSSP FOR WHICH THERE ARE NO
ALTERNATIVES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER. NINE SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS YOUR
REQUIREMENT PROGRAM RECORD YOUR
YOUTH AND FAMILY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME CALLING HIM BECAUSE-
DEPARTMENT FIFTY ONE EIGHTEEN
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ON THE NATION
AND THE EFFORT THEY THOUGHT THE
WORK RATE INCREASE AND DECREASE.
AT THE AT THE R. T. P. RIGHT.
THANK YOU X. COLOR. ONE SEVEN
FIFTY NINE. HELLO MY NAME IS
TINA ROBERTS AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF FOSTER CARE AND
ADOPTIONS AT DAVID AND MARGARET
USE AND FAMILY SERVICES LOCATED
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY I'M
CALLING IN TO OPPOSE UNDER
DEPARTMENT FIVE ONE EIGHT ZERO
ITEM ONE ATTACHED TO THE S. T.
R. T. P. N. A FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. ONE SEVEN SIXTY SIX.
ONE SEVEN SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE SEVEN THIRTY TWO. HI
MY NAME IS THERESA AGAIN THE
DIRECTOR TO THE NETWORK RIGHT
THIRTY FOUR COUNTIES IN THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO VALLEY. DOES
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AN S. AND
P. M. S. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. PARDON ME JUST ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE SEVEN
SEVENTY I'M BOB BOOKS READING
ON THE AGENDA FAMILY SERVICES I
OPPOSE CUTS TO HOSPITALITY
AGENCIES IDENTIFIED ONE EIGHT
ZERO ZERO ONE PLEASE CONTINUE
TO. HOLD FOR THE SAFE AND
STABLE. THANK YOU THANKS CALLER.
ONE SEVEN DETAIL YOU NEED TO
GET ALL THE TIME. REMEMBER YOU
HEALTH AND HEALTH PLANS. RIGHT
WHILE WE OPPOSE. THE
ELIMINATION THE BACK HE ISSUE
R. ONE SEVEN ZERO ONE THANK YOU.
OUR. LINE FIFTY TWO. LINE FIFTY
TWO. LINE SEVEN TWENTY NINE.
BUT HE ADMITSTHAT THE PROGRAM
AND A LOT OF QUALITY CHOICE IN
A BILLING AND I DO APOLOGIZE IN
THE NATION MET HE. ADDED
FEEDBACK. THANK YOU THANKS.
LINE TWO OH FIVE. LINE TWO OH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
YES PLEASE CONTINUE. MY NAME IS
LANA HARDING AND I'M A HUGE FAN
RIGHT B. BATH AND CAD
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF THE
DELEGATES CENTERS AND I OPPOSE
AGENDA ITEM FOUR ONE SEVEN ZERO
IF YOU WON THE ELIMINATION OF
FEEDBACK. THANK YOU. RIGHT
THANK YOU WOULD MAKE NO WE'VE
HEARD FROM SEVERAL WITNESSES-
CALLING- OPPOSING THE
ELIMINATION OF CEDAR AND M. S.
ASSISTS THE M. S. S. P. PROGRAM
SO WE HAVE FOR YOU I WANNA BE
SURE WE'RE ABLE TO HEAR FROM
OTHER. ADVOCATES WHO MAY WANT
TO TALK ABOUT OTHER ISSUES AS
WELL. SO AND ALSO OF COURSE
EVERYONE CAN SUBMIT COMMENTS TO
US VIA THE- WEBSITE AS WELL SO
DIGESTIBLE INTERACTS ON BE SURE
WE- HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FROM
OTHER ADVOCATES WHO MAY BE ON
THE LINE AS WELL I APPRECIATE
ALL THE ADVOCATES CALLING FOR.
YEAH OPPOSING THE PROPOSAL
EMANATION OF M. S. P. AND C.
BASS WE HAVE HEARD YOU. ALL
RIGHT LET'S SAY THE NEXT CALLER.
LINE SEVEN OH ONE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON DONNA WITH HEARING
DISABILITY ACTION I'M A BOSNIAN
ANIMATIONS OF SHIVA'S MOTHER
SPEAK UNDER REDUCTIONS OF
FUNDING FOR HIS SUPPORT I USE
THE IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES
THE MENTAL SECURITY INCOME
ANOTHER BATTLE PROGRAM
SEARCHING HERE AND. PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES OUR NATION THAT
BIG INTO. OILS I'M FINE IN
DESIGN OF GREAT ORAND THANK
YOU. THAT YOU NEXT CALL. LINE
FOR TWENTY TWO. HI GOOD EVENING
MY NAME THE GREASE IN THE WORLD
AND I'M NOT ARE YOU JUST AS
PROVIDER WHAT TWENTY FIFTEEN
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS AND I AM
OPPOSED TO BLIND ITEM FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY NUMBER 37% CUT IT- GAVIN
NEWSOM HAS THE POLLS I THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER.
LINE SIX SEVENTY NINE. ONE SIX
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS KELSEY CAME. YES
PLEASE CONTINUE. AND I'M
CALLING TO OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF MSP AND THE BASS.
THANK YOU NO OTHER MATCH
PROGRAM. THAT CAN PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT MSF BNC PAST
PROVIDE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER. WINDS SEVEN
SIXTY FOUR. HELLO GERMAN HANDED
TO ME MY NAME IS CHERYL READY I
AM THE CLINICAL DIRECTOR FOR
SAN DIEGO CENTER FOR CHILDREN
ON BEHALF OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE FOSTER CHILDREN I
OPPOSE THE 5% RATE CUT TO
RESIDENTIAL CARE AND THE
ELIMINATION OF THE FFA SOCIAL
WORKER RATE AS PROPOSED IN ITEM
FIVE ONE EIGHT ZERO ISSUE ONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER. ONE SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE. IRELAND INDIGO COUNTY I'M
CALLING ABOUT ITEM FIVE ONE
EIGHT ZERO ISSUE NUMBER ONE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE S. T. R. T.
P. RATE REDUCTION THIS WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE FOSTER YOUTH IN
A THERAPEUTIC RESIDENTIAL CARE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER. ONE SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR.
ONE SEVEN SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OUR NEXT LINE COLOR IS
FLYING SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT. ONE
SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE'LL HAVE TO HIT.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SIR. HI MY
NAME IS SET TO APPEAR ON THE
TLC DIRECTOR OF FOSTER CARE AND
ADOPTION I'M ALSO A RESOURCE
PARENT AND I'M CALLING TO
OPPOSE ANY CUTS S. T. R. T. P.
AND UPDATES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALL. ONE SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE. THE MINUTE. HELLO
THIS IS GETTING A TANK FROM
CALL OF CRACK AND I'M ALSO
CALLING TO EXPRESS OUR
OPPOSITION TO ANY KIND OF P. R.
T. P. RATE OR TO THE FOSTER
CARE SOCIAL WORKER RIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANKS CALLER.
ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KARLEY MACMURRAY MINIMUM PROUD
SOCIAL WORKER WITH THE MSSP
PROGRAM IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
REGARDING ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
FIVE MY COLLEAGUES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION
OF MS THIRTEEN WE URGE YOU TO
DO THE SAME SO WE CAN KEEP OUR
SENIOR STATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR. ONE SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE. GOOD EVENING I'M
PATRICIA ALL OF THE CHILD HELP
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY I'M THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR WE SERVE
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN IN KERN
FRESNO ORANGE LEFT AND LET THE
MEMBERS BY NAME IF YOU NOT
FOUND ANY CHILD HELP STRONGLY
OPPOSES THE CUT U. S. E. R. T.
P. FFA AND THE FORM OF FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE DEPARTMENT FIVE
ONE EIGHT O. S. U. M. ONE THANK
YOU ON BEHALF OF THE HUNDREDS
OF CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. THAT
WE SERVE. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. WINDS NINETY EIGHT. HI
AN ARMED WITH CALIFORNIA FAMILY
LIFE CENTER I AM AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SH AND I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS MY OPPOSITION TO
DEPARTMENT FIRED ONE EIGHTY
ISSUE ONE. AND ALSO ANY CUTS TO
SOCIAL WORKER RIGHT WELL THESE
CODES IN THE BUDGET WILL CAUSE
LONG LASTING HARM BY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING SAFETY NET DESIGNED
TO SUPPORT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
YOU ARE FOSTER YOUTH AND THOSE
IN OUR CARE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. ONE EIGHT OH SIX. BY
NATO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
SORRY GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
THE ONLY CURRENT CALLING WITH
HEALTH PROJECTS UNDER.
INFIRMARY INTEGRATED COUNTY AND
I'M CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE ELIMINATION OF THEMSSP
PROGRAM AND I ASK THAT YOU DO
THE SAME THANK YU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER. LINE
FIFTY TWO. AND THERE ARE NO
OTHER COMMENTERS AT THIS TIME
OKAY CAN YOU CHECK OUT ONE MORE
TIME TO BE SURE THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE. WHO WISHES TO COMMENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. AND YOU HAVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. OKAY. THIRTEEN
THIRTY ANY ADDITIONAL. PEOPLE
ON THE LINE. JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE FOUR OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PARDON ME JUST A
MOMENT. WE DO HAVE MORE PEOPLE
ARE QUEUING UP AT THIS MOMENT
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT OKAY. I
WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE FOR THE
PEOPLE WERE QUEUING UP- IT'S
SOMEONE ELSE'S TESTIFIED ON
THAT ITEM. I JUST PLEASE MAKE
REFERENCE TO THAT- YEAH AND ITS
NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON ANY PARTICULAR
ITEMS THAT WERE. HEARING AND
OUR VOTE ONLY CALENDARS. SO
AGAIN IT'S NAME POSITION NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION IF
YOU WISH TO GIVE EXPLANATIONS
PLACEMENT THOSE IN WRITING TO
OUR COMMITTEE OF YOUR WEB PAGE.
ONE SIX SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS LINDSAY EMI HONG WITH HAND
IN HAND THE DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS
NETWORK WE STRONGLY OPPOSE-
ITEMS FIFTY ONE EIGHTY ISSUE
TWO AND THREE SFI AFTER HE AND
I AGE AT THAT AS WELL AS ITEM
FOUR ONE SEVEN ZERO ISSUE. ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
ONE FOUR EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FINE FOR EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE RESPOND. LINE
SIX EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SIX EIGHTY EIGHT. MY
NECK MY NAME IS TANYA TRUCKLOAD
SHE I'M ON. A WIDER. AND FROM
ORANGE COUNTY. ON I DON'T PUSH
THE ONE A ISSUE THREE I WILL
POST THE CORNERS THE ALSO 47%
CUT BY HSN HOURS THAT TARGETS
LOW INCOME SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU THANKS VERY
MUCH OUR NEXT CALLER. ONE SEVEN
NINETEEN. HELLO YES HI THANK
YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS DEBBIE
NOW AND I'M SINGLE PARENT OF A
DISABLED CHILD- AND I'M WORRIED
AND OPPOSED TO CUT RESPITE
PROGRAM WE COULD DEPEND ON SO
DEFINITELY THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER. ONE SEVEN
HUNDRED. HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL
JAGA AND I'M WITH HIM AGAIN B.
AT THE INSTITUTE ON AGING
EXCEPT THAT THE CO I'M CALLING
IF YOU WILL BECAUSE THE
ANIMATION APARTMENT FIFTY AND I
REQUEST THAT YOU DO THE SAME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. BLIND. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK YES PLEASE PLEASE CONTINUE.
I THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO SPEAK WITH US AND I HAD
SPOKEN WITH BEFORE MY NAME'S
AMBER BUSH I JUST WANTED TO
POINT OUT. OKAY DID WE LOSE.
I'M AFRAID SO OKAY THE NEXT
CALLER RECENTLY TO COMMON
WRITING THEN- PLEASE CONTINUE
NEXT CALL. SHE MET. I'M AFRAID
NOT OKAY ALL RIGHT BUSH PLEASE
CONTINUE LINE SIX NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE'RE GONNA
GO TO THE LINE OF LINE SEVEN.
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SEVEN SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M GONNA GO TO
THE LINE OF SIX SEVENTY FOUR.
SIX SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS ERIN STRAIN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ARQUEBUS TOWNIES SERVING FOUR
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WITH IBD
REGARDING ITEM FORTY THREE
HUNDRED ISSUE ONE A WE OPPOSE
THESE PROPOSED SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET CUTS DDS NAMELY THE RE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE INTERCOM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE THE COST
SHARING PROGRAM AND THE
REDUCTION TO PROVIDER RATES
STILL BE. DEVASTATING CUTS ARE
FRAGILE SYSTEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER. ONE TWO
NINETY NINE. LINE TWO NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI- MY
NAME IS THAT THAT YOU MIGHT GET
A MIND I PROVIDER. ON A
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE BUDGET
CUTS OFF ALL THE SOCIAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE HELPING A LOT
OF PEOPLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. WINDS FIVE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
I'M BOB MYERS SAYS YOLO DON'T
THEY HELP CENTER ON BEHALF OF
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND FRAGILE
ADULTS WHO DEPEND ON ADHD IN
THE BACK THE LIVES SAFELY IN
THE COMMUNITY I ASK YOU TO
CLOSE FORTY ONE SEVENTY ISSUE
ONE ELIMINATION AT THE BACK
THEN AND I THOUGHT HE THANK
YOU. SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. ONE SEVEN OH SIX WHAT.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE CONTINUE. HI MY NAME IS
NATALIE MARTINEZ AND I AM ABLE
TO WHAT I EXPECT. I THE IN THE
BY. ONE EIGHT ZERO AN ITEM
NUMBER THREE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. LINE FOR FIFTY
NINE. HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICE
BROWN I'M WITH S. V. I. U.
TWENTY FIFTEEN MM AND- YOU KNOW
WITH YOUR PROVIDER. I DO NOT
AGAIN. FIVE ONE EIGHT ZERO
NUMBER THREE. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALL.
ONE SIX TWENTY TWO. ONE SIX
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE. SIX
SEVENTY NINE POINT SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIX
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
LINE. SEVEN FORTY THREE POINT
SEVEN FORTY THREE ONE IS OPEN.
THE DOCTOR CHAIRMAN PLANNING
COMMITTEE WE HAVE SPOKEN IN THE
PAST MY NAME IS SPELLED G. AT
TRIAL I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CHILD THE CO DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THIS YEAR I'M ALSO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE SPANISH NOT
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES. THIS IS IN
REGARDS TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE ONE
SEVEN FIVE ISSUE NUMBER ONE
JUST TO SAY THAT WE OPPOSE THE
REDUCTION- TO CHILD SUPPORT
FUNDING- PROGRAM UPON HIS
MEDIAN HONORABLE FAMILY TREE
BY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR. SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. WINE HELLO EDEL. WHAT
LINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS LESLIE MATTHEWS AND I'M
A PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITH
ALTERNATIVE FAMILY SERVICES I'M
OPPOSED TO ITEM FIVE POINT
EIGHT ZERO ISSUE ONE WHICH
WOULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT FOSTER
USED BY DECREASING AGENCIES
ABILITY TO RETAIN STAFF. CAN
PROVIDE POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR
HUGE I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
RECENTLY OBTAINED YOU. USE
THANK YOU WE'RE JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION SO IF FOR JOB
POSITION UNLESS THERE'S ANOTHER
ITEM YOU SHOULD OPPOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER. LINE
FOUR NINETY SEVEN. HI CAN I BE
HEARD THANK YOU YES PLEASE CALL
MY- WE CAN HEAR YOU AND YEAH
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE
PLEASE CONTINUE NAME ORG NAME
ORGANIZATION AND- ITEM AND YOUR
POSITION ON THAT ITEM. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR FOUND AND ALL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM YOU
CANNOT OUT MONTENEGRO I AM AN
IN HOME SUPPORT- SUPPORT
SERVICE PROVIDER IN SAN DIEGO.
I AM ALSO THE DISTRICT CHAIR
ALL YOU W. NINE DIEGO AND I'M
CALLING BECAUSE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE 7% CUT. HOURS OF OUR
CLIENT DOT 7% COPIES OUT TO BE
A DOUBLE EDGED KNIFE THAT CUTS
AND URGED BOTH FIGHT THAT FIGHT
ALL DOUBLE LEVEL MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY AND THE PROVIDERS. I
THINK PUBLICLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMPUTER HE CONCEDED THAT
RIGHT THANK YOU YOUR FIRST OF
THE 7% CUT ON I JUST US. THANK
YOU. THANKS CALLER YEAH. NINE
SEVEN FIFTH ONE. HELLO THIS IS
CAN BE ON THE C. O. OF THE TO
CHANGE AND S. T. R. T. P.
SERVING GANG ENTRENCHED YOU BUY
OPPOSED COULD BE ONE EIGHTY
ITEM ONE THE- THAT THAT THEY
CUT AND THIS ISSUE THE S. P. R.
T. P. CUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER. LINE. EIGHT
FOURTEEN. ONE EIGHT FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS JOE FORD FROM HATHAWAY
SYCAMORES CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. AND I WANT. OPPOSE
ANY CUTS TO SHORT TERM
THERAPEUTIC RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS. OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NEXT CALL. LINE EIGHT
TWENTY ONE. HELLO THIS IS
BARBARA BONDURANT I LIVE IN LA
VERNE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
I AM AT HOME CARE PROVIDER WITH
THE RHS SHOWS FOR MY DISABLED
SON AND I WOULD LIKE TO-
OPPOSED 27% CUT THROUGH THE
HOURS FOR THE I. HSS
RECIPIENTS. AND ALSO ANY CUTS
TO MEDI CAL AND OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES THESE ARE THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE THE SAFETY NET THAT WE
HAVE PAID AGAIN TO OUR TAXES
OUR ENTIRE WORKING LIFE AND WE
CAN'T DO WITHOUT IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. EIGHTY
THANK YOU. IT APPEARS THAT WE
HAVE NO MORE COMMENTERS AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT LIKE THE PROMPT
AGAIN. WELL I THINK WE'VE GIVEN
A PROMPT AND- WE SCAN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ONE RETURN THIS
TO- HEARING ROOM FORTY ONE OH
THREE BECAUSE WE DO HAVE- I
BELIEVE SOMEONE THE AUDIENCE
WHO'S PREPARED TO TESTIFY.
TICKETS YOU. MR LONDON YOU CAN
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND AGAIN-
pTHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING OR
SUPPORTING YEAH SURE THING-
THIS CHAIRMAN THANK YOU CARL
LONDON HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHEN REGISTER OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE THREE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN CUTS TO
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS. FOR
PEOPLE WITH I. D. D. THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE AND
ALSO URGE YOU TO LOOK MORE
CLOSELY AT THE EARLY THE ISSUES
DISCUSSED EARLIER ON THE
INCREASED STATE OPERATED
FACILITIES INCREASE THAT- WAS
DISCUSSED DURING THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ITEM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH. I THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT OKAY WITH THAT I
THINK WITH DAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH MODERATOR I BELIEVE THIS-
CONCLUDES- PUBLIC COMMENT-
VERBAL PUBLIC COMMENT I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT. IF YOU WISH TO
CONTINUE MAKE PUBLIC CARMAKERS
YOU TO EMAIL US. VIA OUR
WEBSITE SO YOU CAN GO TO THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE. SEPT ME
NUMBER THREE WEBSITE HELPING
HIM SERVICES IN EMAIL- YOUR
POSITION AND CERTAINLY CAN.
TALK X. EXPRESS MORE LIFE THE
REASONS WHY AND SUCH AN EMAIL
AND THAT WILL BE PART OF THE
RECORD OF THIS HEARING SO AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE. THAT WITH
THAT NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
OUR- CALENDAR SO. WE HAVE HERE.
WE HAVE ONE HUNDRED ITEMS ON
HER VOTE ONLY CALENDAR- WITH
OUR STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS. DEAR
HANDS ON HERE. SO I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A NOTE OF THE CHANGE TO
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR WHICH IS
ISSUE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AS
PART OF AGING D. E. V. V.
PENALTY BACK PHIL HAS BEEN
IMPROPERLY DONE A FIGHTS A
PROPOSAL THAT WAS SUSTAINED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION THIS ISSUE'S
BEEN WITHDRAWN IS BEING
WITHDRAWN BY THE ADMINISTRATION
SO THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
ISSUE NUMBER TWO IS NOW THE
HOLD OPEN AND WE WILL NOT BE
VOTING ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO ON
THE- ONLY CALENDAR. WE WILL
ALSO. C. WE ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT
THERE'S A RECOMMENDATION HOLD
ITEMS ISSUES NUMBER.
214-172-5406 535-772-8080
1-838-485-8890 SIX NINETY EIGHT
AND NINETY NINE SO WE WOULD NOT
BE TAKING A VOTE ON THOSE ITEMS
THAT WILL BE HELD OPEN AND I'LL
BE REFERRED TO THE FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE. SO NOW WE'LL DO IS
WE'LL TAKE ON THE ERROR MEETING
ITEMS- SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS- FIRST WE'RE GONNA TAKE ON
THE ITEMS. IN WHICH- THERE. IS
AN- EXTENSION FROM THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS SO. THAT'S
THE ONLY. ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTY
SIX. SO SECRETARY ACTUALLY WELL
I GUESS FIRST IN QUESTION IS
ZERO IS THERE A MOTION ON ON
THIS ITEM OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR TADA SO ON ISSUE
EIGHTY SIX US SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CAN I. RETIRE
I'VE MELINDA STAIN. OKAY SO
THAT ITEMS OUT TWO ZERO. NEXT
WE HAVE ITEMS IN WHICH- THERE'S
A- NO RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS THOSE ARE
ISSUES NUMBER. THREE FOUR SIX
EIGHT NINE TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
NINE THIRTY THIRTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR TO  EIGHTY SEVEN.
ARE THERE ANY EXTRACTIONS FROM
THAT LIST OKAY THERE NO
EXTRACTIONS FROM THAT LIST IS
THERE A MOTION TO ADOPT THESE
ITEMS IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR TADO SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HAN HI TOTAL I
BELINDA. OKAY THOSE ITEMS ARE
OUT TO ONE. FINALLY WE HAVE
OUR- CONSENT CALENDAR AND THOSE
ARE ITEMS NUMBER. SHE'S NUMBER
ONE FIVE SEVEN TEN THROUGH
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN THROUGH. 242-628-3230
338-404-0140 FOUR FORTY FIVE
FORTY EIGHT THROUGH. FIFTY TO
FIFTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT THREE
SIXTY ONE. HOW IT FIFTY EIGHT
THROUGH SEVENTY ONE. SEVENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE TO NINETY FIVE
NINETY SEVEN AND ONE HUNDRED
AND AGAIN THE MOTION WOULD BE
TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS SERVICE ON
THOSE IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SIR
HER TADO SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
CALL THE ROLL. TEN HI THE
TUNNEL HI MELINDA HI OKAY THIS
IS STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
OUT THREE ZERO. OKAY RIGHT SO I
THINK THAT CONCLUDES OUR- ROLL
CALL. VODE ITEMS AT LEAST THREE
THINGS. JUDGE WOMAN STRUCK. SO
OKAY HOLD ON ONE SECOND PLEASE.
THERE'S ONE OTHER ITEM THAT- SO
WE WILL BE TAKING A VOTE ON
DISCUSSION ITEM NUMBER ONE
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT AGING-
THIS IS A VOTE ON THE ONE TIME
REDUCTION TO SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS IN THE ONE TIME
REDUCTION TO AGING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CENTERS THE
REDUCTION TO LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM. ELIMINATION
OF MSP AND ELIMINATION OF THE
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
PROGRAM WILL BE HELD OPEN
ACTUALLY PLANNED FOR TWENTY
HOLLAND MEETS HER FIVE YEAR.
OKAY JUST FOR CLARITY SO V.
ITEM THAT WE'RE MOVING IT THAT
WILL BE VOTING ON. IS T. TO
REJECT THE ONE TIME REDUCTION
TO SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS
AND TO REJECT THE ONE TIME
REDUCTION TO AGING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CENTERS
THAT'S THE MOTION. I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT OTHER PROPOSALS FOR
REDUCTION TO LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM IN THE NATION
M. S. S. P. AND ELIMINATION OF
SEA BASS WILL BE HELD OPEN SO
NOT VOTING ON THOSE SO. THE
MOTIONS ON THIS AFRICAN NATIONS
TO REJECT THE ONE TIME
REDUCTION TO SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS IN THE REJECT THE ONE
TIME REDUCTION TO AGING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CENTERS IS
THERE A MOTION. HELLO OKAY IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR TADO.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS.
IN HI THE TITLE I MELINDA'S HI.
OKAY SO THOSE ITEMS HAVE BEEN
REJECTED PER STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS. THREE ZERO.
OKAY AND THEN WE ARE ALSO
HOLDING OPEN THE FOLLOWING.
IRMA DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
ISSUE ONE HUNDRED APARTMENTS
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES AND
ISSUE ONE THROUGH FOUR UNDER
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES SO
THESE ARE BEING HELD OPEN SO
THERE'S NO VOTE TO BE TAKEN AT
THIS TIME. MA'AM SECTORS THAT
CONCLUDE THE OKAY SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR VOTE- VOTING.
ROLE FOR TODAY. HIS HEARING.
OKAY THE END. OKAY WELL THAT
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING OF BUT IN
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES I WANNA THANK
ALL EVERYONE WHO'S PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S HEARING AND- AGAIN
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PEOPLE-
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS- THE LA- IN THE
PARK FINANCE I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO MADE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY I ALSO APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE IS WE'VE
WORKING THROUGH THIS NEW
MENTALITY HERE I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF THE CAUCUS
STAFF AND INSTANTLY. CALLED OUR
TECHNICIANS HERE AS WELL WHO'S
HAD TO JUGGLE S. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE MODERATOR AS WELL I
KNOW THAT THERE THERE'S A- LOT
OF WORK THAT HAPPENS TO MAKE
THINGS HAPPEN TO LOOK SMOOTH OR
EVEN NOT SO SMOOTHLY AT TIMES
BUT- PEOPLE WORK VERY HARD TO
TRY TO FACILITATE PEOPLE'S
PARTICIPATION SO AGAIN I REALLY
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR.
THAT FURTHER WORK ON THIS AND-
SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND EFFORT AND
COOPERATION- URICH AND ALSO
AGAIN REMINDER THAT IF YOU HAVE
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS PLEASE SUBMIT THEM
TO THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE- ON
OUR WEBSITE- AND REGARDS AND
EACH- OF BUDGET ITEMS AND- BUT
THAT WE HAVE CONCLUDED THIS
AGENDA THE SENATE BUDGET SENATE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE ON
NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. IS ADJOURNED.